ASSEMBLY MEMBER FLORA NOTICES
THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM.
THE SERGEANT AT ARMS WILL
PREPARE THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN
THE ABSENT MEMBERS THE CLERK
WILL CALL THE ROLL.
AGUIAR-CURRY [inaudible]
ARAMBULA.
OUR QUE HAN.
BERMAN.
BIGELOW [inaudible]
BLOOM.
BURNER **** BATH [inaudible]
BONTA [inaudible]
BRO [inaudible]
BURKE [inaudible]
CALDERON CARILLO [inaudible]
CERVANTES CHAU [inaudible]
CHEN.
DAVID CHIU.
CHOI [inaudible]
KANSEN CHU [inaudible]
COOLEY [inaudible]
COOPER [inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM [inaudible]
DALLY [inaudible]
DALY [inaudible]
DEEP IN [inaudible]
FLORA [inaudible]
FONG [inaudible]
FRAZIER [inaudible]
FRIEDMAN [inaudible]
GABRIEL.
GALLAGHER CRISTINA GARCIA.
EDUARDO GARCIA [inaudible]
GIPSON GLORIA.
GONZALEZ IS GRAY [inaudible]
GRAYSON HOLDEN.
IRWIN JONES SAWYER [inaudible]
KALRA.
KAMLAGER-DOVE.
KILEY [inaudible]
LACKEY LEVINE.
LIMON.
LOW [inaudible]
MAIENSCHEIN.
MATHIS.
MAYES MCCARTY.
MEDINA [inaudible]
MELENDEZ MULLIN.
MURATSUCHI.
NAZARIAN.
OBERNOLTE O'DONNELL PATTERSON
PETRIE-NORRIS QUIRK [inaudible]
QUIRK SILVA [inaudible]
RAMOS REYES THREE OF US ROBERT
RIVAS RODRIGUEZ.
RUBIO [inaudible]
SALAS SANTIAGO [inaudible]
SMITH [inaudible]
STONE [inaudible]
TING VOEPEL [inaudible]
WALDRON WEBER WICKS.
WOULD [inaudible]
MISTER SPEAKER
.
MEMBERS PLEASE JOIN US ON THE
ASSEMBLY FLOOR WE WOULD LIKE TO
GET STARTED AND REACH A QUORUM
SO WE CAN GET OUR BUSINESS GOING
THANK YOU
.
MEMBER IS A QUORUM IS PRESENT.
WE ASK OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS
IN THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER IN AN
ART GALLERY TO PLEASE STAND FOR
THE PRAYER.
TODAY'S PRAYER WILL BE OFFERED
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER FLORA.
PLEASE BOW YOUR HEADS LORD MAY
WOULD BE MINDFUL OF THE NEEDS OF
THOSE AROUND US.
MAYOR ACTIONS ALWAYS ENABLE THE
SPIRIT OF FREEDOM TO THRIVE AND
TAKE ROOT.
MAY WE FIND A WAY TO LIVE FREELY
WHILE RESPECTING THE FREEDOMS OF
OTHERS.
MAY THIS BE GOD'S WILL.
A MAN.
WE ASK OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS
TO REMAIN STANDING AND JOIN US
FOR THE FLAG SALUTE PLEASE JOIN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BIGELOW AS HE
LEADS US IN THE PLEDGE.
MEMBERS AND GUESTS WILL YOU
PLEASE JOIN ME IN SAYING OUR
PLEDGE I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO
THE UNITED STATES OF IT IS A
LITTLE [inaudible]
YES.
THANK YOU YOU MAY BE SEATED.
MOVING TO THE READING OF THE
PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL ASSEMBLY
CHAMBER SACRAMENTO WEDNESDAY MAY
FIFTEENTH TWENTY NINETEEN
RECENTLY MET AT SEVEN AM ON WILL
STEVEN S. CHOI ASSEMBLYMEMBER
SIXTY EIGHT DISTRICT PRESIDING
CHIEF COOKIE DOTSON WILSON AT
THE DESK.
WE QUICK KATHLEEN M. LUIS READ
MISTER CALDERON MOVES AND MISTER
FLORES SECONDS THAT THE READING
OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL BE
DISPENSED WITH.
PRESENTATIONS OF PETITIONS THERE
ARE NONE.
DIRECTIONS IN REFERENCE TO BILLS
WILL BE DEFERRED REPORTS IN
COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED READ
AND AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR THERE
ARE NONE MESSAGES FROM THE
SENATE THERE ARE NONE.
MOVING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS TODAY'S ABSENCES ARE
ASSEMBLY COOLEY FOR AN ILLNESS
IN ASSEMBLY MEMBER GARCIA FOR A
DEATH IN THE FAMILY
.
MEMBERS WOULD LIKE TO WELCOME
SOME GAS TO OUR CHAMBER TODAY.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CARILLO HAS SOME
GAS IN THE GALLERY SHE WOULD
LIKE WE WOULD ALL LIKE TO
WELCOME BOARD MEMBERS FROM HOPE.
HISPANICS ORGANIZE FOR POLITICAL
EQUALITY WHO ARE REPRESENTS WHO
ARE PRESENT SENDING.
MARK TO HEAR HEAR TO PER MARK
HOPEFULLY TINA ACTION DAY THANK
YOU FOR JOINING US TODAY
[inaudible]
WE HAVE A GAS IN THE GALLERY.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SMITH HAS A
GROUP HERE THEY'RE HERE. TO FOR
ADVANCED PLACEMENT DAY WE'D LIKE
TO WELCOME THESE DISTINGUISHED
TEACHERS STAR GALLERY
[inaudible]
AND MEMBERS.
MOVING TO BUSINESS ON THE DAILY
FILE FILE ITEMS CHIU AND THREE
WILL BE PASSED TO RETAIN FILE
ITEM.
FOR AB FOR FIFTY ONE THE CLERK
WILL READ ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR
FIFTY ONE BY SELLING OVER
SANTIAGO AND ACTUALLY TO HEALTH
FACILITIES
.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE
MISTER RANDY ARE YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED OPEN ON THIS MATTER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND IT'S
A PLEASURE TO BE BACK I WANT TO
THANK MY COLLEAGUE FROM.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I WANT
TO THANK MY COLLEAGUE FROM LOS
ANGELES WHO CARRIED THIS MEASURE
FOR ME WHILE I WAS INDISPOSED.
BUT IT'S A PLEASURE TO BE BACK
MADAM SPEAKER AND IT'S A
PLEASURE TO BE PRESENTING ON AB.
FOR FIFTY ONE THIS IS A MEASURE
WHICH WOULD REQUIRE PSYCHIATRIC
UNITS WITHIN GENERAL ACUTE CARE
HOSPITALS PSYCHIATRIC HEALTH
FACILITIES AND PSYCHIATRIC
HOSPITALS REGARDLESS OF WHETHER
THEY MAINTAIN AN EMERGENCY
DEPARTMENT. TO TO PROVIDE
EMERGENCY CARE TO RELIEVE OR
ELIMINATE PSYCHIATRIC EMERGENCY
MEDICAL CONDITIONS.
AS I FAR TOO WELL NO EMERGENCY
PHYSICIANS HAVE EXPERIENCED
TROUBLE TRANSFERRING PATIENTS TO
PRIVATE PSYCHIATRIC FACILITIES
THAT DO NOT MAINTAIN AN
EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT.
THERE IS A CONCERN THAT SOME
PSYCHIATRIC HOSPITALS ARE USING
LANGUAGE IN CURRENT LAW WHICH
ONLY APPLIES TO CALIFORNIA
HOSPITALS THAT MAINTAIN AND
OPERATE AN EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT.
AS A WAY TO NOT ACCEPT ALL
PATIENTS.
IF A PSYCHIATRIC HOSPITAL AVOIDS
TAKING PATIENTS IT LIMITS ACCESS
TO CARE.
AND REDUCES CAPACITY OF ALREADY
SCARCE MENTAL HEALTH RESOURCES.
AB FOR FIFTY ONE IS SPONSORED BY
THE CALIFORNIA CHAPTER OF THE
AMERICAN COLLEGE OF EMERGENCY
PHYSICIANS AND HAS RECEIVED
STRONG BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND I
HUMBLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE HERE
TODAY -- THANK YOU MISTER
ARAMBULA.
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THIS MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE PALM MEMBERS VOTE
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
ON MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF THOSE WHO DESIRE
TO VOTE -- YEAH -- MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE [inaudible]
THE
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE
ROLE IN TELEVOTE.
I FIFTY FIVE NEWS HERE THIS
MEASURE PASSES
.
FILE ITEMS FIVE THROUGH -- EIGHT
PAST ENTERTAINS WE WILL PASS
TEMPORARILY ON FILE ITEMS NINE
AND TEN FILE ITEMS ELEVEN
THROUGH.
SIXTEEN WILL BE PASSED TO RETAIN
MOVING TO FILE ITEM SEVENTEEN AB
ELEVEN NINETY THE CLERK WILL
READ.
I SOMETHING ELEVEN NINETY BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER IRWIN.
NECKLINE UNMANNED AIRCRAFT.
IS THERE WHEN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
OPEN ON THIS MATTER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I RISE
TODAY TO PRESENT AB ELEVEN
NINETY WHICH SEEKS TO PROVIDE A
STATEWIDE FRAMEWORK FOR DRONE
REGULATION.
CURRENTLY THERE IS A LACK OF
STATEWIDE GUIDANCE AS TO WHERE
WHEN AND HOW UNMANNED AIRCRAFT
SYSTEMS CAN BE OPERATED LEGALLY
AND SAFELY.
BY WORKING WITH INDUSTRY LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AB ELEVEN NINETY SIX
TO PROVIDE A STATEWIDE FRAMEWORK
FOR DRONE REGULATION GOING
FORWARD THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I'VE
OF THANK YOU MISS IRWIN SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
THE MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLLING
TALLIED ABOUT AYE AYES FIFTY
FIVE KNOWS YOUR THIS MEASURE
PASSES.
FILE ITEMS EIGHTEEN THROUGH
TWENTY EIGHT WILL BE PASSING
RETAINS.
MOVING TO FILE ITEM TWENTY NINE
AB ELEVEN FORTY SIX THE CLERK
WILL READ.
AS ONLY WILL ELEVEN FORTY SIX BY
SOMETHING MEMBER BERMAN AND
ACTUALLY PRIVACY.
MR BERMAN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
OPEN ON THIS MATTER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES AB ELEVEN FORTY SIX
WHAT IN STORE THAT A NEW OTOR
VEHICLE DEALER MAY CONTINUE TO
RETAIN.
VEHICLE INFORMATION AND
OWNERSHIP INFORMATION IN ORDER
TO SHARE IT WITH AN AUTOMOBILE
MANUFACTURER FOR THE PURPOSE OF
ENABLING EITHER WARRANTY WORK OR
A SAFETY RECALL.
ALL OTHER PROVISIONS OF OUR
LANDMARK CONSUMER PRIVACY LAW
WOULD REMAIN IN THE FACT
INCLUDING A CONSUMERS RIGHT TO
ACCESS THEIR PERSONAL
INFORMATION. TO KNOW WHAT IS
BEING COLLECTED AND SHARED AND
THE ABILITY TO INVOKE CONSUMER
REMEDIES MY OFFICE IS THAT
PRODUCTIVE CONVERSATIONS WITH
STAKEHOLDERS AND I LOOK FORWARD.
TO CONTINUING TO REFINE THE BILL
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER BERMAN SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THIS MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE.
TO ALONG MEMBERS GO WHO DESIRE
TO VOTE.
ALONG MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
CLICK WELL CLOSE THE ROLLING
TALLY THE VOTE EYES FIFTY THREE
NO ZERO THIS MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEMS THIRTY THROUGH THIRTY
FOUR WE PASS TEMPORARILY.
FILE ITEM.
THIRTY FIVE AB ELEVEN THIRTY
EIGHT THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL ELEVEN THIRTY
EIGHT PRICE ONLY MEMBER
GALLAGHER AND OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY TO BUSINESS.
MISTER GALLAGHER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED OPEN ON THIS MATTER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
AB ELEVEN THIRTY EIGHT A LINE
STATE AND FEDERAL LAW BY
REQUIRING SOCIAL MEDIA PROVIDERS
TO RECEIVE PARENTAL CONSENT
BEFORE ALLOWING MINORS UNDER THE
AGE OF THIRTEEN TO CREATE SOCIAL
MEDIA ACCOUNTS.
I WITH THE AMENDMENTS THAT WE
TOOK PREVIOUSLY ALL OPPOSITION
HAS BEEN REMOVED IS OFFICIALLY
NEUTRAL ON THE BILL.
AND I WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE THE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER GALLAGHER
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THIS MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ON MEMBERS OF THOSE WHO DESIRE
TO VOTE.
ALONG MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALONG MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESERVE
IT.
OUR MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLLING
TALLY THE VOTE AYE AYES FORTY
THREE KNOWS FIVE THIS MEASURE
PASSES.
FILE ITEMS THIRTY SIX TO FORTY
ONE WE PASS TEMPORARILY MOVING
TO FILE ITEM FORTY TWO A. B.
FIVE THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE WITH
AMENDMENTS BY SOME REMEMBER
GONZALEZ.
MISKIN DOLLARS YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU I WANT TO
BE VERY CLEAR MEN GO MORE IN
DEPTH ON THESE AMENDMENTS AND I
USUALLY DO BECAUSE I WANT TO
MAKE SURE EVERYBODY UNDERSTANDS
WHAT WE'RE DOING WITH THIS
IMPORTANT BILL.
AS MANY OF YOU KNOW AB FIVE
CODIFIES THE DYNAMICS ROLLING
INTO STATE LAW.
WILL PROVIDE A CLEAR AND
CONSISTENT STANDARD -- TO
DETERMINE EMPLOYMENT STATUS FOR
ALL WORKER PROTECTION LAWS THIS
BILL HAS AND WILL CONTINUE TO BE
A WORK IN PROGRESS AND IT'S A
BILL THAT WE ACTUALLY HAVE TO
MOVE THIS YEAR.
BY NOT MOVING IT WE SIMPLY ARE
ALLOWING THE SUPREME COURT'S
READING TO APPLY TO EVERYBODY.
THE AMENDMENTS TODAY BEFORE YOU-TODAY WELL ONE EXEMPTS HAIR
STYLISTS AND BARBERS UNDER THE
CONDITION THAT THE WORKER USES
BOOTH RENTALS TO RUN THEIR OWN
SMALL BUSINESS OUR IN OUR FREE
FROM DIRECTION AND CONTROL OF
THIS LAWN.
WHERE THE LEAST THEIR SPACE AND
REQUIRE THAT THEY OBTAIN A
DISPLAY A BOOTH RENTAL PERMIT
SIMILAR TO HOW THEY ALREADY
DISPLAY THEIR LICENSES FOR
BARBERENA IN COSMETOLOGY?
ADDITIONALLY THESE AMENDMENTS
INCLUDING EXEMPTION FOR
INDIVIDUALS CONTRACTING TO
PROVIDE PROFESSIONAL SERVICES
THAT REQUIRE A LICENSE TO
PRACTICE LAW DENTISTRY
ARCHITECTURE ENGINEERING AND
ACCOUNTING OR AN ADVANCED DEGREE
INVITE INVOLVING A SPECIALIZED
COURSE OF STUDY.
IN THE MINISTRATION OF HUMAN
RESOURCES FOR THE FIELD OF
MARKETING.
THE HIRING ENTITY MUST
DEMONSTRATE THE INDIVIDUAL
PROVIDING PROFESSIONAL SERVICES
UNDER THE CONTRACT MAINTAINS A
BUSINESS LOCATION AND HAVE THE
ABILITY TO ENGAGE IN OTHER
CONTRACTS FOR SERVICE.
HAS THE ABILITY SET THEIR OWN
HOURS AMONG OTHER SPECIFIED
CRITERIA.
AND FINALLY THE MEMBERS ALSO
PROVIDE CLARITY FOR REAL ESTATE
LICENSEES ON THE TEST THE
GOVERNOR EMPLOYMENT STATUS.
I HOPE YOU'LL VOTE I ON THESE
AMENDMENTS AND ULTIMATELY I HOPE
YOU REALIZE THAT I I WOULD BE
HAPPY TO DROP THIS BILL
COMPLETELY -- BUT IN FACT THE
CLARITY THAT WE'RE PROVIDING
HELPS ALL BUSINESSES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS GONZALES WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE WILL TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ON THE ADOPTION OF THESE
AMENDMENTS.
ALL THOSE IN FAVOR OF THE
AMENDMENT SAY AYE.
ALL OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE AYES HAVE IT THE AMENDMENTS
ADOPTED THEY'LL BE OUT TO PRINT
AND BACK TO FILE.
FILE ITEM FORTY THREE WILL
TEMPORARILY PASS ON MOVING FILE
ITEM FORTY FOUR EIGHTY NINE THE
CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY WILL NINE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER REYES AND OTHERS
AND ACTUALLY TO EMPLOYMENT.
MISS REYES YOU'RE NOT YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK ON THIS
MATTER THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER
IN NUMBERS.
THE CALIFORNIA FAIR EMPLOYMENT
AND HOUSING ACT IS DESIGNED TO
PROTECT EMPLOYEES FROM WORKPLACE
HARASSMENT.
DISCRIMINATION RETALIATION BASED
ON PROTECT THE CHARACTERISTICS
SUCH AS SEX AND GENDER.
SEXUAL ORIENTATION GENDER
IDENTITY RACE AGE RELIGION
DISABILITY AND MORE.
AB NINE WILL EXTEND THE FILING
REQUIREMENTS FROM ONE YEAR. TO
THREE YEARS FOR BOTH PUBLIC AND
PRIVATE EMPLOYEES TO COME
FORWARD WITH EMPLOYMENT
DISCRIMINATION CLAIMS.
AND TODAY I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS RAZ SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THIS MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MOM MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
ON MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
OF MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE
.
MISS RESIDENTS THE CALL.
FILE ITEMS FORTY FIVE AND FORTY
SIX WOULD PASS TEMPORARILY MOVED
TO FILE ITEM FORTY SEVEN AB
THIRTY SEVEN THE CLERK WILL READ
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY SEVEN BY
SOMETHING MEMBER JONES SAWYER
AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY TAXATION
TO TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY TAX
LEVY.
MISTER JOHN SORRY YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED OPEN ON THIS MATTER
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER A. B.
THIRTY SEVEN WOULD ALLOW
CANNABIS BUSINESS THE FILE AS
SOLE PROPRIETORS OR AS
PARTNERSHIPS TO DEDUCT ORDINARY
NECESSARY BUSINESS EXPENSES.
FROM THEIR PERSONAL INCOME STATE
TAXES THE ABILITY TO DEDUCT
EXPENSES INCURRED WHILE
CONDUCTING BUSINESS ISN'T YOUR
ENJOYED BY ALL LEGITIMATE
BUSINESSES WENT FINDING TAXES.
CAMPUS WHILE LEGAL IN CALIFORNIA
IS STILL A FEDERAL CONTROLLED
SUBSTANCE AS RESULT CAN WAS
BUSINESSES THAT ARE NOT
INCORPORATED ARE TAXED AT HIGHER
RATES THAN ANY OTHER LEGAL
BUSINESS IN THE STATE.
AB THIRTY SEVEN WHAT A LINE TO
CORPORATE AND THE PERSONAL TAX
CODE TO ALLOW LEGAL CAMPUS
VISITS TODAY DOT LEGITIMATE
OPERATIONAL EXPENSES.
AB THIRTY SEVEN WILL HELP CAMPUS
BUSINESSES AND A LEGAL INDUSTRY
AND OUT OF THE ILLEGAL MARKET
MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE BOAT.
THANK YOU MISTER JONES SAWYER
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THIS MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
LONG MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLLING
TALLY THE EYES FORTY SEVEN NO
ZERO THIS MEASURE PASSES.
THE FILE ITEM FORTY EIGHT AB
FORTY ONE THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL FORTY ONE BY
FAMILY MEMBER GALLAGHER AND
OTHERS AND I CLING TO DISASTER
RELIEF DECLARING THEIR TO SEE
THEIR UP TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY.
MR GALLERY YEAR RECOGNIZED OPEN
ON THIS MATTER.
YES THANK YOU MAN SPEAKER
MEMBERS I'M PROUD TO PRESENT TO
YOU AB FORTY ONE WHICH WOULD
REQUIRE THE STATE TO COVER THE
LOCAL PORTION OF THE CLEAN UP
AND REPAIR COSTS.
ASSOCIATED WITH THE CAMPFIRE --
BY REQUIRING THE STATE TO COVER
THESE LOCAL COSTS IT WILL HELP%
US.
HELP OUR COMMUNITIES REBUILD IN
THE AFTERMATH OF THE MOST
DEVASTATING WILDFIRE IN
CALIFORNIA HISTORY I WANT TO
THANK MY COLLEAGUES WHO HAVE
BEEN.
SO HELPFUL AND IN IN HELPING US
RECOVER HAVE BEEN VERY SUPPORT
OF THIS THIS MEASURES RECEIVE
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT.
THROUGHOUT THE PROCESS AND ASK
FOR YOUR AYE THE THIS MORNING
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER
GALLAGHER.
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THIS MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ON NUMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
HOW LONG MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE?
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TELLING THE VOTE.
ON THE URGENCY AYE AYES FIFTY
NINE NO ZERO ON THE BILL ICE
FIFTY NINE NEWS HERE THIS
MEASURE PASSES.
WE FILE ITEM FORTY NINE AB FORTY
FOR THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL FORTY FOUR WITH
AMENDMENTS BY SELLING MEMBER
FRIEDMAN.
MS FRIEDMAN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
SPEAK ON THIS MATTER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER -- I
RISE TODAY FOR THE PURPOSE OF
ADDING SIMPLE CLARIFYING
AMENDMENTS TO AB FORTY FOUR
THESE AMENDMENTS WOULD CLARIFY
THE DEFINITION OF FOR AND USED.
FOR PROVIDE AN EXEMPTION FOR THE
SKINS AND HEALTH OF ANIMALS
PERVERTS PRESERVE THROUGH
TAXIDERMY PROVIDE AN EXEMPTION
FROM THE RECORDING KEEPING
REQUIREMENT FOR PAWN SHOPS AND
OTHER SECOND HAND SELLERS.
THAT USE CALIFORNIA UPON AND
SECONDHAND DEALERS SYSTEM AND
ADDS A SERVES US SEVERABILITY
CLAUSE I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
YOUR AYE VOTE ON THESE
CLARIFYING AMENDMENTS TO THE
BILL CAN GO OUT TO PRINT AND
BACK ON FILE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS FRIEDMAN.
MR FOR YOU ARE RECOGNIZED IN
THIS MATTER.
MADAM SPEAKER WE OPPOSE THESE
AMENDMENTS ASK FOR A ROLL CALL
VOTE OKAY THANK YOU MISTER FOR
MISTER CHOI YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
ON THIS MATTER.
MR TRY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED IN
THIS MATTER.
THANK YOU SPEAKER AND A MEMBERS
SAW -- YA STANDING IN OPPOSITION
OF WHAT AB POLE FORTY FOUR
COLLEAGUES SO MISTER CHOI THIS
IS JUST ON AMENDMENTS WOULD YOU
LIKE TO SPEAK ON THE AMENDMENTS.
ALL AMENDMENTS [inaudible]
THANK.
WE WILL TAKE A ROLL CALL VOTEON
THE ADOPTION OF THESE AMENDMENTS.
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL THOSE WHO DESIRE TO GO
PLEASE VOTE.
ALL THOSE WHO DESIRED -- PLEASE
VOTE.
THIS IS ON THE AMENDMENTS.
ALL THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE
PLEASE VOTE [inaudible]
OKAY.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE WE NEED A
MAJORITY OF THOSE PRESENT AND
VOTING AYE AYES FORTY ONE KNOWS
TWELVE THE AMENDMENTS.
ARE ADOPTED THEY ARE OUT TO
PRINT AND BACK TO FILE
[inaudible]
FILE.
MOVING FILE ITEM FIFTY AB FORTY
FIVE THE CLERK WILL READ
ASSEMBLY BILL FORTY FIVE BY SOME
THE MEMBER MARK STONE AND OTHERS
AND ACTUALLY TO INMATES.
MR STONE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED OPEN
ON THIS MATTER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS ABOUT TWENTY YEARS AGO.
THIS FOR FOR DEALING WITH THE
MEDICAL SITUATION CAUGHT UP WITH
THOSE WHO ARE ON THE INSIDE OF
PRISONS AND WE DECIDED AS A
STATE TO REQUIRE PRISONERS TO
PAY COPAYS BEFORE THEY GET
ACCESS TO MEDICAL BENEFITS.
THE RESEARCH OF THE LAST TWENTY
YEARS SHOWS THAT THIS IS
ENTIRELY INEFFECTIVE IN IN FACT
CREATES A SIGNIFICANT BARRIER TO
DELIVERY OF HEALTHCARE. TO THOSE
WHO ARE INSIDE PRISONS AND JAILS.
CALIFORNIA APARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS REHABILITATION JUST
ENDED THIS PRACTICE A FEW WEEKS
AGO BECAUSE THE REALITY IS WHEN
INMATES ARE MAKING EIGHT CENTS
AN HOUR.
A CO PAY A FIVE DOLLARS IS A
WEEK'S WORTH OF PAY.
THIS BILL REMOVES THE STATUTORY
AUTHORITY FOR THE STATE'S EVER
IMPLEMENT THAT AGAIN AND REMOVES
THE STATUTORY AUTHORITY FOR
LOCAL JAILS AS WELL HAVE TALKED
TO A NUMBER OF SHARES ABOUT THIS.
AND THERE ARE FEW SHARE STILL
CHARGING A FEW COUNTY STILL
CHARGING COPAYS A NUMBER DO NOT
BECAUSE IN NONE OF THE CASES
DOES THE COLLECTION.
PAY OFF THE ADMINISTRATIVE
EXPENSE OF IMPLEMENTING THAT
PROGRAM.
AND THE RESEARCH SHOWS THAT
THERE COPAYS OR NOT AT ALL AN
IMPEDIMENT TO FRIVOLOUS VISITS
THAT THERE ARE OTHER WAYS THAT
SHARES CAN MANAGE.
THOSE KINDS OF PROGRAMS.
THIS BILL IS.
GOOD POLICY THIS BILL WILL
ENSURE THAT PEOPLE WHO ARE
INSIDE EITHER JAILS AND PRISONS
GET ACCESS TO THE MEDICAL CARE
THAT THEY NEED WHEN THEY NEED IT.
THEREBY REDUCING MEDICAL COSTS
IN THE FUTURE AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR IT EITHER.
THANK YOU MISTER STANDS SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THIS MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRED OF
THE ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE
TO VOTE.
ON MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
CITING NEEDS FORTY ONE ALL
MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
MISTER SAM IS THE CALL.
FILE ITEMS FIFTY ONE THROUGH
FIFTY FIVE WILL BE PASS
TEMPORARILY.
THE FILE ITEM FIFTY SIX AB ONE
THIRTY SIX THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE THIRTY SIX
WITH AMENDMENTS BY SOMETHING
MEMBER QUIRK SILVA.
IS QUIRK SILVA YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED ON THIS MATTER THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND MEMBERS
ARE RIGHTS FOR PURPOSES OF
AMENDMENTS ON AB.
ONE THIRTY SIX THE AMENDMENT
SPECIFICALLY ADD LANGUAGE TO
INCLUDE TAX SCHEMES MADE THROUGH
BUSINESS EXPENSES OR TRADE.
URGES THE CALIFORNIA FRANCHISE
TAX BOARD TO ALSO INVESTIGATE
ANY ON LAWFUL DEDUCTIONS THAT
MAY HAVE BEEN TAKEN BY
CORPORATIONS ON THEIR CORPORATE
TAX RETURNS DEFINES FINAL
DETERMINATION OF GUILT.
AND ADDS ALL CRIMINAL COMPLAINT
CASE NUMBERS ASSOCIATED WITH THE
COLLEGE ADMISSIONS SCANDAL I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS QUIRK SILVA
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE [inaudible]
ON ALL MEMBERS SAID WHO DESIRE
TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED DESIRED ABOUT
THIS IS ON THE AMENDMENTS.
ON MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS GO TO DO THAT I
WOULD VOTE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE
ROLE IN TALLY THE VOTE AYE AYES
FORTY ONE NEWS HERE WE NEED A
MAJORITY OF THOSE PRESENT IN
VOTING THESE AMENDMENTS ARE
ADOPTED THEIR OUT TO PRINT IN
BACK TO FILE -- IF I LET HIM
FIFTY SEVEN AB ONE THIRTY NINE
THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE THIRTY NINE BY
SONY MEMBER QUIRK SILVA AND
ACTUALLY TO HOUSING.
MISS QUIRK SILVA YOUR AGAIN
RECOGNIZED ON THIS MATTER.
YES THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKERS AND
MEMBERS TODAY I AM PRESENTING AB
ONE THIRTY NINE THE EMERGENCY
AND TRANSITIONAL HOUSING ACT
MEMBERS WE KNOW THAT WE ARE IN A
CRISIS.
THIS YEAR AND WILL CONTINUE TO
BE AND LESS WE ACT ON HOUSING AS
THE HOMELESSNESS CRISIS IN
CALIFORNIA CONTINUES WE NEED
EVERY COMMUNITY DID ASSESS THE
NEED FOR EMERGENCY SO.
EMERGENCY AND TRANSITIONAL
HOUSING THIS BILL UPDATES
CALIFORNIA'S HOUSING ELEMENT LAW
TO REFLECT THE STATE'S HOMELESS
CRISIS AND THE NEED FOR EVERY
COMMUNITY TO BETTER ASSESS THE
NUMBER OF INDIVIDUALS AND
FAMILIES FACING HOMELESSNESS.
AND IMPLEMENT MORE TARGETED
TRANSITION STRATEGIES TO LONG
TERM PERMANENT HOUSING FOR THESE
CALIFORNIA'S MEMBERS WE HAVE
COUNTIES THAT ARE UNDER COUNTY
IN THEIR HOMELESS.
NUMBERS WE HAVE SCHOOL DISTRICTS
THAT ARE UNDER COUNTING THEIR
STUDENTS WHO ARE HOMELESS AND
LESS WE HAVE AN ACCURATE COUNT
FOR THESE NUMBERS WE WILL NOT BE
ABLE TO PROVIDE THE HOUSING THAT
IS NECESSARY.
THIS BILL WOULD REQUIRE A LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO IDENTIFY AND ZONE
ENOUGH SITES TO ACCOMMODATE IT'S
EXTREMELY LOW INCOME REGIONAL
HOUSING NEEDS.
AND REFLECT THE MOST RECENT
HOMELESS POINT IN TIME.
MEMBERS THIS IS A VITAL NUMBER.
THAT WE MUST ADDRESS IN OUR
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS MUST PLAN FOR
HOUSING.
THIS BILL ENJOYS BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT IN AS RECEIVE NO NO
VOTES I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU.
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THIS MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE WRONG.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE AYE AYES FIFTY
SEVEN NEWS HERE THIS MEASURE
PASSES.
FILE ITEM FIFTY EIGHT WILL BE
PASS TEMPORARILY MOVING TO FILE
AND FIFTY NINE AB ONE NINETY
FIVE THE CLERK WILL READ
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE NINETY FIVE
BUY SOMETHING MEMBER PATTERSON
AND ACTUALLY TO HOUSING.
MISTER PATTERSON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER -- MEMBERS AB ONE NINETY
FIVE IMPLEMENTS A NUMBER OF
RECOMMENDATIONS BY THE STATE
AUDITOR. TO IMPROVE REPORTING
PROCEDURES BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT.
LAST YEAR THE AUDITOR FOUND THE
DEPARTMENT DID NOT OBTAIN THE
REQUIRED PERFORMANCE REPORTS.
DID NOT PERFORM ON SITE
MONITORING FOR ITS GRANT BASED
PROGRAMS AND THAT LACKS
OVERSIGHT MAY HAVE PREVENTED
INDIVIDUALS AND FAMILIES IN NEED.
FROM OBTAINING TIMELY ASSISTANCE
THIS IS AN ACCOUNTABILITY
MEASURE THAT WILL ENSURE THAT
THE MONEY FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING
ACTUALLY GOES. TO AFFORDABLE
HOUSING THIS BILL PASSED OUT OF
THE ASSEMBLY HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT COMMITTEE
ON CONSENT HAS ENJOYED UNANIMOUS
SUPPORT HAS NO OPPOSITION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER PATTERSON.
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THIS MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF THOSE WHO DESIRE
[inaudible]
TO CLERK WILL.
CLOSE THE ROLE IN TELEVOTE EYES
FIFTY NINE KNOWS YOUR THIS
MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING TO FILE ITEM SIXTY AB ONE
NINETY SIX THE CLERK WILL READ
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE NINETY SIX BY
SOMETHING MEMBER GONZALEZ AND
ACTUALLY THE PAID FAMILY LEAVE
MAKING A PREPARATION THEREFORE.
MISS CONSEILLERS YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED OPEN ON THIS MATTER.
THANK YOU SPEAKER I'M PROUD TO
BE PRESENTING A WOMEN'S CAUCUS
PARITY BILL AB ONE NINETY SIX
WHICH WOULD ENSURE ALL WORKERS
USING THE STATE'S PAID FAMILY
PROGRAM COULD ACTUALLY USE IT.
RIGHT NOW THE INCOME REPLACEMENT
FOR WOMEN -- ARM MEN WHO GO OUT
I'M PAID FAMILY LEAVE IS 6270%
OF THEIR SALARY THAT MEANS IF
YOU'RE A MINIMUM WAGE WORKER FOR
YOU TO BE ABLE TO LIVE ON 6270%
OF YOUR SALARY ESPECIALLY WHEN
YOU'VE JUST HAD A BABY.
I'M WOULD BE NECESSARY FOR YOU
TO UTILIZE THAT LEAVE NONE THE
LESS THESE THESE LOW INCOME --
MEN AND WOMEN WHO ARE PAYING END
THROUGH PAYROLL TAX ARE READY TO
THIS PROGRAM WHAT THIS WOULD DO
IS SAY THAT YOU GET A 100%
INCOME REPLACEMENT FROM THAT
SAME FUND.
NO ADDITIONAL COSTS -- FOR THOSE
FOR SIX WEEKS.
THIS IS A GOOD BALLOTS ENJOYED
SOME BIPARTISAN SUPPORT NIGHT
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS GONZALES.
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THIS MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE [inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE THE ROLE IN TELEVOTE EYES
FIFTY KNOWS THREE THIS MEASURE
PASSES.
WE TO FILE ITEM SIXTY ONE A. B.
TWO OH NINE THE CLERK WILL READ.
THAT'S ON THE BILL TWO OH NINE
BY SOME REMEMBER LIMóN AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY TO PARKS.
SIMONE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED OPEN
ON THIS MATTER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AB TWO
OH NINE ESTABLISHES THE OUTDOOR
EQUITY GRANT FUNDING PROGRAM AT
THE DEPARTMENT OF PARKS AND
RECREATION TO INCREASE THE
ABILITY OF UNDERSERVED AN
ASTERISK.
POPULATIONS TO PERSIST THE BAIT
AND OUTDOOR ENVIRONMENTAL
EDUCATION PROGRAMS THE BILL DOES
ALLOW FOR ANYONE IN THE STATE TO
APPLY FOR THESE GRANTS.
STUDIES HAVE FOUND THAT STUDENTS
TO PARTICIPATE IN AFTER
EDUCATION PROGRAMS EXPERIENCE
STRONG INCREASE IN SCIENCE TEST
SCORES AND IMPROVEMENTS IN
CONFLICT RESOLUTION PROBLEM
SOLVING AND LEARNING MOTIVATION.
AB TWO OH NINE HAS NO OPPOSITION
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS THE MON SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THIS MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLLING
TALLY THE VOTE AYE AYES FIFTY
FIVE NO ZERO THIS MEASURE PASSES.
WHEN A FILE ITEM SIXTY TWO A. B.
TWO THIRTEEN THE CLERK WILL READ
ASSEMBLY BILL TWO THIRTEEN BY
SOMETHING MEMBER REYES AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT FINANCE?
STRESS YOU ARE RECOGNIZED OPEN
ON THISMATTER THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS AB TWO THIRTEEN
IS A MEASURE BUILT ON FAIRNESS.
REVENUES WHICH WERE PREVIOUSLY
ALLOCATED TO CITIES IT ANNEXED
INHABITED TERRITORIES.
WERE TAKEN AWAY IN TWO THOUSAND
ELEVEN DURING CALIFORNIA'S
RECESSION OVER ONE HUNDRED AND
FORTY ANNEXED CITIES LOST
REVENUE DUE TO THIS LEGISLATION.
AB TWO THIRTEEN RESTORES
REVENUES MOVING FORWARD FOR THE
CITY'S MAKING THEM WHOLE BASED
ON AN EXPECTATION THAT THEY
COULD USE THESE FUNDS TO PROVIDE
SERVICE SUCH AS EXPANSIONS.
AND PUBLIC SAFETY TO THEIR NEW
RESIDENTS THIS BILL THIS BILL
HAS RECEIVED UNANIMOUS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS RAY S. MISTER
GALLAGHER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED ON
THIS MATTER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I RISE
IN SUPPORT OF THIS LEGISLATION
THIS IS ABOUT FAIRNESS MEMBERS
IN ENSURING THAT.
THESE JURISDICTIONS WHO WERE
PROMISED THESE THESE MONIES AND
THAT THIS WOULD BE REALLOCATED
FAIRLY IN ACCORDINGLY SO I I ASK
FOR YOUR AYE THE THANK YOU
MISTER GALLAGHER STRESS WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU I'VE A MISS SMITH.
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ON MEMBERS VOTED DESIRED BURKE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TELLING THAT I SIXTY ONE KNOWS
YOUR THIS MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM SIXTY THREE TO SIXTY
FIVE WILL BE PASS TEMPORARILY --
IN FILE ITEM SIXTY SIX AB TWO
FIFTY EIGHT THE CLERK WILL READ.
SOME ABLE TO FIFTY EIGHT BY
SELLING MEMBER JONES SAWYER AND
ACTUALLY THE PEOPLE HEALTH AND
MAKING A PREPARATION THERE.
FOR MISTER JONES ARE YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED OPEN ON THIS MATTER
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I RISE
TO PRESENT AB TWO FIVE EIGHT A
BILL THAT WERE USED FUND FROM
PROP SIXTY POOR.
AIR MARK FOR TREATMENT AND
PREVENTION TO FUND SUSTAINABLE
SCHOOL HEALTH AND MENTAL HEALTH
PROGRAM.
THIS BILL ADDRESSES THE NEED FOR
ADDITIONAL SCHOOL SUPPORT
SERVICES THE BILL IS STRUCTURED
SUCH THAT GRANTS WILL LEVERAGE
ADDITIONAL FEDERAL RESOURCES
SPECIFICALLY A 50% FEDERAL
REIMBURSEMENT FOR MEDI CAL
ELIGIBLE SERVICES.
CURRENT RATIOS OF SUPPORT STAFF
ARE TERRIBLE WITH ONE COUNSELOR.
FOR EVERY SIX HUNDRED EIGHTY
STUDENTS ONE NURSE FOR EVERY TWO
THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED STUDENTS
AND ONE SOCIAL WORKER FOR EVERY
NINE THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED
STUDENTS.
THIS BILL WILL PROVIDE GRANTS TO
ALLOW SCHOOL TO MAKE THEIR OWN
DECISIONS WHAT SERVICES BEST FIT
THE NEEDS OF THEIR STUDENTS.
THIS BILL HAS RECEIVE UNANIMOUS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK THE AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER JONES SAWYER
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THIS MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE WRONG.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRED
BURKE WELL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE AYE AYES FIFTY
NINE NEWS HERE THIS MEASURE
PASSES.
WIENER FILE ITEM SIXTY SEVEN AB
TWO SIXTY THREE THE CLERK WILL
READ ASSEMBLY BILL TWO SIXTY
THREE BY FAMILY MEMBER BURKE AND
ACTUALLY TO TAXATION.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED OPEN ON THIS
MATTER THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS AB TWO SIXTY THREE
WILL EXPAND THE EXISTING
REQUIREMENT UNDER REVENUE AND
TAXATION CODE SECTION. FORTY ONE
TO ALL TAX EXPENDITURES UNDER
THE PERSONAL INCOME TAX LINE
CORPORATION TAX LAW IN GENERAL
EXISTING LAW REQUIRES THAT ALL
NEW TAX CREDITS CONTAINS
SPECIFIC GOALS.
PURPOSES AND OBJECTIVES ALONG
WITH DETAILED AND PERFORMANCE
INDICATORS FOR THE LEGISLATOR
FOR TO USE WHEN EVALUATING THE
TAX CREDITS EFFECTIVENESS.
THESE REQUIREMENTS ARE
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT WHICH IS
WHY THE REVENUE IN TAX COMMITTEE
HAS MADE IT A PRACTICE TO IMPOSE
THEM ON ALL NEW EXPENDITURES NOT
JUST TAX CREDITS.
AB TWO SIXTY THREE ENJOYED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND HAS NOT
RECEIVED A SINGLE NO VOTE I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE.
THANK YOU SOMEONE MEMBER BURKE
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THIS MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE WRONG.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY VOTE AYE AYES FIFTY THREE
KNOWS ONE THIS MEASURE PASSES.
BY LATE IN SIXTY EIGHT PASS
TEMPORARILY MOVING TO FILE ITEM
SIXTY NINE AB TWO EIGHTY NINE
THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWO EIGHTY NINE BY
SOMETHING MEMBER FONG AND OTHERS
AND ACTUALLY THE PUBLIC RECORDS
MAKING APPROPRIATION THEREFORE.
YOU'RE FINE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
OPEN ON THIS MAP.
I THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER
MEMBERS IS MY PLEASURE TO
PRESENT.
AB TWO EIGHTY NINE CURRENTLY
STATE AGENCIES CAN DENY
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC RECORDS ACT
REQUEST KNOWING THAT THERE IS NO
APPEALS OPTION OTHER THAN TO SUE
THE AGENCY IN COURT WHICH IS NOT
FEASIBLE AND TO COSTLY FOR MANY
IN THE PUBLIC.
THIS BILL ADDRESSES THIS PROBLEM
BY ESTABLISHING AND I'M ON BUT
THE PERSON WHO CAN REVIEW THE
DENIED PUBLIC RECORDS ACT
REQUEST AND SERVE AS AN
INDEPENDENT REFEREE. TO THE SIDE
OF THE STATE AGENCY HAD A
LEGITIMATE GROUNDS FOR DENYING
THE REQUEST.
AB TWENTY NINE ADDRESSES A
LOOPHOLE IN THE PUBLIC RECORDS
ACT PROCESS SO THEY CAN DO IT SO
THAT IT CAN DO WHAT IT WAS
INTENDED TO DO WHICH IS TO BRING
TRANSPARENCY.
FAIRNESS AND ACCOUNTABILITY TO
OUR GOVERNMENT.
THE BILL HAS RECEIVED UNANIMOUS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT THIS FAR AND
IS SUPPORTED BY MEDIA
ORGANIZATIONS SUCH AS THE SAID
AS SUCH AS A SAN DIEGO UNION
TRIBUNE AND THE LA DAILY NEWS.
I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO THANK MY
DISTINGUISHED COLLEAGUE ARBEL
CHAIRWOMAN OF THAT PUBLISHES
COMMITTEE FOR JOINT AUTHORIZED
JOINT AUTHORING THE SUPPORT
MEASURE WITH ME I REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER FONG SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THIS MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF THOSE WHO DESIRE
TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE I SIXTY THREE
KNOWS HERE THIS MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM SEVENTY WILL BE PASS
TEMPORARILY MOVING TO VIOLATE IN
SEVENTY ONE AB THREE OH TO THE
CLERK WILL READ ASSEMBLY BILL
THREE OH TWO BY FAMILY MEMBER
BERMAN AND OTHERS AND I PLAN TO
COMMUNITY COLLEGES [inaudible]
THE TERM.
MR BERMAN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
OPEN ON THIS MATTER THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES.
A RECENT REPORT WHICH SURVEYED
NEARLY FORTY THOUSAND STUDENTS
AT FIFTY SEVEN COMMUNITY
COLLEGES ACROSS CALIFORNIA FOUND
THAT 19% OF RESPONDENTS
EXPERIENCE HOMELESSNESS.
IN THE PREVIOUS YEAR.
THIS TRANSLATE TO NEARLY FOUR
HUNDRED THOUSAND COMMUNITY
COLLEGE STUDENTS STATEWIDE.
THIS NOT THIS NUMBER IS NOT ONLY
SHOCKING AND TRAGIC BUT IT'S A
CALL TO ACTION.
THIS IS WHY I INTRODUCED AB
THREE OH TWO WHICH WOULD REQUIRE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES TO GRANT
OVERNIGHT ACCESS TO THEIR
PARKING FACILITIES FOR HOMELESS
STUDENTS TO SLEEP IN THEIR
VEHICLES.
UNDER AB THREE OR TWO EACH
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT WILL
BE PROVIDED BROAD FLEXIBILITY TO
DEVELOP AN IMPLEMENTATION PLAN
THAT MEETS THEIR LOCAL NEEDS AND
CIRCUMSTANCES.
THE HARSH REALITY IS A COMMUNITY
COLLEGE STUDENTS ARE ALREADY
SLEEPING IN THEIR VEHICLES WHILE
WE WORK ON A LONG TERM APPROACH
OF BUILDING MORE HOUSING.
AB THREE OH TWO IS A STEP WE CAN
TAKE NOW TO ALLEVIATE THE FEAR
AND SUFFERING THAT HOMELESS
STUDENTS ARE FACING TONIGHT.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER BERMAN SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THIS MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THEIR OWN.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
CLERK WELL CLOSE THE ROLE AND
TALLY THE VOTE AYE AYES FIFTY
ONE KNOWS FIVE THIS MEASURE
PASSES.
FILE ITEM SEVENTY TWO WILL PASS
TEMPORARILY.
THE FILE ITEM SEVENTY THREE AB
THREE FOURTEEN THE CLERK WILL
READ ASSEMBLY BILL THREE
FOURTEEN BY SOMETHING MEMBER
BONTA AND ACTUALLY TO PUBLIC
EMPLOYMENT.
MR BONTA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED OPEN
ON THIS MATTER THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES.
AB THREE FOURTEEN WOULD CREATE
UNIFORMITY CONSISTENCY AND
CERTAINTY ACROSS ALL OF
CALIFORNIA'S PUBLIC SECTOR LABOR
RELATIONS LAWS BY GRANTING ALL
PUBLIC EMPLOYEES.
EQUAL RIGHTS TO RESEMBLE PAID
TIME OFF TO ENGAGE IN SPECIFIED
ACTIVITIES RELATED TO EMPLOYER
EMPLOYEE RELATIONS.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER BONTA SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THIS MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
LONG MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
CLICK WELL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TELEVOTE EYES FORTY THREE KNOWS
FOURTEEN THIS MEASURE PASSES.
WHEN FILE ITEM SEVENTY FOUR AB
THREE TWENTY NINE THE CLERK WILL
READ ASSEMBLY BILL THREE TWENTY
NINE BY SOMETHING MEMBER
RODRIGUEZ AND ACTUALLY THE
HOSPITALS?
MISTER RODRIGUEZ YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED OPEN ON THIS MATTER
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
SB THREE TWENTY NINE WOULD
ADDRESS INCONSISTENCIES AND
PENALTIES. FOR ASSAULTS VERSES
BATTERY COMMITTED AGAINST ALL
HEALTH CARE WORKERS ON THE
HOSPITAL PROPERTY WHEN VIOLENCE
OCCURS IN THE HOSPITAL PATIENTS
CAN BE INJURED OR TRAUMATIZED TO
THE POINT THAT THEY LEAVE.
AND DO NOT GET SEEN IT CAN ALSO
INCREASE WAIT TIMES AND DISTRACT
EMERGENCY STAFF FROM FOCUSING ON
OTHER PATIENTS WHO URGENTLY
REQUIRE MEDICAL ASSISTANCE WE
MUST PROTECT OUR PATIENTS BUT
ALSO MAKE SURE.
OUR HOSPITAL STAFF IS TAKEN CARE
OF THANK YEAR STRUCK ROUTE FRY
WROTE.
THANK YOU MISTER RODRIGUEZ
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THIS MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE WRONG.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ON MEMBERS GO TO DESIRED VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TELLING VOTE AYE AYES FIFTY
EIGHT KNOWS HERE THIS MEASURE
PASSES.
WE ARE PREPARED TO LIFT THE CALL
AND FILE ITEM FORTY FOUR AB.
NINE THE CLERK WILL POST.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ON MEMBERS VOTE HE DESIRED VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THAT ICE FORTY SIX KNOWS
THREE THIS MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING TO FILE ITEM SEVENTY FIVE
AB THREE THIRTY ONE THE CLERK
WILL READ.
A SOME OF ALL THREE THIRTY ONE
BY SOMETHING MEMBER MEDINA AND
OTHERS AND EXPLAIN TO PEOPLE
INSTRUCTION.
MR MEDINA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
OPEN ON THIS MATTER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER IN
MEMBERS TODAY I PRESENT ASSEMBLY
BILL.
THREE THIRTY ONE A BILL THAT
WILL REQUIRE AN CHORUS OF ETHNIC
STUDIES. TO BE A HIGH SCHOOL
GRADUATION REQUIREMENTS.
BEGINNING IN THE SCHOOL YEAR.
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR TWENTY TWENTY
FIVE STUDIES HAVE PROVEN THAT
THE EFFECT ON STUDENTS WITH THE
COURSE.
IN ETHNIC STUDIES IMPROVES NOT
ONLY ATTENDANCE BUT ACADEMIC
ACHIEVEMENT.
THIS MEASURE IS SUPPORTED BY THE
ASIAN PACIFIC ISLANDER
LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS.
THE LEGISLATIVE LATINO CAUCUS
THE LEGISLATIVE BLACK CAUCUS.
AND THE LEGISLATIVE JEWISH
CAUCUS.
AS WELL AS BY THE NATIVE
AMERICAN CAUCUS.
YESTERDAY AS WE TALKED ABOUT.
CHARTER SCHOOLS WE BROUGHT UP
THE IMPORTANCE.
OF THE LA STUDENT WALK OUT IN
NINETEEN SIXTY EIGHT BY LATINO
STUDENTS.
WE CELEBRATE MANY.
HOLIDAYS IN THIS CHAMBER.
WE HAVE MANY.
COMMEMORATIONS OF HISTORICAL
EVENTS.
BUT YET WHEN WE CELEBRATED HERE
WE DON'T GIVE HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS THE SAME OPPORTUNITY TO
LEARN ABOUT THOSE SAME EVENTS.
VERY RECENTLY THE CONNECTICUT
LEGISLATURE.
PASSED A BILL TO MAKE.
LATINO AND BLACK STUDIES.
OFFERING IT TO THE CONNECTICUT
STUDENTS.
AND WHEN THEY DID THAT ONE OF
THE MEMBERS ON THAT CHAMBER GOT
UP.
ANY PAPER CLIPPED.
A VERY CURRENT US HISTORY BOOK
THAT IS USED IN IN CONNECTICUT.
THE PAPER CLIP HOW MANY PAGES
[inaudible]
FOCUSED ON AFRICAN AMERICAN
HISTORY.
IN THIS COUNTRY.
AND I CAN TELL YOU I HAVEN'T
BEEN A U. S. HISTORY TEACHER
THAT IS VERY FEW PAGES
[inaudible]
WE ARE [inaudible]
IN A STATE LIKE CALIFORNIA WITH
SUCH DIVERSITY.
IT IS BEYONDTIME THAT ALL
STUDENTS ARE GIVEN THE
OPPORTUNITY. TO LEARN ESSENTIAL
HISTORY OF THIS STATE AND THIS
NATION.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE
ON A. B..
THREE THIRTY ONE YOU MISTER
MEDINA DOCTOR WEBER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK ON THIS
MATTER.
YES I REALIZE IS A PROUD CO
AUTHOR OF AB -- THREE THIRTY ONE
THAT WOULD BRING ETHNIC STUDIES
TO A HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS YEAH
WE'VE TALKED A LOT IN THIS IN AS
POINTED OUT BY THE AUTHOR WE'VE
TALKED A LOT IN THIS HOUSE ABOUT
ETHNIC STUDIES AND CELEBRATING
BLACK HISTORY MONTH API MONTH
WITH THAT YOU KNOW THE CHICANO
MONTH.
WE GO ON AND ON WITH THIS
DISCUSSION AND BECOMES NO MORE
THAN RELIGIOUS CEREMONIAL
STATEMENT AND IF WE REALLY
BELIEVE THAT ARE THAT WE NEED A
HISTORY THAT IS UPDATED THAT OUR
CHILDREN NEED TO UNDERSTAND THE
TOLD TOTAL HISTORY OF CALIFORNIA.
AND THE WONDER AND BEAUTY OF ITS
DIVERSITY AS WELL AS WHAT IT HAS
DONE WHEN IT HAS BEEN
IMPLEMENTED. TO RESTORE
CONFIDENCE IN STUDENTS THEN WE
NEED TO DO THIS THIS IS VERY
VERY IMPORTANT.
YOU KNOW THIS PAST WEEKEND I WAS
HONORED BY MY STUDENTS OF THE
UNIVERSITY FOR FORTY YEARS OF OF
DEVELOPING A PROGRAM CALLED THE
BLACK BACCALAUREATE.
AND ONE OF THE THINGS I WAS
INTERESTED IN I WAS INTERESTING
IN LISTENING TO MY STUDENTS WHO
CAME FROM ALL AREAS ACROSS THE
NATION FOR THE CELEBRATION IT'S
AN EAGLE STATE.
WAS THEY TALKED ABOUT SOMETIMES
HOW JUST HAVING THE INFORMATION
FOR THE FIRST TIME IN THEIR
LIVES.
BEING ABLE TO BE IN AN ETHNIC
STUDIES CLASS AT THE UNIVERSITY
MANY OF THEM WISH THEY'D HAD IT
IN HIGH SCHOOL.
BUT HAVING IT CHANGED THEIR
PERSPECTIVE OF WHAT THEIR
MISSION WAS IN LIFE AND HOW THEY
GOT SOMEHOW ANOTHER THE
CONFIDENCE AND THE COURAGE. TO
BASICALLY CHALLENGE THEMSELVES
IN THE FIELDS OF ENGINEERING AND
SO MANY OTHER AREAS AND SO I I
LOOK AT THAT AND IT WAS REALLY A
WONDERFUL EXPERIENCE AS
CONTINUING TO SAY.
HOW IMPORTANT ETHNIC STUDIES WAS
WITH THEM AT THE COLLEGE LEVEL
AND THEY WISH THEY'D HAD IT
EARLIER?
WE PASSED A RESOLUTION IN THIS
FOR WHEN I FIRST CAME HERE SOME
SEVEN YEARS AGO.
AND THAT RESOLUTION WAS A
CELEBRATION OF ETHNIC STUDIES
AND SOME OF YOU WERE HERE AT
THAT TIME REMEMBER THAT MANY OF
THE MEMBERS ON THE FLOOR.
GOT UP AND TALKED ABOUT HOW
IMPORTANT THIS INFORMATION WAS
IN MOTIVATING THEM TO STAY IN
COLLEGE AND TO MOVE FORWARD AND
TO BECOME THE PROFESSIONALS THEY
BECAME.
NOT ONLY WAS IT THAT THAT THE
AFRICAN AMERICANS AND HISPANIC
FACULTY MEMBERS WERE HERE SAYING
THIS BUT WE HAD MANY OF YOU WHO
WOULD NOT MANY OF OUR WHITE
COLLEAGUES TALKED ABOUT.
HOW HAVING THAT INFORMATION WAS
SO IMPORTANT IN SHAPING WHO THEY
BECAME IN THEIR VIEW OF
CALIFORNIAN THE BUTTE VIEW OF
THE U. S.?
SO I STRONGLY RECOMMEND THAT WE
FINALLY STEPPED FORWARD.
AND DO THIS FIRST STEP IN TERMS
OF REQUIRING ETHNIC STUDIES IN
OUR HIGH SCHOOLS BECAUSE IT WILL
DEFINITELY CHANGE THE
PERSPECTIVE OF A HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS AND WHEN IT HAS BEEN
THOROUGHLY IMPLEMENTED WE SEE
THAT IT CHANGES.
THE BEHAVIOR THE ACADEMIC
EXCELLENCE ALL THOSE THINGS
CHANGE BECAUSE IT IMPROVES THE
PERSPECTIVE OF THAT STUDENT IN
HOW THEY FIT IN THIS WORLD AND
WHAT THEIR MISSION IS.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK THE AYE BILL
FOR AB THREE THIRTY ONE THANK
YOU DOCTOR RUBBER MISS RAMOS YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED ON THIS MATTER
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES I ALSO RISE IN
SUPPORT OF AB.
THREE THREE ONE I THANK MY
COLLEAGUE FROM RIVERSIDE FOR
AUTHORING THIS BILL.
I'M A PROUD JOINT AUTHORED ON
THIS MEASURE AS I KNOW THE POWER
OF TEACHING STORIES THAT HAVE
LONG.
GONE ON TOLD MAKING SURE THAT WE
BRING THAT THIS CITY AND
DIVERSITY OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA INTO THE EDUCATIONAL
ACADEMIA WORLD.
ON THE SEVEN WELLINGTON
RESERVATION WE WORKED HARD TO
EDUCATE OUR YOUTH ON THE HISTORY
TO EMPOWER THEM TO BECOME
STRONGER MEMBERS OF OUR
COMMUNITY.
EMPOWERING STUDENTS WITH THIS
KNOWLEDGE WILL ALWAYS PAY
DIVIDENDS FOR OUR COMMUNITY AS A
WHOLE AND I THANK MY COLLEAGUES
ONCE AGAIN AND URGE YOUR VOTE I
VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER RAMOS MISTER
MEDINA WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
ON A CAR I THANK MY COLLEAGUES
AND RESPECTFULLY ASK OUR I'LL
GO.
THANK YOU MISTER MEDINA SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THEIR OWN.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ON MEMBERS VOTED IS THERE TO THE
ALL MEMBERS VOTED DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE AYE AYES FIFTY
THREE KNOWS ONE THIS MEASURE
PASSES.
FILE ITEM SEVENTY SIX WE PASS
TEMPORARILY MOVING TO FILE ITEM
SEVENTY SEVEN AB THREE SIXTY
EIGHT THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL THREE SIXTY EIGHT
BY SOMETHING MEMBER QUIRK SILVA
AND ACTUALLY THE VETERANS
CEMETERIES.
QUIRK SILVA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
OPEN ON THIS MATTER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS TODAY I RISE TO BRING
FORWARD.
AB THREE SIXTY EIGHT FOR SOME OF
YOU WHO HAVE SERVED WITH ME
SINCE TWENTY FOURTEEN YOU MIGHT
BE REMEMBER THIS PUSH FOR A
CEMETERY.
THIS IS NOT THE FIRST TIME WE
HAVE PRESENTED THE BILL THIS
BILL HAS BEEN AMENDED IN AND IS
NOW BRING BOUGHT BOUGHT UP
BROUGHT BACK TO THE ORIGINAL
SITE. TO THE PRESENT A SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA.
VETERANS CEMETERY AT THE FORMER
EL TORO MARINE CORPS AIR STATION.
AT THE ARTIST'S SITE IN IRVINE.
MEMBERS THIS IS A CONTROVERSIAL
BILL.
THERE ARE.
PEOPLE WHO SUPPORT THIS BILL AND
PEOPLE WHO DON'T.
I ASK YOU TO THINK ABOUT THOSE
VETERANS IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
THAT ORANGE COUNTY IS THE
LARGEST COUNTY WITHOUT A
VETERANS CEMETERY THE CLOSEST
ONE IS THE RIVER SIDE VETERANS
CEMETERY WHERE THERE IS A LONG
WAIT IN A LONG DISTRICTS FORMS
COUNTY.
FAMILY MEMBERS TO VISIT.
NOW WHY IS THIS CONTROVERSY ALL.
BECAUSE IT SIMPLY IS A DEVELOPER
FIGHT THAT IS GOING ON ON AND ON
AND IRVINE FOR A PIECE OF LAND
THAT IS A HISTORIC PIECE OF LAND.
THIS LAND IS THE FORMER.
MARINE AIR BASE WHERE MANY
VETERANS LEFT.
A MEMBERS MANY OF THEM DID NOT
RETURN.
AND NOW WHEN WE HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO CREATE.
A SOUTHERN CALAVERAS CALIFORNIA
VETERANS CEMETERY WE CONTINUE TO
STILL HAVE THOSE DEVELOPER
FIGHTS AND SOME LOCAL RESIDENTS
SAY BUT WE DON'T WANT TO TRAFFIC.
BUT WE DON'T WANT THOSE GUNS
SALUTES.
BUT WE DON'T WANT PEOPLE IN OUR
NEIGHBORHOOD.
I MEMBERS THERE IS A TIME YOU
NEED TO STAND UP AND STAND UP
FOR THOSE WHO FOUGHT FOR US.
THOSE WHO DIED FOR US AND
INSTEAD OF SAYING WE DON'T LIKE
THE SOUNDS OF GUN SALUTES WE
THINK OF EVERY TIME WE HEAR
THOSE GUN SALUTES WE ARE SAYING
GOODBYE. TO A VETERAN THAT
SERVED US WE ARE SAYING THANK
YOU FOR YOUR SERVICE AND STATE
OF WE DON'T LIKE THE SOUND OF
THAT NOISE WHEN WE SAY WE DON'T
WANT THEM BURIED IN OUR NAY AND
NEIGHBORHOOD.
AND STEAD WE SHOULD WELCOME TO
DO OUR NEIGHBORHOODS BECAUSE WE
ARE LOSING THOSE VETERANS EVERY
SINGLE DAY THIS IS NOT.
A CITY DECISION IT IS A REGIONAL
DECISION A MEMBERS.
I OFTEN SEE VETERANS OR AGING IN
THEIR NINETIES ARE WORLD WAR TWO
VETERANS AND THEY SAY WHEN IS
THAT GOING TO GET DONE.
SO I ASK YOUR SUPPORT FOR A
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA VETERANS
CEMETERY AT THE ORIGINAL ARTIST
SITE AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU AS QUIRK SILVA MESTRE
CHOI YOU ARE RECOGNIZED ON THIS
MATTER.
THANK YOU SPEAKER RIGHT AND THE
COLLEAGUES SO.
I RISE IN OPPOSITION OF A AB.
THREE TO SIXTY EIGHT COLLEAGUES
AS SOON -- I AM A VETERAN OF US
THE KOREAN ON ME AND AS A
VETERAN I HAVE A GREAT
APPRECIATION AND THE RESPECT.
FOR OUR BAD OR ON COMMUNITY IN
CALIFORNIA PARTICULARLY ON THE
EVE OF LAW.
THE M. MEMORIAL DAY.
THIS ISSUE OF BEING IN AWE OF
BROUGHT FOUR DOOR IN A BE THIRTY
SIX D. H..
S. ON ONGOING DEBATE.
AND ALSO VERY A CONTROVERSIAL
ISSUE IN ORANGE COUNTY OVER THE
LOCATION OF THE OF THAT THEY'RE
ON THE US AMATORY.
I WAS A PART OF THE ORIGINAL
DISCUSSIONS SO TO ESTABLISH YOU.
THE SEVEN CEMETERY AND I FORTY
FOUR ACTUALLY -- OF FORTY FOUR
EIGHT AND THE PROPOSED AMENDED
DOT AND RESTATED DEVELOPMENT WE
MONTH THAT WITH WHAT WE CALL S.
R. ADHA -- A DOESN'T MAKE ANY
SENSE TO YOU ABOUT THE JUST A
SIMPLY THE ORIGIN OUR SITE THE
HIGH RISK FOR THAT AS A US ASIDE.
EIGHT THE ISSUE AT HAND OUT WITH
HIS SUPPOSED TO SIDE -- CENTERS
SO OWN DECONTAMINATION OF EST --
DOT WILL COST OF NINETY ONE
MILLION DOLLARS SO IT'S JUST A
TO CLEAN UP UP PREPARATION COSTS
ALONE.
AND CALIDAD DOESN'T HAVE THAT
KIND OF MONEY AND OUR MEMBER
POSTED BY -- SHE INTENDS TO FIND
THE MONEY.
FROM THE STATE BUDGET.
THIS ONLINE NINETY ONE MILLION
DOLLARS IS NOT JUST DAHLE.
IMPOSSIBLE TO REACH.
THIS MATTER IS ARE CURRENTLY
BEING DEBATED.
AND THE DISCUSS THAT AT THE BOTH
THE COUNTY AND THE CITY LEVEL.
AND THE SHOULD BE KEPT TO THE A
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS SO FOR THE IS
THE DECISION.
MANY PARENTS OF THE ELEMENTARY
AND HIGH SCHOOLS TO NEARBY IN
FACT THE THREE SCORES SAW OUT
WITHIN NOT.
ONE THOUSAND FEET.
WHICH IS OF A VIOLATION OF THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT THOUGH THEY
AT THAT CEREMONY ON A GUN SALUTE.
THAT THE COMPANY -- TWENTY
DURING THE CLASSROOM -- SESSION
THAT THE NOISE ORDERED
DEFINITELY ALL DAY LONG WILL
DISRUPT THE BECAUSE OF WE
ANTICIPATE THE VERY HIGH TRAFFIC
GO.
OUT WITH THAT THOUGH CEREMONIES
TO ADOPT THE WE'RE ALL GO ON IN
THAT THE PROPOSED SITE.
THE ORIGIN ORDERS SITE AB ONE SO
IT'S ALL CONTAMINATED A AND A
WAS EXCHANGED.
ARE.
UP TO A CLEANER SITE THE HOWEVER
FOR POLITICAL REASONS SO IT WAS
THE REVOTE INTO BACK TO ORIGIN
OUR SITE.
AND ORANGE COUNTY VETERANS ARE
THE CIVILIANS.
COLLEAGUES THIS TYPE OF A MATTER
SOB BEST A DECIDED BY LOCAL
BODIES OF THE GOVERNMENT AND I'M
NOT THE SACRAMENTO I URGE YOU IN
THE VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER TRIMESTER DAILY
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED ON THIS
MATTER THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS I RISE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL.
WHICH DOES AUTHORIZE THE USE OF
A SITE.
IN THE CITY OF IRVINE IN ORANGE
COUNTY FOR THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA VETERANS CEMETERY
CITY OF IRVINE AGREED TO THIS
SITE FIVE YEARS AGO.
IN IN GOOD FAITH I AM HOPING
THAT THEY WILL.
STICK TO THEIR COMMITMENT.
THAT SITE IS LOCATED IN THE
FORMER EL TORO MARINE CORPS AIR
STATION.
SHARES A LONG HISTORY IN ORANGE
COUNTY DATING BACK TO WORLD WAR
TWO ERA.
THE STATE HAS DEDICATED TIME AND
RESOURCES TO ENSURING THAT OUR
VETERANS IN ORANGE COUNTY AND
ELSEWHERE IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
WILL HAVE A FINAL RESTING PLACE.
THIS BILL FURTHERS THAT GOAL IN
HONORS THE LEGACY OF THE WOMEN
AND MEN THAT HAVE SERVED OUR
COUNTRY.
THIS BILL IS TOTALLY CONSISTENT
WITH PREVIOUS ACTIONS OF THIS
BODY. FOR VETERANS CEMETERY IN
IRVINE.
I THANK THE AUTHOR MISS QUIRK
SILVA FOR HER HARD WORK.
IN HER FOCUS IN BRINGING THIS
BILL FORWARD AND RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU
MISTER DALY WAS QUIRK SILVA
WOULD YOU LIKE CLASS.
THANK YOU MEMBERS AS WE GO INTO
A THREE DAY HOLIDAY.
THAT ENDS WITH MEMORIAL DAY AND
WE WALK ORDER.
MARCH IN A CEREMONY THAT HONORS
OUR VETERANS ACROSS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND WE PUT UP OUR RED
WHITE AND BLUE.
WHAT BETTER WAY TO SAY THANK YOU
AND SHOW OUR GRATITUDE THEN TO
SUPPORT ANOTHER FINAL RESTING
PLACE FOR SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
VETERANS?
AND WHEN WE THINK ABOUT THEIR
FIGHT AND THE THE FIGHT THAT
THEY HAVE TAKEN TO PROVIDE FOR
OUR FREEDOM AND DEMOCRACY.
HAVING A PLACE THAT IS CLOSE FOR
THEIR FAMILIES TO VISIT THEM.
HAVING A PLACE THAT SHOWS
RESPECT -- HISTORIC SITE IS THE
WAY WE CAN DO THAT SO I
SINCERELY ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT
AND ASKED RESPECTFULLY ASK.
FOR A. B.. THREE NINE SIX
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MISS QUIRK SILVA
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF THOSE WHO DESIRE
TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE [inaudible]
CLICK.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TELEVOTE EYES FIFTY EIGHT KNOWS
ONE THIS MEASURE PASSES.
WHO TO FILE ITEM SEVENTY EIGHT
AB THREE SIXTY NINE THE CLERK
WILL READ ASSEMBLY BILL THREE
SIXTY NINE BY SELLING MEMBER
WEBER AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY
THE PUBLIC POST SECONDARY
EDUCATION?
DOCTOR WEBER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
OPEN ON THIS MATTER THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER AND MEMBERS SO
THIS MORNING I RISE TO PRESENT
TO YOU AB.
THREE SIX NINE A BILL RELATING
TO THE STRUCTURE OF SALARIES FOR
THE CSU EMPLOYEES.
THIS WILL BE FAMILIAR TO MANY OF
YOU BECAUSE THIS BILL HAS BEEN
BEFORE THIS HOUSE.
SEE IF SHE WAS THE ONLY STATE
AGENCY THAT DOES NOT PROVIDE
SALARY STEPS TO ITS STAFF.
SORRY STEPS ARE INCREASES BASED
ON JOB PERFORMANCE AND LONGEVITY
AND I WANT TO EMPHASIZE THAT.
IN NINETEEN NINETY SIX THE CSU
BOARD OF TRUSTEES OUTSIDE OF THE
BARGAINING PROCESS UNILATERALLY
ELIMINATED EXISTING EMPLOYEE
SALARIES STEPS.
THIS HAS RESULTED IN NEW HIRES
EARNING HIGHER SALARIES THAN
EXISTING EMPLOYEES WHO HAVE
WORKED IN THE SAME
CLASSIFICATION FOR MANY YEARS.
THIS IN EQUITY HAS CREATED A
NINETY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS IN
VERSION GAP BETWEEN THE SALARIES
OF NEWLY HIGH.
ORDER IN THE CHAMBER PLAN LONG
EMPLOYED SEE ISSUE STAFF.
BUT TWO DECADES THE ISSUE HAS
BEEN UNWILLING TO REINSTATE
SALARY STEPS WITH THIS
PARTICULAR GROUP.
DESPITE THE FAILURE OF THE
EXISTING SORRY STEP AND THE
INABILITY OF EMPLOYEES TO EARN A
FAIR AND EQUITABLE WAY.
AB THREE SIXTY NINE WOULD
REINSTATE THE 5% STAFF ALWAYS
STEP WAS THE ISSUE SUPPORT STAFF.
THE INCREASE WILL BE MADE
ANNUALLY WHEN EMPLOYEES MEET THE
STANDARDS WAS SATISFACTORY
PERFORMANCE AS DETERMINED BY THE
EMPLOYEES ADMINISTRATORS.
KEEP IN MIND THIS IS A A
PERFORMANCE EVALUATION AND HE'S
AT A MERIT SALARY THAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT.
AND THAT BECOMES IMPORTANT.
THE CURRENT STRUCTURE DOES NOT
FACILITATE THIS AND AS A AS A
FORMER C. ISSUE EMPLOYEE WHO I'D
MINUTES WAS AN ADMINISTRATOR WHO
HANDLED WITH MY STAFF.
THIS WAS A PROBABLY THE MOST
DIFFICULT THING TO HAVE YEAR
AFTER YEAR SORRY WHO A FACULTY
WHO PERFORMED AT A HIGH LEVEL OR
MET GOALS AND OBJECTIVES.
NOT ABLE TO GET MERIT INCREASES
FACULTY GOT MERIT INCREASES
ADMINISTRATORS GET MERIT
INCREASES THIS GROUP OF OF
EMPLOYEES OF THE LOWEST PAID
INDIVIDUALS.
WE HAVE BROUGHT THIS BEFORE YOU
AND YOU'VE SUPPORTED EACH YEAR
WE'RE OPTIMISTIC THAT WOULD A
NEW GOVERNOR THAT THIS WILL
HAPPEN.
THAT IT WILL FINALLY HAPPEN ONE
WOULD THINK THAT AFTER
PRESENTING THIS BILL YEAR AFTER
YEAR AND HAVING IT EMBRACE BY
THE ASSEMBLY AND THE SENATE EACH
YEAR.
THAT AT LEAST DID AT AND HAVING
THE GOVERNOR SAY WELL THIS
SHOULD BE DONE IN COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING.
YOU WOULD THINK THAT THEY WOULD
FINALLY PUT IT IN COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING BUT THEY HAVE NOT
BEEN ABLE TO AFFECT THE
INSTITUTE OF THE THE THE
ADMINISTRATION AND THE AND THE
TRUSTEES TO BASICALLY PUT THIS
IN THERE AND HAVE A CONVERSATION
ABOUT IT.
AND GIVE THE MERIT INCREASES
THESE ARE THE HARDEST WORKING
PEOPLE IN OUR INSTITUTION AND
THAT THE LOWEST PAID IN.
BUT BY AND LARGE THE LOWEST PAID
INDIVIDUALS IN THE INSTITUTION
THESE ARE OUR BECAUSE DALIAN'S
OUR JANITORS AND IF YOU OTHER
OFFICE WORKERS SO I REALLY
REALLY HOPE THIS YEAR.
THAT WE WILL NOT ONLY PASSES ON
THIS FLOOR BUT WE WILL MAKE IT A
PRIORITY FOR THIS GOVERNOR TO AT
FAIRNESS BECAUSE EVERYONE ELSE
HAS THIS.
HAPPENED.
EVEN YOU IN THIS HOUSE GIVE YOUR
STAFF OF MERIT INCREASES THE GO
BEYOND THE 3% OR WHATEVER IT IS
BECAUSE THEY WORK HARD AND YOU
WANT THEM TO STAY WITH YOU INTO
BEING GAZE INVOLVED.
I'M TELLING YOU AT THE
INSTITUTION THIS HAPPEN
INITIALLY FOR FACULTY.
AND I CAN REMEMBER HOW IT
AFFECTED OUR FACULTY WE HAD
PEOPLE BEING HIRED IN TO DO JOBS
THAT WERE WERE MAKING MORE THAN
THOSE OF US WHO HAD BEEN THERE
FOR LONG PERIODS OF TIME.
IT IS DEMORALIZING TO HAVE SUCH
IN A SYSTEM THAT EXIST AND IT
REALLY IS VERY DEVASTATING TO
THEM AND MOST OF THE OTHER ORGAN
THAT THE OTHER GROUPS THE
FACULTY AND ADMINISTRATORS.
HAVE FOUGHT BECAUSE THEY HAVE
MORE CLOUT AT THE INSTITUTION
AND HAVE GOTTEN THIS DONE.
WE MUST DO IT FOR THIS GROUP OF
EMPLOYEES BECAUSE IT IS CLEAR
THAT THE SYSTEM WILL NOT DO IT
FOR THEM I RESPECTFULLY ASK THE
AYE BOTH AB.
THREE SIX NINE THANK YOU DOCTOR
EVER MISTER PATTERSON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED ON THIS MATTER THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND MEMBERS UP
I RISE IN VERY STRONG SUPPORT.
OF THIS BILL AND I WANT TO TAKE
THIS -- HOME TO FRESNO
CALIFORNIA I WANT TO SPEAK HERE.
ON BEHALF OF THE MANY EMPLOYEES
AT FRESNO STATE.
HAVING THE PRIVILEGE OF
REPRESENTING THE CITY OF FRESNO
FOR EIGHT YEARS AS ITS MAYOR.
AND LIVING IN FRESNO AND
ACTUALLY HAVING A RADIO STATION
THERE FOR THIRTY YEARS.
I GOT TO KNOW THESE PEOPLE THESE
ARE THE BACKBONE OF FRESNO STATE.
I KNOW THEM AND I REPRESENT THEM
AND THEY ARE EXPERIENCING
PRECISELY WHAT THIS BILL SEEKS
TO ADDRESS.
IT IS EMPLOYEES SUCH AS OUR
GROUNDS KEEPERS JANITORS AND
THOSE WHO PAID FRESNO STATE
BULLDOGS STADIUM AND MAKE IT
READY FOR PRIME TIME AT FOOTBALL
GAMES.
MANY OF THEM HAVE TO WORK.
A SECOND JOB TO MAKE ENDS MEET.
THESE ARE THE EMPLOYEES THAT
KEEP CSU CAMPUSES RUNNING.
BUT YET MEN THINK ABOUT THIS
WHEN A NEW EMPLOYEE.
GETS HIRED.
THEY'RE STARTING SALARY MAY BE
MUCH HIGHER THAN SOMEONE WHO HAS
BEEN EMPLOYED. FOR TWENTY YEARS
OR MORE.
SO I THANK MY COLLEAGUE FROM SAN
DIEGO FOR BRINGING AB THREE SIX
NINE FOUR WOULD ONCE AGAIN I
SUPPORTED ORIGINALLY.
I SUPPORTED AGAIN I'M ASKING MY
COLLEAGUES BOTH SIDES OF THE
AISLE SUPPORT A. B. THREE SIX
NINE TODAY TO ENSURE THAT ALL
CSU EMPLOYEES ARE PAID WHAT THEY
DESERVE AND HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
FOR STEP INCREASES LIKE EVERYONE
ELSE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER
PATTERSON SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE DR I WORK WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
I THANK MY COLLEAGUE FROM OF
FROM FRESNO AND ALL OF YOU
WHO'VE EXPRESSED AN INTEREST AND
CONCERN AND A COMMITMENT TO THIS.
WE MUST GET THIS DONE THIS IS
ABOUT FAIRNESS AND AS I SAID
I'VE LIVED WITH IT AS AN
ADMINISTRATOR AND BEING FEELING
VERY VERY CONFLICTED WITH NOT A
WITH MY STAFF.
OF NOT BEING ABLE TO PROVIDE
THEM WITH THE SUPPORT THEY NEED
IS THESE ARE LIKE I SAID
OFTENTIMES THE LOWEST PAID
INDIVIDUALS AT THE INSTITUTION.
UP BECAUSE OF THE CURRENT SYSTEM
THEY'RE MAKING AN AVERAGE OF
SEVEN HUNDRED EIGHTY DOLLARS
LESS THAN ANY NEW HIRE IN THEIR
CURRENT JOB.
THAT IS UNACCEPTABLE VERY
UNACCEPTABLE AND SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOU I BOTH
AB.
THREE SIX NINE OF FOR OUR C.
ISSUE STAFF AND THAT WE
BASICALLY TAKE THIS TO THE
GOVERNOR'S DESK AND AND AND EVEN
MORE STRENGTH TO BASICALLY GET
IT PASSED I RESPECTFULLY ASK THE
AYE VOTE.
BABY THREE SIX NINE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED DESIRE TO THE
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE I FIFTY TWO NO
ZERO THIS MEASURE PASSES.
WHEN FILE ITEM SEVENTY NINE AB
THREE SEVENTY EIGHT THE CLERK
WILL READ ASSEMBLY BILL THREE
SEVENTY EIGHT BY STANLEY MEMBER
LIMóN AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY
CHILD CARE?
THIS LIMON YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
OPEN ON THIS MATTER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER.
AB THREE SEVENTY EIGHT SIX TO
CREATE A SUSTAINABLE CAREER
PATHWAY AND SUPPORTS.
THOSE WHO EDUCATE AND CARE FOR
OUR EARLIEST LEARNERS.
CALIFORNIA'S EARLY CARE AND
EDUCATION WORKFORCE IS COMPRISED
PRIMARILY OF WOMEN AND
PREDOMINANTLY WOMEN OF COLOR.
THIS IS A WORK FORCE THAT OFTEN
DOES NOT EARN A LIVABLE WAGE AND
QUALIFIES FOR THE SAME SUBSIDIES
THE FAMILIES THEY SERVE USE.
AS THE FIFTH LARGEST ECONOMY
WORK FORCE ISSUES FOR CURRENT
WORK FIRST AND THE FUTURE WORK
FORCE MUST REMAIN AT THE
FOREFRONT OF OUR THINKING.
THE ASSEMBLY BLUE RIBBON
COMMISSION ON CHILD CARE WORKED
TIRELESSLY OVER THE LAST TWO
YEARS TO DEVELOP A COMPREHENSIVE
SET OF RECOMMENDATIONS.
IN ADDRESSING THE ISSUES WITH
THE CURRENT E. C. WORK FORCE.
ONE OF THE RECOMMENDATIONS IT'S
JUST TO SUPPORT COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING RIGHTS FOR FAMILY
CARE HOME PROVIDERS BOTH LICENSE
AND FAMILY AND FRIEND AND
NEIGHBOR.
CALIFORNIA RUNS A TWENTY FOUR
HOUR A DAY WORKFORCE BUT OUR
CHILD CARE OPTIONS FOR WORKING
FAMILIES DO NOT MEET THAT NEED.
NOR DO THEY SUPPORT THOSE TO
PROVIDE CHILD CARE.
THIS BILL PROFESSIONAL EYES IS
INCREASE STABILITY FOR FAMILY
CARE PROVIDERS BY MAKING QUALITY
TRAINING AVAILABLE TO ALL
PROVIDERS THROUGH COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING.
I ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT ON A. B.
SEVEN THREE SEVEN EIGHT FOR ALL
WORKING FAMILIES IN NEED OF
CHILD CARE AND THOSE WHO SUPPORT
OUR EARLIEST LEARNERS.
THANK YOU MISTER MON MISTER
MCCARTY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED ON
THIS MATTER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I RISE
AS I THOUGHT IT WAS A CO AUTHOR
BUT I WOULD MISS TO MISS THAT SO
WE'LL FIX THAT IN IN THE SENATE
SIDE.
I'M IS STRONG SUPPORTER THIS AS
WAS MENTIONED WE ADDRESS THIS ON
OUR BLUE RIBBON COMMISSION WHICH
WAS -- COACH I COACH HERE BY
MYSELF AND MY COLLEAGUE FROM LOS
ANGELES COUNTY.
AND AS THE AUTHOR MENTION THAT
TOO LONG WE'VE IGNORED PEOPLE
THAT WORK IN THE SERVICE
INDUSTRY DOMESTIC WORKERS TO
CHILD CARE WORKERS ARE PRE K.
WORKERS AND AS WE KNOW.
PREDOMINATELY WOMEN RAMLI WOMEN
OF COLOR AND IT'S NO WONDER WHY
WE HAVEN'T STEPPED UP AND STOOD
BY THESE WORKERS AND SO THIS
MEASURE DOES JUST THAT.
IT FOCUSES ON COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING WILL SOME PEOPLE SAY
THAT'S JUST ABOUT WAGES THIS IS
GONNA.
BREAK OUR BANK IN THE STATE
BUDGET AND YES WILL HAVE A
DISCUSSION DONE THAT BY THE ROAD
BUT THIS IS MORE ABOUT HAVING A
VOICE AT THE TABLE.
THAT'S WHAT UNIONS ARE ABOUT
BEING ABLE TO SIT THERE AND TALK
ABOUT WORKING CONDITIONS.
THE DIRECTIONS OF THE INDUSTRY
CURRICULUM THE WHOLE.
ISSUE OF WHAT IS PROVIDED TO OUR
YOUNGEST LEARNERS.
AND THEN AGAIN THE IN THE
INDIVIDUALS THAT WORK IN THIS
INDUSTRY ARE LITERALLY PAID FAST
FOOD WAGES.
NOT TO DIMINISH OUR FAST FOOD
WORKERS BUT THEY QUALIFY. FOR
THE SAME PROGRAMS WHERE THEY
TEACH.
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN THAT MEANS
THAT MANY TIMES THEY CAN GO AND
GET A JOB AT A FAST FOOD
RESTAURANT -- COSCO AND MAKE
MORE MONEY AND THAT LEAVES A LOT
OF UNCERTAINTY FOR THE WORK
FORCE AND THAT IMPACTS NOT ONLY
THEMSELVES BUT ALSO THE KIDS IN
THESE PROGRAMS.
SO THIS WILL FOCUS ON INCREASING
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT WHAT'S
WILL HELP THE WORK FORCE BUT
ALSO MAKE SURE WE IMPROVE
QUALITY AS WELL THIS IS A SOUND
MEASURE.
AND ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE THIS
MORNING THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER MCCARTY MISTER
GALLAGHER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED ON
THIS MATTER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
AND AND I I RISE IN OPPOSITION
TO THIS BILL AND I AND I
DEFINITELY APPRECIATE WHERE MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SANTA BARBARA IS
COMING FROM -- BUT I THINK.
THE CONCERN THAT I HAVE AS WE'VE
BEEN TALKING ABOUT THIS A LOT
THIS YEAR.
IS ACCESS AND AFFORDABILITY OF
CHILD CARE.
AND YOU KNOW MANY IN THIS ROOM
KNOW PERSONALLY -- THAT THE COST
OF CHILDCARE IS IS VERY HIGH AND
MY CONCERN IS THAT -- THIS IS
GOING TO LEAD TO HIGHER CHILD
CARE COSTS THAT ARE ALREADY VERY.
OUT OF REACH FOR MANY PEOPLE IN-THE STATE.
AND SO I WOULD URGE A NO VOTE ON
THIS I THINK THERE ARE OTHER
WAYS.
OTHER THAN COLLECTIVE BARGAINING.
TO HELP INSURE THAT PEOPLE ARE
GETTING PAID.
HIGHER WAGES ARE BETTER WAGES --
BUT THIS IS THIS IS NOT THE ONLY
WAY AND I AND I AM CONCERNED
AGAIN ABOUT THE COST.
THE COST IS ALREADY TOO HIGH FOR
CHILD CARE IN THIS STATE AND
THIS IS ONLY GOING TO MAKE IT
HIGHER.
THANK YOU MISTER GALLAGHER
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THIS MATTER MISS THEM
AND WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU I DO WANT TO SAY THAT.
THE IMPORTANCE OF INVESTING IN
pOUR WORK FORCE MEANS THAT WE
HAVE A WORK FORCE AND WHEN WE
THINK ABOUT THE COST THAT WE'RE
INVESTING IN OUR WORK FORCE
INNER CHILD CARE WORK FIRST IT
ENSURES THAT PEOPLE ARE ABLE TO
TAKE ON THAT JOB.
WE WILL HAVE A SCARCITY.
OF WORKERS FOR CHILD CARE IF WE
DO NOT INVEST AND THEN IF WE DO
NOT PAY.
LIVABLE WAGES WITH THAT MEMBERS
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
CLERK WILL OPEN THEIR OWN.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED DESIRED VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE
ROLE IN TALLY THE VOTE ICE FORTY
THREE KNOWS THIRTEEN THIS
MEASURE PASSES.
VIOLATE IN EIGHTY PASS
TEMORARILY FILE ITEM EIGHTY ONE
EIGHTY FOUR OH SIX THE CLERK
WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR OF SIX BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOW MOAN AND
OTHERS AND EXPLAIN TO DISABILITY
COMPENSATION.
WAS THE MODE YOU ORGAN
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT AND AB FOUR OH
SIX WHICH WILL ENSURE ALL
DOCUMENTS RELATED TO PAID FAMILY
LEAVE WILL BE AVAILABLE IN THE
MOST COMMONLY.
SPOKEN LANGUAGES IN OUR STATE
WITH 44% OF CALIFORNIANS OVER
THE AGE OF FIVE SPEAKING A
LANGUAGE OTHER THAN ENGLISH IN
CALIFORNIA HOMES IT IS VITAL
THAT ALL COMMUNICATIONS ARE MADE.
IN LANGUAGES OTHER THAN ENGLISH.
THERE IS A WIDE AGREEMENT THAT
NON ENGLISH SPEAKING POPULATION
FACE.
CHALLENGES ACCESS FACE
CHALLENGES ACCESSING THEIR PAID
FAMILY LEAVE BENEFITS AB FOUR OH
SIX WILL PROVIDE A TRANSLATED
APPLICATION WHICH WILL BE
MEANING FOR THE LOWER THE
BARRIER TO NON ENGLISH SPEAKERS.
FOR CLAIMING THAT BENEFIT WE DID
TAKE AMENDMENTS IN ASSEMBLY
INSURANCE THIS BILL HAS RECEIVED
UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN
BOTH ASSEMBLY INSURANCE AND
APPROPRIATIONS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS LIMóN SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THIS MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS GO TO DESIRE TO VOTE.
ON MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRED BOTH.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE EYES FIFTY SIX
MINUTES ZERO THIS MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM EIGHTY TWO EIGHTY FOUR
OH NINE THE CLERK WILL READ
ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR OH NINE BY
SOMETHING MEMBER LOW MOAN AND
ACTUALLY THE CLIMATE CHANGE MISS
LIMóN YOUR AGAIN RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AB FOR A
NINE ESTABLISHES A COMPETITIVE
GRANT PROGRAM TO HELP
AGRICULTURE IN CALIFORNIA ADAPT
TO CLIMATE CHANGE THIS PROGRAM
WILL DEVELOP CLIMATE ADAPTATION
TOOLS RESOURCES AND TRAININGS TO
HELP FARMERS AND RANCHERS PLAN
FOR AND ADAPT TO CLIMATE CHANGE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTES.
THANK YOU MISS LIMóN SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THIS MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESERTED
THE ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE
TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE I FIFTY NINE
KNOWS HERE THIS MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEMS EIGHTY THREE THREE
FIVE PASS TEMPORARILY.
FILE ITEM EIGHTY SIX EIGHTY FOUR
FORTY NINE THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR FORTY NINE BY
FAMILY MEMBER GALLAGHER AND
ACTUALLY TO TRANSPORTATION.
MISTER GALLAGHER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED OPEN ON THIS MATTER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
I AM PROUD TO PRESENT TO YOU AB
FOR FORTY NINE WHICH WOULD ALLOW
YOU THE CITY AND YUBA AND SUTTER
COUNTIES TO KEEP FUNDS FROM THE
SALE.
OF PROPERTIES OF THE DEPARTMENT
OF TRANSPORTATION ORIGINALLY
ACQUIRED TO BUILD A THIRD BRIDGE.
ACROSS THE FEATHER RIVER TRAVEL
OVER THE FOR THE RIVER IS
EXPECTED TO MORE THAN DOUBLE BY
TWENTY THIRTY FIVE AND CURRENT
INFRASTRUCTURE HAS BEEN DECLARED
FUNCTIONALLY OBSOLETE.
SIMILAR TRANCERS HAVE BEEN
APPROVED IN OTHER PARTS OF THE
STATE.
I IN TWO THOUSAND AND EIGHT AND
TWO THOUSAND AND THIRTEEN YOU
YOU ALL SUPPORTED THIS BILL LAST
TERM -- UNFORTUNATELY GOVERNOR.
VETOED IT SO WE'RE HOPING FOR
BETTER LUCK THIS YEAR.
AND I ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT ONCE
AGAIN.
AFTER AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU
THANK YOU MISTER GALLAGHER
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THIS MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE AYE AYES SIXTY
KNOWS HERE THIS MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM EIGHTY SEVEN THROUGH
EIGHTY NINE WILL PASS
TEMPORARILY MOVING TO FILE ITEM
NINETY AB FIVE HUNDRED THE CLERK
WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE HUNDRED BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GONZALEZ AND
ACTUALLY TO EMPLOYEES MISS
CONSOLIDATING ARE RECOGNIZED
OPEN ON THIS MATTER THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER.
MANY PEOPLE DON'T REALIZE THAT
OUR SCHOOL EMPLOYEES I DON'T
HAVE PAID FAMILY LEAVE OR EVEN
PAID PREGNANCY LEAVE.
SO IF A WOMAN IS TO GET PREGNANT --
HAVE COMPLICATIONS DUE TO
PREGNANCY MISCARRIAGE OR
CHILDBIRTH SHE MUST FORCED USE
HER VACATION DAYS -- ARE SICK
DAYS AND THEN VACATION DAYS AND
THEN AS SHE GETS PARTIAL PAID
MINUS THE COST OF A SUBSTITUTE
TEACHER.
IT'S TIME TO CHANGE THAT AND
WORKFORCE IT'S OVER 70% FEMALE
CURRENT LAW DISCRIMINATES
AGAINST THESE WOMEN WHO CHOOSE
TO HAVE CHILDREN.
IT FORCES THEM TO TO THE DEBATE
PLEASE BASICALLY ALL OF THEIR
LEAVE BEFORE THEY CAN EVEN GET --
PARTIAL PAY.
I REINTRODUCES BILL WE WE PASSED
IT LAUGHTER ON A BIPARTISAN
BASIS IT WAS -- FORTUNATELY
VETOED BY THE GOVERNOR BUT WE'VE
INTRODUCED REINTRODUCED TO
BECAUSE IT'S THAT IMPORTANT.
YOUNG WOMEN SHOULDN'T HAVE TO
DECIDE WHETHER OR NOT -- THEY
CAN PLAN THEIR PREGNANCY AROUND
THE SCHOOL YEAR IN ORDER TO
ENSURE THAT THEY DON'T LOSE ALL
OF THEIR LEAVE AND NOT BE ABLE
TO CONTINUE -- TO STAY HOME
DURING THIS CRITICAL TIME -- IN
HAVE TO USE IT ALL BEFORE EVEN
THE BABY IS BORN I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR NINE ABOUT.
THANK YOU MISS GONZALEZ SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THIS MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE BY FIFTY EIGHT
KNOWS YEAR THIS MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM NINETY ONE AB FIVE
AWAIT THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE OH EIGHT BY
STANLEY MEMBER KANSEN CHU AND
ACTUALLY THE DRINKING WATER.
MR TO YOU ARE RECOGNIZED OPEN ON
THIS MATTER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND THE
MEMBERS I RISE 2% AB FIVE ZERO
EIGHT WHICH IMPROVE ON EXISTING
WATER BORE PROCESS IS.
CREATING UNDER AB TWENTY FIVE
OLD ONE TO DELIVER YOU.
SAFE DRINKING WATER TO SMALL
COMMUNITIES WHO RELY ON DOMESTIC
WELLS AND SMALL WATER SYSTEMS.
THE BILL REQUIRES THAT THE WATER
BOARD INFORMED RESIDENTS.
IF THE OWNER OF THE DOMESTIC
WELL OR TO OWNING IS WAS HOLDING
CONSENT. TO ALLOWING THE BOARD
TO PROVIDE SAFE WATER TO DEAR
TENANTS.
IN ADDITION THIS BILL CLARIFY
THAT THE OLD OLD OLDER TO
CONSOLIDATION CASES.
RECEIVING WATER SYSTEM CAN ONLY
CHARGE A CAPACIDADE FEED THAT
THE LINE WAS.
AND DOES NOT EXCEEDS EXCEED THE
CALLS OF FRUIT PROVIDING THE
SERVICE.
THIS BILL HAS NO OPPOSITION AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
RIVAL.
THANK YOU MISTER CHIU SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THIS MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ON MEMBERS GO TO DESERVE A ALL
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
WHERE WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE AYE AYES FORTY
EIGHT KNOWS FOURTEEN THIS
MEASURE PASSES?
WIENER FILE ITEM NINETY TWO
EIGHTY FIVE TWENTY NINE THE
CLERK WILL READ ASSEMBLY BILL
FIVE TWENTY NINE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER RAMIS AND OTHERS
AND ACTUALLY THE STATE EMPLOYEES.
THIS AROMAS YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
OPEN ON THIS MATTER.
THANK YOU.
MADAM SPEAKER AND AB FIVE TWO
NINE PROHIBITS THE PRACTICE OF
IMPOSING ON THE SPOT MANDATORY
OVERTIME OF ANY PSYCHIATRIC
TECHNICIAN OR PSYCHIATRIC
TECHNICIAN ASSISTANT WORKING AT
A STATE HOSPITAL.
CHRONIC STAFFING ISSUES AT OUR
STATE HOSPITAL HOSPITALS HAS
OBJECTED STAFF TO WORK MANDATORY
OVERTIME.
RESULTING IN BACK TO BACK EIGHT
HOUR SHIFTS CREATING HEALTH
HAZARDS FOR PATIENTS AND STAFF.
WHEN I SERVED AS A SEMINAL
COUNTY SUPERVISOR I TOWARD
PATTON STATE HOSPITAL AND SEEING
THE CHALLENGES THAT STAFF TAKES
THEIR IN THE SAFETY ISSUES THAT
THAT EXIST?
I WALKED INTO AN AREA WE'RE ALL
PATIENTS WERE.
AND WHAT I SAW WAS A SINGLE LINE
SEPARATING PATIENTS FROM
EMPLOYEES.
THERE WAS NO WALLER BARRIER.
SO SAFETY IS SOMETHING THAT WE
CONTINUE TO ADDRESS.
AND I MAKE REFERENCE TO MY VISIT
TO PENN STATE HOSPITAL TO
HIGHLIGHT THE NEED TO PROVIDE
EMPLOYEES SAFETY AT OUR STATE
HOSPITALS.
PUTTING A STOP TO FORCED
OVERTIME ON A SACK PSYCHIATRIC
TECHNICIAN NOT ONLY STRENGTH IS
EMPLOYEE SAFETY BUT ALSO ENSURES
PATIENTS RECEIVE PROPER CARE AND
ATTENTION.
THIS BILL HAS NO OPPOSITION AND
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER OMINOUS MISS
WALDRON YOU ARE RECOGNIZED ON
THIS MATTER THANK YOU I DIDN'T
EXPECT TO SPEAK ON THIS BILL BUT
I RISE IN STRONG SUPPORT.
WE'VE SEEN THIS BILL A COUPLE OF
TIMES IN DIFFERENT FORMS.
THESE PSYCHIATRIC TECHNICIANS.
AS AS OUR OUR OF OUR COLLEAGUE
JUST DESCRIBED.
THEY WERE VERY SERIOUS JOB THERE
IN VERY DANGEROUS CONDITIONS IN
MANY ASPECTS AND UNBEKNOWNST TO
MANY.
MANY OF THESE FOLKS ARE WOMEN
AND THEY'RE WORKING IN THESE
THESE JOBS IN THE PSYCHIATRIC
HOSPITALS UNDER SOME VERY --
INTENSE OF ENVIRONMENTS SO AND
AND AND THE OTHER THING WITH THE
THE OVERTIME YOU KNOW THEY MAKE
THEIR PLANS FOR THE DAY THEY'VE
GOT CHILDCARE ISSUES THEY'VE GOT
FAMILY ISSUES THEY'RE TRYING TO
LEAVE AND THEN THEY'RE CALLED
BACK I MEAN IT'S JUST NOT
APPROPRIATE.
AND IT'S THE OUT THE OTHER THING
THAT'S NOT APPROPRIATE IS THAT
IT'S BEEN GOING ON FOR YEARS SO
I REALLY URGE AN AYE VOTE ON
THIS BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU
MISS WALDRON SECULAR KERR YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED ON THIS MATTER.
MEMBERS I STAND IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL AS WELL THE NAPA STATE
HOSPITALS IN MY DISTRICT THERE
ARE SIX HUNDRED FIFTY EIGHT
PSYCH TEXAN PLOY THERE IN ABOUT.
65% OF THESE WORKERS ARE WOMEN
SUPPORTING THIS BILL MEANS
SUPPORTING WOMEN AND FAMILIES I
URGE YOU TO JOIN ME IN SUPPORT
OF AB.
FIVE TWENTY NINE THANK YOU MAY
SECULAR CURRY SEEING AND HEARING
NO FURTHER DEBATE WAS FROM US
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU -- MANAGER KNOWS OR
SHOULD I VOTE THANK YOU CLERK
WILL OPEN THEIR OWN.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED IS THERE TO
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE I SIXTY FOUR
KNOWS ONE THIS MEASURE PASSES.
BY LATE IN NINETY THREE AB FIVE
THIRTY NINE THE CLERK WILL READ
ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE THIRTY NINE
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER LIMóN AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY TO CONSUMER
LOANS.
THIS LIMON YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
OPEN ON THIS MATTER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER.
AB FIVE THIRTY NINE IS AN
IMPORTANT CONSUMER PROTECTION
BILLS THAT IS YEARS OVERDUE.
HIGH COST LOANS HAVE EXPLODED IN
CALIFORNIA OVER THE PAST DECADE.
THESE LOANS START AT TWENTY FIVE
HUNDRED DOLLARS AND HAVE
INTEREST RATES.
FROM 2100% TO MORE THAN 2100%.
FAR TOO OFTEN CONSUMERS ARE
UNABLE TO REPAY THESE EXPENSIVE
LOANS. ONE OUT OF THREE BARS WHO
OBTAINED THESE LOANS. FOR MORE
THAN A HUNDRED THOUSAND
CALIFORNIA FAMILIES EACH YEAR.
CANNOT AFFORD THEIR LOAN
PAYMENTS AND FALL INTO DEFAULT.
THIS PROCESS RESULT IN DAMAGE
CREDIT FOR THE CONSUMER.
AND CAN ALSO LEAD TO THEIR
PAYCHECK BEING GARNISHED THEIR
BANK ACCOUNT CLOSED OR THEIR CAR
BEING REPOSSESSED. ONE OUT OF
THREE TIMES MEMBERS.
I CANNOT THINK OF ANOTHER
PRODUCT THAT FEELS SO OFTEN
WITHOUT GOVERNMENT STEPPING IN
TO INTERVENE.
THE IDEA THAT CONSUMERS WILL NOT
HAVE CREDIT OPTIONS IF THIS BILL
PASSES IS NOT REALISTIC.
THE RESPONSIBLE LENDERS WHO
SUPPORT THIS BILL HAVE FOUND
WAYS TO OFFER SAFE AFFORDABLE
CREDIT OPTIONS TO BARS WITH
DAMAGE CREDIT FOR EVEN NO CREDIT
SCORE AT ALL.
THESE LENDERS PROVIDE MORE THAN
TWO BILLION.
DOLLARS OF CREDIT ACCESS EACH
YEAR TO CALIFORNIA BARS.
AND LET'S BE CLEAR.
ON THE ISSUE OF HIGH COST
INSTALLMENT LOANS CALIFORNIA IS
AN OUT LIAR.
WE ARE AMONG A SMALL MINORITY OF
STATES THAT DO NOT CAP INTEREST
RATES ON THESE LOANS. THIRTY
EIGHT STATES IN OUR COUNTRY.
HAVE TAPPED [inaudible]
THIS PRODUCT.
I HAVE WORKED HARD TO FIND A
COMPROMISE THAT COULD EARN THE
SUPPORT FROM BOTH CONSUMER
GROUPS AND LENDERS ALIKE.
AB FIVE THREE NINE IS THE RESULT
OF THOSE NEGOTIATIONS.
WE ALSO HAVE A STRONG COALITION
OF LOCAL GOVERNMENTS.
LABOR ORGANIZATIONS RELIGIOUS
ORGANIZATIONS AND VETERAN GROUPS
WHO SUPPORT THIS EFFORT.
AFTER SO MANY YEARS OF FAILED
THE TREND TO ADDRESS THIS
PROBLEM I ASK YOU TO JOIN ME IN
ADVANCING THIS IMPORTANT POLICY.
THAT WILL BENEFIT BOTH CONSUMERS
AND RESPONSIBLE LENDERS ALIKE.
THANK YOU MISTER MON RESTAURANT
MOST YOU ARE RECOGNIZED ON THIS
MATTER.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND AND I
RISE IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL IT
REALLY DOES COME INTO THE THE
CHARACTER OF OUR COMMUNITIES
WHEN YOU START TO LOOK AT
PREDATORY LENDING.
AND YOU'RE BEING TOLD ONE
INTEREST RATE THAT'S COMING UP
IN THIS CASE TEN POINT 49% AND
THEN ONCE YOU AVERAGE IT OUT TO
THE MONTHLY DAILY RATE ON THE
ANNUAL RATE OF OVER A 125%.
I BELIEVE THAT'S OVER BEARING AN
OVER EXHAUSTING TO THE MEMBERS
IN OUR COMMUNITY SO I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL AND URGE
OUR COLLEAGUES TO SUPPORT THIS.
THANK YOU MISTER RAMOS MISTER
CUNNINGHAM YOU ARE RECOGNIZED IN
SPANISH.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
I THOUGHT LONG AND HARD ABOUT
THIS BILL AND I TALKED AT LENGTH
WITH.
MY COLLEAGUE MY NEIGHBOR TO THE
SOUTH -- THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FROM SANTA BARBARA ABOUT THE
GOALS OF THIS BILL -- AND I RISE
IN SUPPORT.
I'D ASK YOU TO CONSIDER THE
FOLLOWING.
THE DICTIONARY DEFINES USE SIRI.
DOES THE LANDING A MONEY WITH AN
INTEREST WITH INTEREST AT AN
UNCONSCIONABLE OR EXORBITANT
AMOUNT.
CONSIDER THAT IF YOU BORROW
TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS
TODAY.
THIS IS MATH BOOKS YOU BAR
TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS
TODAY AT 40% INTEREST.
AND YOU'RE NOT UNABLE TO MAKE
ANY PAYMENTS ON THAT.
IN FIVE YEARS.
COMPOUNDED ANNUALLY IN FIVE
YEARS YOU OWE 1-300-040-0405
DOLLARS AND SIX CENTS.
OVER FIVE TIMES AS MUCH AS YOU
BORROWED FIVE YEARS THAT'S THE
MINIMUM LOAN THIS BILL APPLIES
TO AND THAT'S THE MINIMUM
INTEREST RATE AND THEY'RE
CHARGING OUR CONSTITUENTS.
WAY MORE THAN 40% AND IT ISN'T
DISCLOSED.
TO THEY ARE NOT BEING TOLD IN A
LOT OF THESE PRODUCTS WITH THEIR
THE ACTUAL COST OF THE DEBT THAT
THEY ARE CARING.
MEMBERS EVERY MAJOR WORLD
RELIGION HAS.
COUNSEL AGAINST YOU SIR.
BECAUSE IT DESTROYS COMMUNITIES
AND FAMILIES.
WE NEED TO STAND UP TO PROTECT
THEM.
ON A FREE MARKET CAPITALIST
UNDERSTATED UNASHAMED OF IT.
BUT SOMETIMES WE NEED TO STAND
UP AND PROTECT PEOPLE THAT ARE
BEING PREYED UPON.
YOU HEARD HER SAY ONE THIRD OF
PEOPLE TO BORROW.
FROM THIS PARTICULAR PRODUCT ONE
THIRD DON'T PAY IT BACK.
THEY'RE PUTTING CHANGE ON
THEMSELVES IN THE FORM OF DEBT.
AND THEY NEED OUR HELP I ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MISTER CUNNINGHAM
MISTER GRAYSON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED ON THIS MATTER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I RISE TODAY IS JOINT
AUTHORS OF AB.
FIVE THIRTY NINE AS MY COLLEAGUE
FROM SANTA BARBARA NOTED AB FIVE
THIRTY NINE SEEKS TO BRING MUCH
NEEDED PROTECTIONS AND TO THE
SMALL DOLLAR LENDING SPACE.
AS WE STAND HERE TODAY THERE ARE
PEOPLE IN OUR COMMUNITIES OUR
NEIGHBOURS FRIENDS AND FAMILY.
WHO ARE TAKING OUT LOANS THAT
ARE STRUCTURED TO BE NEARLY
IMPOSSIBLE TO PAY BACK LOANS
THAT ARE DEATH TRAPS AND
PERPETUATE THE CYCLE OF POVERTY?
FOR ITS PART TOO LONG THOSE WHO
HAVE ARGUED AGAINST COMMON SENSE
REFORMS SUCH AS THIS HAVE SAID
THAT PEOPLE NEED ACCESS TO A
HUNDRED AND 50% 2100%. TWO
HUNDRED AND 50% CREDIT BECAUSE
THAT INTEREST RATE REPRESENTS
THE RISK SO OF SUBPRIME LENDING
HOWEVER THE DATA TELLS US THAT
RISK BASED PRICING IS SIMPLY NOT
HAPPENING.
IF LENDERS WERE IN FACT WRITING
LOANS BASED ON RISK YOU WOULD
EXPECT TO SEE LOANS FROM ALL
UNDER SPREAD ACROSS A RANGE OF
INTEREST RATES REPRESENTING ALL
SEGMENTS OF THE SOME PRIVATE
SUBPRIME MARKET.
INSTEAD LOANS FROM TWENTY FIVE
HUNDRED TO FIVE THOUSAND ARE
HEAVILY CONCENTRATED AROUND AND
OVER A 100% APR AND WORST OF ALL
NUMEROUS LENDERS RIGHT NO LOANS
LESS THAN A 100% APR.
WE ALL KNOW THE STORE FRONTS IN
ADVERTISEMENTS THAT WE SEE IN
OUR COMMUNITIES.
IT'S NO COINCIDENCE THAT MOST
HIGH COST LENDERS ARE
CONCENTRATED IN ECONOMICALLY
DISADVANTAGED AREAS OVER THE
YEARS BILLIONS OF DOLLARS HAVE
BEEN EXTRACTED FROM COMMUNITIES.
THAT CAN LEAST AFFORD IT
FORTUNATELY AND HISTORICALLY FOR
THE FIRST TIME THIS REFORM
EFFORT IS SUPPORTED BY A BROAD
COALITION OF LENDERS WHO RIGHT
AND WILL CONTINUE TO WRITE
RESPONSIBLE LOANS INTO THE
SUBPRIME MARKET.
THE LARGEST SINGLE LENDER IN
THIS SPACE IS ALREADY WRITING
LOANS AT LOWER RATES THAN THIS
BILL PROPOSES DESPITE WHAT THE
OPPOSITION WILL FORECAST WE KNOW
LENDING WILL NOT DRY UP BECAUSE
OF THIS BILL.
AB FIVE THIRTY NINE WILL
PRESERVE REAL AND FAIR ACCESS TO
CREDIT WELL IN BEING SOME OF THE
MOST ABUSIVE PREDATORY LOANS IN
OUR STATE AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER GRAYSON MISSED
KAMAGRA OF YOU ARE RECOGNIZED ON
THIS MATTER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I TO
HAVE LENGTHY CONVERSATIONS WITH
THE AUTHOR MY COLLEAGUE FROM
SANTA BARBARA -- BECAUSE IT'S A
COMPLICATED ISSUE.
YOU KNOW IT'S A LARGER ISSUE
THAN WHAT'S IN THIS BILL BUT I
THINK THIS BILL HAS SOME GOOD
ADJUSTMENTS TO HOW WE LAND.
AT THE END OF THE DAY THOUGH
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT POOR PEOPLE.
AND PEOPLE WHO ARE DEEMED
UNDESIRABLES OR HIGH RISK AND
THEY ARE PREYED UPON.
BY PAYDAY LOAN OPERATORS AND
THEY'RE REDLINED BY TRADITIONAL.
LENDING INSTITUTIONS IN THE
REALITY IS [inaudible]
THAT WITH.
OUT THESE ALTERNATIVE FINANCIAL
SERVICE PROVIDERS THOSE FOLKS
WOULD ACTUALLY HAVE NO WHERE
ELSE TO GO.
BECAUSE THEY ARE YOU RACED.
FROM THE APPLICATION PROCESS AND
FROM THE DOORS OF OUR
TRADITIONAL LENDING MARKETS.
BUT WE HAVE TO DO SOMETHING
BECAUSE IF WE DON'T WE WILL
CONTINUE TO ALLOW POOR FOLKS.
AND FOLKS WHO HAVE NO CREDIT OR
BAD CREDIT TO BE PUT IN THIS
DANGEROUS CYCLE OF EVOLVING AND
INCREASING DEBTS.
AND I HOPE THAT AT SOME POINT
AFTER THIS BILL PASSES AND GET
MOVED ON TO THE SENATE.
THAT WE CAN HAVE DIFFERENT
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT HOW WE
INCENTIVIZE ALL KINDS OF
FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONS TO WORK
WITH FOLKS POOR PEOPLE AND FOLKS
WHO HAVE NO CREDIT OR BAD CREDIT
TO HELP THEM REBUILD AND
ESTABLISH THE KIND OF CREDIT
THAT WE ALL HOPE TO HAVE.
SO IT IS WITH THATTHAT I WANT
TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING
THIS BILL FORWARD AND I'LL BE
SUPPORTING IT.
THINKING HAS COME UNDER DENNIS
RUBIO YOU ARE RECOGNIZED ON THIS
MATTER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I RISE TO RESPECTFULLY
VOICE MY CONCERNS WITH THE
POTENTIAL IMPACT.
OF THAT AB FIVE THIRTY NINE WILL
HAVE.
THE BILL CAPS INTEREST RATES ON
CALIFORNIA LICENSE CONSUMERS
FINANCE LOANS OVER TWENTY FIVE
HUNDRED DOLLARS 236%.
ALTHOUGH THE BILL IS DESIGNED TO
HELP CALIFORNIANS WHO CAN LEAST
AFFORD TO PAY HIGH INTEREST
RATES I HAVE CONCERNS I KNOW I
WILL IMPACT SOME OF MY
CONSTITUENTS WOULD NEED THIS
ACCESS TO CAPITAL.
MANY POOR PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA
WHO LIVE PAYCHECK TO PAYCHECK DO
NOT HAVE QUICK ACCESS TO CASH
WHEN THE FALL SHORT.
ON PAYING BILLS AT TIMES IN
ORDER TO GET THROUGH THE WEEK
AND WE SEE FUNDS IMMEDIATELY TO
PUT FOOD ON THE TABLE THESE
ESTABLISHMENTS ARE THEIR ONLY
OPTION.
THIS BILL DOES NOT TAKE AWAY THE
NEED FOR CAPITAL AND I WORRY
THAT THIS UNMET NEED WILL BE
FILLED.
BY ON LICENSE INTERNET OR TYPE
OF LENDERS WHO WILL HAVE NO
INTEREST RATE LIMITS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER BE HONEST
GONZALEZ YOU ARE RECOGNIZED ON
THIS MATTER.
THANK YOU I RISE AND I AM PROUD
SUPPORT AS A CO AUTHOR OF THIS.
AT THIS MEASURE AND I'LL SAY
THIS.
IT IT WASN'T AUTOMATIC THAT I
SUPPORTED THIS WHEN I FIRST CAME
HERE I HAD QUESTIONS AS WELL IN
AND I THINK -- MY COLLEAGUE FROM
LOS ANGELES TO BRINGING UP SOME
OF THOSE ISSUES I LIVE IN AN
EXTREMELY.
ON BANKS UNDER BATES COMMUNITY
IF YOU GO DOWN -- THE MAJOR
STREET IN IN MY HOMETOWN MICE MY
THE AREA I LIVE IN CITY HEIGHTS
EVERY SINGLE BLOCK YOU SEE
LENDERS OF DIFFERENT TYPES.
AND YOU DON'T SEE BANKS AND YOU
CERTAINLY DON'T SEE CREDIT
UNIONS AND SO I UNDERSTAND ANNE
ACTUALLY BELIEVED THAT THEY WERE
NECESSARY FOR SOME FOLKS WHO
OTHERWISE COULDN'T.
HAVE OF THE ACCESS TO CAPITAL
THAT THEY NEED.
BUT OVER THE PAST FEW YEARS AND
BEING HERE AND ACTUALLY
EXPLORING THIS FURTHER YOU
REALIZE THAT'S NOT EXACTLY
WHAT'S HAPPENING.
THERE MANY TIMES -- THAT THE
CHAIR BANKING AND I TALKED ABOUT
DOING THIS AND I HAVE ACTUALLY
DID WHERE YOU GO INTO ONE OF
THESE FOLKS I HAVE A CREDIT
SCORE OF OVER.
EIGHT HUNDRED BUT THEY WERE MORE
THAN HAPPY TO OFFER ME A LARGE A
LOAN AND A VERY LARGE RATE
WITHOUT ANY TYPE OF OF BELIEVE.
IF I HADN'T KNOWN BETTER THAT I
DIDN'T NEED THAT TYPE OF LOAN.
THIS IS NOT SOMETHING THAT
HAPPENS IN A COMMUNITY LIKE MINE
WHERE YOU ACTUALLY HAVE PEOPLE
WHOSE CREDIT NOT ALL OF THEIR
CREDIT IS TERRIBLE.
SOME OF THEM HAVE NO CREDIT
BECAUSE THEY BUT NOT BANKS AND
WE'VE ACTUALLY CREATED PILOT
PROGRAMS TO SERVE THOSE FOLKS AT
THIS RATE AT A 36% RATE.
IT'S POSSIBLE IT'S DOABLE.
THE STORES UNFORTUNATELY ARE
PREYING ON COMMUNITIES LIKE MINE
WHERE THERE ISN'T.
OTHER INFRASTRUCTURE AND WE DO
NEED TO DO MORE I DO UNDERSTAND --
BOTH OF MY COLLEAGUES WE NEED TO
DO MORE TO BRING PEOPLE INTO OUR
COMMUNITIES WE HAVE TO FIGURE
OUT HOW TO INCENTIVIZE LENDING
IN OUR COMMUNITY IS NOT JUST TO
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE ARE HAVING A
HARD TIME.
BUT YOU FOLKS WANT TO START A
SMALL BUSINESS WE REALLY NEED
THIS KIND OF ACCESS TO CAPITAL.
BUT WE HAVE TO STOP WHAT'S
HAPPENING IT IS JUST.
UNCONSCIONABLE IT'S NOT OKAY AND
SO I AM PROUD TO BE PART OF THIS
I KNOW -- THIS IS A TOUGH.
PULL AND I DON'T THINK WE'VE
EVER SEEN THIS KIND OF COALITION
COMING TOGETHER BIPARTISAN.
ACROSS ALL PARTS OF THE STATE TO
FINALLY SAY ENOUGH IS ENOUGH SO
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR NINE OUT THANK YOU MISS AND
SALAS.
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE MISTER SPEAKER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK ON THIS
MATTER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS MEMBERS I RISE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB FIVE THIRTY NINE
AND CONSIDERED TO BE AS
IMPORTANT AS ANY PIECE OF
LEGISLATION WE WILL VOTE ON THIS
YEAR.
WE HAD TRIED BEFORE IN THIS
HOUSE AND IN THIS IN THIS
BUILDING TO AND PREDATORY
LENDING BUT WE MUST SUCCEED THIS
YEAR.
THIS IS NOT JUST A POLITICAL
ISSUE THIS IS A MORAL ISSUE WE
CAN NOT BE COMPLICIT WITH
EXORBITANT INTEREST RATE LOANS.
THAT VICTIMIZE WORKING PEOPLE
WHO LIVE FROM PAYCHECK TO
PAYCHECK.
OPPONENTS OF THIS BILL WILL TELL
YOU THAT IT WILL IT RESTRICT
ACCESS TO CREDIT FOR THE PEOPLE
WHO NEED IT MOST.
THOSE ARE MERELY TALKING POINTS
OF AN INDUSTRY THAT HAS
REPEATEDLY LIED TO MEMBERS OF
THIS BODY.
DOES THE TALKING POINTS OF AN
UNSCRUPULOUS INDUSTRY.
DON'T BE FOOLED BY THEM.
THE ONLY ONES FACING RESTRICTED
ACCESS ARE THOSE LENDERS
THEMSELVES WHO WANT ACCESS TO
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES SO THAT
THEY CAN CONTINUE TO PREY ON
THEM.
WE ALREADY HAVE RESPONSIBLE
LENDERS WITH BILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
AS A BUSINESS SERVING THE SAME
SUBPRIME CONSUMERS.
THOSE LENDERS LIMIT THEMSELVES
TO THE INTEREST RATES IN THIS
BILL.
AND THOSE LENDERS ARE IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL.
PRACTICE OF PREYING ON PEOPLE IN
DESPERATE CIRCUMSTANCES THAT
INCLUDES WORKING PEOPLE WITH
SUDDEN HOSPITAL BILLS?
BORROWING IS NORMAL.
WE DO IT ALL THE TIME WITH
CREDIT CARDS IN WITH HOME LOANS.
BUT LOANS OFFERED AT RATES THAT
COURTS HAVE ALREADY FOUND ON
REASONABLE.
DO NOT HELP BORROWERS AT RISK I
ASK YOU TO VOTE YES ON IB AB.
FIVE THIRTY NINE THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER SOMEONE YOU MAY
CLOSE.
I THINK WE'VE HEARD TODAY.
BOTH THE STRUGGLES WE'VE HAD TO
GET HERE TO GET TO THIS MOMENT.
BUT I WANT TO ALSO REMIND PEOPLE
THAT THIS IS CLEARLY MOVING THE
NEEDLE. FOR THE FOR THE LAST
FOURTEEN YEARS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
HAS TRIED TO DO SOMETHING ABOUT
A PRODUCT THAT HAS FAILED
CALIFORNIANS. HUNDRED THOUSAND
PEOPLE YOUR DEFAULT.
IN OUR STATE. TWENTY THOUSAND
PEOPLE A YEAR IN OUR STATE LOSE
THEIR CAR BECAUSE OF THIS
PRODUCT [inaudible]
THIS BILL.
IS OUR ATTEMPT TO MOVE FORWARD
IT'S OUR ATTEMPT TO MAINTAIN A
RESPONSIBLE AND HENCE HEALTHY
FINANCIAL PRODUCTS ON THE MARKET.
AND STILL ALLOW ACCESS TO
CAPITAL.
THIS IS BEEN TESTED THIS RATE
pTHIRTY EIGHT OTHER STATES HAVE
TESTED IT.
AS HAS OUR FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
WHEN THEY IMPLEMENTED THAT
MILITARY LENDING ACT.
WE KNOW THAT WE WILL MAINTAIN.
ACCESS TO CAPITAL. FOR THOSE
THAT HAVE WORRIED ABOUT
BUSINESSES GOING AWAY FROM
CALIFORNIA.
pBY RESPONSIBLE LENDERS.
A BILL THAT TELLS YOU THAT THE
BUSINESSES WHO ARE DOING THE
BEST THING AND OFFERING CAPITAL.
WILL STAY HERE.
AND THEY ARE READY TO MOVE
FORWARD.
YOU HAVE BUSINESSES THAT ARE
TELLING YOU THAT THEY'RE LOOKING
FOR REGULATORY STABILITY.
BECAUSE JUST LAST YEAR.
OUR CALIFORNIA SUPREME COURT.
UNANIMOUSLY SAID THAT THESE THIS
PRODUCT WAS UNCONSCIONABLE.
THEY DIDN'T KNOW THE RATE BUT
THEY KNEW THERE WAS A PROBLEM.
YOU ALSO HAVE.
THE THREAT OF THE BALLOT
INITIATIVE.
LOTS OF DISCUSSIONS ABOUT WHAT
THE RATE COULD BE.
THE 36% HAS BEEN TESTED.
IT'S BEEN A STANDARD FOR OUR
ACTIVE MEMBERS OF THE MILITARY.
AND IT'S SOMETHING THAT
CALIFORNIA CAN DO AND SHOULD DO.
THIS DOES NOT ELIMINATE OUR NEED.
TO CONTINUE TO ADDRESS THE ROOT
CAUSE OF THIS WHICH IS POVERTY.
FINANCIAL PRODUCTS SHOULD NOT BE
A SUBSTITUTE FOR CORE ISSUES
LIKE POVERTY AND THAT'S WHAT
THIS PRODUCT HAS BECOME.
MEMBERS I ASK THAT YOU CONSIDER
VOTING IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
BECAUSE CALIFORNIANS NEED US TO
PROTECT THEM CALIFORNIANS NEED
US TO DO THE RIGHT THING.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE [inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY THE VOTE
AYE AYES FIFTY SEVEN NO ZERO
THIS MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING TO VIOLATED NINETY FOUR
AB FIVE FORTY THE CLERK WILL
READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE FORTY BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER THE MON AND
ACTUALLY TO POST SECONDARY
EDUCATION.
MS Là M<c.cyan> YOU ARE AGAIN</c>
RECOGNIZED FOR THIS MATTER.
MEMBERS BECAUSE YOU HAVEN'T HAD
ENOUGH OF ME TODAY -- I AM
BRINGING FORWARD AB FIVE FORTY
R. DREAMER INCENTIVE GRANT
MEMBERS AS WE THINK ABOUT HOW TO
SUPPORT TO US ALL.
HIGHER ED STUDENTS I WANT IS TO
THINK ABOUT WAYS THAT WE CAN
SUPPORT -- STUDENTS WHO ARE
DREAMERS.
AB FIVE FORTY LAW ALLOWS FOR
STUDENTS WHO ARE AND DOCUMENTED
TO BE PART OF OUR UNIVERSITIES
THROUGH IN STATE TUITION THIS
ALLOWS US TO EXPAND OUR SUPPORT
AS CALIFORNIANS FOR EIGHTY FIVE
FORTY STUDENTS AND DREAMERS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS SOMEONE SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THIS MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE AYE AYES FIFTY
ONE KNOWS ELEVEN THIS MEASURE
PASSES.
FILE ITEM NINETY FIVE AB FIVE
FIFTY THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE FIFTY BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FLOOR AND OTHERS
AND ACTUALLY THE VETERANS MR FOR
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED ON THIS
MATTER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I RISE
TODAY TO PRESENT AB FIVE FIFTY
WHICH WOULD ESTABLISH A MEDICAL
FOSTER HOME PILOT PROGRAM.
MEDICAL FOSTER HOMES ARE AN
OPPORTUNITY GIVE ELIGIBLE
VETERANS TO LIVE IN AFFORDABLE
PRIVATE HOME ENVIRONMENT RATHER
THAN INSTITUTIONAL SETTING.
AB FIVE FIFTIES A PATHWAY TO
MAKING THAT POSSIBLE
RESPECTFULLY ASK DR -- THANK YOU
MISTER FLORA SEEING AND HEARING
NO FURTHER DEBATE ON THIS MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ON MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
QUIRK WELL CLOSE THE ROLLING
TALLY THE VOTE I SIXTY SIX KNOWS
YOUR THIS MEASURE PASSES BY
LIGHTING SEVENTY SIX IN NINETY
SEVEN WILL TEMPORARILY PASS.
FILE ITEM NINETY EIGHT AB SIX OH
SEVEN THE CORPORATION.
ASSEMBLY BILL SIX OR SEVEN BY
SOMETHING MEMBER CARILLO AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY TO PROBATION.
HIS CAREER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
OPEN ON THIS MATTER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER THAN
MEMBERS I'M HERE 2% AB SIX OH
SEVEN A MODEST BUT IMPORTANT
REFORM TO OUR CURRENT SENTENCING.
AND JUDICIAL PRACTICES FOR
CERTAIN ON SIRIUS A NON VIOLENT
DRUG OFFENSES.
CURRENT LAW PROHIBITS JUDGES TO
EVALUATE ALL THE CIRCUMSTANCES
OF A CASE AND APPLY THEIR
DISCRETION IN SENTENCING.
INSTEAD JUDGES ARE FORCED TO
CHARGE AND INCARCERATE PEOPLE
WHO WOULD BE BETTER TREATED AND
SUPERVISED IN THEIR COMMUNITIES
UNDER PROBATION.
AB SIX OH SEVEN ALLOWS JUDGES TO
USE THEIR DISCRETION TO ORDER
PROBATION SERVICES FOR OFFENSES
THAT CURRENTLY MANDATE
INCARCERATION INTO COUNTY JAILS
OR STATE PRISONS.
THIS BILL DOES NOT CHANGE
SENTENCING STRUCTURE OR
EFFECTIVE MAXIMUM SENTENCES.
THIS BILL ALSO HAS NO OPPOSITION.
UNDER AB SIX OH SEVEN JUDGES
WILL STILL CHOOSE TO SEND
INDIVIDUALS TO PRISON OR JAIL
BUT ALLOWS JUDGES TO WEIGH THE
FACTS AND USE OTHERS OTHER
AVENUES TO ACHIEVE.
JUSTICE.
PROBATION PROVIDE SERVICES SUCH
AS EFFECTIVE DRUG TREATMENT.
THAT MAY NOT BE AVAILABLE AND
ALL COUNTY JAILS.
JUST LAST YEAR CONGRESS PASSED
AND THE PRESIDENT SIGNED THE
FIRST STEP ACT INCLUDING AN
EXPANSION.
OF COURT DISCRETION FROM
MANDATORY MINIMUMS AND A
REDUCTION IN SENTENCES FOR DRUG
OFFENSES.
AB SIX OH SEVEN IS CONTINUING
THE NATIONAL DISCUSSION AROUND
JUDICIAL INDEPENDENCE OVER
SENTENCING AND MASS
INCARCERATION.
THERE IS OVERWHELMING BIPARTISAN
CONSENSUS THAN MANDATORY
MINIMUMS FOR DRUG OFFENSES NEED
TO BE REPEALED AND GREATLY
AMENDED.
JUDGES MUST BE ABLE TO EVALUATE
CRIMES AND GRANT PROBATION.
WHEN IT IS THE INTEREST OF
JUSTICE AND IN THE INTEREST OF
PUBLIC SAFETY AND IT'S
CONSISTENT WITH THE VALUES OF
OUR COMMUNITIES I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE?
THANK YOU MISS CARILLO SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THIS MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE WRONG.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE [inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY THE VOTE
ICE FORTY FIVE NEWS TWELVE THIS
MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING BACK TO FILE ITEM TEN AB
THIRTEEN NINETEEN THE CLERK WILL
READ.
A CYNICAL THIRTEEN NINETEEN BY
SOME REMEMBER ARAMBULA AND
ACTUALLY THE MIGRANT EDUCATION.
SIR RAMBLE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED ON
THIS MATTER THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND BEFORE I BEGIN I
WANT TO THANK MY COLLEAGUE FROM
OAKLAND WHO SHEPHERDED THIS BILL
WHILE I WAS INDISPOSED.
BUT THIS IS A BILL ABOUT MIGRANT
EDUCATION AND I WANTED TO TALK
ABOUT ONE MIGRANT STUDENTS IN
PARTICULAR.
AND THAT'S MY FATHER.
MY FATHER WHEN HE WAS A STUDENT
GREW UP WORKING THE FIELDS MUCH
LIKE MY GRANDPARENTS DID AND
MOVED AROUND OUR GREAT STATE.
BUT THERE WERE TIMES WHEN HE HAD
DIFFICULTIES ACCESSING EDUCATION
LIKE OTHER STUDENTS BECAUSE AS
THE SEASONS CHANGED.
HIS JOB MOVED.
THIS BILL BEFORE YOU TODAY WILL
ALLOW MIGRANT STUDENTS THE
OPTION OF RETURNING TO THE
SCHOOL IN WHICH THEY WERE
CONTINUING THEIR EDUCATION.
INSTEAD OF WHERE THEIR CURRENT
RESIDENCE IS.
BECAUSE EXISTING SCHOOL BOARD
DISTRICT POLICIES REQUIRE
STUDENTS TO ENROLL IN THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT OF THEIR RESIDENTS.
IT REQUIRES MIGRANT STUDENTS TO
ALMOST EVERY YEAR RE LOCATE AND
RE ENROLL.
THIS LEADS TOWARDS MIGRANT
STUDENTS HAVING HIGHER DROP OUT
RATE THAN TRADITIONAL STUDENTS
AND I ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT IN
HELPING US TO PROTECT THE NEARLY
ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND MIGRANT
STUDENTS THAT OUR STATE HAS.
AND SUPPORT AB THIRTEEN NINETEEN
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU MISTER ARAMBULA SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THIS MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ON MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE I SIXTY KNOWS
HERE THIS MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEMS NINETY NINE THROUGH
ONE HUNDRED ONE PASS TEMPORARILY
IN FILE ITEM. ONE OH TWO EIGHTY
SIX FIFTY SEVEN THE CLERK WILL
READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL SIX FIFTY SEVEN BY
SOMETHING MEMBER EIGHT MEN AND
ACTUALLY TO AGRICULTURE MAKE IN
PREPARATION THEREFORE.
SEGMENT YOU ARE RECOGNIZED ON
THIS MATTER THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MA'AM SPEAKER THE MEMBERS.
AB SIX FIFTY SEVEN EXTENDS A
SUNSET ON COMMERCIAL FEED
LICENSE INSPECTION FOR FIVE
YEARS ENSURING THAT YOUR POULTRY
AND LIVESTOCK FOOD IS HEALTHY I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS EGGMAN SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THIS MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS GO TO DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALONG MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE
TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLUES THE ROLAND
TALLY THE VOTE I FIFTY NINE
KNOWS YOUR THIS MEASURE PASSES.
MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER SIR TO PURSUANT TO
ASSEMBLY RULE NINETY SIX A
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO RE
REFER A. B..
EIGHT FIFTY FOUR MASON
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE TO THE
RULES COMMITTEE WITHOUT
OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE THE
ORDER.
FILE ITEMS ONE OH THREE THREE
ONE OH SIX WILL PASS TEMPORARILY
FILE ITEM ONE OH SEVEN AB SIX
SEVENTY SEVEN THE CLERK WILL
READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL SIX SEVENTY SEVEN
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHOI AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY TO ENTER
COUNTY ADOPTION.
MISTER CHOI YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
ON THIS MATTER [inaudible]
MADAM SPEAKER AND THE MEMBERS
SIZE STAND TODAY 2%.
SB SIX SEVEN SEVEN THIS BILL IS
A SIMPLE OR TOO MANY TARIAN
BUILT TO SAVE INTERNATIONALLY
ADOPTED CHILDREN BY US CITIZENS.
FROM BECOMING UNDOCUMENTED OR
ILLEGAL.
WHO WOULD BE SUBJECT TO
DEPORTATION LATER IN LIFE?
IF AND WHEN THEY RUN INTO THE
LAW.
MOST OF THESE CHILDREN WHO ARE
BROUGHT INTO THE U. S. ALL OF
VERY YOUNG AROUND. ONE TWO WHAT
THREE EVEN FIVE YEARS OLD.
BY -- OF GOING THROUGH A
STRINGENT US EDIBLE REQUIREMENTS
ALL OF THE HOME COUNTRY THE
PROBLEM BEGINNING BEGINS SO WHEN
THEY ARRIVE IN CALIFORNIA.
CURRENTLY CALIFORNIA YES I WANT
DONE LAOS TO STATES.
THAT STILL REQUIRES A REAL TOP --
ADOPTION IN CERTAIN SITUATIONS.
THIS PROCESS -- REQUIRES SO
LEGAL STEPS OF FOR PARENTS AT
AND UNFORTUNATELY YOU FOR SOME
CHILDREN THIS IS -- NOT FOLLOWED
THROUGH AND THE CREATES A
PROBLEM I HAVE WELL MANY SAID
THE CASES SO THAT -- HOLD.
WE REALLY TONE ARM WHEN I SEE
THE REPEATED US SO I CAN SHE HAD
THE WHOLE STORY SO IF YOU WANT
TO I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
I'VE WORKED.
THANK YOU MISTER CHOICE SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THIS MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS OF THOSE WHO DESIRE
TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
INTELLIGENT EYES FIFTY FIVE NO
ZERO THIS MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM ONE AWAIT AB SIX
SEVENTY EIGHT THE CLERK WILL
READ ASSEMBLY WILL SIX SEVENTY
EIGHT BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER FLORA
AND ACTUALLY MEDI CAL MR FOR YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED IN THIS MATTER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I RISE
TO PRESENT AB SIX SEVENTY EIGHT
WHICH WOULD RESTORE PODIATRIC
COVERAGE UNDER MEDICARE AL AND
MAKE AUTHORIZATIONS BILLION.
AND POLICIES CONSISTENT WITH
THOSE IN A POSITION PERFORMING
THE SAME SERVICES AS YOU MAY
KNOW THE BUDGET CUTS IN TWO
THOUSAND NINE A LIMITED PRIOR TO
SERVICES UNDER MEDICARE.
BECAUSE OF THIS LIMITATIONS HAVE
LEAD TO COSTLY DELAYS IN FOOT
TREATMENT MOST OFTEN RESULTING
PATIENTS WAITING.
STILL SO BAD THE REQUIRES A
COSTLY ER VISIT AB SIX SEVEN
EIGHT WOULD STREAMLINE THE
POLICIES WERE PROVIDE BETTER
HEALTH OUTCOMES FOR MOST BLOCKS
LOCAL POPULATION.
RESPECTFULLY ASK PRIVATE.
THANK YOU MISTER FLORA SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THIS MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
PHAM MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE ICE FIFTY FOUR NO
ZERO THIS MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM ONE OH NINE
TEMPORARILY PASS BY LEN ONE TEN
EIGHTY SIX EIGHTY FIVE THE CLERK
WILL READ.
SOME LEGAL SIX EIGHTY FIVE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER REYES AND OTHERS
ACTUALLY THE JUVENILES MISS
REYES YOU ARE RECOGNIZED OPEN ON
THIS MATTER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS AB SIX EIGHTY FIVE
PROVIDES MUCH NEEDED ASSISTANCE
TWO TRIBES AND THEIR MEMBERS IN
ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THEY ARE
ADEQUATELY REPRESENTED IN TRIBAL
CHILD WELFARE CASES.
IN NINETEEN SEVENTY EIGHT
CONGRESS PASSED A QUORUM THE
INDIAN CHILD WELFARE ACT TO
PROTECT THE INTERESTS OF TRIBAL
CHILDREN AND PROMOTE STABILITY
AND SECURITY FOR TRIBES AND
THEIR MEMBER FAMILIES.
HOWEVER CALIFORNIA LEADS THE
NATION IT QUIRK APPEALS IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN CALIFORNIA HAD
ONE HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE OF THE
NATION'S TWO HUNDRED SIX
APPEALED CASES.
IN SECOND PLACE WAS ALASKA WITH
ONLY THREE APPEALS THIS
ILLUSTRATES THE DRAMATIC LEVEL
OF WHICH CALIFORNIA GENERAL'S
OFFICE ESTABLISHED IN IT WILL
COMPLIANCE TASK FORCE.
IN.
TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN THE TASK
FORCE CONCLUDED THAT MANY TRIBES
DO NOT HAVE RESOURCES SUFFICIENT
TO RETAIN COUNSEL LEAVING TRIBES
AS A SOUL I'M REPRESENT A PARTY.
IN TRYING TO CHILD WELFARE CASES
WERE EQUAL APPLIES.
MY PASSING AB SIX EIGHTY FIVE
THE RECOMMENDATION OF THE TO
THIS TASK FORCE WILL FINALLY BE
FULFILLED BY STOP USING A GRANT
PROGRAM TO HELP FINANCIALLY
SUPPORT.
TRIBES AND THEIR FAMILIES IN IT
COURT CASES.
DOING THIS HELPS TO ENSURE
APPROPRIATE DUE PROCESS FOR
TRIBAL COMMUNITIES IN CHILD
WELFARE CASES WHICH IS WHY THIS
BILL HAS RECEIVED UNANIMOUS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT.
DURING THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU MISS FRANCIS
DRAMAS YOU ARE RECOGNIZED ON
THIS MATTER THANK YOU.
MADAM SPEAKER AND AND I THINK MY
JOIN AUTHOR AND MY COLLEAGUE
FROM SUMMER DO YOU KNOW WHICH
YOU REPRESENT IN THE INLAND
EMPIRE TOGETHER.
AND ONE FIFTH OF AWFULLY
RECOGNIZED TRIBES ARE IN
CALIFORNIA.
OF THAT NUMBER THE STATE IS HOME
TO APPROXIMATELY SEVEN HUNDRED
AND TWENTY THREE THOUSAND THERE
IS MORE THAT'S MORE POPULATION
ANY OTHER STATE.
IN THE NATION.
WHEN WE'RE DISCUSSING THE ISSUES
SURROUNDING THE INDIAN CHILD
WELFARE ACT IS ONE THAT INVOLVES
A POPULATION THAT IS MOST
DISPROPORTIONATELY REPRESENTED
IN CHILD WELFARE?
THIS BILL WILL ADDRESS THE GAPS
EXISTING WITHIN OUR COURSE TO
PROVIDE CRITICAL LEGAL SERVICES
THAT WILL ENSURE TRIBAL CHILDREN
AND FAMILIES CAN NAVIGATE THE
CHILDREN THE INDIAN CHILD
WELFARE ACT.
IN THE END WE WANT TO ENSURE
THAT THE INDIAN CHILD WELFARE
ACT FUNCTIONS TO THE BE THE BEST
INTEREST OF INDIAN CHILDREN IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
BRINGING FAMILIES TOGETHER I
THANK THE AUTHOR AND TO OUR
COLLEAGUES I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MR RAMA'S WALDRON YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED ON THIS MATTER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS AS PRINCIPAL CALL AUTHOR
I RISE IN SUPPORT OF AB.
SIX EIGHTY FIVE NOT EVERY EVERY
COURT APPOINTED LEGAL COUNSELORS
TRAINED TO MANAGE INTRICATE
INDIAN CHILD WELFARE CASES.
AND NOT EVERY EVERY TRIBE HAS
THE FINANCIAL CAPACITY. TO
PROVIDE THEIR OWN LEGAL COUNSEL.
AND SO CALIFORNIA LEADS THE
NATION IN INDIAN CHILD WELFARE
ACT APPEALS THIS BILL WOULD
RECTIFY THAT ISSUE.
SB SIX EIGHTY FIVE WOULD PROVIDE
MUCH NEEDED TRAINING AND ACCESS
TO LEGAL COUNSEL FOR TRIBAL
CHILDREN AND THEIR FAMILIES I
URGE AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS WALDRON MISS
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE THIS RACE WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE.
WOULD LIKE TO THANK MY JOINT
AUTHORS FOR THEIR COMMENTS
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR IPHONE.
QUIRK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS OF THOSE WHO DESIRE
TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRED OF
THE CLICK WELL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE I SIXTY FOUR NEWS
HERE THIS MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM ONE ELEVEN A. B. SEVEN
OH ONE THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN OH ONE BY
SOMETHING MEMBER WEBER AND
ACTUALLY TO EXONERATED PRISONERS
DOCTOR WEBER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
ON THIS MATTER YES MADAM SPEAKER
SAID MEMBERS I'M HERE TO PRESENT
TO YOU AB SEVEN OH ONE THAT THIS
BILL SEEKS GIVING HOUSING
ASSISTANCE TO INDIVIDUALS WHO
HAVE BEEN WRONGFULLY CONVICTED.
AB SEVERAL ONE BILLS ON THE
PREVIOUS WORK TO RIGHT THE
WRONGS FOR PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN
FAILED IN THE MOST HARMFUL WAY.
THIS BILL ENTITLED EXONERATES TO
FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR
HOUSING COSTS UPON RELEASE AND
ALLOW THEM TO SEE FUNDS FOR
REASONABLE HOUSING COSTS AFTER
THEIR RELEASE TO HELP REBUILD
THEIR LIVES AND WE JOIN THEIR
COMMUNITIES.
THIS BILL SPONSORED BY THE
EXONERATED NATION IN CALIFORNIA
ATTORNEYS FOR CRIMINAL JUSTICE
AND SUPPORTED BY THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION
ELLA BAKER CENTER FOR HUMAN
RIGHTS THE DRUG POLICY ALLIANCE
AND TENANTS TOGETHER.
THIS BILL HAS RECEIVED NO NO
VOTES AND HAS NO OPPOSITION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU DOCTOR WEBER SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THIS MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS GO TO DESIRED VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE I SIXTY TWO NEWS
HERE THIS MEASURE PASSES.
WE WILL TAKE A RECESS UNDER CALL
OF THIS SPEAKER LUNCH WILL BE
SERVED IN.
THE RULES ROOM FOR THE
REPUBLICAN CAUCUS AND IN THE
MEMBERS LINE FOR THE DEMOCRATIC
CAUCUS WE WILL BE BACK.
ON FILE AT ONE PM.
HOUSE IN THE BRIEF RECESS
IS
BACK IN SESSION PLEASE REPORTS
OF THE FLOOR
.
MEMBERS PLEASE REPORT TO THE
FLOOR WE LIKE TO COMMENCE WITH
BUSINESS
.
WE CAN ENTERTAIN A VOTE CHANGE
NOW MISTER CHOI YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR VOTE CHANGE.
THANK YOU STEVEN CHOI FOR IT AB.
THREE SIXTY EIGHT NO TO NOT
VOTING.
VOTE CHANGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHOI
ASSEMBLY BILL THREE SIXTY EIGHT
NO TO NOT VOTING.
MR FONG YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR A
CHANGE.
AB -- FIVE HUNDRED BUT CHANGE I
TO NOT VOTING.
MR MAYES YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
ABOUT.
USE ME THE CLERK WILL REPEAT
VOTE CHANGE FONG ASSEMBLY BILL --
FIVE HUNDRED TO NOT VOTING.
MR MAYES YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR VOTE CHANGE I HAVE TO AB
THREE OH TWO I TO NOT VOTING.
VOTE CHANGE MAYES ASSEMBLY BILL
THREE OH TWO ARE NOT VOTING.
AND AB THREE THREE ONE I TO NOT
VOTING.
WELL CHANGE MAYES ASSEMBLY BILL
THREE THIRTY ONE I TO NOT
LOADING
.
FILE ITEM ONE NINETEEN AB EIGHT
HUNDRED THE CLERK WILL READ.
SOME PEOPLE EIGHT HUNDRED BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KANSEN CHU
ANOTHER'S INOCULATED CIVIL
ACTIONS.
MR TO YOU ARE RECOGNIZED OPEN ON
THIS MATTER THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER.
AND SOME MEMBERS OF THE ASSEMBLY
HERE.
I AM HERE 2% AB.
EIGHT HUNDRED IT'S A BILL WHICH
WILL ALLOW PARTICIPANT IN THE
SECRETARY SECRETARY OFF THE
STATE.
SAFE AT HOME PROGRAM TO FILE
COURT DOCUMENTS AND USING NAMES
LIKE JAMES OR JOHN TOLD.
THE SAVE AL HOME PROGRAM ALLOW
VICTIMS OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
STALKING AND HUMAN TRAFFICKING.
TO USE TO SECRETARY OF THE
STATE'S ADDRESS ON THEIR PUBLIC
RECORD IN ORDER TO PREVENT
POTENTIAL.
IF YOU FROM THE ASYLUM.
I'M TED THE PURPOSE OF AB.
EIGHT HUNDRED IS TO ALLOW
PROGRAM PARTICIPANTS TO EXTEND
THEIR CONFIDENTIALITY AND ALLOW
FLYING FILING COURT MATTERS
WITHOUT FEAR THAT THE
PARTICIPANT'S NAME WILL APPEAR
ON THE PUBLIC.
CORD RECORD THIS BILL WAS ON
CONSENT IN THE POLICY COMMITTEES%
AND HAVE STRONG BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHOOSE SEEING
AND HEARING MY FOR THE DEBATE ON
THIS MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THEIR OWN.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRED
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE [inaudible]
AND THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE
ROLE IN TALLY THOUGH IT ICE
FIFTY NO ZERO THIS MEASURE
PASSES.
FILE ITEMS ONE EIGHTEEN ONE
TWENTY ONE TWENTY ONE PASS
TEMPORARILY FILE AND ONE TWENTY
TO PASS TEMPORARILY.
VIOLATE ONE TWENTY THREE AB
EIGHT FORTY TO THE CLERK WILL
READ.
SOME PEOPLE EIGHT FORTY TWO BY
SOME REMEMBER THE BONE ANOTHER'S
ACCOLADES SHOUTED TRADITION MR
MON YOU ARE RECOGNIZED OPEN ON
THIS MATTER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER ASSEMBLY
BILL EIGHT FOUR TWO WILL ENSURE
THAT ALL ELIGIBLE LOW INCOME
PUBLIC SCHOOL STUDENTS INCLUDING
OUR YOUNGEST LEARNERS ARE
GUARANTEED ACCESS TO NUTRITIOUS
FREE.
OR LOW COST MEAL DURING EACH
PROGRAM DAY WHILE ATTENDING
PRESCHOOL OR CHILD CARE AT A
PUBLIC SCHOOL OR CALIFORNIA
STATE PRESCHOOL PROGRAM NO CHILD
SHOULD GO HUNGRY WHILE ATTENDING
A CALIFORNIA SUBSIDIZED
CHILDCARE OR PRESCHOOL WHETHER
IN SCHOOL PRIEST.
WHETHER IN SCHOOL PRESCHOOL OR
IN CHILDCARE ALL TRUE ALL
CHILDREN NEED ACCESS TO MEALS TO
HEALTHY MEALS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS LIMóN SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THIS MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED IS THERE TO
VOTE.
LONG MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
QUIRK WELL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TELL ME THAT I FIFTY ONE KNOWS
YOUR THIS MEASURE PASSES
.
WHEN A FILE ITEM THREE NINETY
SEVEN AB ONE SIXTY ONE THE CLERK
WILL READ?
SOME PEOPLE ONE SIXTY ONE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TING AND OTHERS
AN ACCOLADE A SOLID WASTE MR
TING YOU ARE RECOGNIZED OPEN ON
THIS MATTER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER.
AB SIX ONE SIX ONE IS OUR IS MY
SKIP THE SLIP BILL.
OF THIS GET THE FOOT BILL
REQUIRES ON JANUARY TWENTY FIVE
JANUARY.
ONE TWENTY TWENTY THAT
BUSINESSES PROVIDE PAPER
RECEIPTS UPON REQUEST.
ALSO IN CHEN BY JANUARY FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR IT ALLOWS
CUSTOMERS TO CHOOSE BETWEEN
THREE OPTIONS ASKING ASKING FOR
IT NO RECEIPT.
IN E. RECEIPT OR A PAPER RECEIPT.
IN ADDITION WE ADDED
SIGNIFICANTLY MORE EXEMPTIONS TO
ASSIST SMALL BUSINESSES SO THAT
SMALL BUSINESSES THAT GROSS
UNDER TWO MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR
WILL BE EXEMPT FROM OUR
LEGISLATION.
IN ADDITION WE ALSO ADDED
AMENDMENTS IN APPROPRIATIONS
THAT.
BUSINESSES THAT USE BPA SLASH B.
P. S. FREE PAPER.
AND ALSO DO NOT INCLUDE
NONESSENTIAL INFORMATION MEETING
INFORMATION THAT'S NOT PERTINENT
TO THE RECEIPT.
IT WOULD ALSO BE EXEMPT ALSO
HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS ARE ALSO
EXEMPT -- THE REASON WE'RE DOING
THE BILL IS WE HAVE A PROBLEM
THAT EVERY SINGLE PIECE ALMOST
EVERY SINGLE PIECE OF RECEIPT
THAT WE HAVE IS ACTUALLY LACED
WITH BPA OR BE PS WHICH MEANT
MANY OF US KNOW IS A VERY TOXIC
CHEMICAL.
IN FACT WE WENT TO THE
EXTRAORDINARY LIMIT TO ACTUALLY
MAKE SURE THAT BABY BOTTLES.
AND BOTTLES THAT WE DRINK WATER
OUT OF DON'T HAVE B. P. IT.
YET EVERY DAY WE ARE EXPOSING
OURSELVES TO THIS KIND OF
CHEMICAL BY TOUCHING THE
RECEIPTS THAT WE'RE GETTING
WE'RE JUST BUYING EVERYDAY
PRODUCTS.
IN ADDITION TO MAKE THESE
RECEIPTS NATIONALLY WE ARE USING
APPROXIMATELY THREE MILLION
TREES AND NINE BILLION.
GALLONS OF WATER.
WE'RE AT A STAGE NOW WITH THESE
RECEIPTS ARE DIFFICULT TO
RECYCLE BECAUSE THEY ARE VERY
SMALL AND IT'S HARD FOR MANY OF
THE MACHINES TO CATCH.
ALSO IN ADDITION THEY DON'T
COMPOST SO WITH SAN FRANCISCO
WHERE WE HAVE COMPOST I WAS
ACTUALLY SHOCKED TO LEARN
BECAUSE OF THIS CHEMICAL WHEN I
WAS PUTTING IT INTO MY COMPOST
BIN.
IT ACTUALLY WAS POLLUTING OUR
COMPOST SO AGAIN BY JUST MAKING
THERE'S MUCH MORE OF A ASK FOR
THE PAPER RECEIPT RATHER THAN
MAKE SURE THAT EVERYBODY GETS
THAT.
WE THINK WE CAN SAVE A LOT OF
PAPER REDUCE A LOT OF WAYS AND
ALSO HELP STOP EXPOSURE TO SOME
VERY DANGEROUS CHEMICALS WITHOUT
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE
ON AB.
ONE SIXTY ONE THANK YOU MISTER
CHANG SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THIS MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
THE ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE
TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
THIS BILL NEEDS FORTY ONE ALL
MEMBERS VOTED A THIRD OF A
MR
TEAM IS A CALL [inaudible]
THE FILE.
SOME PEOPLE SEVEN NINETY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER TAKEN OUT RELATE
TO RECYCLING.
MR TING YOU ARE RECOGNIZED OPEN
ON THIS MATTER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AB SEVEN
NINETY TWO ESTABLISHES.
A TIME FRAME TO HAVE A MINIMUM
RECYCLING CONTENT.
IN OUR PLASTIC BEVERAGE BOTTLES
UNFORTUNATELY ABOUT A YEAR AND A
HALF AGO MUCH OF THE RECYCLING
THAT WE WERE PUTTING INTO OUR
BLUE BINS WHICH WAS BEING
SHIPPED OVERSEAS TO CHINA.
CHANGED BECAUSE CHINA STOP
TAKING MUCH OF THAT WASTE.
SO UNFORTUNATELY WHAT MANY
PEOPLE ACTUALLY HAVEN'T EVEN
REALIZE IS MUCH OF THAT
RECYCLING THAT WE THOUGHT WAS
ACTUALLY GETTING RECYCLED.
IS GOING EITHER TO LANDFILL
GOING INTO THE OCEAN BEING
INCINERATED.
THE ONE THING IT'S NOT BEING IS
RECYCLED.
AND SO WHAT WE'VE WANTED TO DO
WAS TO TRY TO CREATE GUIDELINES
AND GOALS WHERE WE ACTUALLY HAVE
A MINIMUM AMOUNT OF RECYCLING.
IN EVERY -- BEVERAGE BOTTLE IN
CALIFORNIA.
MANY COMPANIES HAVE ALREADY DONE
THIS IF YOU IF YOU GET A NAKED
JUICE BOTTLE THEY ALREADY
ADVERTISED THEIR THAT THEIR
BOTTLES 1100% RECYCLED.
IF YOU TALK TO THE WATER
COMPANIES OF NESTLE IN NIAGARA
THEY'RE ALMOST AT 30% RECYCLED
CONTENT SO THIS CAN BE DONE.
EUROPE IN FACT THE EUROPEAN
UNION ALREADY JUST ESTABLISHED.
GUIDELINES INCLUDING GOALS WERE
THE EUROPEAN UNION HAS PLEDGED
TO DO 25% BY TWENTY TWENTY FIVE
AND 30% BY.
TWENTY THIRTY SO OUR BILL
ESTABLISHES THE FOLLOWING
GUIDELINES WE WANT TO HAVE. 25%
BY 202150% BY TWENTY TWENTY FIVE
IN 75%.
BY.
TWENTY THIRTY AND WE BELIEVE BY
SETTING THE GOAL GETTING THESE
GUIDELINES THEN THE PLASTIC
BOTTLES THAT WE HOPE TO ACTUALLY
GET RECYCLED WILL ACTUALLY BE
RECYCLED.
NOT SOMEWHERE ELSE INCH LIKE
CHINA OR SOME OTHER OVERSEAS
MARKETS.
RIGHT HERE IN CALIFORNIA WELL WE
ACTUALLY HAVE FACTORIES WAITING
AND WANTING TO TAKE THIS PRODUCT
RECYCLING.
IN SELL IT BACK IN SO WE THINK
THIS WILL HELP CALIFORNIA
BUSINESSES THIS WILL MAKE SURE
THAT THE BOTTLES THAT WE ARE
THINKING ARE GETTING RECYCLE
ACTUALLY BE RECYCLED.
AND WE THINK THIS WILL MAKE A
HUGE DIFFERENCE FOR THE
ENVIRONMENT JUST ONE SCARY NO.
IF WE DON'T DO ANYTHING ABOUT
OUR PLASTICS AND I KNOW WE HAVE
OTHER -- PLASTICS BILLS COMING
UP BUT IN THE NEXT COUPLE DAYS
IF WE DON'T DO ANYTHING ABOUT
WHAT WE'RE DOING WITH PLASTICS
WE WILL HAVE MORE PLASTIC IN THE
OCEAN.
THAN FISH BY.
TWENTY FIFTY SO MEMBERS THAT'S A
PRETTY SCARY THOUGHT SO WITHOUT
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE
ON A. B..
SEVEN NINE TWO YOU MISTER KING
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THIS MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
ALL MEMBERS VOTED IS THERE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
STILL NEEDS FORTY ONE NOW
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE AYE AYES FORTY
ONE KNOWS.
ELEVEN THAT MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEMS ONE TWENTY FOUR
THROUGH ONE TWENTY SIX WILL PASS
TEMPORARILY FILE ITEM ONE TWENTY
SEVEN A. B. NINE TWENTY SEVEN
THE CLERK WILL READ. NINE TWENTY
SEVEN BY SOME MEMBERS JONES
SAWYER ACCOLADE CRIMES.
MISTER JONES SAWYER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED OPEN ON THIS MATTER
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER A. B.
NINE TWO SEVEN REVISED THE STATE
LAW BY REQUIRING.
I FIND YOU KNOW THE DEFENDANT'S
ABILITY TO PAY PRIOR TO THE
ASSESSMENT OF A FINDER'S FEE.
THIS IS OVER TEN BILLION IN
OUTSTANDING FEE AND FIND THAT IN
CALIFORNIA WOULD CLEARLY SHOWS
THAT WE ARE OVER RELIANCE ON ON
COLLECTIBLE FINDS FROM POOR
DEFENDANTS.
THIS BILL CREATES A PRESUMPTION
THAT THE HOMELESS THOSE ON THOSE
ON NEED SPACE ASSISTANCE AND
THOSE MEETING THE DEFINITION OF
VERY LOW INCOME ARE UNABLE TO
PAY THESE FEES AND FINES.
IT ALSO ESTABLISHES A SYSTEM OF
FACTORS FOR COURTS TO CONSIDER
WHEN EVALUATING ABILITY TO PAY
EASING COURT WORKLOAD.
THIS BILL IS IN LINE WITH RECENT
COURT RULINGS IN THIS AREA THE
SECOND COURT OF APPEALS IN
CALIFORNIA HELD AT IMPOSING
FINES WITHOUT AN ASSESSMENT OF
ABILITY TO PAY WITH A VIOLATION
OF DUE PROCESS.
THE SUPREME COURT ALSO NOTED
THAT EXCESSIVE FEES ARE THREAT
TO CIVIL LIBERTIES IN THE RECENT
THAMES VERSES INDIANA CASE THIS
BILL HAS RECEIVED NO NO VOTES
MEMBERS ARE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOU EITHER.
THANK YOU MISTER JONES SAWYER
SINGING HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THIS MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ON MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESERVE IT.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
LOW'S THE ROLE IN TELEVOTE AYE
SPORTY'S EIGHT KNOWS ONE THAT
MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEMS ONE TWENTY EIGHT
THROUGH ONE THIRTY WILL PASS
TEMPORARILY.
I ONE THIRTY ONE A. B. AT TEN
FOR THE CLERK WILL READ.
SOME MIDDLETON -- FOR BY SOME
MEMBER MCCARTY AN ACCOLADE
AMERICA.
IT'S A MCCARTY YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED OPEN ON THIS MATTER.
THANK YOU.
THIS MEASURE AB ONE ZERO ZERO
FOUR DOUBLE CHECKING Là
IMPROVED ENAMEL SCREENINGS FOR
CHILDREN EIGHT EIGHT ZERO THREE
THREE UNDER THE EARLY.
PERIODIC SCREENING DIAGNOSIS AND
TREATMENT BENEFIT UNDER MEDICARE
AS WE KNOW 85% OF BRAIN
DEVELOPMENT OCCURS DURING THE
FIRST THREE YEARS OF LIFE.
THESE ARE CRITICAL YEARS.
AND BUILDING ARCHITECTURE FOR
THE YOUNGSTERS BRAIN FOCUSING ON
LIFETIME LEARNING BEHAVIOR AND
HEALTH.
EARLY IDENTIFICATION PREVENTION
WORKS THIS IS WHAT THIS MEASURE
IS ALL ABOUT WILL HELP KIDS GET
PREVENTION.
AND GIVE THEM A BETTER START IN
EDUCATION AND LIFE.
AND THEREFORE ASK YOUR I. BUT
THIS MORNING THANK YOU THANK YOU
MISTER MCCARTY SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THIS MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THEIR OWN.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ON MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
ALONG MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE
TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY THE VOTE
I SIXTY SEVEN NEWS HERE THIS
MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM ONE
THIRTY TWO AB TEN TWENTY TWO THE
CLERK WILL READ.
SO MIDDLE TEN TWENTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WICKS AND OTHERS
AN ACCOLADE MACAU FRESH. SIX YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED OPEN ON THIS
MATTER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS.
CAL FOR US IS THE STATE'S MOST
EFFECTIVE ANTI HUNGER PROGRAM WE
HAVE FOUR MILLION PEOPLE IN
CALIFORNIA CURRENTLY RECEIVING
CAL FOR US BENEFITS.
FEDERAL WELFARE REFORM
IMPLEMENTED STRICT TIME LIMITS
TO ABLE BODIED ADULTS WITHOUT
DEPENDENCE RECEIVING SNAP
BENEFITS.
UNLESS AN INDIVIDUAL LIVED IN
THE STATE OR COUNTY WITH A
WAIVER WORK AN AVERAGE OF TWENTY
HOURS.
UP OR ARE GRANTED INDIVIDUAL
EXEMPTION THE FEDERAL
ADMINISTRATION HAS PROPOSED
RULES TO ELIMINATE THESE WAIVERS
WHICH WILL DRASTICALLY RESTRICT
THE STATE'S FLEXIBILITY. TO
PROTECT OUR MOST VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS.
AB TEN TWENTY TWO PROVIDES
BENEFITS TO PREVENT HUNGER AND
ACCESS TO CAL FIRST EMPLOYMENT
TRAINING PROGRAMS TO INDIVIDUALS
WHO LOSE ELIGIBILITY. FOR
FEDERALLY FUNDED CALPERS DUE TO
THE STRICT TIME LIMITS.
ACCESS TO FOOD I BELIEVE IS ONE
OF THE MOST FUNDAMENTAL BASIC
HUMAN RIGHTS.
AND IT'S TIME FOR CALIFORNIA TO
STEP UP AND ENSURE THAT EVERYONE
HAS THE ACCESS THAT THEY NEED I
WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS WHERE X. SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THIS MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
ON MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE ICE FIFTY KNOWS
HERE THIS MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM ONE THIRTY THREE A. B.
TEN TWENTY FIVE THE CLERK WILL
READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TEN TWENTY FIVE BY
SOME REMEMBER GRAYSON AN
ACCOLADE THE TRANSPORTATION MR
GRAYSON YOU ARE RECOGNIZED OPEN
ON THIS MATTER MADAM SPEAKER
MEMBERS I RISE TODAY IS AUTHOR
OF AB. TEN TWENTY FIVE TEN
TWENTY FIVE REMOVES THE
OBLIGATION FOR CONTRA COSTA
COUNTY TO REIMBURSE THE STATE OF
UP FOR TRANSPORTATION PLANNING
AND DEVELOPMENT ACCOUNT GRANTS
USED TO DEVELOP.
THE SAN RAMON BRANCH CORD OR
HOME TO THE IRON HORSE TRAIL
REGIONAL TRAIL IT WILL ALSO
REQUIRE THE COUNTY TO INCLUDE A
REPRESENTATIVE FROM C. CTA.
ON THE IRON HORSE TRAIL CORD OR
MANAGEMENT PROGRAM ADVISORY
COMMITTEE THIS BILL ALLOWS THE
COUNTY TO CONTINUE PLANNING TO
MAXIMIZE THE IRON HORSE REGIONAL
TRAILS BENEFITS FOR CONSTITUENTS
IN THE BAY AREA.
THIS BILL HAS ENJOYED UNANIMOUS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN COMMITTEE
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER GRAYSON SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THIS MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ON MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE I SIXTY EIGHT
KNOWS ONE THIS MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM ONE THIRTY FOUR AB TEN
TWENTY SEVEN THE CLERK WILL READ
SOME PEOPLE TEN TWENTY SEVEN BY
SOME REMEMBER BURKE AN ACCOLADE
A TAXATION TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY TAX LEVY.
MISS BURKE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
OPEN ON THIS MATTER THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER I RISE TODAY TO
PRESENT AB TEN TWENTY SEVEN
WHICH MODIFIES THE CAL COMPETES
TAX CREDIT PROGRAM BY ALLOWING
THE STATE TO DIRECTLY INVEST IN
HIGH PERFORMING COMPANIES.
AB TEN TWENTY SEVEN WORKS WITH
THE EXISTING CAL COMPETES
FRAMEWORK BY ALLOWING A TAXPAYER
OFFERING INTERESTED IT'S COMPANY
AS PART OF THE CREDIT
APPLICATION PROCESS.
THIS PROGRAM IS COMPLETELY
VOLUNTARY AND MEET AT THE
ELECTION OF THE COMPANY.
BY ALLOWING THE STATE TO
CONSIDER AN OWNERSHIP INTEREST
AS ONE OF THE FACTORS IN
EVALUATING AN APPLICATION
SMALLER COMPANIES THAT ARE
UNABLE TO MAKE THE SUBSTANTIAL
INVESTMENTS AS COMPARED TO
LARGER COMPANIES WILL HAVE AN
EASIER TIME.
QUALIFYING FOR A CREDIT.
ADDITIONALLY ALLOWING THE STATE
TO SHARE IN THE SUCCESS OF A
COMPANY WILL ALLOW US TO RAISE
THE CAPITAL NEEDED TO MAKE
ADDITIONAL INVESTMENTS ABOVE AND
BEYOND WHAT IS CURRENTLY
ALLOCATED TO GO BUSINESS.
IMPACT IF SUCCESSFULLY
IMPLEMENTED GOBIZ CAN BECOME A
SELF FUNDED PROGRAM AB TEN
TWENTY SEVEN ALLOWS MORE
TAXPAYERS TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
THE CAL COMPETES TAX CREDIT
PROGRAM.
AND ALLOWS IT STATE TO FIND
FUTURE INVESTMENTS I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AND I ABOUT.
THANK YOU MISS BURKE SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THIS MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
THE ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE
TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE AYE AYES FIFTY
FIVE NEWS HERE THIS MEASURE
PASSES.
WE'LL TEMPORARY PASS ON FILE
ITEMS ONE THIRTY FIVE THROUGH
ONE FORTY SIX FILE ITEM ONE
FORTY SEVEN A. B. ELEVEN FIFTY
THREE THE CLERK WILL READ.
SO MAYBE ELEVEN FIFTY THREE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WICKS AN ACCOLADE
TO COMMITTEE COLLEGES MISS WICKS
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED OPEN ON THIS
MATTER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS CURRENTLY IN K. THROUGH
TWELVE SCHOOLS SCHOOL EMPLOYEES
ARE REQUIRED TO TAKE TRAINING TO
IDENTIFY CHILD ABUSE.
CASES AND AND AND REQUIRED TO
REPORT THAT THE DOES NOT EXIST
IN OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGE
CAMPUSES -- AND THIS BILL
BASICALLY EXTEND THAT WE NEED TO
EXTEND THAT TRAINING TO
COMMUNITY COLLEGE CAMPUSES
BECAUSE WE HAVE MORE AND MORE
MINERS AND YOUNG PEOPLE ON
COMMUNITY COLLEGE CAMPUSES
BECAUSE OF DOING MOMENT WITH
HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS.
AS WELL AS CHILD CARE FACILITIES
THAT ARE NOW ON COMMUNITY
COLLEGE CAMPUSES.
MY BILL IS BI PARTISAN AND I
WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR I
DON'T.
THANK YOU MISS WICKS SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THIS MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO GO.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTES I SIXTY FOUR NO
ZERO THIS MEASURE PASSES.
IRELAND ONE FORTY EIGHT AB
ELEVEN FIFTY EIGHT THE CLERK
WILL READ.
SO MY ROLE I'M FIFTY EIGHT BY
SOME REMEMBER CARILLO AN
ACCOLADE TO SAFETY IN EMPLOYMENT.
MISS CARILLO YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
OPEN ON THIS MATTER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I AM PROUD TO PRESENT
ASSEMBLY BILL.
ELEVEN FIFTY EIGHT WHICH SEEKS
TO PROTECT OUR WORKER SAFETY BY
ALLOWING FOR THE TEMPORARY
SUSPENSION OF A PERMIT TO
CONSTRUCT AN ELEVATOR.
IF AN INSPECTION DETERMINES THAT
THE WORK DOES NOT COMPLY WITH
THE APPLE GOAL BUILDING
STANDARDS STATE LAW REQUIRES THE
NO ELEVATOR OR ESCALATOR BE
OPERATED WITHOUT A VALID.
AND CURRENT PERMIT ISSUED BY THE
ELEVATOR UNIT WITHIN THE
DIVISION OF OCCUPATIONAL SAFETY
AND HEALTH ALSO KNOWN AS CAL
OSHA.
AB ELEVEN FIFTY EIGHT SIX TO GET
AHEAD OF THE ISSUES [inaudible]
CURRENTLY -- SORRY LOST LESS MY
PLATE GIVE ME ONE SECOND --
HOWEVER CERTAIN ELEVATOR COMPANY
THROUGH HAVE BEGUN INCORPORATING
INNOVATIVE TECHNOLOGIES AND
CONVEYANCE THAT HAVE NO ONLY
INSTALLED ELEVATORS THAT FAIL TO
COMPLY WITH CAL OSHA STANDARDS.
AND THEN THOUGHT REMEDY THROUGH.
A VARIETY OF VARIANCE
APPLICATION AS A RESULT THERE IS
THE GREAT PRESSURE ON PUBLIC
AGENCIES SUCH AS SCHOOLS OR
UNIVERSITIES.
WHO ARE THEN OFTEN FACE WITH
REMOVING AN ELEVATOR COSTING
SEVERAL MILLIONS OF DOLLARS TO
GRANT AN EXCEPTION?
AB ELEVEN FIFTY EIGHT SIX TO GET
AHEAD OF THIS ISSUE BY PROVIDING
THAT A PERMIT. TO BUILD OUR WORK
IN THE CONVEYANCE MAY BE
TEMPORARILY SUSPENDED PENDING
NOTICE AND THE OPPORTUNITY
CONSENT TO CONTEST THE
SUSPENSION.
IF THE WORK PERFORMANCE THE TERM
TO VIOLATE BUILDING CODE OR
OCCUPATIONAL SAFETY STANDARDS
AND I WORK I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST MY BOOK.
THANK YOU MISS CARILLO SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THIS MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED A THIRD OF THE
PHONE NUMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE.
TO ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE
TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE I SIXTY SIX NO ZERO
THIS MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEMS ONE FORTY NINE TO ONE
FIFTY TO PASS TEMPORARILY FILE
ITEM ONE FIFTY THREE AB TWELVE
TWENTY SEVEN THE CLERK WILL READ.
THE BILL TWELVE TWENTY SEVEN BY
SOME REMEMBER OBERNOLTE AN
ACCOLADE A HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES MR OBERNOLTE YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED OPEN ON THIS MATTER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
AB TWELVE TWENTY SEVEN WOULD
IMPLEMENT A RECOMMENDATION BY
THE STATE AUDITOR TO REQUIRE
INFORMATION SHARING BETWEEN
AGENCIES WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT
OF SOCIAL SERVICES REGARDING
SAFETY VIOLATIONS COMMITTED BY
LICENSEES.
SHARING THIS INFORMATIONAL
BETTER PROTECT THE VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS THAT THESE AGENCIES
ARE TASKED WITH DEFENDING
REQUEST DRIVE VOTE ON AB.
TWELVE TWENTY SEVEN THANK YOU
MISTER OBERNOLTE SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THIS MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF THOSE WHO DESIRE
TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE I SIXTY SEVEN
KNOWS HERE THIS MEASURE PASSES.
VIOLATE ONE FIFTY FOUR AB TWELVE
THIRTY TO THE CLERK WILL READ.
SOME PEOPLE TWELVE THIRTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GLORIA ACCOLADE
ENERGY EFFICIENCY MR GLORIA YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED OPEN ON THIS
MATTER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I RISE
TO PRESENT AB.
TWELVE THIRTY TWO THIS BILL
ADDRESSES THE POTENTIAL MISUSE
OF THE LOW INCOME WEATHERIZATION
PROGRAM.
BY REQUIRING THE BENEFITS OF
THIS PROGRAM REACH AND REMAIN
WITH THE LOW INCOME HOUSEHOLDS
FOR WHICH THEY ARE INTENDED AB
TWELVE THIRTY TWO IS SUPPORTED
BY A BROAD AND DIVERSE COALITION
OF ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE.
HOUSING AND SOCIAL JUSTICE
ORGANIZATIONS IT HAS NO
REGISTERED OPPOSITION I ASK FOR
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER GLORIA SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THIS MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRED
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE AYE AYES FIFTY
TWO NEWS FIFTEEN THIS MEASURE
PASSES.
WE WERE TEMPORALLY PASS AND I AM
ONE FIFTY FIVE AND ONE FIFTY SIX
A. B. TWELVE FIFTY THREE THE
CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TOOL FOR THREE
THREE BY SOME REMEMBER ROBERT
RIVAS ANOTHER'S AN ACRYLATE
LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
ESTHER RIVAS YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
OPEN ON THIS MATTER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER --
ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE FIFTY THREE
SEEKS TO IMPROVE EFFICIENCIES IN
THE DELIVERY OF MUNICIPAL
SERVICES.
THIS BILL WOULD ESTABLISH A FIVE
YEAR PILOT PROGRAM. TO PROVIDE
GRANT FUNDING TO LAUGH GOES IN
DISADVANTAGED [inaudible]
THE COMMUNITIES.
THE COMMUNITIES WHO
SIGNIFICANTLY LACK THE FINANCIAL
ABILITY TO FINANCE IMPORTANT
LASKO ACTIVITIES AND STATUTORY.
THEDIRECTIVES THIS BILL IT
FOLLOWS A RECOMMENDATION FROM
THE TWO THOUSAND AND SEVENTEEN
LITTLE HOOVER -- THE COMMISSION
REPORT ON SPECIAL DISTRICTS
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER RIVAS SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THIS MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO THE
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLLING
TALLY THE VOTE I CITY FIVE KNOWS
THIRTEEN THAT MEASURE PASSES.
VIOLATE ONE FIFTY SEVEN AB
TWELVE FIFTY FOR THE CLERK WILL
READ.
SOME PEOPLE TWELVE BEFORE BY
SOME REMEMBER KAMLAGER-DOVE AND
OTHERS AN ACCOLADE ABOUT CATS IS
COMING OVER TO HAVE YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED OPEN ON THIS MATTER
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
SPEAKER I ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT
FOR ASSEMBLY BILL.
TWELVE FIFTY FOUR AB TWELVE
FIFTY FOUR MAKES IT UNLAWFUL TO
HUNT OR OTHERWISE TAKE A BOBCAT
EXCEPT UNDER SPECIFIED
CIRCUMSTANCES UNTIL JANUARY.
ONE TWENTY TWENTY FIVE THE
BOBCAT HUNTING SEASON MAY BE RE
OPENED ONLY UPON THE DEVELOPMENT
OF A FISH AND GAME COMMISSION
STUDY TO INFORMING COORDINATE
MANAGEMENT DECISIONS REGARDING
BOBCAT POPULATIONS.
INCLUDING AFFECTS ON THEIR PREY
DISEASE ABATEMENT AND CONTROL OF
INVASIVE INVASIVE SPECIES SUCH
AS NUTRIA RAT.
A RECENT YOU AND REPORT --
DELIVERED AN ALARMING ASSESSMENT
OF THE FATE OF ANIMAL LIFE AND
BIODIVERSITY AND ON THE EARTH.
AND ONE MILLION SPECIES ARE
THREATENED WITH EXTENSION
EXTINCTION EXTENSION EXTINCTION.
WITHIN DECADES LET'S NOT ADD
BOBCATS TO THAT LIST DUE TO
TROPHY HUNTING I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS KAMAGRA DEATH
MISTER TO BIGELOW YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED ON THIS MATTER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER TODAY I
RISE IN OPPOSITION OF THE B.
TWELVE FORTY FIVE WHICH WOULD
BAN THE TAKE THE BOBCATS UNTIL
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE IS PRESENTED.
AB TWELVE FIT DE FOR TWELVE
FORTY FIVE PUTS THE CART BEFORE
THE HORSE BY BANNING THE TAKE
THE BOBCATS ENTIRELY.
WITHOUT ANY DATA DID JUSTIFY
THIS ACTION.
HOW CAN WE JUSTIFY BANNING THE
SPORT WHEN BOTH STATE AND
FEDERAL WILDLIFE MANAGEMENT
AUTHORITIES HAVE INDICATED THE
BOBCAT POPULATION IS HEALTHY AND
NOT IN DANGER OF DECLINE?
THIS MAJOR WOULD NEGATIVELY
IMPACT THE HUNTING LICENSE
REVENUE WHICH FUNDS ARE
CONSERVATION EFFORTS FOR
FISHERIES AND ARE WILDLIFE.
MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A
NO VOTE ON THIS BILL.
YOU MISTER BIGELOW SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE WAS
COME OTHER W. LIKE CLOSE.
YES THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I
RESPECT THE COMMENTS MADE BY MY
COLLEAGUE ACROSS THE AISLE AND
HE HAS BEEN CONSISTENT IN HIS
CONCERNS ABOUT THIS ISSUE AND SO
I APPRECIATE THAT CONTINUED
CONSISTENCY.
BOBCAT HUNTING PROVIDES MINIMAL
RESOURCES TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
FISH AND WILDLIFE IN TERMS OF
REVENUE.
TAX COST A MERE THREE DOLLARS
AND TWENTY FOUR CENTS AND
CONTRIBUTE LESS THAN FORTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS ANNUALLY.
THEY MAKE UP LESS THAN 1% OF
TOTAL HUNTING REVENUE IN.
TWENTY EIGHTEEN THE LAST
STATEWIDE BOBCAT POPULATION
ASSESSMENT IS OVER THIRTY YEARS
OLD IT IS WHOLE HOLDEN HOLY
OUTDATED.
AB TWELVE FIFTY FOUR SUPPORTS
THE NOTION THAT WILDLIFE
MANAGEMENT SHOULD BE BASED UPON
THE BEST AVAILABLE SCIENCE AND
THE MOST CURRENT AND BY SETTING
A PLACE BY SETTING IN PLACE
REQUIREMENT THAT THE DFW DEVELOP
A COMPREHENSIVE BOBCAT
MANAGEMENT PLAN.
THAT AMONG OTHER THINGS WILL
INCLUDE AN UPDATED STATEWIDE
POPULATION ESTIMATES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ON MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE AYE AYES FORTY
FIVE KNOWS EIGHTEEN THIS MEASURE
PASSES.
FILE ITEM ONE FIFTY EIGHTY BE
TWELVE FIFTY FIVE THE CLERK WILL
READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE FIFTY FIVE
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER ROBERT RIVAS
AN ACT RELATING TO HOUSING
MYSTERY THIS YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
OPEN ON THIS MATTER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER SO
ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE FIFTY FIVE
CREATES A STATE WIDE INVENTORY
OF UNUSED OR SURPLUS CITY -- AND
COUNTY PROPERTY FOR POTENTIAL
HOUSING OPPORTUNITIES WHILE
LEAVING THESE DECISIONS ON USE
TO LOCAL ARM.
COULD CONTROL THE GOAL OF THIS
LEGISLATION IS TO HELP STIMULATE
UNEXPECTED OPPORTUNITIES FOR
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS OPPORTUNITIES
FOR NEW HOUSING PROJECTS
PROJECTS THAT WILL CERTAINLY
HELP ADDRESS OUR STATE WIDE
HOUSING SHORTAGE.
THIS BILL HAS RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
THANK YOU MEN'S BECAUSE THANK
YOU MISTER RIVAS SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THIS MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESERVE
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY TO VOTE I SIXTY SEVEN NO
ZERO THIS MEASURE PASSES BY LEN
ONE FIFTY NINE AB TWELVE SIXTY
THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE SIXTY BY
SOME REMEMBER MAIENSCHEIN AND
ACKLEY INTO ENDANGERED WILDLIFE.
MR MAIENSCHEIN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED OPEN ON THIS MATTER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS THOUSANDS OF EXOTIC
ANIMALS ARE KILLED FOR THEIR
SKINS EACH YEAR THESE ANIMALS
SUFFER GREATLY FOR THE SAKE OF
FASHION EVEN WALL ALTERNATIVES
EXIST.
THERE IS A BROADER ARRAY OF
LUXURIOUS CRUELTY FREE MATERIALS
AVAILABLE FOR USE INCLUDING
EMBOSSED IMITATION WHETHER THAT
LOOKS AND FEELS THE SAME AS
EXOTIC SKIN WITHOUT ANY OF THE
CRUELTY.
SEVERAL LARGE RETAILERS OF
ALREADY LED THE CHARGE IN
BANNING THE SCANS INCLUDING
CHANEL AND TAYLOR HMM ADIDAS AND
VICTORIA'S SECRET TO NAME JUST A
FEW.
AB TWELVE SIXTY WOULD BAN THE
SALE AND IMPORTATION WITH INTENT
TO SELL A BIG ONE IS HIPPOS
CAYMANS AND SEVERAL SPECIES OF
LIZARDS.
THANK YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AND I ABOUT.
THANK YOU MISTER MAIENSCHEIN
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THIS MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED IS THERE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF THOSE WHO DESIRE
TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY VOTE ICE FIFTY TWO KNOWS
WELL THIS MEASURE PASSES.
IRELAND ONE SIXTY AB TWELVE
SEVENTY THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE SEVENTY BY
SOME REMEMBER MARK STONE
ACRYLATE TO FALSELY THE FALSE
CLAIMS ACT.
MR STONE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED OPEN
ON THIS MATTER THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER YES THIS IS A MARK STONE
BILL THAT IS SUPPORTED BY THE
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S ASSOCIATION.
PERHAPS THAT'S ALL I NEED TO SAY.
BUT A LITTLE BIT FURTHER THAN
THAT THIS IS ABOUT FALSE CLAIMS
NOT CLAIMS AGAINST THE STATE
FALSE CLAIMS AGAINST THE STATE
WERE MOSTLY.
THIS IS.
SUPPORTED BY IN IN ACTUALLY
SPONSORED BY THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL BECAUSE CALIFORNIA HAS A
TAX GAP OF OVER ALMOST TWENTY
BILLION DOLLARS.
THAT MEANS TWENTY BILLION
DOLLARS -- THE STATE ALREADY.
THAT IS NOT EASILY RECOVERABLE
SO WE'RE TRYING TO ADJUST THE
FALSE CLAIMS ACT STATUTES SO
THAT THE ATTORNEY GENERAL CAN
BETTER GO AFTER.
THOSE SCOFFLAWS AND MAKE SURE
THAT WE ARE COLLECTING THE
REVENUES THAT WE CAN WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR IBM.
THANK YOU MISTER STAND SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THIS MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE ICE FORTY EIGHT
NO SIXTEEN THIS MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM ONE SIXTY ONE WILL BE
PASS TEMPORARILY FILE AND ONE
SIXTY TWO AB TWELVE EIGHTY SEVEN
THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE EIGHTY
SEVEN BY SOME REMEMBER THIS ERIN
AND OTHERS AN ACCOLADE THE
PUBLIC SOCIAL SERVICES.
MISTER NAZARIAN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED OPEN ON THIS MATTER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AB
TWELVE EIGHTY SEVEN REQUIRES THE
STATE DEPARTMENT OF AGING IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF REHABILITATION HEALTH CARE
SERVICES AND SOCIAL SERVICES. TO
DEVELOP A PLAN AND STRATEGY FOR
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF A
STATEWIDE NO WRONG DOOR SYSTEM
THAT WILL ASSIST OLDER ADULTS --
INDIVIDUALS WITH DISABILITIES
AND CARE GIVERS IN OBTAINING
ACCURATE INFORMATION AND TIMELY
REFERRALS TO COMMUNITY SERVICES
AND SUPPORTS A. B. TWELVE EIGHTY
SEVEN ALSO REQUIRES THE
DEVELOPMENT OF A UNIVERSAL
ASSESSMENT TOOL.
AND PROCESS TO STREAMLINE ACCESS
TO SERVICES THROUGH A
COORDINATED ASSESSMENT --
PROCESSES I BY DEVELOPING A NO
WRONG DOOR SYSTEM WE ENSURE THAT
OUR SENIORS PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES AND THEIR FAMILIES
WILL RECEIVE THE SERVICES THAT
THEY DESPERATELY SO NEED.
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER NAZARIAN SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THIS MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED DESIRED VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE I SIXTY NINE NEWS
HERE THIS MEASURE PASSES.
MILITARILY PASSED IN NINETEEN
SIXTY ONE SIXTY THREE FOR ONE
SIXTY FIVE FILE ITEM ONE SIXTY
SIX A. B. THIRTEEN OH SEVEN THE
CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTEEN OH SEVEN
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER BLOCK RUBIO
AND OTHERS AN ACCOLADE A STUDENT
FINANCIAL AID.
THROUGH THE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
OPEN ON THIS MATTER THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER I RISE TO PRESENT
AB THIRTEEN OH SEVEN THE COLLEGE
OPPORTUNITY ACT.
I BELIEVE THAT IT IS CRITICAL TO
ENSURE EVERY STUDENT HAS ACCESS
TO FUNDING FOR COLLEGE.
AND COST SHOULD NEVER BE THE
FINAL DETERMINATION WHEN
CHOOSING A COLLEGE TO ATTEND.
THIS BILL WILL BRING STABILITY
TO THE CAL GRANT A WORD BY
IMPLEMENTING A NEW FUNDING
FORMULA FOR STUDENTS ATTENDING
PRIVATE.
NONPROFIT UNIVERSITIES.
UPON SIX UPON SUCCESS OF AB
THIRTEEN OH SEVEN CAL GRANT
AWARDS FOR PRIVATE NONPROFIT
COLLEGES WILL INCREASE IN A JUST
WITH FUTURE INCREASES IN
ALLOCATIONS.
FOR THE CSU.
CAL GRANT AWARDS PROVIDE
CRITICAL FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE TO
STUDENTS AND CAN OFTEN BE THE
FINAL DETERMINATION ON SCHOOL
AXIS.
NOT ONLY DOES THE CAL GRANT
PROVIDE AND AFFORDABLE PATHWAY
TO COLLEGE IT SERVES A
SIGNIFICANT POPULATION OF
UNDERSERVED STUDENTS.
THIS BILL RECEIVED UNANIMOUS
SUPPORT IN POLICY AND FISCAL
COMMITTEES AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS RUBIO SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THIS MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS AND WHO DESIRE TO
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLLING
TALENT BUT I SEVENTY ONE KNOWS
HERE THIS MEASURE PASSES BY LEAD
ONE SIXTY SEVEN AB THIRTEEN TEN
THE CLERK WILL READ.
SOME LEGAL THIRTEEN TEN BY SOME
THE MEMORY IS AN ACCOLADE A
TRAFFIC VIOLATORS SCHOOL THIS
RACE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED OPEN ON
THIS MATTER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
AB THIRTEEN TOWN DEALS WITH
TRAFFIC SCHOOL.
NORMALLY YOU HAVE NINETY DAYS TO
PAY THIS WILL EXTENDED TO ONE
HUNDRED EIGHTY DAYS PROVIDING AN
EQUALIZING ACCESS TO TRAFFIC
SCHOOL. FOR THOSE WHO CAN LEAST
AFFORD IT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS RARE SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THIS MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESERVE THE
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE I SIXTY SIX NO
ZERO THIS MEASURE PASSES BY
LIGHT IN ONE SIXTY EIGHTY BE
THIRTEEN THIRTEEN THE CLERK WILL
READ.
SOME MIDDLE THIRTEEN THIRTEEN BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER THREE OF US
AUSTIN ACRYLATE A STUDENT DEBTS
THIS RIVAS YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
OPEN ON THIS MATTER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I'M PROUD TO PRESENT AB
THIRTEEN THIRTEEN WHICH SEEKS TO
ENSURE THAT OUR STUDENTS FUTURE
IS NOT HELD HOSTAGE BY COLLEGES.
BY PROHIBITING POST SECONDARY
SCHOOLS FROM REFUSING TO PROVIDE
A TRANSCRIPT ON THE GROUNDS OF
THE STUDENT OWES A DEBT.
AB THIRTEEN THIRTEEN EASES A
STUDENT'S ABILITY TO PAY OFF
THEIR DEBT AND PRESERVES IDEA
THAT STUDENTS DESERVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SUCCEED.
THIS BILL HAS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
AND OPPOSITION I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER BASS.
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THIS MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THEIR OWN.
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TELLING VOTE I SIXTY FIVE NEWS
HERE THIS MEASURE PASSES IRELAND
ONE SIXTY NINE AB THIRTEEN
TWENTY THE CLERK WILL READ.
SOME PEOPLE THIRTY TWENTY BY
SOME REMEMBER THIS AREA THAN
OTHERS AN ACCOLADE A PUBLIC
EMPLOYEE RETIREMENT SYSTEMS
STERN IS ERIN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
OPEN ON THIS MATTER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AB
THIRTEEN TWENTY WOULD REQUIRE
THE BOARDS OF CALPERS AND CAL
STIRS TODAY BEST PUBLIC EMPLOYEE
RETIREMENT FUNDS FROM ANY
INVESTMENT VEHICLE ISSUED BY.
OWNED CONTROLLED OR MANAGED BY
THE GOVERNMENT OF TURKEY THE
LIQUIDATION OF INVESTMENTS IS
CONTINGENT UPON THE PASSAGE OF A
FEDERAL LAW.
ISSUING SANCTIONS AGAINST TURKEY
FOR THE FAILURE TO RECOGNIZE THE
ARMENIAN GENOCIDE.
THIS CONTINGENCY CLAUSE ENSURES
CALIFORNIA'S POLICY TO DIVEST
FROM TURKEY REMAINS CONSISTENT
WITH PAST DIVESTMENT FROM
FOREIGN NATIONS INCLUDING SUDAN
AND IRAN IN THAT PURRS AND STIRS
WILL NOT DIVEST UNTIL THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAS TAKEN
ACTION FIRST.
REPUBLIC OF TURKEY'S
UNWILLINGNESS TO RECOGNIZE THE
GENOCIDE AND THEIR UNRELENTING
CAMPAIGN THE DENIED THE GENOCIDE
CONTINUES TO DISCRIMINATE
AGAINST ARMENIANS WEEKS THE
SYRIANS.
AND OTHER ETHNIC MINORITIES WHO
SUFFERED AT THE HANDS OF THE
TURKISH GOVERNMENT.
CALIFORNIA HAS CLEAR POLICY ON
THE GENOCIDE.
AS DEMONSTRATED BY DECADES OF
LEGISLATIVE RESOLUTIONS AND
GUBERNATORIAL PROCLAMATIONS THIS
BILL CONTINUES CALIFORNIA'S
COMMITMENT TO ACT APPROPRIATELY
AGAINST COUNTRIES.
THAT HAVE A RECORD OF HUMAN
RIGHTS VIOLATIONS AND UNDERMINE
DEMOCRACY AND WITH THAT I ALSO
WOULD LIKE TO THANK ALL MY
COLLEAGUES WHO IN PREVIOUS YEARS
HAVE BEEN HERE TO SUPPORT THIS
BILL -- UNFORTUNATE THERE WAS A
MINOR HICCUP.
AFTER MUCH DELIBERATION AND
CONVERSATION -- THE PREVIOUS
GOVERNOR WAS NOT ABLE TO COME TO
A PLACE TO SIGN THE BILL AND
VETOED IT AND THAT'S WHY I
NEEDED TO BE INTRODUCED AT THIS
YEAR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU MISTER IS THERE IN
MISTER QUIRK YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
ON THIS MATTER -- YES JUST TO
SAY THE REASON I'M GOING TO VOTE
FOR THIS.
HAS A LOT TO DO WITH THE FACT
THAT THE PRESIDENT OF TURKEY IS
TRYING TO ELIMINATE DEMOCRACY IN
THIS COUNTRY IS LOCKING UP ALL
OF HIS.
OPPONENTS ARE STOPPING THE PRESS
STOPPING ACADEMICS BOB I THINK
WE NEED TO SEND A MESSAGE TURKEY
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS FRIEDMAN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED ON THIS MATTER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I RISE
TODAY IS A PROUD CO AUTHOR OF
THIS MEASURE AND I WANT TO THANK
THE AUTHOR FOR HIS COURAGEOUS
STANCE IN BRINGING THIS FORWARD --
I KNOW THAT THIS IS FOR SOME
PEOPLE A CONTROVERSIAL BILL BUT
I WANT TO REMIND PEOPLE THAT THE
UNITED STATES.
HAS.
SO FAR REFUSED TO RECOGNIZE WHAT.
WORLD HISTORIANS NO HAPPEN FOR A
FACT WHAT PEOPLE KNOW FROM THEIR
IMMEDIATE FAMILY MEMBERS
HAPPENED IS A FACT.
I'M WITHOUT WORLDWIDE
RECOGNITION OF WHAT WAS THE
FIRST GENOCIDE OF THE TWENTIETH
CENTURY.
YOU'RE NEVER GOING TO HAVE
HEALING IS FOR THOSE FAMILIES
THAT WERE TORN APART AND CENTER
AROUND THE WORLD.
AND YOU'LL WHAT MESSAGE DO YOU
SEND TO DICTATORS AND OTHERS
THAT MIGHT COMMIT THESE KINDS OF
ATROCITIES.
IF A COUNTRY LIKE THE UNITED
STATES ISN'T WILLING TO STAND UP
AND CONDEMN.
WHAT HAPPENED SO WITH THAT I
URGE ALL OF YOU TO SUPPORT THIS
BILL TODAY THANK YOU?
THANK YOU MISS FRIEDMAN MISTER
IS ARYAN SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DELAY WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE.
I WOULD JUST THE RESPECTFULLY
ASK HER AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESERVE
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE ICE FORTY SIX NO
ZERO THIS MEASURE PASSES.
TEMPORARILY PASSAM VIOLATE ONE
SEVENTY FILE ITEM ONE SEVENTY
ONE AB THIRTEEN FIFTY ONE THE
CLERK WILL READ.
SOME PEOPLE THIRTEEN FIFTY ONE
BY SOME REMEMBER LACKEY AN
ACCOLADE PUBLIC TRANSIT.
MR LACKEY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
OPEN ON THIS MATTER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AB.
THIRTY FIFTY ONE WHAT AUTHORIZED
THE CALIFORNIA TRANSPORTATION
AGENCY TO CONSULT WITH PUBLIC
TRANSIT OPERATORS TO ASSIST.
I'M SORRY TO ASSESS THE
PROCEDURES THE MINISTRATION OF
RIDE SERVICES FOR INDIVIDUALS
WITH PHYSICAL AND DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES.
IT COULD TAKE NEARLY A MONTH
BEFORE PERSON WITH A DISABILITY
CAN USE NAY AGENCIES PARA
TRANSIT SERVICE WOULD
CONSIDERING THE ENTIRETY OF THE
APPLICATION PROCESS.
MOREOVER IT'S EVEN MORE
BURDENSOME FOR THESE INDIVIDUALS
WITH DISABILITIES WHO NEED A
RIDE IN A JURISDICTION OUTSIDE
THEIR ORIGINALLY APPROVED
SERVICE AREA. FOR EXAMPLE IF AN
INDIVIDUAL IS DEEMED ELIGIBLE
FOR SERVICE IN SACRAMENTO BUT
WAS VISITING LOS ANGELES SERVICE
AREA.
THAT INDIVIDUAL WOULD HAVE TO GO
THROUGH A LENGTHY PROCESS TO
PROVE THEIR ELIGIBILITY WHICH
INVOLVES.
SENDING A FAX.
THIS BILL INITIATE.
THE PROCESS WHICH OUR STATE
COULD BEGIN IDENTIFYING GAPS IN
THE DOLERITE APPEAR TRANSIT
SYSTEM.
AND BEGIN STREAMLINING THE
PROCESS IN WHICH INDIVIDUALS
WITH PHYSICAL AND DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES.
CAN USE RIGHT SERVICES FREELY
THIS BILL ENJOYS VICE PARTISAN
SUPPORT AND I WOULD APPRECIATE
YOUR SUPPORT OF VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER LACKEY SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THIS MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS OF THOSE WHO DESIRE
TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TELEVOTE I SIXTY SIX NO ZERO
THIS MEASURE PASSES.
WE WILL TEMPORARILY PASS AND I
AM IS ONE SEVENTY TWO AND ONE
SEVENTY THREE FILE ITEM ONE
SEVENTY FOUR AB THIRTEEN SEVENTY
SEVEN THE CLERK WILL READ.
SO MIDDLE THIRTEEN SEVENTY SEVEN
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER WORKS ANOTHER
CYCLE AND CAL FRESH.
MISS WICKS YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
OPEN ON THIS MATTER THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER AND MEMBERS IF YOU
LIKED MY LAST CAL FRESH BILL I
HAVE ANOTHER ONE FOR YOU THAT
YOU'RE GONNA LOVE.
AS YOU ALL KNOW FOOD AND
SECURITY AMONG HOUSEHOLDS WITH
SCHOOL AGE CHILDREN REMAINS HIGH
ACROSS CALIFORNIA AND HUNGER IS
ASSOCIATED WITH NEGATIVE HEALTH
DEVELOPMENTAL.
AND EDUCATIONAL OUTCOMES AND
CHILDREN WHO GROW UP IN FOOD
SECURE HOUSEHOLDS OFTEN FALL
BEHIND. TO REDUCE CHILL CHILD
HUNGER THE FREE AND REDUCED
PRICE MEALS PROGRAM HAS HELPED
GET HELP TO CHILDREN GAIN ACCESS
TO ADEQUATE FOOD.
AND IS INTRODUCED TO INCIDENTS
SECURITIES AND PROMOTE HEALTHY
DEVELOPMENT.
HOWEVER A SIGNIFICANT PORTION OF
CHILDREN WHO ARE ON THE FREE
REDUCED PRICE MEALS PROGRAM ARE
NOT RECEIVING BENEFITS THROUGH
CAL FRESH.
HIGHER PARTICIPATION IN
CALIFORNIA SHE WOULD HELP TO
REDUCE THESE FOOD SECURITIES MY
BILL AB THIRTEEN SEVENTY SEVEN
WILL DIRECT STATE DEPARTMENT
LOCAL HEALTH SERVICE AGENCIES
AND KEY STAKEHOLDERS TO EXAMINE
DATA.
AND ELIGIBILITY REQUIREMENTS
ACROSS THE DIFFERENT BENEFITS
PROGRAMS IN ORDER TO FIND THE
BEST POSSIBLE SOLUTION TO
DEVELOP A STATEWIDE PROCESS.
THAT WOULD IMPLEMENT AND
ACCELERATE ENROLLMENT OF
CHILDREN IN THE CALIFORNIA.
THIS BILL HAS BI PARTISAN
SUPPORT AND I WOULD RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS WICKS SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THIS MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALONG MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE
TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE I SEVENTY ONE NO
ZERO THIS MEASURE PASSES FILE
ITEM ONE SEVENTY FIVE AB
THIRTEEN EIGHTY TWO THE CLERK
WILL READ.
SOME PEOPLE THIRTEEN EIGHTY TWO
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER AGUIAR-CURRY
AND OTHERS AN ACT RELATING TO
PUBLIC SOCIAL SERVICES.
IS AGUIAR-CURRY YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED OPEN ON THIS MATTER
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
AB THIRTEEN EIGHTY TWO WELL
ESTABLISHED AS PART OF THE
MASTER PLAN FOR AGING.
A COMPREHENSIVE STRATEGY FOR
PREPARING AND SUPPORTING
CALIFORNIA'S PAID HER FOR AN
PRAYER PARAFFIN PROFESSIONALS
BORN -- AND PROFESSIONAL
WORKFORCE AS WELL AS THE UNPAID
FAMILY CARE GIVER WORKFORCE THIS
BILL RESPONSE TO THE NEEDS OF AN
AGING CALIFORNIA BY PROVIDING
RECOMMENDATIONS.
TO ESTABLISH IN SCALE THE WORK
FORCE DEMANDS FOR HOME CARE
WORKERS.
INCREASED GERIATRIC RELATED
COMPETENCIES IN HEALTH CARE.
AND BUILD OFF OF RECOMMENDATIONS
OUTLINED FOR THE CALIFORNIA TASK
FORCE FOR FAMILY CARE GIVING.
AB THIRTEEN EIGHTY TWO IS A
PIECE OF MULTI BILL ACKAGE TO
ESTABLISH THE CALIFORNIA MASTER
PLAN FOR AGING AND DIRECT
PRIORITIES FOR THE STATE TO
ADDRESS.
THE RAPIDLY INCREASING NEED I
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER AGUILAR CURRY
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS OF THOSE WHO DESIRE
TO VOTE.
ON MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRED
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE I SEVENTY KNOWS
HERE THIS MEASURE PASSES.
PASS TEMPORARILY ON FILE ITEM
ONE SEVENTY SIX FILE ITEM ONE
SEVENTY SEVEN AB THIRTEEN EIGHTY
FIVE THE CLERK WILL READ SOME
PEOPLE THIRTEEN EIGHTY FIVE BY
SOME REMEMBER SANTIAGO AN
ACCOLADE COURT REPORTING.
MISTER SANTIAGO YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED OPEN ON THIS MATTER
THANK YOU MEN'S BECAUSE THIS
BILL WOULD PROPOSE A MODEST
INCREASE FOR TRANSCRIPTS REPAIR
BY FFICIAL COURT REPORTERS.
ARE SPECKLING ASPEN AYE VOTE.
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THIS MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS GO TO DESIRED BOTH.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE AYE AYES FORTY
THREE KNOWS FOURTEEN THIS
MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM ONE SEVENTY EIGHT AB
THIRTEEN NINETY ONE THE CLERK
WILL READ.
SOME PEOPLE THIRTY NINETY ONE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BONTA AN
ACCOLADE TO ELECTIONS MR BONTA
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED OPEN ON THIS
MATTER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES A. B. THIRTEEN NINETY
ONE IMPROVES THE ACCESSIBILITY
OF TRANSLATED VOTING MATERIALS
FOR CALIFORNIA'S LIMITED.
ENGLISH PROFICIENT VOTERS THE
BILL HAS RECEIVED UNANIMOUS
SUPPORT AND HAS NO OPPOSITION.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER BONTA SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THIS MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS GO TO DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE AYE AYES FIFTY
FIVE NO ZERO THIS MEASURE PASSES
FILE ITEM ONE SEVENTY NINE AB
THIRTEEN NINETY THREE THE CLERK
WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTEEN NINETY
THREE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER WEBER
ANOTHER SNACK LATER PEOPLE
INSTRUCTION.
DOCTOR WEBER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
OPEN ON THIS MATTER THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER AND MEMBERS ARE
RISE TO PRESENT TO YOU AB.
THIRTEEN NINETY THREE THIS WOULD
REQUIRE THE INSTRUCTIONAL
QUALITY COMMISSION TO INCLUDE
THE HISTORY AND CULTURAL STUDY
OF LAOTIAN AMERICANS.
IN THE DEVELOPMENT OF THE
CURRICULUM RELATE RELATIVE TO BE
A NAME NAM WAR REFUGEE
EXPERIENCE IN AMERICA.
LAST YEAR WE PASS AB EIGHT
NINETY FIVE BACK WHEN AND THAT
REQUIRES ACCU SEED TO DEVELOP A
MODEL CURRICULUM ON THE
VIETNAMESE AMERICAN REFUGEE
EXPERIENCE WE LIST OF THE NUMBER
OF OF GROUPS THAT WOULD BE
INCLUDED BUT WE FAIL TO LIST.
THE LAOTIAN COMMUNITY THE
HISTORY OF THE LAOTIAN REFUGEE
IN THE COUNTRY OF LABELS WHICH
IS INSEPARABLE FROM THE HISTORY
OF VIETNAM WAS NOT INCLUDED IN
SB EIGHT NINETY FIVE THIS IS A
CLEAN UP.
AND TO BASICALLY INCLUDE THE
LAOTIAN AMERICAN HISTORY IN OF
THE SAME AYE QC -- THAT WILL BE
TAKING PLACE IS BILL AS RECEIVE
NO NO VOTE AND HAS NO OPPOSITION
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
BOTH.
THANK YOU DOCTOR EVER SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THIS MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
WHERE WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY VOTE I SIXTY SIX KNOWS
HERE THIS MEASURE PASSES WILL
PASS TEMPORARILY AND VIOLATED
ONE EIGHTY FILE ITEM? ONE EIGHTY
ONE EIGHTY FOURTEEN SEVENTEEN
THE CLERK WILL READ ASSEMBLY
BILL FOURTEEN SEVENTEEN BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLANCA RUBIO AND
OTHERS AN ACCOLADE CANNABIS AND
MAKING AN APPROPRIATION
THEREFORE.
MISS RUBIO YOU ARE RECOGNIZED TO
OPEN ON THIS MATTER THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME -- TO PRESENT TODAY
ON A. B. FOURTEEN SEVENTEEN AN
ACT RELATING TO THE ADVERTISING
OF UNLICENSED CANNABIS
BUSINESSES.
AS WE ALL KNOW THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA STARTED ISSUING STATE
LICENSES AT THE BEGINNING OF
LAST YEAR. FOR CANNABIS
BUSINESSES TO OPERATE IN THE
STATE.
DESPITE SOME SUCCESS DURING THE
FIRST YEAR OF LEGAL SALES THE
BLACK MARKET.
THE BLACK MARKET HAS CONTINUED
TO FLOURISH DRIVING DOWN LEGAL
SALES.
IN ADDITION TO DWINDLING TAX
REVENUES THE UNDERGROUND MARKET
PRESENTS SERIOUS PUBLIC SAFETY
AND PUBLIC HEALTH THREATS TO OUR
COMMUNITIES.
AB FOURTEEN SEVENTEEN WILL
TARGET THE BLACK MARKET BY
CRACKING DOWN ON THE SPECIFIC
PROBLEM THE ADVERTISING OF THESE
ILLEGAL CANNABIS BUSINESSES.
CERTAIN PLATFORMS HAVE BEEN WELL
DOCUMENTED WHEN IT COMES TO THE
PRACTICE OF ADVERTISING ILLEGAL
OPERATIONS IN EXCHANGE FOR
PROFIT.
AB FOURTEEN SEVENTEEN WILL
INCREASE DISCLOSURE REQUIREMENTS
AND CREATE CIVIL PENALTIES FOR
ENTITIES WOULD DECIDE TO AID AND
ABET.
IN THE ADVERTISEMENT OF THE
LEGAL OPERATIONS.
AS A LEGISLATURE WE CANNOT SAY
THAT WERE TAKING THE CANNABIS
BLACK MARKET SERIOUSLY IF WE
ALLOW THE UNREGULATED PROMOTION
AN ADVERTISEMENT OF ILLEGAL
BUSINESSES. TO EXIST WITHOUT
CONSEQUENCES WE KNOW THAT THESE
ADVERTISEMENTS DRIVE BUSINESSES
TOWARDS ILLEGAL OPERATORS AND
MUST FIND A WAY TO RESTRICT THIS
PRACTICE.
THIS BILL IS IN CURRENT FORM HAS
NO OPPOSITION THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS RUBIO SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THIS MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALONG MEMBERS OF THOSE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL FLOWS THE ROLAND
TALLY THE VOTE AYE AYES FIFTY
SIX NO SIX THIS MEASURE PASSES.
GOING BACK TO FILE ITEM ONE
SEVENTY AB THIRTEEN TWENTY EIGHT
THE CLERK WILL READ SOME LEGAL
THIRTEEN TWENTY EIGHT BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER HOLDEN AND
ACTUALLY THE OIL AND GAS.
MR HOLDEN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
OPEN ON THIS MATTER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS.
ARE THERE ARE TENS OF THOUSANDS
OF OLD AND POTENTIALLY LEAKING
OIL AND GAS WELLS IN CALIFORNIA.
SOME OF THESE SITES ARE IDLE
DESERTED OR HAZARDOUS AND THOSE
ARE THE FOCUS OF THIS BILL.
LIKE ACTED PRODUCTION SITES IDLE
DESERTED AND HAZARDOUS OIL AND
GAS WELLS CAN LEAD POLLUTION.
FOR EXAMPLE IN TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN A PAIR OF IDA WELLS AND
IDLE OIL AND GAS WELLS WERE
FOUND LEAKING HAZARDOUS LEVELS
OF GAS IN THE ECHO PARK
NEIGHBORHOOD IN LOS ANGELES.
LESS THAN A HUNDRED FEET FROM
NEARBY RESIDENTS.
IN ADDITION EARLIER THIS YEAR
AND OIL OLD OIL WELL IN MARINA
DEL REY EXPERIENCED A RELEASE
DURING REMEDIATION WORK.
POTENTIAL EMISSIONS FROM IDA
WELLS INCLUDE METHANE AND
BENZENE.
NOTHING IS A CLIMATE CHANGE GAS
MANY TIMES MORE POWERFUL THAN
CARBON DIOXIDE WHILE OTHER CO.
IN MID AIR POLLUTANTS LIKE
BENZENE CAN CAUSE CANCER.
AB THIRTEEN TWENTY EIGHT WOULD
MAKE THIS INFORMATION ON LEAKS
PUBLICLY AVAILABLE.
CREATING A BODY OF INFORMATION
THAT IS IMPORTANT TO KNOW IN THE
SIZE AND SCOPE OF THE EMISSIONS
FROM IDLE AND DESERTED WELLS.
INFORMATION COLLECTED UNDER A.
B. THIRTEEN ANDTHIRTEEN TWENTY
EIGHT CAN BE USED TO CREATE A
BETTER UNDERSTANDING OF THE
EMISSIONS FROM ALL OF
CALIFORNIA'S OIL.
AND GAS WELLS.
ALL RIGHT -- IN DESERTED WELLS
CAN LEAK.
AND DO LAKE.
AND WHEN THEY DO WE CAN RESULT
IN EMISSIONS THAT CONTRIBUTE TO
CLIMATE CHANGE AND ENDANGER THE
PUBLIC HEALTH.
WE'RE IN COMMUNICATION WITH
WHISPER.
AND PLAN TO ADDRESS THEIR
CONCERNS IN THE SENATE.
AB THIRTEEN TWENTY EIGHT SIX TO
ADDRESS THIS ISSUE A LOW COST BY
REQUIRING DATA ALREADY COLLECTED
TO BE MADE PUBLIC.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
ABOUT.
THANK YOU MISTER HOLDEN SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THIS MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.%
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TELEVOTE EYES FORTY ONE KNOWS
TWENTY ONE THIS MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM ONE EIGHTY TWO A. B.
FOURTEEN TWENTY FOUR THE CLERK
WILL READ.
SOME PEOPLE FOURTEEN TWENTY FOUR
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER BERMAN ANOTHER
SNACK LATER PUBLIC RESOURCES.
MR BERMAN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
OPEN ON THIS MATTER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES IT'S TAKING A DECADE
TO BUILD OUT THE NEARLY TWENTY
THOUSAND PUBLIC ELECTRIC VEHICLE
CHARGING STATIONS.
IN CALIFORNIA WITH THE
COMBINATION OF PRIVATE
INVESTMENT STATE DOLLARS AND
REPAIR FUNDS.
THEIR RESOURCES BOARD HAS
PROPOSED A PAYMENT TECHNOLOGY
REGULATION THAT WOULD REQUIRE
MOST CHARGING STATIONS TO BE
REPLACED ENTIRELY.
WE NEED TO PRESERVE THESE
INVESTMENTS AND EXPAND CHARGING
INFRASTRUCTURE IN CALIFORNIA NOT
TAKE EXISTING INFRASTRUCTURE OUT
OF OPERATION AND INCREASED COSTS.
AB FOURTEEN TWENTY FOUR PROPOSES
AN ALTERNATIVE THAT IN STORES
OPEN ACCESS TO CHARGING STATIONS
WITHOUT UNDERMINING THE PROGRESS
WE'VE MADE SO FAR.
IT WOULD REQUIRE CHARGING
STATIONS TO BE EQUIPPED WITH A
TOLL FREE NUMBER FOR CREDIT CARD
PAYMENTS TAKEN OVER THE PHONE.
IN REQUIRE AT LEAST TWO
ADDITIONAL PAYMENT METHODS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER BERMAN SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THIS MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ON MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS I READ THE
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE AYE AYES FIFTY
NINE KNOWS HERE THIS MEASURE
PASSES.
PREPARED TO LIFT THE CALL ON
FILE ITEM FIFTY AB FORTY FIVE
THE CLERK WILL POST.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED DESERTED VOTE.
MOM MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE BOTH
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TELLING THE VOTE AYE AYES FORTY
TWO NOS NINETEEN THIS MEASURE
PASSES. TO LET THE CALL ON FILE
ITEM THREE NINETY SEVEN AB ONE
SIXTY ONE THE CLERK WILL POST.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ON MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS ARE DESIRABLE CLERK
WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY
VOTE ICE FORTY TWO KNOWS TWENTY
THIS ITEM MEASURE PASSES.
PASS TEMPORARILY AND FILE ITEMS
ONE EIGHTY THREE ONE EIGHTY FOUR
FILE ITEM ONE EIGHTY FIVE AB
FOURTEEN FORTY THREE THE CLERK
WILL READ.
SOMETHING ASSEMBLY BILL FOURTEEN
FORTY THREE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
MAIENSCHEIN ACCOLADE AMID MENTAL
HEALTH SIR MAIENSCHEIN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED OPEN ON THIS MATTER
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS IN NOVEMBER TWO THOUSAND
FOR CALIFORNIA VOTERS PASSED
PROPOSITION B. THREE THE MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES ACT.
THE LAW CALLED FOR THE
ESTABLISHMENT OF THE MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES OVERSIGHT AND
ACCOUNTABILITY COMMISSION.
A. B. FOURTEEN FORTY THREE WILL
REQUIRE THE COMMISSION TO
ESTABLISH TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
CENTERS TO SUPPORT COUNTIES IN
ADDRESSING MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES
THAT ARE OF STATEWIDE CONCERN.
THIS WILL ESTABLISH AND IDENTIFY
WITH STAKEHOLDER INPUT WHICH
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES ARE THE
MOST PRESSING THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AND I ABOUT.
THANK YOU MISTER MAIENSCHEIN
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THIS MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESERVE A
ON MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE I SIXTY SIX KNOWS
HERE THIS MEASURE PASSES BY
LIGHT A MONEY SIX EIGHTY
FOURTEEN FIFTY ONE THE CLERK
WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL FOURTEEN FIFTY ONE
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOW AND
OTHERS AN ACCOLADE TO ELECTIONS.
HELLO YOU ARE RECOGNIZED OPEN ON
THIS MATTER THANK YOU VERY MUCH
BEEN A SICK REMEMBERS AB
FOURTEEN FIFTY ONE MAINTAINS
INTEGRITY OF OUR ELECTORAL
PROCESS WITH RESPECT.
TO DIRECT DEMOCRACY I
RESPECTFULLY ASK PRIVATE.
THANK YOU MISTER LOS SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THIS MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ON MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
QUIRK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE ICE FORTY FIVE NO
SEVENTEEN THIS MEASURE PASSES.
PASS TEMPORARILY IN FILE ITEM
ONE EIGHTY SEVEN FILE ITEM ONE
EIGHTY EIGHT AB FOURTEEN SIXTY
THE CLERK WILL READ.
SOME PEOPLE FOURTEEN SIXTY BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WEBER AND OTHERS
NOT RELATE TO THE CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY DOCTOR WEBER
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED OPEN ON THIS
MATTER THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS I RISE TO PRESENT TO
YOU AB FOURTEEN SIXTY WOULD
SEEKS TO HAVE ETHNIC STUDIES.
AS A GRADUATION REQUIREMENT IN
THE CAL STATE UNIVERSITY SYSTEM.
SEE ISSUE EDUCATES THE MOST
ETHNICALLY DIVERSE STUDENT
POPULATION IN THE WORLD AND THIS
DIVERSITY SHOULD BE CELEBRATED
BY INSTITUTIONALIZING A
CURRICULUM THAT IS INCLUSIVE.
AND REFLECTIVE OF THE STUDENT
CULTURES AND BACKGROUNDS THEY
SERVE.
IT HAS BEEN FIFTY YEARS SINCE
THE C. ISSUE ESTABLISH THE FOR
BIRTH PLACE.
OF OF ETHNIC STUDIES AT SAN
FRANCISCO STATE.
ALL OF ALMOST ALL OF OUR
CAMPUSES ALREADY ROOMMATE
MAINTAIN SOME LEVEL ETHNIC
STUDIES ON THEM.
ETHNIC STUDIES FILLS A GAP OF
KNOWLEDGE AND CORRECT.
CORRECT INSTANT INTENTIONAL
MISREPRESENTATION OF PEOPLE OF
COLOR THEIR HISTORIES AND CONTRA
RECENT EXPERIENCES.
THIS BILL IS NOT DESIGNED TO
INCREASE THE NUMBER OF
REQUIREMENTS TO YOU IT'S
REQUIRED FOR GRADUATION BUT
MERELY TO MAKE VARIOUS OPTIONS
AVAILABLE THAT BASICALLY ENHANCE
THE ETHNIC STUDIES CURRICULUM.
WE JUST PASSED A BILL TO MAKE
SURE THAT ETHNIC STUDIES WAS
TAUGHT IN OUR HIGH SCHOOLS THE
REALITY IS IT WILL NOT BE TAUGHT
IN OUR HIGH SCHOOLS AND NOT
TAUGHT WELL UNLESS IT IS PEOPLE
ARE WELL TRAINED AT THE C. ISSUE.
WHICH PRODUCES MOST OF OUR
TEACHERS FOR THE SYSTEM.
THIS BILL WOULD ALSO REQUIRE
THAT THE ACADEMIC SENATE TO WORK
WITH THE C. ISSUE COUNSEL ON
ETHNIC STUDIES TO DEVELOP CORE
COMPETENCIES TO ACHIEVE.
RICHIE BY STUDENTS TO TAKE THESE
COURSES THIS BILL SPONSORED BY
THE CALIFORNIA FACULTY
ASSOCIATION WHICH IS A MAIN
FACULTY ASSOCIATION SEE ISSUE.
BY THE LA DEMOCRATIC PARTY BUT
AS THE ARE YOU AT A HOST OF
OTHER ORGANIZATIONS SUPPORTING
ETHNIC STUDIES BUT BEING TAUGHT
AT OUR UNIVERSITY -- WE
RESPECTFULLY I ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU DOCTOR WEBER SEEING.
MR MEDINA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED ON
THIS MATTER THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER IN MEMBERS I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF AB.
FOURTEEN SIXTY AS A PROD CO
AUTHOR AS WE DID FOR HIGH SCHOOL
GRADUATION REQUIREMENT.
I DON'T THINK WE CAN CONSIDER A
PERSON TRULY EDUCATED UNLESS HE
HAS HERE SHE HAS.
A BROAD KNOWLEDGE OF ALL GROUPS
SO RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
VOTE ON A. B..
FOR SIXTY THANK YOU MISTER
MEDINA SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE DOCTOR WEBER
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE I JUST.
I VOTE THEIR NORMAL.
POSITION TO THIS BILL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH BURKE WILL OPEN THE
ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED AS OUR TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF THOSE WHO DESIRE
TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TELEVOTE EYES FORTY NINE KNOWS A
LEVIN THIS MEASURE PASSES.
PASS TEMPORARILY ON FILE ITEM
ONE EIGHTY NINE FILE ITEM ONE
NINETY AB FOURTEEN SIXTY SIX THE
CLERK WILL READ SOME PEOPLE
FOURTEEN SIXTY SIX BY SOME
REMEMBER URBAN ACCOLADE
EDUCATION DATA -- WHEN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED OPEN ON THIS MATTER --
THE THANK YOU MADAM.
SPEAKER CALIFORNIA.
MAKE SURE I HAVE THE RIGHT BILL.
CALIFORNIA IS JUST ONE OF JUST A
HANDFUL OF STATES LACKING A DATA
SYSTEM THAT SPANS ACROSS
EDUCATIONAL SEGMENTS AND INTO
THE WORK FORCE OUR CURRENT
SYSTEMS EXISTENCE SILOS THAT DO
NOT SPEAK TO EACH OTHER.
MEANING POLICY MAKERS AND
RESEARCHERS ARE UNABLE TO ANSWER
BASIC QUESTIONS ABOUT STUDENT
PROGRESS AND OUTCOMES.
AB FOURTEEN SIXTY SIX IS A
CRUCIAL FIRST STEP IN CREATING A
STATEWIDE LONGITUDINAL DATA
SYSTEM THAT STUDENT DATA SYSTEM
THAT LEVERAGES EXISTING SYSTEMS
WHILE PROTECTING STUDENT.
PRIVACY.
THIS WILL GIVE LEGISLATORS THE
TOOLS THEY NEED TO MAKE
DECISIONS BASED ON COMPLETE AND
MEANINGFUL INFORMATION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR I PO.
THANK YOU MISS IRWIN.
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED IS THERE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS THERE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRED BOTH.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TELEVOTE AYE SIXTY THREE KNOWS
ZERO THIS MEASURE PASSES.
PASS TEMPORARILY FILE ITEM ONE
NINETY ONE FILE ITEM ONE NINETY
TWO AB FOURTEEN EIGHTY THREE THE
CLERK WILL READ.
SOME PEOPLE FOURTEEN EIGHTY
THREE BY SOME IMMIGRATION AND
ACTUALLY THE HOUSING.
MR GRAYSON YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
OPEN ON THIS MATTER THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE TO
PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL.
FOURTEEN EIGHTY THREE AB
FOURTEEN EIGHTY THREE DIRECT
CITIES AND COUNTIES TO PARTNER
WITH THEIR LOCAL NPOS AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT TO PRODUCE
A COMPREHENSIVE SET OF HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT PIPELINE DATA.
TRANSPARENCY IN BETTER DATA WILL
GIVE US A CLEAR PICTURE OF WHAT
WORKS AND WHAT DOESN'T AND IT
WILL DRIVE BETTER DECISION
MAKING AS WE SEARCH FOR
SOLUTIONS. TO OUR HOUSING
AFFORDABILITY CRISIS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER GRAYSON SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THIS MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
PHONE NUMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE
TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
IN TALLY THE VOTES AYE AYES
SIXTY NO ZERO THIS MEASURE
PASSES FILE ITEM ONE NINETY
THREE AB FIFTEEN HUNDRED THE
CLERK WILL READ.
SOME PEOPLE FIFTEEN HUNDRED BY
SOME REMEMBER CARILLO INOCULATE
A HAZARDOUS SUBSTANCES HIS
CAREER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED OPEN
ON THIS MATTER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I AM PROUD 2% ASSEMBLY
BILL FIFTEEN HUNDRED WHICH WAS
STRAINED LOCAL AUTHORITIES TO
TAKE IMMEDIATE ACTION AGAINST
LOCAL THREATS.
TO THE PUBLIC HEALTH AND SAFETY
INCLUDING THE ABILITY FOR LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS TO DIRECT THE
FACILITY OR PORTION OF A
FACILITY. TO TEMPORARILY
DISCONTINUE THE OPERATIONS THAT
COST AN EXPOSURE.
IN CALIFORNIA MULTIPLE
REGULATORY AUTHORITIES HAVE
JURISDICTION OVER BUSINESSES
THAT HANDLE OR GENERATE
HAZARDOUS WASTE.
AND MATERIALS THAT POSE A RISK
TO PUBLIC HEALTH AND SAFETY.
LOCALLY A CERTIFIED UNION
PROGRAM AGENCY IS RESPONSIBLE
FOR IMPLEMENTING AND ENFORCING
HAZARDOUS MATERIALS AND WASTE
LAWS.
AND THE LOCAL HEALTH OFFICER HAS
GENERAL AUTHORITY TO PROTECT THE
PUBLIC'S HEALTH AND EXPAND THE
TORT AUTHORITY ONLY AFTER A
COUNTY WIDE EMERGENCY IS
DECLARED.
CURRENTLY SOME FACILITIES THAT
EMIT HAZARDOUS SUBSTANCE OF
CONTINUE TO OPERATE BECAUSE THEY
DO NOT MEET.
REGULATORY LEAVE MINIMUM
STANDARDS TO CEASE OPERATIONS
IMMEDIATELY.
THIS BILL IT'S IMPERATIVE TO
ENSURE THAT LOCAL AUTHORITIES
CLOSEST TO THE COMMUNITIES
IMPACTED BY TOXIC POLLUTION.
CAN EXPEDITIOUSLY EXPEDITIOUSLY
PROTECT PUBLIC HEALTH AND SAFETY
THIS IS A BILL THAT ACTUALLY
GENERATED FROM OUR DISTRICT
FOLLOWING.
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT FIFTY ONE
FOLLOWING THE EXITE
CONTAMINATION.
AFTER A CONVENING THAT WE DID
WITH OUR COMMUNITY A YEAR AGO
WITH FELLOW MEMBERS WHO ARE
IMPACTED AS WELL AS THE SPEAKER.
AB FIFTEEN HUNDRED WILL ENABLE
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS TO DIRECT
THE FACILITY OR A PORTION OF A
FACILITY TO TEMPORARILY
DISCONTINUE THE OPERATIONS THAT
HAVE EXPOSED THEIR COMMUNITIES.
TO HARMFUL TOXIC MATERIALS.
UNTIL THE ISSUE IS CORRECTED AB
FIFTEEN HUNDRED IS COMMONSENSE
LEGISLATION THAT WILL ENABLE OUR
LOCAL AUTHORITIES TO ACT IN THE
INTEREST OF OUR CONSTITUENTS.
AND BETTER PROTECT COMMUNITIES
PUBLIC HEALTH AND SAFETY WILL
COORDINATING WITH THE PROPER
AGENCIES I LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUE THE WORK WITH OUR
STAKEHOLDERS AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS CARILLO SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THIS MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE -- MEMBERS VOTED IS
THERE TO VOTE.
LONG MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE THE CLERK
WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY THE
VOTE ICE FORTY NINE NEWS HERE
THIS MEASURE PASSES.
VIOLATED ONE NINETY FOUR A. B.
FIFTEEN NO ONE THE CLERK WILL
READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL FIFTY NO ONE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LOW AN ACCOLADE
OF FIREARMS MR LE YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED OPEN ON THIS MATTER
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS AB FIFTY NO ONE
ESTABLISHES FIREARM PROCEDURES
WITH RESPECT TO BALLISTICS USED.
IN CASES OF CRIMINAL ACTIVITY
AND THIS BILL WILL SOLVE
ADDITIONAL GUN CRIMES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK PRIVATE.
THANK YOU MISTER LOS SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THIS MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED DESIRED VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE AYE AYES FORTY
NINE NO ZERO THIS MEASURE PASSES.
PASS TEMPORARILY ON FILE ITEMS
ONE NINETY FIVE ONE NINETY SIX
FILE ITEM ONE NINETY SEVEN AB
FIFTEEN SIXTEEN THE CLERK WILL
READ.
SOMEBODY BILL FIFTEEN SIXTEEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN ACCOLADE
A FIRE PREVENTION IS FRIEDMAN
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED OPEN ON THIS
MATTER THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER
MEMBERS IN 200-017-2000 EIGHTEEN
OVER THREE MILLION ACRES BURNED
IN HIGH FIRE HIGH SEVERITY
WILDFIRES.
IN OVER THIRTY THOUSAND
STRUCTURES WERE DESTROYED OVER
ONE HUNDRED CALIFORNIANS HAVE
DIED FROM WILDFIRES OVER THE
LAST TWO YEARS.
HOW FIRE KEEPS RECORDS OF THE
LARGEST AND MOST DESTRUCTIVE
WILDFIRES IN THE STATE'S HISTORY
AND EACH YEAR THOSE RECORDS
CONTINUE TO BE BROKEN AND WE
ANTICIPATE THIS THIS TO BE THE
NEW TREND? FOR AND FOR THAT --
TIME TO COME.
LAST YEAR MY AB TWENTY NINE
ELEVEN AND OTHER PARTS OF THE
WILDFIRE PREVENTION AND RECOVERY
LEGISLATIVE PACKAGE MADE
IMPORTANT IMPROVEMENTS TO
CALIFORNIA'S FIRE PREVENTION
EFFORTS.
HOWEVER THERE ARE ADDITIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES TO IMPROVE FIRE
SAFETY IN CALIFORNIA COMMUNITIES.
AB FIFTEEN SIXTEEN WILL IMPROVE
DISPENSABLE SPACE COMPLIANCE AND
PHASE IN A NEW NON COMBUSTIBLES
OWNED RIGHT NOW SIR NEXT TO
STRUCTURES.
REQUIRE THE USE OF RIGHT TREAT
RIGHT PLACE FOR FUTURE PLANTING
UNDER ELECTRICAL LINES IN HIGH
FIRE HAZARD ZONES.
THIS WILL REDUCE UTILITY
REGISTRY -- BUT JUST VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT COSTS AND WILDFIRES
CREATE A GUIDE BOOK TO PROVIDE
LANDOWNERS OPTIONS OF VEGETATION
THAT WOULD NEVER GROW INTO
ENERGIZED CONDUCTORS AND CAUSE
FIRES.
MODERNIZE CAL FIRES REQUIREMENTS
TO PROVIDE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
TO LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ON FIRE
PREVENTION AND APPROPRIATE
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT.
ALL OF THE PARTS OF THE BILL
WILL ASSIST IN PREVENTING
DESTRUCTIVE WILDFIRES FROM
CAUSING HAVOC IN CALIFORNIA AND
REDUCE THE NUMBER OF HOMES
DESTROYED BY WILDFIRES.
WE WILL CONTINUE TO TAKE A
MOMENT IN THE SENATE. TO REMOVE
ANY OBLIGATION ON LAND OWNERS TO
REMOVE ANY VOLUNTEER VEGETATION
THAT THEY DIDN'T PLANT THAT'S
UNDER POWER LINES.
AB FIFTEEN SIXTEEN HAS RECEIVED
A BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND AS THE
SUPPORT OF THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY THE SIERRA CLUB.
RESOURCE CONSERVATION DISTRICTS
FIRE SAFE COUNCILS THE BUILDING
INDUSTRY THE INSURANCE INDUSTRY
AND AS D. G. ANY I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS FRIEDMAN SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THIS MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED IS THERE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF THOSE WHO DESIRE
TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE ICE FIFTY SEVEN
KNOWS ONE THIS MEASURE PASSES
FILE ITEM ONE NINETY EIGHTY BE.
FIFTEEN NINETEEN WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL FIFTEEN NINETEEN
BY THE COMMITTEE -- BUSINESS A
PROFESSION TONIGHT RELATING
HEALING ARTS STILL -- YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED OPEN ON THIS MATTER
THANK YOU VERY MUCH BETTER
SECURE MEMBERS MEMBERS THESE ARE
A NUMBER OF BILLS IN SERIES WITH
RESPECT TO THE SUN SAID
EXTENSION OF THE CONSUMER
PROTECTION BOARD THIS IS THE
DENTAL BOARD SENSE THAT ARE
STRICTLY ASK PRIVATE.
THANK YOU MISTER LOWE SINGING
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THIS MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TELLING VOTE I SIXTY THREE NO
ZERO FILE ITEM ONE NINETY NINE
THE CLERK WILL READ.
SOME PEOPLE FIFTEEN TWENTY BY
THE COMMITTEE OF THE BUSINESS A
PROFESSIONS AND I BELIEVE THE
PROFESSIONS OF LOCATIONS MAKING
AN APPROPRIATION ARE FOR MR LOW
YOUR AGAIN RECOGNIZED MEMBERS
THIS BILL IS THE COURT REPORTER
SPORTSCENTER RESPECTFULLY ASK
PRIVATE.
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE ON MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TELLING VOTE I SIXTY THREE KNOWS
HERE THIS MEASURE PASSES FILE
ITEM TWO HUNDRED A. B. FIFTEEN
TWENTY ONE THE CLERK WILL READ.
SOME PEOPLE FIFTEEN TWENTY ONE
BY THE COMMITTEE ON BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS AND I BELIEVE THE
PROFESSIONS OF LOCATIONS MR LOW
YOUR AGAIN RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISTAKEN MEMBERS THIS
IS THE CALIFORNIA BOARD OF
ACCOUNTANCY SENSE THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR ABOUT.
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE CLERK WILL OPEN THE WRONG
ALL MEMBERS VOTED IS THERE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO THEIR TO
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLAIRE WELL CLOSE THE ROLLING
TALLY THE VOTE I SIXTY TWO NOTES
HERE AS MEASURE PASSES BY LIGHT
INTO A ONE AB FIFTEEN TWENTY TO
THE CLERK WILL READ.
SOME PEOPLE FIFTEEN TWENTY TWO
BY THE COMMITTEE ON BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS AND I RELATED
PROFESSIONS OF LOCATIONS MR LOW
YOUR AGAIN RECOGNIZED THAT IS A
GOOD MEMBERS THIS IS THE BORDER
PROFESSIONAL ENGINEERS LAND
SURVEYORS AND GEOLOGISTS SENSE
THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK RIGHT
VOTE.
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE CLERK WILL OPEN THEIR OWN
ALL MEMBERS ROAD USER TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED IS ERICA.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED DESERTED PHOTO.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE I SIXTY ONE NEWS
HERE THIS MEASURE PASSES.
BY LIGHT INTO A TWO A. B.
FIFTEEN TWENTY THREE THE CLERK
WILL READ SOME REAL FIFTEEN
TWENTY THREE BY THE COMMITTEE ON
BUSINESS A PROFESSION TO NOT
RELATED BUSINESS.
AND MR LOW YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS THIS IS THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ATHLETIC
COMMISSION SUNSET EXTENSION TO
ENSURE HAT PROTECTIONS FOR ALL.
ATHLETES IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR A VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER LOWE FEAR
BREVITY.
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE.
ON MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE DEVOTE.
ALL MEMBERS AT HIS THERE'D VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRED
VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TELEVOTE AYE SIXTY TWO NO THEIR
THIS MEASURE PASSES.
WE TO FILE ITEM ONE SEVENTEEN AB.
SEVEN EIGHTY FOUR BURKE WILL
READ.
DID YOU GET IT -- FILE ITEM ONE
SEVENTEEN AB SEVENTY FOUR FOR
SOME REASON SOMEONE WILL SEVEN
EIGHTY FOUR BY SOME MEMBER
MULLIN ALKYLATED TAXATION TO
TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY TAX LEVY.
MISTER MIND YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
SPEAKER AB SEVENTY FOUR WHEEL
EXAM ZERO MISSION TRANSIT BUSES
OR Z. BEES.
FROM THE STATE PORTION OF THE
SALES TAX UNTIL JANUARY FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR IN ORDER TO
ADVANCE THE DEPLOYMENT OF ZERO
EMISSION BUSES IN CALIFORNIA.
ALMOST HALF OF THE STATE'S BUS
POPULATION CONTAINS DIESEL
ENGINES WHICH AMID A COMPLEX
MIXTURE OF AIR POLLUTANTS THAT
CAUSE CANCER PREMATURE DEATH IN
A BEEN IDENTIFIED AS TOP
CONTRIBUTORS TO CLIMATE CHANGE.
MANY TRANSIT AGENCIES IN
CALIFORNIA BEGUN REDUCES
EMISSIONS BY DEPLOYING SEABEES
HOWEVER THESE TECHNOLOGIES MORE
EXPENSIVE THAN DIESEL
ALTERNATIVES AND TRANSIT
AGENCIES ARE OFTEN CAST TRAP.
LOSING MONEY AT THE FARE BOX AND
RELYING ON FEDERAL STATE AND
LOCAL SUBSIDIES TO COVER CAPITAL
COSTS.
AS THE AIR RESOURCES BOARD IS
NOW MANDATING THAT PUBLIC
TRANSIT AGENCIES CONVERT THEIR
FLEETS TO ZERO MISSION
TECHNOLOGIES BY.
TWENTY FORTY AB SEVENTY FOUR
WILL ASSIST THESE AGENCIES BY
EXISTING THE BY EXEMPTING THESE
BUSES FROM THE STATE PORTION OF
SALES TAX FOR FOUR YEARS HELPING
AGENCIES OVER COM.
AN IMPORTANT UP FRONT FUNDING
SHORTFALL THAT CURRENTLY IMPEDES
THE PROCUREMENT OF SEABEES AND
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER MULLIN SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THIS MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ON MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLICK WELL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY VOTE AYE SIXTY NO ZERO
THIS MEASURE PASSES MOVING TO
FILE ITEM ONE TWENTY TWO AB
EIGHT THIRTY NINE THE CLERK WILL
READ.
SOME PEOPLE EIGHT THIRTY NINE BY
SOME REMEMBER MULLIN ACRYLATE A
CLIMATE CHANGE JUST REMIND YOU
ARE AGAIN RECOGNIZED.
MADAM SPEAKER AB EIGHT THIRTY
NINE ONE ACT TO CLIMATE
ADAPTATION FRAMEWORK TO GUIDE
THE STATE OVER THE COMING YEARS
TO ENSURE WE HAVE A THOUGHTFUL
SET OF GOALS COORDINATED
GOVERNMENT ACTIONS AN INNOVATIVE
FUNDING MECHANISMS IN PLACE. TO
ADDRESS OUR CLIMATE ADAPTATION
NEEDS CALIFORNIA'S DONE GREAT
WORK TO DATE INVESTING IN
RESEARCH AND DEVELOPING GUIDANCE
IN PLANNING FOR ADAPTATION TO
CLIMATE CHANGE.
AB EIGHT THIRTY NINE TAKES AN
IMPORTANT NEXT STEP TO ADD MORE
URGENCY IN ACCOUNTABILITY TO
THOSE EFFORTS.
IN ORDER TO MEASURE THE STATE'S
PROGRESS IN BUILDING AND
INVESTING IN ADAPTATION RIVER
AND RESILIENCY PROJECTS THIS
BILL DIRECTS THE NATURAL
RESOURCES AGENCY THAT TIME
TABLES AND METRICS. TO THE
SAFEGUARDING CALIFORNIA PLAN IT
ALSO CREATES A FINE THAT THE
RESOURCES AGENCY IN TREASURER
WILL MANAGE TO DEVELOP GRANDSON
INNOVATIVE FINANCING FOR THE
RECOMMENDED PROJECTS.
GIVEN THE BREATH COMPLEXITY%
PERVASIVENESS AND DANGER OF
CLIMATE CHANGE THIS TARGETED
FUNDING ACCOUNTABILITY IS NEEDED
AND I ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MISTER MULLIN SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THIS MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE ICE FIFTY NO SIX
THIS MEASURE PASSES MOVING TO
FILE ITEM. ONE NINETY FIVE AB
FIFTEEN OWN NINE THE CLERK WILL
READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL FIFTEEN OH NINE BY
SOME REMEMBER WILD SNACK LAID A
SOLID WASTE.
MR MOWING YOUR AGAIN RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU AGAIN MADAM SPEAKER
FINALLY AB.
FIFTEEN OH NINE ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
BERMAN SENATOR HELEN I
INTRODUCED AB FIFTEEN OH NINE IN
RESPONSE TO A FIRE CAUSED ME A
LITHIUM ION BATTERY AT THE SHORE
WAY FACILITY IN SAN MATEO COUNTY.
WHICH CAUSED A POINT FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS IN DAMAGES THAT
SHUT DOWN THE FACILITY FOR
NINETY DAYS AND TOOK OVER A YEAR
TO RESTORE.
THIS IS JUST ONE COSTLY EXAMPLE
OF THE INCREASING RISK OF FIRES
FROM LITHIUM ION BATTERIES THAT
ARE IMPROPERLY DISCARDED IN THE
MUNICIPAL WASTE STREAM.
EXISTING LAW ALREADY PROHIBITS
THESE BATTERIES ARE BEING THROWN
IN THE TRASH AND REQUIRES LARGE
RETAILERS TO HAVE A MECHANISM TO
ACCEPT ALL RECHARGEABLE
BATTERIES FROM CONSUMERS FOR
RECYCLING.
BATTERIES THAT ARE EMBEDDED IN
DEVICES ARE NOT SUBJECT TO THIS
LAW SO WE PROPOSED THAT
RETAILERS HELP IMPROVE THE
COLLECTION OF PRODUCTS WITH
EMBEDDED LITHIUM ION BATTERIES.
BY ESTABLISHING A TAKE BACK
PROGRAMMER DEPOSIT SYSTEM OR
SIMILAR PROGRAM WE ARE MAKING
SURE THAT FLEXIBILITY IS ALLOWED
SINCE THERE'S SUCH A WIDE ARRAY
OF PRODUCTS THAT HAVE THESE
BATTERIES IN THEM.
IT IS A GROWING CONCERN WHEN IT
COMES TO MANUFACTURERS OF LOOSE
LITHIUM ION BATTERIES WERE
DEALING WITH A MUCH SMALLER
GROUP OF ENTITIES AB FIFTEEN OR
NINE CALLS FOR THEM TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE END OF LIFE
MANAGEMENT OF THEIR PRODUCTS.
WITH A PRODUCER RESPONSIBILITY
MODEL PLEASE JOIN MY COLLEAGUES
FROM THE PENINSULA AYE TO
ADDRESS THIS ISSUE AND ABORT
AVOID ANYMORE OF THESE FIRES IN
OUR COUNTY OR ANYWHERE ELSE IN
CALIFORNIA.
AND ASK FOR A VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER MULLIN SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED IS THERE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALENT VOTE AYE AYES FORTY NINE
NEWS HERE THIS MEASURE PASSES.
VIOLATE IN TWO OH THREE AB
FIFTEEN FORTY EIGHT THE CLERK
WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL FIFTEEN FORTY
EIGHT BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER GABRIEL
AND OTHERS AN ACCOLADE THE STATE
GOVERNMENT.
SIR GABRIEL YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
OPEN ON THIS MATTER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I AM
PLEASED TO PRESENT A. B. FIFTEEN
FORTY EIGHT WHICH WOULD CODIFY
THE CALIFORNIA NONPROFIT
SECURITY GRANT PROGRAM.
AND PROVIDE MUCH NEEDED
ASSISTANCE TO NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS AT RISK OF HATE
MOTIVATED VIOLENCE.
I THINK ALL OF US HAVE SEEN
AFTER THE TRAGIC SHOOTING AT THE
SYNAGOGUE IN PO A IN OTHER
INCIDENTS AROUND THE GLOBE.
THE NEED TO PROTECT COMMUNITIES
THAT ARE RISK OF HATE MOTIVATED
VIOLENCE THIS IS A PRIORITY BILL
FOR THE JEWISH CAUCUS AND WOULD
BE A HUGE STEP FORWARD.
IN PROTECTING COMMUNITIES THAT
ARE TARGETED BACK HATE I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MR GABRIEL SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THIS MATTER THE CLERK WILL.
OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE I SIXTY KNOWS
YOUR THIS MEASURE PASSES FILE.
ITEM -- TO FOR AB FIFTEEN
SEVENTY SIX THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL FIFTEEN SEVENTY
SIX BY SOME REMEMBER CALDERON
ACRYLATE THE TECHNOLOGY MISTER
CALDERON YOU ARE RECOGNIZED OPEN
ON THIS MATTER THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS AB FIFTY SEVENTY
SIX WOULD DIRECT THE GOVERNMENT.
OF OPERATIONS AGENCY TO
ESTABLISH AN ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE WORKING GROUP TO
ANALYSE THE ETHICS IMPROPER
USAGE OF ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE
TECHNOLOGY WITHIN THE CAL WITHIN
CALIFORNIA BUSINESS AND CONSUMER
PRODUCTS.
BEST USES USING DO NOT WHEN IT
COMES TO REGULATING RESPECTFULLY
ASK WHEN I VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER CALDERON SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THIS MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED IS THERE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
ALONG MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE
TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY VOTE EYES FIFTY EIGHT
KNOWS HERE THIS MEASURE PASSES
BY LIGHT INTO A FIVE AB FIFTEEN
EIGHTY THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL FIFTEEN EIGHTY BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LEVINE ACRYLATE
AND AN ACCOLADE A PUBLIC
CONSTRUCTION PROJECTS MR LEVINE
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED OPEN ON THIS
MATTER THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS IF THERE IS A
STATE INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECT
THAT'S GOING TO COST OVER A
BILLION DOLLARS.
IT SHOULD HAVE OVERSIGHT AND
RISK MANAGEMENT AS PART OF THE
PROJECT THIS BILL WILL BRING
THAT TO IT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER LEVINE SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THIS MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED IS OUR TO VOTE.
ON MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TELLING VOTE AYE AYES SIXTY ONE
KNOWS ONE THIS MEASURE PASSES
FILE ITEM TWO OH SIX AB FIFTEEN
EIGHTY EIGHT THE CLERK WILL READ.
THE BILL FIFTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GLORIA ANOTHER'S
AN ACCOLADE WATER MR GLORIA YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED OPEN ON THIS
MATTER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I DO
BELIEVE EVERY MEMBER HERE HONORS
OUR MILITARY VETERANS FOR THEIR
SERVICE THIS BILL WILL ALLOW
THEM TO TAKE THEIR SERVICE AND
TURNING A GOOD PAYING JOBS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER GLORIA SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THIS MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED IS THERE TO
VOTE.
ON MEMBERS VOTED IS THERE TO
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
CLARK WELL CLOSE THE ROLLING
TALLY VOTE EYES FIFTY SIX KNOWS
HERE THIS MEASURE PASSES BY
LIGHT INTO A SEVENTY BE FIFTEEN
NINETY THE CLERK WILL READ.
SOME A BILL FIFTY NINETY BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BLOCK RUBIO AN
ACCOLADE THE TAXATION TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY TAX LEVY.
MISS RUBIO YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
OPEN ON THIS MATTER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT THIS
IMPORTANT BILL TODAY.
ASSEMBLY BILL FIFTEEN NINETY
WILL CREATE A FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLAR TAX CREDIT FOR LOW OR
MODERATE INCOME FIRST TIME HOME
BUYERS WHO PURCHASED A PRINCIPAL
RESIDENCE LOCATED IN A
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITY.
WITH THE WORSENING HOUSING
CRISIS OPPORTUNITY TO FIRST TIME.
HOME OWNERSHIP AND DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES ARE LIMITED DUE TO
INCREASING COSTS ESPECIALLY FOR
INDIVIDUALS AND FAMILIES OF LOW
AND MODERATE INCOME.
THESE INCREASING COSTS INCLUDE
UNFORESEEN EXPENSES THAT CAN
OCCUR SOON AFTER PURCHASE SUCH
AS AND ANTICIPATED REPAIRS.
THESE UNFORESEEN EXPENSES CAN
ALSO THE FIRST TIME AND LAW AND
FIRST TIME LOW AND MODERATE
INCOME HOMEBUYERS EXASPERATED AS
THEY STRUGGLE TO MAINTAIN HOME
OWNERSHIP.
WITH THE SKYROCKETING RENTAL AND
HOUSING COSTS ACROSS THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA.
AB FIFTEEN NINETY CREATES A
FINANCIAL INCENTIVE FOR LOW TO
MODERATE INCOME INDIVIDUALS AND
FAMILIES LOOKING TO PURSUE THE
PURSUE THE PATHWAY TO HOME
OWNERSHIP.
THE BILL IS SPONSORED BY THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS HAS NO OPPOSITION AND
HAS RECEIVED. ZERO NO VOTES TO
DATE.
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT TODAY AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
MISS I GATHER KERR YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED ON THIS MATTER.
MEMBER.
I SUPPORT TAX CREDITS TO HELP
LOW AND MIDDLE INCOME FAMILIES
BUY HOMES.
BUT THIS BILL ONLY BENEFITS
FAMILIES IN CALLIN VIRAL SCREEN
COMMUNITIES.
CALAVERAS SCREEN IS A TOOL USED
TO IDENTIFY PREDOMINANTLY URBAN
COMMUNITIES EXPERIENCING SEVERE
POLLUTION BURDENS.
HOWEVER IT UNDER REPRESENTS
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES IN
RURAL CALIFORNIA.
IT IS IMPORTANT TO ADDRESS URBAN
ENVIRONMENTAL POLLUTION BUT THAT
IS NOT WHAT THIS BILL DOES.
THERE IS NO REASON THAT
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
OUTSIDE OF CHALAM BIO SCREEN
AREA SHOULD NOT ALSO BEEN A FROM
FROM A. B.. FIFTEEN NINETY FOR
THIS REASON I WILL VOTE NO ON
THIS BILL I CONTINUE TO VOTE
AGAINST BILLS THAT MISUSED CAL
ENVIRO SCREEN.
HE WAS IDEA ARE CURRY.
WHO MISTER STONE YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED ON THIS MATTER?
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I
RELUCTANTLY.
RISE IN OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL
I ABSOLUTELY LIED THE AUTHORS
NOTION OF TRYING TO BRING.
PEOPLE INTO HOUSING EARLIER THAN
THEY WOULD OTHERWISE.
BUT BECAUSE USING CALLIN VIRUS
GREEN AS A TOOL PRESENTS A BIT
OF A CHALLENGE TO ME.
THIS WOULD BE REQUIRING THAT THE
HOME BE PURCHASED IN A CALAVERAS
SCREEN AREA WHICH IS AN AREA
CALAVERAS KING WAS PUT IN PLACE.
TO MOVE MONEY AND PROGRAMS INTO
THESE AREAS THAT ARE HURT BY.
BAD AIR QUALITY.
SO WE'RE INCENTIVIZING NOW THE
PURCHASE OF HOMES IN AREAS
IDENTIFIED WITH BETTER QUALITY.
THE REVERSE WOULD BE PROBABLY
MUCH MUCH BETTER THAT IF WE GAVE
THEM THIS CREDIT FOR MOVING OUT
OF THE CALAVERAS SCREEN AREA
THAT'S THE KIND OF A PROGRAM
THAT I THINK WE SHOULD BE.
PROVIDING AN INCENTIVE.
FOR THE VIRUS CAN PROGRAM WAS
NOT REALLY DESIGNED FOR A
PROGRAM LIKE THIS AND BECAUSE OF
THAT BECAUSE IT'S A THOSE ARE
IDENTIFIED AREAS WITH POOR AIR
QUALITY.
WE'RE THEN CONCENTRATING.
UNDERSERVED PEOPLE CONTINUING TO
CONCENTRATE THEM IN AREAS WITH
BAD AIR QUALITY SO I I'M AFRAID
I CANNOT SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU MISTER STAND SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THIS MATTER MISS RUBIO YOU MAY
CLOSE.
THANK YOU IN RESPONSE TO SOME OF
THE CONCERNS RAISED THE MAPS
USED IN AB FIFTEEN NINETY ARE
WIDELY RECOGNIZED AS THE BEST
INDICATORS. FOR HOUSING NEEDS IN
FACT THE MAPS ARE BASED ON AREAS
WITH CONCENTRATION OF PEOPLE
THAT ARE OF LOW INCOME HIGH
UNEMPLOYMENT LOW LEVELS OF
HOMEOWNERSHIP HI RENT BURDEN.
SENSITIVE POPULATIONS OR LOW
LEVELS OF EDUCATIONAL ATTAINMENT.
OTHER MAP SUGGESTED FOR USE IN
THIS BILL DO NOT INCLUDE ANY OF
THESE HOUSING INDICATORS.
THE MAPS INCLUDED IN THIS BILL
HAVE A CENSUS TRACKS IN A
HUNDRED AND SIX OF THE HUNDRED
AND TWENTY LEGISLATIVE DISTRICTS
INCLUDING NINETY FIVE CENSUS
TRACTS IN THE BAY AREA.
AGAIN THIS BILL IS SPONSORED BY
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS HAS NO OPPOSITION TO
RECEIVE ZERO NO VOTES.
THANK YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR I WROTE QUIRK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED AS ART OF THE
ON MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
THIS BILL NEEDS FORTY ONE ALL
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE. TO
REMOVE THE CALL.
MOVING TO FILE ITEM ONE SEVENTY
TWO AB THIRTEEN SIXTY THE CLERK
WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTEEN SIXTY BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TING ACCOLADE TO
FOOD MR TING YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
OPEN ON THIS MATTER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER A. B..
THIRTEEN SIXTY THE BILL WHICH
ESTABLISHES A BASIS BASIC HEALTH
AND SAFETY STANDARDS FOR GROCERY
DELIVERIES THROUGH ONLINE
PLATFORMS.
FROM ONLINE DELIVERY UP
COMPANIES THE BILL REQUIRES THE
DELIVERY PERSON TO HAVE A FOOD
HANDLER CART.
DELIVERY VEHICLE TO MEET VEHICLE
CODE STANDARDS THE ONLINE
PLATFORM AND DRIVER TO ENSURE
THE FOOD IS TRANSPORTED MEETING
SPECIFIED HEALTH AND SAFETY
STANDARDS.
LIMITS NUMBER STOPS A DRIVER CAN
MAKE ALSO IMPOSES LIABILITY
RESPONSIBILITIES ON THE GROCERY
STORE AND WELL AS IMPOSES BASIC
STANDARDS FOR ALCOHOL DELIVERIES
AND ID CHECKS.
AGAIN THE GIG ECONOMY IS VERY
EXCITING AND THE WAY IT'S
CHANGING HOW EVERYTHING GETS
DELIVERED.
IS ABSOLUTELY WONDERFUL IN FACT
I'M A CUSTOMER OF MANY OF THESE
COMPANIES HOWEVER WE WANT TO
ENSURE IS THAT.
THE PRODUCT THE PEOPLE
DELIVERING THOSE PRODUCTS HAVE
BEEN TRAINED PROPERLY.
KNOW HOW TO HANDLE THE FOOD
PROPERLY AND THAT WE'RE GETTING
THE SAME AMOUNT OF HEALTH AND
SAFETY STANDARDS THAT WE WOULD
AS IF WE WERE IN A GROCERY STORE
OR WE OURSELVES WE'RE HANDLING
THIS FOOD.
WHAT THE PROFESSIONALS IN THE
STORES WERE HANDLING THE FOODS
FOR US AGAIN WITHOUT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE ON
A. B.?
THIRTEEN SIXTY THANK YOU MISTER
TANG SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THIS MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED THERE'D VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE VOTE.
BILL NEEDS FORTY ONE ALL MEMBERS
VOTED AS OUR TO VOTE
.
MR TING THERE'S A CALL.
PASS TEMPORARILY AND FILE ITEM
TWO AWAY FILE ITEM TO NINETY BE
FIFTEEN NINETY SIX THE CLERK
WILL READ.
SOME PEOPLE FIFTEEN NINETY SIX
BY THE COMMITTEE ON
ENVIRONMENTAL SAFETY AND TOXIC
MATERIALS AN ACCOLADE A
HAZARDOUS SUBSTANCES.
MR QUIRK YOU ARE RECOGNIZED OPEN
ON THIS [inaudible]
UP.
I THOUGHT YOU SAID AMENDMENTS
YOU DIDN'T MEAN AMENDMENTS DID
YOU I DO NOT SAM AND THEN OKAY.
I HAVE.
MY FAULT.
THANK YOU SPEAKER MEMBER -- A.
B. FIFTEEN NINETY SIX SAID SPENT
IN ALL TO THE METHAMPHETAMINE
CONTAMINATED PROPERTY ACT OF TWO
THOUSAND FIVE IN ORDER TO SET
INTERIM CLEANUP STANDARDS.
PREVENT NO CONTAMINATED PROPERTY
AND PROVIDES DIRECTION TO LOCAL
HEALTH OFFICERS FOR THE
OVERSIGHT AND CLEAN UP.
THE FENTANYL CONTAMINATED
PROPERTIES THE PROBLEM THEY HAVE
IS THAT THERE IS NO -- STANDARD
NOW AND THEY NEED ONE SO THAT
THEY KNOW THEY'VE DONE AN
ADEQUATE JOB.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU DOCTOR QUIRK SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THIS MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED IS THERE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
ALL MEMBERS GO TO DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED I READ THE
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE AND
TELL YOU THAT AYE AYES FIFTY
KNOWS HERE THIS MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM TO TEN A. B. SIXTEEN
OH THREE THE CLERK WILL READ.
SOME BILL SIXTEEN OH THREE BYE
SO MEMORABLE WICKS AN ACCOLADE
OF CRIMINAL JUSTICE.
MISS WICKS YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
OPEN ON THIS MATTER THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER AND MEMBERS.
I WANT TO TALK ABOUT THE GUN
VIOLENCE EPIDEMIC THAT I KNOW
HITS MANY OF OUR COMMUNITIES AND
I KNOW MANY OF US ARE.
IMPACTED ON THIS ISSUE IN
DIFFERENT WAYS AS I THINK I'D
MENTIONED BEFORE YOU KNOW MY
HUSBAND WAS.
GABBY GIFFORDS LEGISLATIVE
DIRECTOR WHEN SHE WAS SHOT.
BUT I ALSO COME FROM A FAMILY OF
HUNTERS AND SO THIS BAIT DEBATE
GETS POLARIZED IN MANY WAYS.
BUT WE KNOW THAT WE STILL OF AN
EPIDEMIC OF GUN VIOLENCE WE KNOW
THAT MANY OF THE COMMUNITIES
THAT WE LIVE IN STILL FACE
CHALLENGES WITH REGARD TO GUN
VIOLENCE IN THE WE LOSE LIVES.
EVERY SINGLE YEAR THIRTY
THOUSAND PEOPLE IN AMERICA DIED
AT THE HANDS OF GUN VIOLENCE
EVERY YEAR.
WE ALSO KNOW THAT WE CAN STOP
THIS IN THIS BODY HAS DONE A LOT
OF WORK TO ADDRESS THIS ISSUE
AND WE HAVE PASSED.
VERY STRONG GUN VIOLENCE
PREVENTION MEASURES OVER THE
YEARS BUT YET WE STILL HAVE
VIOLENCE IN OUR COMMUNITIES.
WHAT WE NEED TO DO IS STOP THE
EPIDEMIC AND STOP THE VIOLENCE
BEFORE IT STARTS AND THAT'S
EXACTLY WHAT THIS BILL WILL DO?
THIS BILLS TO CODIFY THE CAL
THAT PROGRAM.
THE CALIFORNIA VIOLENCE
INTERVENTION PREVENTION PROGRAM.
AGAIN WE KNOW THAT THIS WORKS IN
THE IN THE THESE RESOURCES ARE
TARGETED TO COMMUNITIES THEY GET
HIT THE MOST THAT ARE
EXPERIENCING GOD BY US EVERY
SINGLE DAY.
I WAS VERY PLEASE ALONG WITH
OTHERS. TO HAVE THE GOVERNOR
TRIPLE THE CAL THAT BUDGET
NUMBER IT WAS AT NINE MILLION
IT'S NOW IT TWENTY SEVEN MILLION
DOLLARS PER YEAR.
AND THESE ARE CRITICAL
INVESTMENTS THAT WE NEED TO
SUPPORT.
THIS BILL IS SUPPORTED BY.
GIFFORD'S IT'S SUPPORTED BY MOMS
DEMAND ACTION IS SUPPORTED BY
MANY OF YOU HERE IN THIS BODY
AND I WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS WICKS.
SEE NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE
ITEM [inaudible]
CLICK LIBERAL.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS ARE DESIRABLE
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ALL TELL YOU ABOUT.
AYE AYES FIFTY FOUR KNOWS ZERO
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
WHERE TO PASS RETAIN A FILE ITEM
TO ELEVEN AND?
TO TWELVE WORD FILE ITEM
[inaudible]
TO THIRTEEN THIS GIPSON.
THIS IS FILE ITEM TO THIRTEEN A.
B. SIXTEEN FOURTEEN CORPORATION
ASSEMBLY BILL SIXTEEN FOURTEEN
BY SOME REMEMBER GIPSON ACCOLADE
OF VEHICLES MR GIPSON.
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE TO
PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL A SIXTEEN
FOURTEEN WHICH WHICH WILL EXTEND
THE SUNSET FOR THE CURRENT A DMV
REGISTRATION TECHNOLOGY PILOT
PROGRAM TO JANUARY. ONE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE I RESPECTFULLY ASK
WHAT I VOTE.
THANK YOU MS GIBSON SEEN KNOWN
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE ITEM.
OUR CLUB OTHER ALL.
ALL MEMBERS REYES HAD ABOUT.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE [inaudible]
CLARK WELL [inaudible]
CLOSE ROLE.
HI BUT I FIFTY FIVE NO.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
WE'RE AT FILE I'M TO FOURTEEN AB.
SIXTEEN FORTY FIVE CLICK RATE.
SOME PEOPLE SIXTEEN FORTY FIVE
BY SOME REMEMBER BLOCK RUBIO AND
SUPPORTIVESERVICES.
MISS RUBIO THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I RISE TO PRESENT AB
SIXTEEN FORTY FIVE A BILL THAT
WILL DOES DESIGNATE A DREAM
RESOURCE LIAISON.
AT CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND A
RECOMMENDATION TO THE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA.
AB SIXTEEN FORTY FIVE WOULD CALL
ON OUR HIGHER EDUCATION SYSTEM
TO ESTABLISH ONGOING DREAMER
RESOURCE LIAISON POSITIONS TO
PROVIDE UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS
WITH ADEQUATE EDUCATIONAL
SUPPORT.
AND GUIDANCE OF STATE FUNDED
LEGAL SERVICES.
A REPORT RELEASED THIS MONTH BY
THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
AND OTHERS ACKNOWLEDGE THE NEED
FOR DESIGNATED STAFF ON CAMPUS
TO SERVE UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS.
COLLEAGUES THIS BILL WILL PUT
THEM RIGHT MECHANISM SIMPLY IN
PLACE TO HELP DREAMERS PURSUE A
POST SECONDARY EDUCATION TO
BETTER PREPARE THEM TO ENTER
CALIFORNIANS DEMANDING WORK
FORCE.
THANK YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR ABOUT.
THANK YOU ISRAEL MISS RACE YOUR
RECOGNIZE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
ARE RISES APPROACH HOW TO JOIN
AUTHOR.
OF EIGHTY SIXTEEN FORTY FIVE
BECAUSE I'VE HEARD THE NEEDS
FROM THE STUDENTS MY DISTRICT
AND THEY NEED THEY WANT SOMEONE
DEDICATE A DEDICATED STAFF
PERSON TO BE THE POINT OF
CONTACT PRINT DOCUMENTS STUDENTS.
WE MUST REMEMBER THAT IN
DOCUMENTS STUDENTS FACE MANY
CHALLENGES BECAUSE OF THEIR
STATUS BUT ALSO BECAUSE THE
MAJORITY OF THEM.
ARE FIRST GENERATION COLLEGE
STUDENTS AND NAVIGATING COLLEGE
SYSTEMS ON THEIR OWN.
TODAY OUR UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS
WERE GRADUATING HIGH SCHOOL ARE
NOT.
BEING PROVIDED THE SAME BENEFITS
AS MANY OF THOSE CURRENTLY IN
COLLEGE AND OUR COLLEGE COLLEGES
NEED TO ADDRESS THE NEEDS OF OUR
STUDENTS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MS REYES SAYING NO
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION ON THE
ADAM IS RUBIO YOU MAY CLOSE IF
YOU WISH.
THANK YOU I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
RIVAL.
CLICK LIBERAL.
ALL MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO
VOTE ON MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A
VOTE.
CLICK WELL CLOSE THE ROLE TALLY
THE VOTES.
I WAS FORTY THREE KNOWS.
TWELVE THAT MEASURE PASSES WELL
I'M TO FIFTEEN PASS RETAIN.
FILE ITEM.
TO SIXTEEN AB SIXTEEN FIFTY
EIGHT BY MISS CARILLO
CORPORATION.
ASSEMBLY BILL SIXTEEN FIFTY
EIGHT BY SOME REMEMBER CARILLO
AN ACCOLADE TEACHER
CREDENTIALING.
THIS SCRIPT THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I AM PLEASED TO PRESENT
AB SIXTEEN FIFTY EIGHT WHICH
WILL REQUIRE THE COMMISSION OF
TEACHER CREDENTIALING TO
ESTABLISH A WORK GROUP TO STUDY
ISSUES RELATING TO ADULT
EDUCATION TEACHER CREDENTIALING.
THE WORK GROUP WILL COLLABORATE
WITH REPRESENTATIVES WITH DIRECT
EXPERIENCE WITH AND KNOWLEDGE OF
THE ADULT EDUCATION LANDSCAPE
INCLUDING ADULT EDUCATION
TEACHERS.
AND ADMINISTRATORS WORKING WITH
IN BOTH THE K. THROUGH TWELVE
AND THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGE SYSTEMS.
TOGETHER WORKING MEMBERS WILL
CREATE CRAFT SUGGESTIONS TO
ADDRESS THAT THE THING
INEQUALITY THAN AREAS FOR
IMPROVEMENT WITH AN ADULT
EDUCATION TRAINING HIRING AN
INSTRUCTION.
UNDER EXISTING LAW THERE ARE
DISCREPANCIES BETWEEN THE
CREDENTIALING REQUIREMENTS FOR
K. THROUGH TWELVE EDUCATION
TEACHERS.
AND ADULT EDUCATION TEACHERS IN
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
AB SIXTEEN FIFTY EIGHT WILL
PROVIDE AN OPPORTUNITY FOR OUR
EXPERTS IN THE FIELD OF ADULT
EDUCATION TO COORDINATE.
MEASURED SOLUTIONS AND ENCOURAGE
THE ACCESSIBILITY AND
IMPROVEMENT OF ADULT EDUCATION
STATE WIDE AND I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE.
THE AIM IS CREEL SENIOR
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF A ALL MEMBER
SERVICE OUT OF THEM.
CLERK WILL CLOSER ALL.
TELL IS OF I CITY FOR NO.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM TO SEVENTEEN IS AB
SIXTEEN SIXTY EIGHT BY MISS
CARILLO CROCKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL SIXTEEN SIXTY
EIGHT BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER CARILLO
ANOTHER PERSON ACRYLATE A
RESOURCE CONSERVATION.
CARILLO YOU MAKE IT OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I AM VERY PROUD TO
PRESENT TO ASSEMBLY BILL SIXTEEN
SIXTY EIGHT A BILL THAT WILL
CREATE REAL EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITIES. FOR FORMALLY
INCARCERATED INDIVIDUALS BY
CREATING AN EDUCATION AND
EMPLOYMENT REENTRY PROGRAM TO BE
OVERSEEN BY THE CALIFORNIA
CONSERVATION CORPS.
AB SIXTEEN SIXTY EIGHT PROVIDE
HOPE AND OPPORTUNITIES FOR
FORMER INCARCERATED PEOPLE BY
OFFERING A TRUE PATHWAY TO A
LIVING WAGE JOB THAT MOVES OUR
STATE FORWARD ON CRITICAL
RESOURCE MANAGEMENT OBJECTIVES.
FORMALLY INCARCERATED
INDIVIDUALS OFTEN FACE THE
THEORIES OF SINCERE CHALLENGES
WHEN RE INTEGRATING BACK INTO
SOCIETY.
SUCH AS REDUCE TIES TO THEIR
FAMILIES AND COMMUNITIES AS WELL
AS LOWER LEVELS OF EDUCATION AND
LITERACY THAT SERVICES BURIALS.
FOR GAINFUL EMPLOYMENT POST
RELEASE.
THIS COMMUNITY GAINS EXPERIENCE
AND SKILLS ON HAND CREWS THAT
HAVE REAL EMPLOYMENT VALUE IN
CRITICAL AREAS OF RESOURCE
CONSERVATION AND MANAGEMENT FUEL
IN VEGETATION CONTROL AND THE
FASTER SUPPORT.
AB SIXTEEN SIXTY EIGHT WILL
ENSURE THAT FORMALLY
INCARCERATED PEOPLE CAN UTILIZE
THE SKILLS AND INSPIRATION THAT
THEY HAVE ATTAINED FOLLOWING A
COMPLETION OF THEIR SENTENCE.
OUR STATE IS IN NEED OF A
DYNAMIC WORK FORCE TO ENGAGE IN
CRITICAL AND COST EFFECTIVE
DEFENSES AGAINST NATURAL
DISASTERS.
THIS BILL -- CAME TO FRUITION
WITH OUR CALIFORNIA FORMALLY --
IN WELL OUR CALIFORNIA INMATE
FIREFIGHTER PROGRAM AS WE HAVE
SEEN MANY OF THESE --
FIREFIGHTERS FIGHT THE WHAT IS
NOW THE THE WHILE FIGHTER FIRES
ACROSS OUR STATE.
AND I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN
AYE VOTE.
THERE WAS CREEL MISSED FLORA.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
IN SUPPORT OF SIXTEEN SIXTY
EIGHT AND HAVING WORKED WITH A
LOT OF THE MEN THAT CAME THROUGH
THIS -- PARTICULAR PROGRAM IN
PROGRAMS LIKE THIS.
SOME OF THE BEST PEOPLE THAT
I'VE EVER HAD EXPERIENCE IN THE
PRIVILEGE OF WORKING WITH THE
CAL FIRE CAME THROUGH THIS MY
HIRING CAPTAIN.
CAME THROUGH THE SYSTEM ALELO
LOVELL WEST WAS HIS NAME AND I
TO THIS THERE I TO REALLY TRULY
APPRECIATE HIS STORY.
SO FOR COLLEAGUES AS WE TRAIN
OUR FIREFIGHTERS COMING UP
THROUGH THE DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS WORKING WITH THEM
THROUGH THESE PROGRAMS GETTING
THEM EMPLOYMENT A LOT OF TIMES
THESE FOLKS.
JUST SIMPLY NEED A HELPING HAND
THIS IS A GREAT PROGRAM TO GIVE
IT TO MY REQUEST I WILL.
THANK YOU MISTER FLORES SEEN NO
ADDITIONALDISCUSSION ON THE
ITEM THIS CREAMY CLOSE WE WISH.
THANK YOU -- AND I APPRECIATE MY
COMMENTS -- THE COMMENTS BY MY
COLLEAGUE IN SUPPORT THIS IS A
BILL THAT IN SUPPORT BY THE
CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS IT'S A GREAT
PATHWAY FOR IN MANY FIREFIGHTERS
SAID DO THIS INCREDIBLE.
WORK THAT IS NECESSARY FOR OUR
STATE AND WE AS A STATE IN
RETURN ARE ABLE TO PROVIDE A
PATHWAY FOR GOOD JOBS AND SO I
BELIEVE THIS IS A TOTALLY
AWESOME BILL AND I ENCOURAGE YOU
TO PRESS THE GREEN BUTTON.
THANK YOU FOR THAT TOTALLY
AWESOME PRESENTATION.
SEEING NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION
DEBATE.
OR ANYTHING -- TOOK OVER THE
ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS OF THE CEREMONY.
ALL MEMBERS FOR THE DESIGN OF A
ALL MEMBERS OTHERS OUT OF OUT
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE YOUR ROLL TIDE ABOUT ICE
FIFTY EIGHT NO.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES FILE
ITEM TO EIGHTEEN IS AB SIXTEEN
SEVENTY ONE CLERK WILL READ.
SO MY BILL SIXTEEN SEVENTY ONE
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN AN
ACCOLADE TRANSPORTATION.
MR BERMAN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES SB SIXTEEN SEVENTY
ONE WOULD ALLOW CALTRANS C. H.
B. AND STAKEHOLDER PARTNERS TO
CONTINUE ON ROAD TESTING.
OF TRUCK PLATOONING TECHNOLOGIES
WHICH ALLOWS TRUCKS TO SAFELY
FOLLOW EACH OTHER WITH WITH LESS
THAN ONE HUNDRED FEET OF
FOLLOWING DISTANCE BY SINKING
ACCELERATION AND BRAKING.
DOING SO WILL PROVIDE FOR
ADDITIONAL YEARS FOR CALTRANS TO
BUILD UPON THE BODY OF KNOWLEDGE
IT IS OBTAINED TO DATE.
AB SIXTEEN SEVENTY ONE CONTINUES
CALIFORNIANS TRADITION OF
LEADING AND INNOVATIVE
TECHNOLOGIES A FOCUS ON HUMAN
BENEFITS LIKE DRIVER SAFETY AND
REDUCING EMISSIONS IT'S A
TOTALLY RAD BILL I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
MEMBERS LET'S NOT GO DOWN THIS
ROAD.
SEEING NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION
ON THE AND CARPOOL OVER THERE
ALL.
ALL MEMBERS OTHERS ARE VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO
VOTE [inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT ICE.
FIFTY EIGHT NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES FALLEN TO NINETEEN IS AB
SIXTEEN EIGHTY CORPORATION.
SOME PEOPLE SIXTEEN EIGHTY BY
SOME REMEMBER THE MOMENT
ACRYLATE ACOSTA RESOURCES IS
LAMAR.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTEEN SIXTEEN
EIGHTY RESPONSE TO THE GOVERNOR
GOVERNOR BROWN'S CALL TO BRING
STAKEHOLDERS TO THE TABLE TO
DEVELOP A NEW COASTAL ACCESS
PROGRAM FOR THE PUBLIC OUT
HOLLISTER RANCH MY DISTRICT. FOR
OVER THIRTY SEVEN YEARS THE
PUBLIC HAS BEEN CUT OFF FROM
ENJOYING THE NATURAL TREASURES
OF OFFERED BY OUR CALIFORNIA
COASTLINE WHICH ARE OWNED BY THE
PUBLIC.
THE BILL REAFFIRMS OUR
CONSTITUTIONAL COMMITMENT TO THE
PUBLIC'S RIGHT TO ACCESS TO THE
BEACH IS A HOLLISTER RANCH.
AB SIXTEEN EIGHTY REQUIRES THE
CREATION OF A COMPREHENSIVE PLAN
THAT BUILDS ON THE FUNDAMENTAL
PRINCIPLE THE AXIS TO CALIFORNIA
BEACHES SHOULD BE AVAILABLE FOR
EVERYONE TO ENJOY REGARDLESS OF
THE ZIP CODE.
THE PLAN.
REQUIRES A WORKING GROUP GROUP
WHICH INCLUDES STATE AGENCIES
RANCH OWNERS AND OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MS THE MOM IS QUIRK
SILVA.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER A
MEMBERS MEMBERS I STAND IN
SUPPORT OF AB SIXTEEN EIGHTY AS
SOMEBODY WHO LIVED IN LAND NORTH
ORANGE COUNTY BUT ACCESS STORE
BEACH IS BY TAKING A BUS.
AND HAD THAT PRIVILEGE TO ENJOY
THE CALIFORNIA COAST ALL TOO
OFTEN UP AND DOWN THE COULD
STATE OF CALIFORNIA THERE ARE
SIGNS THERE ARE VERY YEARS THERE
ARE FENCES THAT KEEP OUR
CALIFORNIANS OUT OF OUR STATE
BEACHES.
AND EVEN THOUGH NOT LEGAL
SOMETIMES THE SIGNS.
ARE PUT UP I SAY NO ACCESS ON
PRIVATE PROPERTY.
AND MANY TIMES PEOPLE HAVE TO
FIGHT FOR OUR RIGHTS TO GET TO
OUR BEACHES AND ONE THING I CAN
TELL YOU ABOUT GROWING UP ON THE
COAST OF CALIFORNIA.
ALTHOUGH I HAD TO TAKE THE BUS
THERE FOR AN HOUR -- THAT IN
RICH MY LIFE AND I THINK THE
AUTHOR FOR THIS AND ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT FOR A BI.
SIXTEEN EIGHTY THANK YOU MISS
QUIRK SILVA SEE NO ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSION ON THE ITEM.
CLERK WILL.
YES MISS LIMóN.
CARPOOL OVER THERE ALL
[inaudible]
MEMBERS.
IS ADAMANT ON MEMBERS OF DESIRE
TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLICK WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT
ICE FIFTY NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES FILE ITEM.
TO TWENTY IS AB SIXTY EIGHTY
FOUR MR MAIENSCHEIN COVERAGE.
SOME PEOPLE SIXTEEN EIGHTY FOUR
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER MAIENSCHEIN
ACCOLADE PEOPLE INSTRUCTION.
MR MAIENSCHEIN THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I'M PLEASED
TO AUTHOR A. B. SIXTEEN EIGHTY
FOUR WITH THE SUPERINTENDENT OF
PUBLIC INSTRUCTION TONY THURMAN.
THE BILL CREATES AN ONGOING
PROGRAM FOR THE PURPOSE OF
ESTABLISHING A STATEWIDE
PROFESSIONAL LEARNING
INFRASTRUCTURE. TO SUPPORT
EDUCATORS IN TEACHING READING
AND LITERACY ACROSS GRADES AND
ACROSS CONTENT AREAS LITERACY IS
ABOUT MORE THAN JUST THE ABILITY
TO READ AND WRITE.
GOOD LITERACY EDUCATION CREATES
A FOUNDATION ENABLING OUR
STUDENTS TO GROW AND TO INFORM
CITIZENS BE SUCCESSFUL.
AND BE PRODUCTIVE MEMBERS OF
SOCIETY CONTRIBUTING TO THE
ECONOMIC BY.
TH<c.cyan> THE OF OUR STATE TODAY'S</c>
DIVERSE STUDENTS NEED TO BE
PREPARED FOR TOMORROW'S LITERACY
DEMANDS THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AND I ABOUT.
THANK WHICH MATIA.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON
THE ADAM.
CLARK LIBERAL.
ALL MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS ARE DESIRABLE
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLE AND TELEVOTE EYES.
FORTY FIVE KNOWS EIGHT THAT
MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM TO
TWENTY ONE IS AB SIXTEEN EIGHTY
EIGHT CORPORATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL SIXTEEN EIGHTY
EIGHT BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CALDERON ANOTHER'S AN ACCOLADE
RECIDIVISM MISTER CALDERON.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS LAST YEAR I PARTNER WITH
OUR PUBLIC SAFETY CHAIR TO
REQUEST.
THAT THE JOINT LEGISLATIVE AUDIT
COMMITTEE APPROVING AUDIT TO
EVALUATE THE EFFECTIVENESS OF
CDC OURS IN PRISON
REHABILITATIVE PROGRAMS.
AS A RESULT WE'VE INTRODUCED AB
SIXTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT TO WHICH
ENDEAVORS TO PURSUE THE ODDEST
RECOMMENDATIONS IN ORDER TO
ENSURE THAT CCAR'S
REHABILITATION PROGRAMS REDUCE
RECIDIVISM THIS BILL WILL
REQUIRE CITY SEE OUR TO
ESTABLISH PERFORMANCE TARGETS
PARTNER WITH EXTERNAL
RESEARCHERS AND IMPLEMENT A
COMPREHENSIVE THREE YEAR PLAN.
TO DEVELOP AND IMPLEMENT A
CORRECTIVE ACTION PLAN.
THIS BILL WILL RESULT IN A
THOROUGH EVALUATION OF THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF OUR
REHABILITATION PROGRAMS TO
ENSURE THAT THESE PROGRAMS IN
STATE PRISONS DO INDEED PROMOTE
REDUCTIONS AND SIT RECIDIVISM.
WE HELP THIS BILL WILL ENSURE
THAT PUBLIC FUNDS ARE BEING YOU
PROPERLY UTILIZED AND THE STATE
IS FULFILLING THE REHABILITATIVE
COMPONENT OF CORRECTION
EXPERIENCE OF RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER CALDERON.
SEEN NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE
ITEM.
LOCAL OF THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF RESERVE WELL.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WINNERS ARABLE.
CLICK WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT
A SIXTY FOUR NO.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES FILE
AND TO TWENTY TO PASS RETAIN.
WELL I'M TO TWENTY THREE A. B.
SIXTEEN NINETY SIX CORPORATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL SIXTEEN NINETY SIX
WEISS MEMBER CHAO ANOTHER SOME
ACCOLADE ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
MAKING A THEREFORE.
THEY SHOULD CHECK OUT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS AB SIXTEEN
NINETY SIX ESTABLISHES A PROCESS
INCLUDING TIMELINES FOR
SUBMITTING PROPOSALS TO GO
BUSINESS ON THE ESTABLISHMENT
EIGHT AND FOREIGN INVESTMENT
OFFICE.
CURRENT LAW PROVIDES SCHOOL BIZ
WITH THE AUTHORITY TO ESTABLISH
FOREIGN OFFICES AND ACTIONS TO
TAKE ONCE IT'S DETERMINATION HAS
BEEN MADE TO MOVE FORWARD.
HOWEVER EXISTING LAW IS SILENT
AS TO HOW ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
ENTITIES CAN PROPOSE THE
ESTABLISHMENT OF THE JOINTLY
ADMINISTERED FOREIGN TRADE
OFFICES.
GOBIZ HOUSE NOTED THAT THEY ARE
FLEXIBLE IN HOW PROPOSALS CAN BE
BROUGHT FORWARD.
YET STAKEHOLDER GROUPS HAVE
EXPRESSED CONFUSION AND THAT
MORE FIND A FORMALIZED STRUCTURE
WOULD BE HELPFUL WITHOUT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THE THING IS CHALLENGE.
THE COMMISSION SHALL SEE NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CLARK LIBERAL ON MEMBER SERVERS
ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OTHERS OUT OF CLERK
WELL.
CLOSER ROLE TALLY BUT I SIXTY
ONE NO.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
WELL I DON'T TO TWENTY FOUR AB
SEVENTEEN OH TWO QUICK READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTEEN OH TWO
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER THREE OF US
AUSTIN ACRYLATE HOMELESSNESS.
THIS RIVAS THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER -- AB SEVENTY NO TWO
WILL PROVIDE ADDITIONAL STAFFING
COORDINATING AND FINANCING
COUNCIL AND ADDS NEW REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS TO THE COUNCIL.
IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN SB THIRTEEN
EIGHTY AUTHORED BY SENATOR HOLLY
MITCHELL CREATED THE COUNCIL TO
OVERSEE THE IMPLEMENTATION.
OF HOUSING FIRST GUIDELINES AND
TO IDENTIFY AND COORDINATE STATE
RESOURCES AND SERVICES TO
PREVENT AND END HOMELESSNESS IN
CALIFORNIA.
AB SEVENTY NO TWO TAKES THREE
EXISTING PART TIME POSITIONS AT
THE COUNCIL AND MAKES THOSE FULL
TIME POSITIONS AND ADDS AN
ADDITIONAL THREE POSITIONS TO
THE COUNCIL. FOR A TOTAL OF SIX
NEW POSITIONS TO IMPLEMENT IT'S
LEGISLATIVE LEE.
MANDATED DUTIES TO COMBAT
HOMELESSNESS THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MS RIVAS.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION ON THE ITEM.
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
REVERSAL SARAH VOTE ON MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL CLOSER ALL TRIED
ABOUT AYE SIXTY NO.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES FALLON
TO TWENTY FIVE HAS RETAINED FELL
INTO TWENTY SIX AB.
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN BY MR LEVINE.
MR LEVINE CARPOOL RATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER LEVINE AND
OTHERS AN ACCOLADE THE STATE
PARKS THE SHOW OF A THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS YOU'VE BEEN WITH ME ON
THIS JOURNEY I ASK YOU TO COME
WITH ME ONCE AGAIN.
TO OUR STATE PARKS AND BEACHES
BUT THIS TIME WHERE CHILDREN ARE
NOT PICKING THROUGH CIGARETTE
**** AS THEY'RE MAKING
SANDCASTLES.
WHERE WE'RE NOT DEALING WITH THE
TOXINS IN OUR WATERSHED CENTER
ECOSYSTEM IN OUR STATE PARKS OR
WE SHOULD ALL BE ENJOYING THE
NATURAL BEAUTY AND THE
ENVIRONMENT THAT CALIFORNIA HAS
TO OFFER FOR ALL OF US?
THANK YOU MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MITCHELL BEING SAY NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
REGARDING MR LEVIN'S CHURNING
[inaudible]
CLARK.
SEE NO DISCUSSION OF A COUPLE OF
THEIR ALL.
ALL MEMBERS OF IT IS OUR ABOUT
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A ALL
MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT AYE AYES.
FORTY EIGHT KNOWS FOURTEEN THAT
MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEMS.
TO TWENTY SEVENTEEN TO TWENTY
EIGHT PASS RETAIN FILE ITEM TO
TWENTY NINE AB SEVENTEEN THIRTY
SIX BY MR DAILY [inaudible]
CRACKLE RATE.
SOME PEOPLE SEVENTEEN THIRTY SIX
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER DALY AN
ACCOLADE THE PUBLIC CONTRACTS.
MR DAILY.
YOU MAY OPEN THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER.
THIS BILL REQUIRES.
LOCAL AGENCIES TO ADOPT AND
MAINTAIN A POLICY FOR NOTIFYING
BIDDERS OF AN AWARD OF PUBLIC
CONTRACTS.
PROMPT AND TRANSPARENT
NOTIFICATION ALLOWS ALL BIDDERS
TO EFFICIENTLY ALLOCATE THEIR
TIME AND RESOURCES.
HANDLE EXPAND THE POOL OF
COMPETITIVE BITTERS AVAILABLE
FOR OTHER PUBLIC WORKS PROJECTS
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS DALY CITY NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE BILL.
CLICK LIBERAL [inaudible]
MEMBERS. TO DISCERN BUT ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE?
CLICK WELL CLOSER ROLE.
TELL US ABOUT.
I SIXTY FIVE NO ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES FILE I'M TWO
THIRTY IS AB SEVENTEEN FIFTY ONE
QUICK READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTEEN FIFTY
ONE BY SIMPLY MEMBER DAVID CHIU
AN ACCOLADE THE PUBLIC UTILITIES
THE CHURCHILL.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
COLLEAGUES IN PARTS OF
CALIFORNIA THERE ARE SMALL WATER
SYSTEMS I CAN'T AFFORD TO
ADDRESS DEFERRED MAINTENANCE OR
HAVE CONTAMINATED DRINKING WATER.
THAT COULD CONSOLIDATE WITH
NEARBY WATER SYSTEMS THAT ARE
LARGER.
UNFORTUNATELY THE APPROVAL
PROCESS FOR THE CONSOLIDATION
WATER SYSTEMS HAPPEN TIME
CONSUMING -- IN SOME CASES STATE
APPROVAL TAKEN AS LONG AS
SIXTEEN MONTHS WE ALL KNOW THAT
THE LONGER REVIEW TAKES THE
LONGER CALIFORNIANS ARE LEFT
WITH UNDRINKABLE WATER OR
SYSTEMS IN DISREPAIR.
THIS BILL WOULD IMPOSE FLEXIBLE
DEADLINES ON THE CPC FOR
CONSOLIDATION APPROVAL AND
ENSURE THE CPC HELP IMPLEMENT OR
STATES POLICY TO PROVIDE
DRINKING WATER -- THAT IS CLEAN
AND SAFE FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS
WITH THAT RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHIU.
SEE NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE
ITEM CLICK LIBERAL [inaudible]
WELL.
SARAH VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE.
IN A MEMBER SERVICE ARE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLICK WELL.
CLOSE ROLE TELL ME ABOUT I SIXTY
SIX NO ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES
FILE ITEMS.
TO THIRTY ONE THROUGH TWO THIRTY
THREE PASS RETAIN FILE ITEM.
TO THIRTY FOUR AB SEVENTEEN
SIXTY SEVEN COVERAGE.
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTY SIXTY
SEVEN BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER ROMMEL'S
ANOTHER'S AN ACCOLADE OF PEOPLE
HEALTH MYSTERONS.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER THIS
BILL EXPANDS A SUICIDE
PREVENTION POLICIES THIS SCHOOL
DISTRICTS DEVELOP FOR GRADES.
SEVEN THROUGH TWELVE TO INCLUDE
A POLICY ON THE YOUTH SUICIDE
PREVENTION FOR GRADES ONE
THROUGH.
SIX THE LEGISLATURE HAS WORKED
HARD TO MAKE SIGNIFICANT STRIDES
ON KEEPING KIDS SAFE FROM
BULLYING AND HARASSMENT IN AND
OUT OF THE CLASSROOM.
BULLYING CAN LEAD TO DEPRESSION
IN SOME CASES SELF HARM BY
SUICIDE.
IN MY DISTRICT.
WE SEE IN A SERIES OF SIR --
SUICIDES TAKE PLACE AS EARLY AS
A PERSON IN THE SIXTH GRADE.
SUICIDES IN ALL PARTS OF OUR
SOCIETY AND ALL AGE RANGES IS AN
EPIDEMIC AND WHILE THE ISSUE OF
ADOLESCENT SUICIDE.
HAS RECEIVED FOCUS IN RESOURCES
IN RECENT YEARS RATES OF YOUTH
SELF HARM AND SUICIDE HAVE
TRAGICALLY INCREASED.
WHILE OTHER RESOURCES -- SCHOOL
DISTRICTS PROVIDE ARE EXPENSIVE
TO MOST AGE RANGES SUICIDE
PREVENTION POLICIES ARE GREAT
EXCLUSIVE.
ONLY TARGETING THAT GRADES SEVEN
THROUGH TWELVE THESE GREAT
EXCLUSIVE POLICIES CAN
TRAGICALLY LEAVE BEHIND STUDENTS
WHO ARE ALSO AT RISK IN A YOUNG
AGE.
WE UNDERSTAND THAT THESE ISSUES
ARE SENSITIVE THAT'S WHY THIS
BILL WILL ENSURE THAT THESE
POLICIES ARE SPECIFICALLY
CREATED TO BE AGE APPROPRIATE.
AB SEVENTEEN SIXTY SEVEN SEEKS
TO BUILD ON THE WORK OF LOCAL
EDUCATION AGENCIES BY EXPANDING
SUICIDE PREVENTION POLICIES TO
BEGIN TO ADDRESS.
ADDRESS YOUTH SUICIDE DOING SO
WILL FOCUS LOCAL EDUCATION
AGENCIES ATTENTION ON ADDRESSING
THE RISK OF YOUTH SUICIDE EARLY
ON PREVENTING.
FUTURE.
USE SUICIDES.
I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MR RAMA'S SEEING NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO
VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
IT IS OUT OF CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ROLE TALLY THE VOTE I
SIXTY THREE NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
THERE WAS WITHOUT OBJECTION ALL
MORNING MOVE BACK IN THE FILE
THE FILE ITEM. TWO TWENTY EIGHT
WE'RE GOING TO TAKE UP FILE I'M.
TO TWENTY EIGHT AB SEVENTEEN
THIRTY ONE CLICK WITH.
SOME LEGAL SEVENTEEN THIRTY ONE
BY SOME REMEMBER FOR HORROR
MATHEMATICALLY THE BUSINESS.
IS BOERNER HORVATH YES THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES WE
ALL KNOW TOO WELL THAT WE'RE IN
THE MIDST OF A HOUSING CRISIS.
WE TALK ALL THE TIME ABOUT
INCREASING SUPPLY BUT WE SPEND
VERY LITTLE TIME ADDRESSING THE
REMOVAL SUPPLY FROM THE HOUSING
MARKET.
WHERE THIS HAPPENS MOST OFTEN AS
WELL WHEN HOMES INTENDED FOR
FAMILIES AND SENIORS AND
VETERANS AND WORKING FAMILIES?
ARE REMOVED OFTEN PERMANENTLY
FROM THE HOUSING STOCK FOR FULL
TIME SHORT TERM VACATION RENTALS.
ALL CITIES IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA CAN REGULATE.
OR BAN SHORT TERM VACATION
RENTALS AS THEY SEE FIT.
THIS IS NOT TRUE BECAUSE OF THEM.
THE COASTAL COMMISSION REQUIRES
OUR CITIES TO HAVE SHORT TERM
VACATION RENTALS BECAUSE THEY
HAVE ONLY PURVIEW OVER ACCESS TO
THE COAST.
WITH NO AUTHORITY TO BOUNCE THAT
WITH IMPACT OF REMOVAL OF
HOUSING FROM THE HOUSING STOCK
IN THE CITY'S.
SAN DIEGO COUNTY IS ONE OF THE
BEST RATIOS FOR LOWER COST
COASTAL COMBINATIONS PER CAPITA
IN THE STATE.
BUT ON TOP OF THAT WE HAVE
APPROXIMATELY ELEVEN THOUSAND
SHORT TERM VACATION RENTALS MOST
OF WHICH ARE FULL TIME.
WHEN WE'RE ADEQUATE PROVIDING
ACCESS TO THE COAST WHY WOULD WE
EVER CREATE A SYSTEM THAT ALLOWS
FOR THE FIGURES HAVE DEMOLITION
OF HOUSING FROM HOUSING STOCK?
AB SEVENTEEN THIRTY ONE SIX
ADDRESS THIS ISSUE IN A VERY
NUANCED WAY.
BRANDISHING A PILOT PROGRAM FOR
FIVE YEARS AND SAN DIEGO
COUNTIES COASTAL ZONE.
REGULATING SHORT TERM VACATION
RENTAL PLATFORMS.
I WANT TO BE CLEAR ABOUT WHAT AB
SEVENTEEN THIRTY ONE DOES AND
DOES NOT DO.
AB SEVENTEEN THIRTY ONE SAYS
WHEN THE PRIMARY RESIDENT IS NOT
ON SITE THE SHORT TERM VACATION
RENTAL PLATFORM MAY BOOK A UNIT
IN THE SAN DIEGO COUNTY COASTAL
ZONE. FOR UP TO THIRTY DAYS THAT
MEANS OF A PROPERTY OWNER OWNS
OWNER PLATFORM HOPS THEY MAY USE
PLATFORMS FOR UP TO NINETY DAYS.
BASED ON THE CHROME CURRENT
NUMBER PLATFORMS THE MARKET --
THIS THAT'S AN ENTIRE STE HER
SUMMER FOR US IN VIDEO COUNTY OR
ALMOST EVERY WEEKEND OF THE
ENTIRE YEAR.
AB SEVENTEEN THIRTY ONE ALSO
IMPORTANTLY REQUIRES THAT SHORT
TERM VACATION WITH THE PLATFORMS.
COLLECTED RETURN TRANSIT
OCCUPANCY TAX TO THE LOCAL
CITIES WHICH IS KEY FOR CITIES
TO PAY FOR VISITORS SERVING
SERVICES -- BUT TOURISTS USE AS
WELL AS GIVING NECESSARY
TRANSPARENCY FOR ENSURING WHERE
SHORT TERM VACATION RENTALS ARE
OPERATING THEY ARE SAFE AND
RESPONSIBLE.
AB SEVENTEEN THIRTY ONE I WANNA
BE CLEAR ABOUT WHAT IT DOESN'T
DOESN'T DO AB SEVENTEEN THIRTY
ONE DOES PRESERVE LOCAL CONTROL
BY REGULATING THE PLATFORMS AND
NOT THE CITIES.
AS WELL AS IMPORTANTLY GIVING
THEM A TOOL TO ZONE AREAS
RESIDENTIAL TOURISM WHERE THEY
INTEND FOR SHORT TERM VACATION
RENTALS. TO BE EXCLUDED FROM-ABOUT.
PRESERVES COASTAL ACCESS THROUGH
RUNNING PILOT PROGRAM IN THE
COUNTY THAT IS THE MOST LOW COST
COAST ACCOMMODATIONS IN THE
STATE.
AS WELL AS THE BASS PER CAPITA
RATIO.
ALSO THOSE PRIMARY RESIDENCE OR
ONSITE REMAIN UNREGULATED BY
THIS BILL AS WELL AS UP TO
NINETY DAYS ON EXISTING PUT THE
PLATFORMS.
THAT IS A LOT OF COASTAL ACCESS
THAT IS NOT REMOVING HOUSING
FROM OUR HOUSING STOCK AND
RESTORING ACCOMMODATIONS FOR
FAMILIES TEACHERS FIREFIGHTERS
ARE WORKING FAMILIES.
PRISONERS PROPERTY RIGHTS BY NOT
REGULATING PROPERTY OWNERS
EVERYTHING HOMEOWNERS DID BEFORE
SHORT TERM VACATION RENTAL
PLATFORMS.
THEY CAN STILL DO FOR THE LOCAL
ORDINANCES THEY CAN READ TO
FAMILY OR FRIENDS THEY CAN PUT
UP A WEBSITE THEY COULD PUT A
SIGN IN FRONT OF THEIR HOUSE.
IT JUST CAPS THE UNINTENDED
IMPACT -- SHORT TERM VACATION
RENTAL PLATFORMS TO FURTHER
DISTORT OUR HOUSING MARKET.
AB SEVENTEEN THIRTY ONE DOES NOT
DO MANY THINGS IT DOES NOT BAN
SHORT TERM VACATION RENTALS IT
DOES NOT APPLY TO AREAS OUTSIDE
OF SAN DIEGO COUNTY'S COASTAL
THOUGH.
IT DOES NOT BAN ACCESS TO THE
COAST OR PREVENT YOUR
CONSTITUENTS FROM VISITING SAN
DIEGO WE WOULD LOVE TO HAVE YOU.
COLLEAGUES I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE TODAY ON
SEVENTEEN THIRTY ONE THANK YOU
MISS BURKHALTER.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON
THE ITEM.
THE CLUB THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS OF DESIRE TO VOTE
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE ABOUT
.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A
ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A TAKES.
FORTY ONE KIRK WELL CLOSE ROLL
TIDE ABOUT AYE AYES [inaudible]
FORTY TWO NO.
SIXTEEN THAT MEASURE PASSES.
BACK IN REGULAR FILE ORDER.
THIS IS FILE ITEM TO THIRTY FIVE
A. B. SEVENTEEN SEVENTY MISTER
FRAZIER CLERK WILL READ.
SOME PEOPLE SEVENTEEN SEVENTY BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRAZIER ACCOLADES
ARE RECYCLING.
MR FRAZIER EMAIL.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
MY BILL TODAY'S VERY STRAIGHT
FORWARD.
IN TWENTY THIRTEEN MY BILL AB
FIVE THIRTEEN DIRECTED CALORIE
CYCLE TO CREATE A PROGRAM WHICH
ALLOWED AWARDS GRANTS TO CITIES
COUNTIES SPECIAL DISTRICTS AND
PARKS FOR FUNDING PUBLIC WORKS
PART PROJECTS WOULD.
UTILIZE WASTE TIRES INCLUDING
THE USE OF RUBBERIZED ASPHALT
CONCRETE AB SEVENTEEN SEVENTY X.
AS A VERY SUCCESSFUL.
PROGRAM TO TWENTY TWENTY FOUR
BILLS HAD NO OPPOSITION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANKS FRAZIER SEEN NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
CLICK WELL CLOSE ROLE TELEVOTE
EYES.
FIFTY NINE NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
WE ARE GOING TO TAKE UP FILE I'M
TWO THIRTY SIX A. B. SEVENTEEN
SEVENTY FOUR BY MISTER BONTA
CORKERY.
SO MIDDLE SEVENTEEN SEVENTY FOUR
BY SOME MEMBER BAHNSEN ACCOLADES
SOON FINANCIALLY DECLARE THE
YEARS WHO HELPS EXPECT ME TO BE.
MR BONTA.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES AB SEVENTEEN
SEVENTIES FOR WOULD AUTHORIZE
THE CALIFORNIA STUDENT AID
COMMISSION TO EXTEND FINANCIAL
AID APPLICATION DEADLINES. FOR
STUDENTS DUE TO NATURAL
DISASTERS OR EMERGENCIES THE
BILL HAS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND
NO OPPOSITION I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER MONTESINOS
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
TAKES FIFTY FOR ALL MEMBERS VOTE
DESIRE TO VOTE [inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT AYE SIXTY
THREE KNOWS HERE ON THE URGENCY
AYE AYES SIXTY THREE KNOWS
YOU'RE ON THE MEASURE.
THAT BILL PASSES.
FILE ITEM TO THIRTY SEVEN PASS
RETAIN FILE ITEM.
TWO THIRTY EIGHT IS AB
[inaudible]
EIGHTEEN OH ONE CORRECT.
SOME AGO EIGHTEEN A ONE BY THE
COMMITTEE ON AGRICULTURE
ACCOLADE ATELYN MAKING AN
APPROPRIATION ARE.
FOR DOCTOR EGGMAN YOU MAY OPEN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS -- THIS IS
THE COMMITTEE AGRICULTURAL BUILT
RELATING TO CATTLE AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU DOT PREGNANCY NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE [inaudible]
CLARK LIBERAL.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
PARK WELL [inaudible]
CLOSER ALL.
CHAU VOTE I SIXTY TWO NO ZERO
THAT MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM TO
THIRTY NINE AB.
EIGHTEEN OH NINE SOME PEOPLE
EIGHTEEN OH NINE BY THE
COMMITTEE ON JOBS ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT AND THE ECONOMY.
AN ACT RELATING TO A DISABLED
VETERAN BUSINESS ENTERPRISES.
MR MANTAS THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS AB EIGHTEEN OH
NINE IS A COMMITTEE BILL THAT
IMPLEMENTS CHANGES TO THE STATE
PROCUREMENT PROGRAM THAT ARE
INTENDED TO SUPPORT DISABLED
VETERAN BUSINESS OWNERS
PARTICIPATING IN STATE CONTRACTS.
THIS BILL HAS ENJOYED BROAD
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT I THROUGHOUT
THE PROCESS AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AYE VOTE.
THE RESTAURANT IS SAYING NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CLICK LIBERAL.
ALL MEMBER SERVICE OUT OF THOSE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO THE
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE [inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE YOUR ROLL TIDE ABOUT AYE
SIXTY EIGHT NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES FILE ITEMS TO FOURTEEN TO
FORTY ONE PASS AND RETAIN AS
WELL AS TWO FORTY TWO THAT
BRINGS US TO FILE ITEM TO FORTY
THREE A. B. H..
BY MR KANSEN CHU CORPORATION.
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHT BY SOME
MEMBER KANSEN CHU ANOTHER'S AND
I PLAYED A PEOPLE HEALTH
[inaudible]
MR CHILL.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER SAM
MEMBER I'M BY HERE PRESENTING AB.
EIGHT WHICH IS A BILL AIM TO
PLACE ONE OR MORE MENTAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS ALL K. TO TWELVE
SCHOOL CAMPUSES.
ESTABLISH A RATIO OF ONE MENTAL
HEALTH PROFESSIONALS.
PER EVERY SIX HUNDRED STUDENTS
WHILE GIVEN SMALLER SCHOOL
FLEXIBILITY TO FULFILL THE
REQUIREMENTS.
AB A REQUIRED.
MONTES TO DIRECT ONGOING
PREVENTION AND EARLY.
INTERVENTION MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES ACT FUNDING FOR SCHOOLS
TO REACH TO THESE REQUIREMENTS.
THE TWENTY SEVENTEEN ALL THOSE
SHOWS THE VOLUME OF UNSPENT
FUNDS IN THE ACCOUNT AND THE
TIME.
IS NOW TO INVESTORS FUNDS INTO
OUR CHILDREN WHO ARE
EXPERIENCING A MENTAL HEALTH
CRISIS.
IN CALIFORNIA OVER THREE HUNDRED
THOUSAND CHILDREN'S.
HEARING AGE FOR AN ELEVEN HOUSE
MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS CALIFORNIA
RANK CLOSE TO THE LAST IN EVERY
SCHOOL SUPPORT STAFF CATEGORY
WHICH OFTEN MEANS CHILDREN NEVER
REACH SERVICES AT ALL.
IN FACT OVER 70% OF CHILDREN
WITH MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS NEVER
RECEIVE TREATMENT.
AND THIS NUMBER JUMPED UP 280%
OR HIGHER FOR CHILDREN IN
POVERTY.
AND DOES THE PARENTS HAVE A
LANGUAGE BERIA.
AB A WILL PROVIDE A BASELINE
REQUIREMENTS FOR MENTAL HEALTH
SUPPORT.
IN SCHOOLS FOR CHILDREN AND USE
ACROSS OUR STATE.
I'LL HAVE I HAVE WORKED WITH HIS
STAKEHOLDERS AND MAKE A MADMAN'S
THAT WERE ADOPTED IN THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE TO
ADDRESS OPPOSITION CONCERN.
THE RESEARCH SHOWS THAT MANY
CHILDREN HAVE A MAD THE MENTAL
HEALTH NEEDS.
AND WHEN DATE REACH OUT FOR HELP.
THERE ARE NOT SUFFICIENT SUPPORT
SERVICES AT ALL WE MUST DO THE
RIGHT THING.
BY TO PROVIDE OUR CHILDREN AND
MAKE SURE THEY HAVE MENTAL
HEALTH SUPPORT.
ON THEIR CAMPUSES IT IS -- CHRIS
CRITICAL INVESTMENT FOR OUR NEXT
GENERATIONS OF LEADERS AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS CHIU MISTER
MURATSUCHI.
YOUR RECORD THANK YOU VERY MUCH
QUESTION FOR THE WELL FIRST OF A
STATEMENT I FULLY SUPPORT.
TO THE THE THE NEED FOR MORE
MENTAL HEALTH COUNSELORS ARE AT
OUR K. THROUGH TWELVE SCHOOLS
BUT MY CONCERN IS FUNDING -- SO
QUESTION FOR THE AUTHOR -- IS IF
I DON'T ACTION.
IS A FUNNY GOING TO COME FROM
PROPOSITION.
NINETY EIGHT NO DOES -- IS TO
SEPARATE FUNDING SOURCES PART OF
KNOWN FROM GENERAL FUND AND
PROBLEMS THEM FROM PROPOSITION.
SIXTY THREE THAT'S WHY WE
REQUIRE A FIFTY FOUR VOTE.
BUT IS NOT TOUCHING THE DID
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT MONEY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHIU.
THAT CLARIFICATION SEE NO
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OF BASED
ON THE ITEM.
CARPOOL OF THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBER SERVICE OUR TO VOTE
THIS TAKES FIFTY FOR ALL MEMBERS
VOTE -- DESIRE TO VOTE THIS IS A
FIFTY FOUR VOEPEL
.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
MR CHIU MOVES A CALL.
SPEAKING OF CALLS I AM PREPARED
TO LET THE CALL ON MS RUBIO'S
MEASURE.
FILE ITEM TO A SEVEN A. B..
FIFTEEN NINETY MS RUBIO CARGO
POSTS [inaudible]
FEDERATION OF ALL MEMBERS WOULD
WISH TO VOTE [inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE BUT I FIFTY
THREE KNOWS TO THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
BACK IN FILE ORDER FILE ITEM TO
FORTY FOUR IS AB FIFTEEN BY
MISTER NAZARIAN CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL FIFTEEN BY SIMPLY
MEMBERS THERE AND ANOTHER SMACK
RELATED STUDENT FINANCIAL AID
MAKING AN APPROPRIATION OF FOUR
MR IS AREA.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AB
FIFTEEN WOULD CREATE A STATEWIDE
CHILD SAVINGS ACCOUNT PROGRAM BY
TASKING THE SCHOLARS SURE
INVESTMENT BOARD TO OPERATE A
MASTER FIVE TWENTY NINE ACCOUNT
OWNED BY THE STATE.
THE PROGRAM WILL ALLOW PRIVATE
PHILANTHROPY TO CONTRIBUTE TO
THE FUND AND ENCOURAGE
ADDITIONAL INCENTIVES FOR LOW
INCOME FAMILIES STUDENTS WILL BE
ABLE TO USE MONEY FROM THE
ACCOUNT FOR A NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT.
HIGHER EDUCATIONAL PURPOSES SUCH
AS TUITION AT A COLLEGE
UNIVERSITY TRADE SCHOOL OR
GRADUATE PROGRAM ROOM AND BOARD
BOOKS COMPUTERS AND OTHER
RELATED QUALIFIED EXPENSES.
AB FIFTEEN ULTIMATELY
JUMPSTART'S COLLEGE SAVINGS FOR
FOR HALF A MILLION CHILDREN EACH
YEAR.
GIVES CHILDREN A REAL WORLD TOOL
TO PRACTICE FINANCIAL LITERACY.
AND ENABLE STUDENTS TO RAISE
THEIR OWN EDUCATIONAL
EXPECTATIONS.
THIS BILL HAS RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT.
AND THE ALSO HAS RECEIVED THE
GOVERNOR'S.
SUPPORT A FIFTY MILLION OF
INVESTMENT IN THE CHILDREN
SAVINGS ACCOUNT IN THE BUDGET.
SO I AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER IS VERY MISTER
MCCARTY.
THANK YOU MATT MISTER SPEAKER
JUST WANT TO CONFIRM THAT THIS
IS A PRIORITY ON OUR BUDGET THAT
WE ARE DEBATING A TWO YEARS AGO
THIS HOUSE PUT THREE MILLION
DOLLARS TO LAUNCH.
EVERY KID COUNT STARTER ACCOUNTS
FOR COLLEGE SAVINGS WE KNOW THE
RESEARCH SAYS IF YOU HAVE AN
ACCOUNT IN YOUR NAME TO GO TO
COLLEGE WHETHER IT'S FIVE
HUNDRED DOLLARS FOR FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS.
YOU'RE JUST AS EQUALLY LIKELY TO
EXPAND YOUR ODDS OF GOING TO
COLLEGE BY ABOUT. EIGHT TO ONE
SO THIS IS A GOOD INVESTMENT TO
MAKE SURE OUR KIDS ARE PREPARED
TO ENTER -- HIGHER EDUCATION
SYSTEM IN CALIFORNIA AND ASK
YOUR EITHER THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER MCCARTY SEE NO
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION ON THE
ITEM.
QUIRK LIBERAL.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLICK WELL CLOSER ALL TIED ABOUT
I FIFTY ARMY AYE AYES.
SIXTY NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES FILE AND TWO FORTY FIVE
HOUSE RETAIN.
FILE ITEM.
TO FORTY SIX AB.
THIRTY TWO MR BONTA CLERK READ.
SOME PEOPLE THIRTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BONTA ANOTHER'S
AN ACCOLADE A PRESENCE MR BONTA.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER THANK
YOU COLLEAGUES A. B. THIRTY TWO
PROHIBITS THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATION FROM RENEWING OR
ENTERING INTO A CONTRACT WITH A
FOR PROFIT PRIVATE PRISON.
FACILITY BEGINNING ON JANUARY
ONE TWENTY TWENTY AND WILL
COMPLETELY PHASE OUT THEIR USE
BY. TWENTY TWENTY EIGHT AS A FOR
PROFIT CORPORATION THESE
COMPANIES HAVE A FIDUCIARY DUTY
TO MAXIMIZE THEIR PROFITS TO
THEIR SHAREHOLDERS THIS DUTY IS
IN CONFLICT WITH THE INVESTMENT.
IN REHABILITATION OF PEOPLE AND
THE REDUCTION OF RECIDIVISM
RATES CONTRACTING WITH FOR
PROFIT PRIVATE PRISONS PRISONS
WAS A TEMPORARY SOLUTION TO
ADDRESS THE SEVERE PROBLEM OF
INMATE OVERCROWDING. TO COMPLY
WITH A FEDERAL COURT ORDER TO
REDUCE THE PRISON POPULATION AND
TO AVOID THE EARLY RELEASE OF
INMATES.
ON FEBRUARY TEN TWENTY FOURTEEN
THE COURT ALSO ARE ORDERED THE
STATE TO SEEK WAYS TO REDUCE THE
NUMBER OF INMATES HOUSED IN OUT
OF STATE PRISONS TO THE EXTENT
FEASIBLE AS A RESULT OF VOTER
INITIATIVES LIKE PROP FORTY
SEVEN AND PROP.
FIFTY SEVEN THERE HAS BEEN A
DECLINE AN INMATE POPULATION
THAT NOW ALLOWS ROOM FOR THE
TRANSFER OF INMATES FROM PRIVATE
TO PUBLIC FACILITIES.
IN ACCORDANCE WITH THE COURT
ORDER LAST YEAR CDC ARE WAS ABLE
TO REMOVE ALL CALIFORNIA INMATES
HOUSE IN A FOR PROFIT PRIVATE
PRISON IN MISSISSIPPI AND IS ON
TRACK TO HAVE ALL INMATES
REMOVED FROM THE ARIZONA PRIVATE
FACILITY.
THIS JUNE SINCE JANUARY TWENTY
THIRTEEN CALIFORNIA'S INMATE
POPULATION HAS BEEN BELOW THE
COURT ORDERED POPULATION CAP AND
SINCE WE ARE SEEN A DOWNWARD
TREND DUE TO PROP FIFTY SEVEN
AND OTHER MEASURES.
IT'S TIME FOR CALIFORNIA TO
ESTABLISH A SENSIBLE TIME LINE
TO PHASE OUT.
THE USE OF FOR PROFIT PRIVATE
PRISONS ALTOGETHER SB THIRTY TWO
WILL BEGIN TO REDIRECT OUR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM TO
INVEST IN AND PRIORITIZE
EFFECTIVE REHABILITATIVE
PROGRAMS WHICH WILL MINIMIZE.
RECIDIVISM RATES AND MAXIMIZE
SUCCESS FOR INMATES UPON THE RE
ENTRY INTO SOCIETY THANK YOU
COLLEAGUES I RESPECTFULLY ASK
THE AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER BARTON SEE NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE [inaudible]
CORPS CORPORAL [inaudible]
MEMBERS OF THE START OF A ALL
MEMBER SERVICE ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE ABOUT
[inaudible]
CLICK WELL.
CLOSER ROTELLA VOTE AYE AYES
FORTY NINE KNOWS.
ELEVEN THAT MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM TO FORTY SEVEN IS AB
THIRTY EIGHT DOCTOR WOULD
CORPORATION.
SOME PEOPLE THIRTY EIGHT BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD NOT RELATE
TO FIRE SAFETY.
DOCTOR WHAT THANK MISTER SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS IN OCTOBER TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN THE TUBS FIRE
STARTING CALISTO GOOD IN UNDER
FOUR HOURS SWEPT TWELVE MILES TO
CINEMA COUNTY IN INTO THE CITY
OF SANTA ROSA.
THE TIME WE FELT AS THOUGH WE
HAD JUST EXPERIENCE A ONCE IN A
LIFETIME TRAGEDY.
SINCE THEN THE THOMAS WOLSEY CAR
IN CAMPFIRES HAVE SADLY PROVEN
US WRONG.
IN ORDER TO ADDRESS THIS
CRITICAL PROBLEM MAYBE THIRTY
EIGHT PROPOSES A TWO PRONGED
APPROACH FIRST WE'RE PROPOSING A
REBATE OR A LOW ORDER WITH NO OR
LOW INTEREST RATE LOOK REVOLVING
LOAN FUND TO HELP PROVIDE MUCH
NEEDED RESOURCES TO HOMEOWNERS
TO RETROFIT.
THEIR PREVIOUSLY CONSTRUCTED
HOMES -- IN IN A HIGH IN VERY
HIGH FIRE HAZARD SEVERITY ZONES
SECOND WE'RE WORKING WITH THE
FIRE SCIENTISTS AND BUILDING
UPON MS FRIEDMAN'S -- AB TWENTY
NINE ELEVEN FROM LAST YEAR THE
TASK THE STATE FIRE MARSHAL WITH
IDENTIFYING LOW COST READ
RETROFITS.
MEMBERS THIS IS NOT A SILVER
BULLET TAKEN AS GENERATIONS TO
GET INTO THIS SITUATION WAS TAKE
US YEARS TO GET OUT OF IT.
BUT I BELIEVE A P. THIRTY EIGHT
WAS THIS IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU DOCTOR WITH SAYING NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE ITEM --
CLUB THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS OF WHO IS OUT OF THE
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A ALL
MEMBERS OF A RESERVE VOTE.
CLICK WELL CLOSER ALL TELL YOU
ABOUT AYE AYES FIFTY ONE KNOWS.
TOO THAT MEASURE PASSES FILE IN
TWO FORTY EIGHT IS AB.
FORTY THREE HI MISTER GLORIA.
CLERK WILL READ.
THE BILL FORTY THREE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GLORIA AND ACT
LIKE A MENTAL HEALTH.
MR GLORIA THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER THIS BILL PROVIDES
GREATER TRANSPARENCY ON HOW
PROPOSITION SIXTY THREE MENTAL
HEALTH DOLLARS ARE SPENT AS WELL
AS OTHER BEHAVIORAL HEALTH FUNDS.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS GLORIA SEE NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE ON
MEMBERS OF THE SAXOPHONE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
THIS TAKES FIFTY FOUR CLOSE THE
ROLE.
TALLY THE VOTE I SIXTY THREE NO
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES ALLEN
TO FORTY NINE IS AB FORTY SEVEN
CORKERY.
SOME PEOPLE FORTY SEVEN BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER DALY AN ACCOLADE
A DRIVER'S LICENSES MR DAILY
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
THIS BILL HOPEFULLY WILL IMPROVE
SAFETY ON OUR ROADS BY
STRENGTHENING THE PENALTY FOR
DISTRACTED DRIVING. TO INCLUDE A
POINT ON THE DRIVING RECORD
AFTER THE FIRST VIOLATION.
DISTRACTED DRIVING CAN BE AS
DEADLY AS IMPAIR DRIVING.
RESEARCH PROVIDED BY THE AUTO
CLUB SUGGESTED DRIVERS TEXTING
WHILE DRIVING OR EIGHT TIMES AS
LIKELY TO BE IN AN ACCIDENT AS
DRIVERS WHO ARE NOT TEXTING.
AS WE CAN ALL IMAGINE AND MAYBE
HAVE EXPERIENCED.
DIVERTING ONE'S EYES FROM THE
ROAD TO TEXT FOR AS FEW AS FIVE
SECONDS WHILE TRAVELING AT A
SPEED OF FIFTY FIVE MILES AN
HOUR.
IS LONG ENOUGH TO TRAVEL THE
LENGTH OF A FOOTBALL FIELD.
IT'S LIKE DOING IT IT'S LIKE
DRIVING WHILE BLINDFOLDED.
THE NATIONAL HIGHWAY TRAFFIC
SAFETY ADMINISTRATION FOUND THE
DISTRACTED DRIVING COUNTS 410%
OF FATAL CRASHES.
IN THE LARGEST PROPORTION OF
DRIVERS WHO WERE DISTRACTED THE
TIME OF A FATAL CRASH WERE
BETWEEN THE AGES OF SIXTEEN TO
NINETEEN THIS MEASURE IS NO
OPPOSITION IS SUPPORTED BY THE
CALIFORNIA POLICE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION.
MOBILITY TWENTY ONE AND THE
AUTOMOBILE CLUB I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER DAILY.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THE ITEM [inaudible]
CLARK LIBERAL [inaudible]
MEMBERS.
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF OUR DESIRE TO
VOTE [inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ROLE TALLY THOSE.
I SIXTY FIVE NO.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
FILE IN TWO FIFTIES AB SIXTY
SEVEN CORPORATION.
ASSEMBLY BILL SIXTY SEVEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER THREE OF US
ANOTHER'S AN ACCOLADE
HOMELESSNESS IS RIVAS.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I AM
PROUD TO PRESENT AB SIXTY SEVEN
BECAUSE THIS WILL ESTABLISH A
STATE DATABASE TO COMPILE AND
CENTRALIZED DATA FROM STATE.
AND LOCAL AGENCIES ON
CALIFORNIA'S HOMELESS POPULATION
AND THE SERVICES PROVIDED IN USE
BY HOMELESS INDIVIDUALS THIS
COMPREHENSIVE DATABASE WILL
ALLOW FOR AN ASSESSMENT.
OF THE COST OF HOMELESSNESS TO
THE STATE IDENTIFY GAPS IN
SERVICES DISCOVER HOW PATTERNS
OF SERVICE -- USE RELATE TO
PATTERNS OF HOMELESSNESS AND
ENHANCE PLANNING AND POLICY
EFFORTS TO REDUCE HOMELESSNESS.
THANK YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MS RIVAS SEE NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CLARK LIBERAL.
ALL MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO
VOTE ON MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL CLOSE THE ROLL TIDE
ABOUT ICE.
FIFTY NINE KNOWS FOR THAT
MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM.
TWO FIFTY ONE IS AB ONE THIRTY
THREE BY MISS QUIRK SILVA CLERK
WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE THIRTY THREE
BY SIMPLY MEMBER QUIRK SILVA
ANOTHER'S AN ACCOLADE THE
TAXATION OF MAKING AN
APPROPRIATION OF FOR THIS QUIRK
SILVA.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER M.
MEMBERS SEVERAL YEARS AGO THIS
BODY RECREATED THE SENIOR
PROPERTY TAX POSTPONEMENT
PROGRAM TO ASSIST LOWER INCOME
SENIORS THE DISABLED.
AND MOBILE HOME OWNERS AND
DEFERRING THEIR PROPERTY TAX
PAYMENTS MANY OF YOU HELPED IN
MAKING THAT ACTION POSSIBLE.
NOW I ASK YOU TODAY TO JOIN IN
MAKING THE PROGRAM MORE
EFFECTIVE FOR A ROOM MORE
REASONABLE IN ITS USE.
AB ONE THIRTY THREE REVISES THE
INCOME LIMIT FOR A HOMEOWNER TO
QUALIFY FOR THE PROPERTY TAX
PROGRAM TO A VARIABLE VERY ABLE
COUNTY SPECIFIC LOAN INCOME.
LIMIT ADJUSTED FOR HOUSE SAW
HOUSEHOLD SIZE BASICALLY THIS
SAYS THAT THE TAX WILL BE
ADJUSTED DEPENDING ON WHERE THEY
LIST WITHOUT I ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT OF THIS PROGRAM TO HELP
KEEP OUR SENIORS.
AND DISABLED AND THOSE LIVING IN
MOBILE HOMES IN THEIR HOMES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS QUIRK SILVA
SAYING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM.
QUIRK LIBERAL.
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
THIS TAKES.
FIFTY FOUR ALL MEMBERS OTHERS
OUT OF A CLERK WILL.
CLOSE THE ROLE TALLY THE VOTE.
I SIXTY NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
FILE ITEM TWO FIFTY TO PASS
RETAIN.
WELL IN TWO FIFTY THREE IS AB
ONE SIX FOUR SEPARATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE SIXTY FOUR BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CERVANTES
ANOTHER'S AN ACCOLADE OF
FIREARMS.
MR BONTA S..
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
FOR A LOT ME TO PRESENT AB ONE
SIXTY FOUR TODAY THIS BILL WILL
CLOSE A LOOPHOLE THAT HAS LEFT
SURVIVORS OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
IN OUR STATE VULNERABLE TO
THREATS OF VIOLENCE AND ACTUAL
ACTS.
OF VIOLENCE AB ONE SIXTY FOUR
WILL PROVIDE SYMMETRY IN OUR
LAWS BY ALLOWING OUR COURTS TO
FULLY HONOR NOT ONLY OUT OF
STATE RESTRAINING ORDERS BUT
ALSO FIRE ARM PROHIBITIONS THAT.
IS PART OF THAT ORDER BY
ENACTING THIS LEGISLATION WILL
BE CLOSING THIS DANGEROUS
LOOPHOLE IN HELPING TO PROTECT.
AYE SURVIVORS OF DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE WITH THE PROTECTION
THAT THEY BOTH NEED AND DESERVE
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR I ABOUT.
THANK YOU MISTER MONTEZ.
SEEN NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
ON THE ITEM CORPORAL
[inaudible]
MEMBERS.
DESIRE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS VOTERS
OUT OF A ALL MEMBER SERVICE OUT
OF THE CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ALL TITLE BUT I SIXTY
NINE NO ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES
FILING.
TO FIFTY FOUR IS AB ONE SIXTY
FIVE COVERAGE.
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE SIXTY FIVE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GABER ON OTHERS
AN ACCOLADE A PEACE OFFICER
TRAINING MR GABRIEL.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I AM
PLEASED TODAY TO PRESENT AB ONE
SIXTY FIVE A BILL THAT WILL
ENSURE THAT OUR LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS ARE PROPERLY TRAINED ON
THE USE OF GUN VIOLENCE
RESTRAINING ORDERS.
OUR LATEST AMENDMENTS HAVE
REMOVED ALL OPPOSITION THIS BILL
SUPPORTED BY LAW ENFORCEMENT AND
PASTOR POLICY COMMITTEE
UNANIMOUSLY RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
YOUR AYE VOTE ON AB.
ONE SIXTY FIVE THANK YOU MR
GABRIEL SAY NO DISCUSSION DEBATE
ON THE ITEM CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE [inaudible]
MEMBERS.
THESE ARE VOTE ON MEMBERS VOTERS
OUT OF THE ALL MEMBERS HER
DESIRE TO VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE ROLL TIDE
ABOUT ICE.
FIFTY NINE NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES FOLLOWED TWO FIFTY FIVE
THIS AB ONE SEVENTY ONE CLERK
READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE SEVENTY ONE BY
SIMPLY MEMBER GONZALEZ AND
OTHERS AN ACCOLADE EMPLOYMENT.
MISS HIS ALL FEMALE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
A PAST ME 60% OF WOMEN HAVE
FACED HARASSMENT ON THE JOB AND
OF THOSE WHO HAVE REPORTED ABOUT
75% SAY THEY'VE BEEN RETALIATED
AGAINST.
NOW IF YOU FILE A LAWSUIT YOU'RE
ACTUALLY PROTECTED FROM
RETALIATION AND THAT'S A GREAT
THING.
BUT AS OF LAST YEAR WHEN WE ARE
DEALING WITH ME TOO MOVEMENT WE
WENT AROUND THE STATE AND TALK.
TO LOW INCOME -- WORKING CLASS
WOMEN WE FOUND THAT MOST AND
DON'T WANT TO FILE LAWSUITS MOST
AND JUST WHAT THE BEHAVIOR TO
STOP.
SO IF THEY'RE A WAITRESS AND AND
IN THE C<c.cyan> IS DOING SOMETHING</c>
INAPPROPRIATE AND THEY REPORTED
TO A SUPERVISOR THEY JUST WANTED
TO STOP.
IN UNFORTUNATELY 75% OF TIME
THAT WOMAN IS RETALIATE AGAINST
HER SHIFT IS A HER SHIFT MAYBE
CHANGED HER EYES SHE MAY BE
FIRED.
AND THERE'S NO LEGAL RECOURSE
WHAT THIS BILL DOES IT'S A
PRESUMPTION OF RETALIATION SO
THAT WITHIN NINETY DAYS OF HER
REPORTING A SEXUAL HARASSMENT
CLAIM TO A SUPERIOR.
IF IF HERSHISER CHANGE IT FOR
HOURS ARE REDUCED IF HE'S FIRED
IT'S PRESUMED THAT IT'S BECAUSE
OF THIS BUT EMPLOYER STILL
RETAINS THE ABILITY TO FIRE AN
EMPLOYEE FOR BECAUSE IT JUST
CAN'T BE BECAUSE SHE REPORT
SEXUAL HARASSMENT.
THIS IS AN IMPORTANT BILL FOR
WOMEN WHO DON'T HAVE ADVOCATES
AND I STRONGLY RECOMMEND AN AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MS GONZALEZ WAS REYES
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
I RISE IN SUPPORT OF AB.
ONE SEVENTY ONE THIS BILL IS AT
THE HEART OF WHY IT IS SO
DIFFICULT FOR SEXUAL HARASSMENT
AND ASSAULTS RUBBERS TO REPORT
THIS BEHAVIOR WHEN IT OCCURS IN
THE WORKPLACE.
MORE OFTEN THAN NOT ONE WORKERS
REPORT VIOLATIONS THEIR
RETALIATED AGAINST.
AB ONE SEVENTY ONE SAYS THAT IF
YOU REPORT THAT YOU WERE
SEXUALLY HARASSED.
AND THE NEXT DAY YOU'RE FIRED OR
YOU PUT IN THE MIKE SHE AFTER
HOURS ARE CUT WE'RE GOING TO
ASSUME THAT THERE'S A CONNECTION
BETWEEN THE TWO EVENTS.
IF THE EMPLOYER HAS GOOD REASON
FOR TERMINATING THE WORKER ALL
THEY HAVE TO DO IS PRESENT THE
EVIDENCE.
THIS BILL ISN'T ABOUT LAWSUITS
AND FILING REPORTS IT'S SIMPLY
ABOUT PROVIDING THESE WORKERS A
SHIELD THEY NEED TO BE ABLE TO
COME OUT AND ENSURE THE BEHAVIOR
STOPS.
THIS BILL FREE SURVIVORS TO
SPEAK OUT AGAINST THE WORKPLACE
CULTURE OF SILENCE AND
EXPLOITATION ARE SPECTRALLY ELSE
FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MS RACES SEE NO
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THE ITEM.
CLARK WILL OPEN THE ROLE
[inaudible]
MEMBERS.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS HER DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT
ICE.
FIFTY ONE KNOWS.
FOR THAT MEASURE PASSED.
THERE WERE SEVERAL PAIR TO LIVE
THE CALL ON FILE ITEM TWO FORTY
THREE AB EIGHT BY MISTER CHIU
KANSEN CHU CORPORAL POST.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER WHICH TO VOTE
TAKES FIFTY FOR ALL MEMBERS
WOULD WISH TO VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL.
CLOSE YOUR ROLL TIDE BUT I SIXTY
NO SIX THAT MEASURE PASSES.
I WAS BACK IN FILE ORDER FILE
ITEM TWO FIFTY SIX IS AB.
ONE SEVENTY THREE QUICK READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE SEVENTY THREE
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER CHAO AN
ACCOLADE A MOBILE HOMES.
MR CHOW.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS IN TWENTY SIXTEEN THE
LEGISLATURE PASSED AB FIVE
EIGHTY SEVEN WHICH ESTABLISH A
TAX ABATEMENT PROGRAM CALL THE
REGISTER YOUR A MOBILE HOME
CALIFORNIA.
IT'S A PROGRAM FOR MOBILE
HOMEOWNERS WHO ARE UNABLE TO
TRANSFER TITLE OF THEIR HOMES
INTO THEIR OWN NAMES DUE TO TAX
DELINQUENCIES THAT WERE INCURRED
BY PRIOR OWNERS.
SINCE THE PROGRAM STARTED IN
TWENTY SEVENTEEN MOBILE HOME
OWNERS HAVE SAVED WELL OVER ONE
POINT FIVE MILLION DOLLARS.
AND A PROGRAM IS ON TRACK TO SEE
MOBILE HOMEOWNERS AND TWO
MILLION DOLLARS BY THE TIME IT
SUNSETS ON DECEMBER THIRTY FIRST.
TWENTY NINETEEN DESPITE THE
SUCCESS THERE ARE STILL TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF HOMEOWNERS WHO HAVE
NOT BEEN ABLE TO TAKE ADVANTAGE
OF THE PROGRAM.
AB ONE SEVENTY THREE WAS SIMPLY
EXTEND THE SUNSET ON THE PROGRAM
FOR ONE YEAR TO CONTINUE TO HELP
MOBILE HOMEOWNERS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER SHALL SEE NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE ADAM
CLERK WILL OPEN ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OTHERS ARE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE YOUR ROLL TIDE ABOUT I
SIXTY SIX NO.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES
.
MEMBERSHIP FILE ORDER.
THIS IS FILE ITEM TWO FIFTY
SEVEN AB.
ONE SEVENTY FOUR ASSEMBLY BILL
ONE SEVENTY FOUR BY SOME
MEMORABLE WOULDN'T ACCOLADE
HEALTH CARE COVERAGE DOCTOR
WOULD.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
ONE OF MOST CRITICAL ISSUES IN
HEALTH CARE IS AFFORDABILITY
SUCH AS AFFORDABLE PRESCRIPTION
DRUGS AFFORDABLE TREATMENTS AND
AFFORDABLE HEALTHCARE PREMIUMS.
ALTHOUGH CALIFORNIA'S MAKE
TREMENDOUS GAINS AS A RESULT OF
THE ACA IN THE INDIVIDUAL MARKET
THERE'S STILL QUITE A WAYS TO GO.
WITHOUT FURTHER STATE ACTION THE
NUMBER OF UNINSURED IN THE STATE
COULD RISE FROM THREE POINT FIVE
MILLION. 420-001-6242 FOUR
MILLION IN TWENTY TWENTY AND
FOUR POINT FOUR IN TWENTY TWENTY
THREE CURRENT ACA PREMIUM
ASSISTANCE MAY BE HELPFUL TO
SOME PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA BUT
NOT ENOUGH INCLUDING THE MIDDLE
CLASS.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSED
BUDGET BILL PROPOSES TO IMPROVE
AFFORDABILITY AND PROVIDES
p75% OF SUBSTANCE HE EXPENDITURES
ALLOCATED TO THOSE WITH INCOMES
BETWEEN 410026100% OF THE
FEDERAL POVERTY LEVEL.
THIS BILL WOULD EXPAND UPON THE
PROPOSAL AND PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
PREMIUM ASSISTANCE AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK ELECT WOULDN'T.
SEE NO DISCUSSION DEBATE
[inaudible]
CORPS CORPORAL.
VOTERS ARE VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ALL TIE VOTE EYES FIFTY
SEVEN NO.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES BALLOT
IN.
TWO FIFTY EIGHT IS AB ONE NINETY
SEVEN COOKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE NINETY SEVEN
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER WEBER ANOTHER
SNACK LADY KINDERGARTEN.
DOCTOR WEBER.
YES MISS JUST MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS ARE RISE TO PRESENT TO
YOU AB ONE NINE SEVEN WHICH
WOULD REQUIRE SCHOOL DISTRICTS
OF OFFER KINDERGARTEN. TO
IMPLEMENT A FULL DAY
KINDERGARTEN PROGRAM.
ACCORDING TO THE EDUCATION
COMMISSION OF THE STATES FULL
DAY KINDERGARTEN ATTENDANCE CAN
HELP CLOSE ACHIEVEMENT GAP EARLY
EARLY ON IN A CHILD'S EDUCATION.
LONGER SCHOOL DAYS ENABLE
CHILDREN TO RECEIVE MORE
INDIVIDUALIZED ACADEMICALLY
FOCUSED AND MEANINGFUL
INSTRUCTION FROM TEACHERS AS
WELL AS WHAT TIME INTERACTING
WITH THEIR PEERS.
THIS CAN LEAD TO INCREASED TEST
SCORES AND GRADE A LONG LIFE
LONG ACHIEVEMENT.
THE POSITIVE EFFECTS OF FULL DAY
KINDERGARTEN EVEN MORE
PRONOUNCED FOR MINORITY AND LOW
INCOME CHILDREN.
BECAUSE MORE AND MORE CHILDREN
PARTICIPATE IN PRESCHOOL AN
URGENT EARLY EDUCATION PROGRAMS
KINDERGARTEN IS NO LONGER THEIR
FIRST EXPERIENCE MANY ARE YOU
ACCUSTOMED TO A FULL DAY PROGRAM
AND READY FOR A FULL DAY
KINDERGARTEN.
THE DIGITAL HOURS PROVIDED UNDER
AB ONE NINE SEVEN WOULD EXPAND
INSTRUCTIONAL TIME FOR ALL
STUDENTS AND GIVE TEACHERS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE AN
ACADEMICALLY RICH EXPERIENCE FOR
EVERY YOUNG LEARNERS.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. EIGHT ACT WEBER SENIOR
DISCUSSION DEBATE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE.
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OTHERS OUT OF THE
ALL MEMBERS THERE IS OUT OF THE
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ALL TRIED ABOUT EYES
FIFTY KNOWS TEN THAT MEASURE
PASSES FILE ITEM TWO FIFTY NINE
IS AB TWO ZERO THREE MR SALAS
CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWO OR THREE BY
SIMPLY RIVER SALAS AND OTHERS AN
ACCOLADE OCCUPATIONAL SAFETY
SAFETY AND HEALTH.
MISTER CELIS.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
SIMPLY BILL TWO OR THREE WILL
IMPROVE WORKER SAFETY AS IT
RELATES TO VALLEY FEVER
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
FAMOUS SALAS SAY NO DISCUSSION
DEBATE.
OUR CLUB THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
DECIDED THAT ALL MEMBERS OTHERS
ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS LETTERS OUT OF A
CLICK WELL.
CLOSER ROLL TIDE OF A AYE SIXTY
NO.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM TO SIXTY IS AB.
TWO OH FOUR COVERAGE.
ASSEMBLY BILL -- TO FOR BY SOME
REMEMBER WOULD KNOCK LEYVA
HOSPITALS DOCTOR WOULD YOU MAIL.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBER
COMMUNITY BENEFITS OF THE
SERVICES NONPROFIT HOSPITALS
PROVIDE TO ADDRESS COMMUNITY
NEEDS IN EXCHANGE FOR THEIR TAX
EXEMPT STATUS.
MAKING INCLUDE SERVICES.
WHY DID TO PROVIDE -- VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS -- CHARITY CARE
SUPPORT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
PROGRAMS AND DONATIONS OF FUNDS
ARE RESOURCES THAT CONTRIBUTE TO
A COMMUNITY PRIORITY SUCH AS
HOUSING.
HOWEVER THERE'S REALLY TRULY NO
STANDARDIZED REQUIREMENTS FOR
CALCULATING REPORTING THE VALUE
OF COMMUNITY BENEFITS THE MAKES
IT DIFFICULT FOR COMMUNITIES TO
KNOW THE VALUE OF THE COMMUNITY
BENEFITS BEING PROVIDED BY THEIR
HOSPITAL.
AB TWO OH TWO OH FOUR REQUIRES
ARE SPREAD TO DEVELOP
REGULATIONS STANDARDIZING THE
CALCULATION THE REPORTING OF
COMMUNITY BENEFITS TO REPORT THE
AMOUNT EACH HOSPITAL SPENDS ON
COMMUNITY BENEFITS.
AND AUTHORIZE ON AUTHORIZES AYE
SPREAD TO FIND HOSPITALS THE
FAILED TO FILL THEIR FILE THEIR
COMMUNITY BENEFIT PLANS.
IT ALSO REQUIRES -- HOSPITALS
REPORT THE COMMUNITY BENEFITS
PROVIDED BY EACH HOSPITAL TO
THEIR COMMUNITY RATHER THAN AS A
HOSPITAL SYSTEM -- ALSO TO POST
THEIR COMMUNITY BENEFIT PLANS ON
THEIR WEBSITE THIS BILL IS
INTENDED TO ENSURE THAT IS A
HOSPITAL AS HOSPITAL SYSTEMS MAY
GROW IN SIZE.
THE INDIVIDUAL HOSPITALS IN THE
SYSTEM REMAIN MEANINGFUL
COMMUNITY PARTNERS I'M WORKING
WITH THE CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION TO ADDRESS THEIR
CONCERNS.
I ASKED FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU DOCTOR WHAT.
SEE NO DISCUSSION DEBATE
[inaudible]
CLARK LIBERAL.
DESIRE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS VOTERS
ARTICLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE YOUR ROLL.
TIDE OF A I SIXTY FOUR NO.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
SURE CALDERON STARK.
THREW ME OFF.
IN FOLLOW ORDER.
AB FARMING FILE ITEM.
TO SIXTY ONE IS AB.
TWO ELEVEN SO MY BILL TO ELEVEN
BY SOME REMEMBER CALDERON THAN
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY THE TAXATION
TO TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY TAX
LEVY.
MISTER CALDERON.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
AB TWO ELEVEN CREATES A TAX
DEDUCTION FOR CONTRIBUTIONS TO A
SCHOLAR SIR FIVE TWO NINE
ACCOUNT WITH A LIMIT OF FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR SINGLE
FILERS AND TEN THOUSAND DOLLARS
DOLLARS FOR JOINT FILERS.
RECENT AMENDMENTS CAP THE INCOME
AN INDIVIDUAL MAY RECEIVE THE
DEDUCTION AT SEVENTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR SINGLE
FILERS AND A HUNDRED TWO
THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR JOINT
FILERS.
SUPPORTING A STUDENTS COLLEGE
JOURNEY IS THE GREATEST
LIFTING PUT PEOPLE OUT OF
POVERTY AND SUPPORTING
CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMIC GROWTH I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER CALDERON.
SENIOR DISCUSSION DEBATE CLERK
LIBERAL.
ALL MY RESEARCH SARAH VOTE ON
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL CLOSER ALL TIED ABOUT
AYE AYES SIXTY FIVE NO.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES FILE
ITEM. TWO SIXTY TWO IS AB TWO
THIRTY TWO CORPORATION.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWO THIRTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CERVANTES
INOCULATED DEATH REGISTRATION.
MISTER MATTOX THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS AB TWO THIRTY
TWO ADDRESSES THE NEED FOR A
MORE COMPREHENSIVE ANALYSIS OF
VETERANS TWO SIDES IN CALIFORNIA.
THIS BILL WILL REQUIRE
ADDITIONAL DATA COLLECTION THE
VA INDICATES THAT THERE ARE MORE
THAN SIX THOUSAND VETERANS
SUICIDES EACH YEAR FROM
200-082-2000 SIXTEEN IN THE
UNITED STATES.
IN ORDER TO ADDRESS THE
STATISTICS IT IS IMPORTANT THAT
SUICIDE PREVENTION EFFORTS ARE
IMPLEMENTED TO BEST SUIT THE
NEEDS OF OUR MOST VULNERABLE
VETERANS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE ABOUT.
THANK YOU MISTER MONTEZ SAYING
NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM.
OUR GLOBAL ROLE.
SERVICE OUT OF VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL CLOSER ALL TIED ABOUT
AYE.
SIXTY EIGHT NO.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM TO SIXTY THREE IS AB.
TWO FORTY FIVE SOME ABLE TO
FORTY FIVE BY SOME WE WERE
MURATSUCHI AND OTHERS NOT REALLY
NARROW.
MISTER MURATSUCHI THANK YOU VERY
MUCH I'M PRESENTING AB TWO FORTY
FIVE TO CREATE THE CALIFORNIA
AEROSPACE COMMISSION CALIFORNIA
THE NATIONAL AND GLOBAL LEADER
AND AEROSPACE INNOVATION AND JOB
CREATION.
HOWEVER OTHER STATES ARE TRYING
TO TAKE AWAY OUR JOBS IN OUR
INDUSTRY ESPECIALLY IN THE
GROWING COMMERCIAL SPACE
INDUSTRY WE NEED TO MAKE SURE WE
MAINTAIN OUR COMPETITIVE
ADVANTAGE.
MANY OF MAY IT MAY RECALL THAT
THIS BILL I GOT TO THE
GOVERNOR'S DESK LAST YEAR THE
GOVERNOR VETOED IT -- ON THE
ARGUMENT THAT -- GOBIZ WAS A
READY -- CONDUCTING THIS
ACTIVITY HOWEVER ACCORDING TO
THE INDUSTRY GO BUSINESS NOT
CONDUCTING THAT INDUSTRY THAT
THAT THAT ACTIVITY THAT'S WHY WE
WE WE NEED THE COUNTS.
CALIFORNIA AEROSPACE COMMISSION
I ASK FOR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER MURATSUCHI SEE
NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBER SERVICE OUT OF THE
ALL MEMBERS ARE DESIRED OF THE
ALL MEMBERS OTHERS ARE THE CLARK
WELL.
CLOSE YOUR ROLL TIDE BUT I SIXTY
SIX NO ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES
FILE ITEM TO SIXTY FOUR IS AB
TWO SEVENTY FIVE CORKERY.
SOME PEOPLE TO SEVENTY FIVE BY
SOME RIVER RAMOS ANOTHER TONIGHT
RELATED IF NATIVE AMERICAN
RESOURCE PROTECTION.
MISTER ROBERTS THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AS CHAIRMAN OF THE
SIMPLY SELECT COMMITTEE ON
NATIVE AMERICAN AFFAIRS.
AND FORMER CHAIRMAN OF THE
CALIFORNIA NATIVE AMERICAN
HERITAGE COMMISSION I AM PROUD
TO PRESENT AB.
TWO SEVENTY FIVE A BILL THAT
WILL STRENGTHEN THE
COMMUNICATION AND COLLABORATION
BETWEEN NATIVE AMERICAN TRIBES
AND STATE AGENCIES AS IT RELATES
TO RID REPATRIATION OF HUMAN
REMAINS AND CULTURAL ITEMS.
THERE EXISTS A SIGNIFICANT LACK
OF TRIBAL KNOWLEDGE IN THE
PROCESS OF IDENTIFYING WHICH
HUMAN REMAINS OR CULTURAL ITEMS
THAT WOULD SHOULD BE REPATRIATED
BACK TO TRIBES FOR REBURIAL. TO
ADDRESS THIS ISSUE THIS BILL
UPDATES CURRENT LAW WITH RESPECT
TO THE POSSESSION OF HUMAN
REMAINS BY REQUIRING TRIBAL
TRADITIONAL KNOWLEDGE TO BE
FACTORED IN THE REPATRIATION
PROCESS.
AND STARTS TO MOVE FORWARD TO
ACKNOWLEDGE CALIFORNIA'S FIRST
PEOPLE.
AB TWO SEVENTY FIVE HAS A
SUPPORT OF VARIOUS TRIBES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE AND ENJOYED
UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT.
I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
AVIS RAMA'S SEEING NO DISCUSSION
DEBATE [inaudible]
CLARK LIBERAL.
ALL MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE ABOUT.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLICK WELL CLOSER ROLL TIDE
ABOUT I SEVENTY NO ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM TO
SIXTY FIVE IS AB THREE HUNDRED
BY MR KANSEN CHU.
CORCORAN ASSEMBLY BILL THREE
HUNDRED BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
KANSEN CHU ACCOLADE I HATE
CRIMES.
MR.
TO CHECK YOUR MISTER SPEAKER SAM
MEMBERS I RISE 2% AB.
THREE HUNDRED WHICH REQUIRED THE
INCIDENT REPORTS USED BY THE LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES TO INCLUDE
A CHECK BOX.
INDICATING WEATHERED THE CASE AT
HAND IS A HATE CRIME OR HATE
INCIDENT.
IT ALSO REQUIRED FOR EACH HATE
CRIME OR HATE INCIDENT THE LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCY MUST COMPLETE
A SUPPLEMENTAL REPORT SPECIFYING
THE TYPE OF BIAS OR MOTIVATION
INVOLVED AND OTHER REVEL IN
INFORMATION THAT WILL HELP AID
IN THE PROSECUTION OF THE CASE.
IT IS IMPERATIVE FOR OUR LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCY TO UTILIZED A
BASS MASSET TO A IDENTIFIED
REPORT AND INVESTIGATE HATE
CRIME.
AND PAID INCIDENCES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHIU SAY NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CLARK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
OF THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OTHERS ARE THOSE
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
WELL CLOSER ALL TIE VOTE I SIXTY
FIVE KNOWS.
ONE THAT MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM TO SIXTY SIX AB THREE
OH SEVEN CORPORATION.
ASSEMBLY BILL THREE OH SEVEN BY
SIMPLY MEMORY AS ANOTHER SNACK
LATELY YOU.
THIS RACE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS AB THRILL SEVEN IS A
GRANT PROGRAM WHICH WOULD AWARD
FUNDS TO NON PROFITS ARE
CONTINUE CONTINUUM OF CARE.
ADMINISTRATIVE ENTITIES TO
PROVIDE SERVICES FOR YOUTH
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS.
AS YOU MAY KNOW CALIFORNIA'S THE
HAS THE HIGHEST RATE OF YOUTH
HOMELESSNESS IN THE NATION WITH
OVER 54% OF THE NATION'S TOTAL
NUMBER.
OF HOMELESS YOUTH RESIDING RIGHT
HERE ON CALIFORNIA'S STREETS.
IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN THERE
WERE OVER TWELVE THOUSAND
UNACCOMPANIED HOMELESS YOUTH IN
CALIFORNIA WITHOUT A SAFE PLACE
TO CALL HOME.
AND AN ADDITIONAL TWENTY THREE
HUNDRED PARENTING USE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS ALONG
WITH THEIR CHILDREN.
THE STATE'S INVESTMENT OF
PROGRAMS TO SUPPORT YOUNG PEOPLE
IN THESE PREDICAMENT IS WOEFULLY
INADEQUATE WITH ONLY TWENTY
COUNTIES IN CALIFORNIA.
IT CALIFORNIA'S FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTIES HAVING DIRECT SERVICES
FOR YOUTH EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS.
WITH THE PASSAGE OF AB.
THREE OH SEVEN WE CAN HELP
SUPPORT LOCAL PROGRAMS TO
PROVIDE APPROPRIATE AND
CULTURALLY INFORMED WRAPAROUND
SERVICES TO ENHANCE EFFORTS TO
COMBAT YOUTH HOMELESSNESS.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THEY ADDRESS MISS ROSS YOUR
RECOGNIZE THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES I ALSO
RISE A SUPPORT OF AB.
THREE OH SEVEN AS THE AUTHOR
KNOWS THE CRISIS OF HOMELESSNESS
IN OUR INLAND EMPIRE COMMUNITY
IS SEVERE.
PROGRAMS THAT TAKE YOU OUT OF
CYCLES OF POVERTY AND
HOMELESSNESS ARE NECESSARY
DURING OUR CURRENT HOUSING
CRISIS.
I AM PROUD TO CALL OUT THROUGH
THIS MEASURE AS I KNOW THAT MY
ANY SUPPORT WE CAN PROVIDE TO
HOMELESS YOUTH WILL GO A LONG
WAY.
I WOULD LIKE TO THANK MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SALMON -- DINO
FOR CONTINUING THE FIGHT FOR
HOMELESS YOUTH ACROSS OUR STATE
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE
VOTES.
THANK YOU RESTAURANTS SEE NO
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
CARPOOL OF THE ROLE.
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
WELL.
CLOSER ALL TIES BUT I SIXTY
THREE NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES FILE ITEM. TWO SIXTY
SEVEN IS AB THREE TEN BY MISTER
SANTIAGO QUICKLY.
ASSEMBLY BILL THREE TEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER SANTIAGO AND
ACTUALLY THE COURTS [inaudible]
MR SANTIAGO.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
AB THREE TEN AS RECENTLY AMENDED
BUT ONLY EXEMPTS A PROBATION
OFFICER FROM JURY JURY IN
CRIMINAL MATTERS UNTIL.
JANUARY TWENTY TWENTY FOUR I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY BOOK.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON
THE ITEM.
COR CORPORAL.
MEMBERS.
DESIRE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS VOTERS
OUT OF A ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT
OF A CLARK WELL CLOSER ALL T<c.cyan></c>
VOTE.
I FIFTY SEVEN NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM TO
SIXTY EIGHT IS AB THREE
SEVENTEEN BY MR DEEP QUICKLY.
ASSEMBLY BILL THREE SEVENTEEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER DEEPEN OTHERS AN
ACCOLADE OF VEHICLES MR DEEP.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
TO PRESENT AB THREE SEVENTEEN
THIS BILL WILL MAKE IT UNLAWFUL
FOR PRIVATE COMPANIES TO SELL
ONLINE VIA BE APPOINTMENTS.
AB THREE SEVENTEEN IS A
BIPARTISAN MEASURE AND HAS
RECEIVED NO NO VOTES -- I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
SEEING THEIR DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE ADAM QUIRK LIBERAL.
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE ON
MEMBERS OF THE START OF A ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL CLOSE THE ROLE TALLY
THE VOTE I SIXTY FOUR NO.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES FILE IN
TWO SIX NINETY THREE EIGHTEEN BY
MR KANSEN CHU CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL THREE EIGHTEEN BY
SOME REMEMBER KANSEN CHU AN
ACCOLADE AMERICA.
MR.
TO CHECK YOUR MISTER SPEAKER SAM
MEMBER AB THREE EIGHTEEN ENSURE
DAD READABILITY ACCURACY AND
CULTURALLY APPROPRIATE HOST MISS
OFF MEDI CAL DOCUMENTS SO THAT
MEDI CAL RECIPIENTS.
CUT UNDERSTAND WHAT -- RECRUIT
GETTING AND HOW FAIR **** TO
THEIR BENEFIT.
AT LEAST ONE OF THE THREE MEDI
CAL RECEIVE HIM THIS KNOCKED.
NATIVE ENGLISH SPEAKER TO
TRANSLATE A MATERIAL THAT MEDI
CAL BENEFITS.
BENEFICIARY RECEIVE ARE OFTEN
WRITTEN IN TO HIDE OFFER MEDIAN
LEVEL OF OR TO BE YOU THE
CONFUSING LANGUAGES THEREFORE
ENSURING THAT TRANSLATED
DOCUMENTS ARE WRITTEN IN PLAIN.
SIMPLE AND CULTURALLY
APPROPRIATE AT LET A LANGUAGE IS
TO IS IMPORTANT TO IMPROVING
HEALTH ****. TO ALL MEDI CAL
RECIPIENTS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS SHOULD SAY NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLICK WELL CLOSER ROLE.
TELL A VOTE.
AYE AYES.
FORTY NINE KNOWS.
THIRTEEN THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WE'RE FILE ITEM.
TO SEVENTY AB THREE TWENTY
DOCTOR QUIRK.
QUICK READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL THREE TWENTY BY
SIMPLY MEMBER QUIRK AND OTHERS
AN ACCOLADE A PEST CONTROL.
DOCTOR QUIRK YOU MAY OPEN.
YOU SEE A FOR I THANK YOU
SPEAKER IN MEMBERS YOU SEE FOR A
NUMBER OF YEARS HAS CAPPED.
A THE CALIFORNIA MOSQUITO
SURVEILLANCE.
AT AND RESEARCH PROGRAM.
AT UC DAVIS THIS WOULD PUT THIS --
PROGRAM INTO LAW I ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU DON'T WORK.
THIS MATHIS HERE RECOGNIZE THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER ON MY TO RISE
IN SUPPORT OF THIS -- JUST BASED
ON THE RECENT NEWS -- THIS WEEK
FINDING OUT THAT WE HAVE ALL
WEST NILE.
ARE BEING FOUND IN THE MOSQUITOS
WITHIN MY DISTRICT ON THIS IS A
PERFECT TIMING.
OF FOR THIS LEGISLATION WE NEED
TO DO MORE.
OF TO GO AFTER THE MOSQUITOES
CELL ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE MEMBERS.
THANK YOU MISTER MATHIS SEE NO
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
OKAY THANK ACT COURT
[inaudible]
CLICK LIBERAL.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE THEM.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE
THE CLERK WILL.
CLOSE THE ROLE AND TALLY THE
VOTE  SIXTY FIVE NO.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS
WE ARE GOING TO MOVE BACK IN THE
FILE. TO FILE ITEM NUMBER.
NINE THERE'S DOCTOR EGGMAN SO
FILE ITEM NUMBER NINE IS AB
THREE SIXTY TWO AND THE CLERK
WILL READ.
SOMETHING ALL THREE SIXTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER EGGMAN AND I
PLANNED CONTROLLED SUBSTANCES.
DOCTOR EGGMAN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS I AM PRESENTING
TODAY AB THREE SIXTY TWO WHICH
WILL BE NEW FOR ANY OF US --
THIS BILL WILL ALLOW SAN
FRANCISCO TO OVERDOSE TO PILOT
AN OVERDOSE PREVENTION PROGRAM.
AS WE KNOW THERE IS AN OPIOID
EPIDEMIC.
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND
ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
AND WE KNOW THAT WE HAVE TRIED
AND TRUE METHODS OF INTERVENTION
AND EARLY TREATMENT PREVENTION
TO BE ABLE TO TREAT THIS -- IN
THE IN THE IN NORTH AMERICA WE
HAVE BEEN HESITANT TO DO THIS --
WE CONTINUE TO SEE OVERDOSE AND
DEATH WE CONTINUE TO SEE THE
INCREASE OF HEPATITIS C. OF HIV
OF PEOPLE BEING OVERDOSING IN
ALLEYS WE CONTINUE TO SEE PEOPLE
IN OUR EMERGENCY SYSTEM POLICE
RESPONDING.
EMERGENCY ROOMS OVERWHELMED.
SO WHAT WE'RE SAYING IS LET'S
GET PEOPLE TREATMENT EARLIER
THAN LATER.
WE ARE IN NO WAY CONDONING DRUG
ABUSE BUT WHAT WE ARE SAYING.
IS HAVING A DRUG ADDICTION
SHOULD NOT BE A DEATH SENTENCE.
WE KNOW THAT THE BEST WAY TO GET
PEOPLE INTO TREATMENT IS TO
BEGIN HAVING A RELATIONSHIP WITH
THEM VERY EARLY ON WE KNOW THAT
PEOPLE WHO USE.
WHO ARE HOMELESS AND ARE USING
ON OUR STREETS IN OUR SCHOOL
GROUNDS IN OUR CHURCH YARDS ARE
LEAVING NEEDLES THAT ARE
DANGEROUS FOR CHILDREN?
DANGERS FOR OTHER ANIMALS AND
NOT GOOD FOR ANYBODY INVOLVED WE
KNOW THAT THERE IS A WAY TO BE
ABLE TO PILOT THIS SAN FRANCISCO
IS WILLING TO PILOT IT.
IT HAS A VERY SHORT SUNSET ON IT
THEY WILL COME BACK WITH A
REPORT ABOUT ABOUT THE
IMPLEMENTATION THE BILL REQUIRES
THAT LAW ENFORCEMENT BE AT THE
TABLE IN ORDER TO ESTABLISH
WHERE THESE ARE GOING TO BE.
THERE IS A EVERY.
OVER TO EVERY DRUG ADDICTION --
A SPECIALTY IS IN SUPPORT OF
THIS THE AMERICAN MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION IS NOW IN SUPPORT OF
IT ALSO.
AGAIN THAT WE HAVE TIME TESTED
IN TRUE INTERVENTIONS THIS GETS
PEOPLE INTO TREATMENT THIS TELLS
PEOPLE THEY DON'T HAVE TO BE
DESTINED TO DIE ON THE STREETS.
THIS TELLS PEOPLE THAT WE KNOW
WE HAVE MORE IMPORTANT THINGS TO
DO WITH OUR PUBLIC SAFETY PEOPLE
THAN GOING OUT TO OVERDOSE ON
THE STREETS WE KNOW THIS ALSO
MEANS THAT PEOPLE DON'T HAVE TO
SIT IN E. OURS TAKING UP SPACE
JAILS TAKING UP SPACE.
BUT THAT WE CAN TREAT THEM.
WHERE THEY WHERE THEY LIVE WE
CAN TREAT THEM WHERE THEY ARE IN
THE MOMENT AND BE ABLE TO INVITE
THEM MAYBE TO GET AN ABSCESS
FIXED MAYBE TO BE ABLE TO GET?
A REPRIEVE FROM DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE WE KNOW IN THESE
OVERDOSE PREVENTION CENTERS
NOBODY HAS EVER DIED OF AN
OVERDOSE ALL WE'RE SAYING IS
GIVE SAN FRANCISCO A CHANCE TO
GIVE PEOPLE A SHOT AT TREATMENT
AND AT LIFE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU DOCTOR I WENT MS
MELENDEZ [inaudible]
YOUR RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER --
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN THIS.
I I APPRECIATE -- THE AUTHOR'S
INTENT -- IN AND I THINK I AGREE
THAT.
WE NEED TO DO SOMETHING.
TO KEEP PEOPLE FROM NOT ONLY
DOING THESE DRUGS BUT OVERDOSING
ON THEM BUT I DON'T THINK THAT
GIVING THEM -- ACCENTUATE
GOVERNMENT SANCTIONED FACILITY
IN WHICH TO DO THEIR DRUGS IS
THE BEST WAY TO GET THEM OFF THE
DRUGS NOW WE'RE IN THE BILL DOES
IT REQUIRE THAT ANY TREATMENT --
MUST BE ATTAINED OR THAT THEY'RE
EVEN.
NECESSARILY DIRECTED TO IT IT'S
IT'S NOT EVEN IN THE BILL AND I
THINK.
BY MAKING A FACILITY LIKE THIS --
WE ARE ESSENTIALLY SPEEDING UP
THEIR DEATH BECAUSE WHEN WE KNOW
THE PEOPLE WHO DO THESE TYPES OF
DRUGS DON'T HAVE A VERY LONG
LIFESPAN IF THEY CONTINUE TO DO
THESE DRUGS THEN.
EVENTUALLY DEATH COMES TO THEM
MUCH QUICKER THAN IT NORMALLY
WOULD AND I JUST I DON'T THINK
IT'S APPROPRIATE THAT WE ARE
SPEEDING UP.
THE DEATH PROCESS FOR THEM I
DON'T DISAGREE THAT.
WE HAVE TO FIND WAYS TO HELP
THEM BUT I DON'T THINK THAT THIS
IS THE ANSWER SO RESPECTFULLY I
WOULD ASK FOR KNOW ABOUT
[inaudible]
DOCTOR CHOI.
YOUR RECORD THANK YOU SPEAKER
AND COLLEAGUES I OR SO -- POLLS
SO AB SIX OF THREE SIXTY TWO OUT
WE HAVE A NATIONAL ON YOUR DOOR
AND A DROGA EPIDEMIC IN THE
COUNTRY.
THAT IS SO AFFECTING OUR
COMMUNITY IS AND FAMILY OF WHILE
I UNDERSTAND MY COLLEAGUE SO
DESIRE TO PROVIDE A SAFE MEANS
OF FOR INDIVIDUALS. TO A
SATISFIED THEY ARE HAPPY AND THE
HOPEFULLY REDUCE THE SPREAD OF
THE DISEASE IS I DO NOT THINK.
THAT THE THE PROLES SALT WATER --
OUTWEIGH THE CONS.
WE HAVE A WE ARE TALKING ABOUT
ESTABLISHING ILLEGAL DRUG USE.
WE CANNOT AND SHOULD NOT HOW
PEOPLE OR UP A BREAK A ADDICTION
BY PROMOTING WASTE TO MAINTAIN --
THE ADDICTION.
IF WE ARE TO TRULY HELP THE
WHOLE SO ARE USING ILLEGAL DRUGS
SO.
AS I TRULY BELIEVE ON MY
COLLEAGUES -- OR TRYING TO DO --
HERE.
OUR OUR LOG TEND NOT TO INCLUDE
THE ENABLING THESE INDIVIDUALS
SO.
IN CONTINUING DALE ADDICTION.
FOR THESE REASONS I ASK YOUR
NOVEL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU DOCTOR CHOI MISS RUBIO
YOUR RECOGNIZE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I AM
ARE RISING TODAY IN SUPPORT OF
OF THE PREVENTION CENTERS
BECAUSE I KNOW THAT WE ALL KNOW
THAT THERE ARE A WHOLE PEELED
OVER [inaudible]
CRISIS IS.
TOUCHING EVERY SINGLE COMMUNITY
THIS IS SPECIFIC TO SAN
FRANCISCO COUNTY IN SAN
FRANCISCO THE MAYOR OF SAN
FRANCISCO WAS HERE LAST YEAR.
AND SHE EXPRESSED HER
WILLINGNESS TO TRY THIS OUT IF
THIS PROGRAM DOES NOT WORK THEN
IT WILL NOT BE EXPANDED TO ANY
OTHER COMMUNITIES.
IF IT DOES WORK THAT WE HAVE A
MODEL TO HELP ALL OF OUR
COMMUNITIES.
ACROSS THE STATE TO HELP THESE
FOLKS WE'RE NOT PROVIDING.
THE BILL DOES NOT PROVIDE THE
DRUGS FOR THOSE FOLKS THEY
ALREADY HAVE THE DRUGS ARE
PROVIDING SAFE.
INJECTION OF FACILITIES WE
CANNOT JUST SIT BACK AND DO
NOTHING I GREW UP IN DOWNTOWN LA
MOST OF MY FRIENDS A LOT OF MY
FRIENDS -- WERE EITHER IN GAINES
OR ADDICTED TO DRUGS AND
UNFORTUNATELY A LOT OF THOSE ARE
GONE.
IF WE DO NOT LOOK FOR WAYS TO
SOLVE THIS ISSUE WE'RE GOING TO
BE IN THE SAME PLACE THAT WE ARE
TODAY THIS IS THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TRY THIS OUT THE MAYOR OF SAN
FRANCISCO IS WILLING -- TO TRIED
IN HER COMMUNITY AND IF IT WORKS
WE CAN EXPAND THE PROGRAM I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THIS IS A CRISIS THAT NEEDS TO
BE -- HANDLE THAN WE CAN HANDLE
IT IF FOR JUST SITTING BACK
PRETENDING THAT IT DOESN'T EXIST
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THERE WAS ROOM IS FRIEDMAN YOUR
RECOGNIZE THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I STAND
TODAY AS A CO AUTHOR OF AB.
THREE SIXTY TWO AND MY ONLY
ISSUE WITH THE BILL RIGHT NOW IS
THAT IT'S LIMITED TO SAN
FRANCISCO -- AND I WOULD POINT
OUT TO MY COLLEAGUES WHO SAY
THAT THEY BELIEVE THAT THIS
ISN'T THE WAY TO ADDRESS THE
DRUG EPIDEMIC.
I WOULD ASK WELL THEN WHAT IS
THE WAY.
BECAUSE WHAT WE'RE DOING RIGHT
NOW IS CLEARLY NOT WORKING AND
DEFENDING THE STATUS QUO.
AND DOING NEXT TO NOTHING WHEN
WE KNOW THAT THERE ARE OTHER
SOLUTIONS OUT THERE THAT CITIES
ARE WILLING TO TRY.
IS SIMPLY NOT ACCEPTABLE IN THE
FACE OF THE DRUG EPIDEMIC.
AND IN CASE ANYBODY THINGS THAT
THIS IS SOME KIND OF CRAZY SHOT
IN THE DARK OF A SOLUTION.
LET ME REMIND EVERYBODY THAT
CANADA HAS EMPLOYED THIS VERY
SAME SOLUTION FOR YEARS AND IS
SEEN IN THE AREAS AROUND.
THE SAFE INJECTION SITES A DROP
IN CRIME.
A DROP IN DEATHS.
A DROP IN DISEASE.
AND MANY OTHER POSITIVE RESULTS.
NOW IN LOS ANGELES AND IN MANY
OTHER PARTS OF THE STATE WHERE
WE HAVE -- DRUGS WE'VE ALSO SEEN
OUTBREAKS OF HEPATITIS AND OTHER
COMMUNICABLE DISEASES.
HAVING PEOPLE IN FACILITIES WITH
TRAINED MEDICAL PROFESSIONALS
WHICH IS WHAT THESE FACILITIES
OFFER.
IS A WAY TO RECOGNIZE AND TREAT
DISEASE BEFORE THEY BECOME AN
EPIDEMIC IN OUR ENTIRE COMMUNITY.
SO IF NOT FOR THE ADDICTS
THEMSELVES.
AND IT SHOULD BE FOR THE ADDICTS
THEMSELVES BUT IF THAT'S NOT IF
THEY'RE LIVES DON'T MEAN ENOUGH
FOR YOU. TO TAKE THIS MEASURE
THEN THINK ABOUT THE REST OF THE
COMMUNITY AND WHAT THEY'RE
BEARING WITH PEOPLE WHO ARE
LIVING ON THE STREETS AND
WITHOUT MEDICAL CARE THIS IS A
WAY TO GET PEOPLE INTO MEDICAL
TREATMENT THAT'S PROVEN AND THAT
WORKS.
AND WITH THAT I WOULD WOULD ASK
YOU TO LOOK DEEP INTO YOUR HEART
AND VOTE I ON THIS MEASURE TODAY
THANK YOU.
MISTER DAVID CHIU YOUR RECOGNIZE
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
COLLEAGUES APPRECIATE YOUR
CONSIDERATION OF A PILOT OF THE
OVERDOSE PREVENTION PROGRAM.
AND LET ME THANK OUR COLLEAGUE
FROM STOCKTON FOR HER.
LONG ADVOCACY ON THIS ISSUE --
AND AS WE JUST HEARD FROM ONE OF
OUR COLLEAGUES -- UNFORTUNATELY
AT THIS TIME THROUGH THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS -- WE HAVE
DECIDED TO JUST NARAL THIS TO
OUR CITY OF SAN FRANCISCO AND
I'M VERY APPRECIATIVE AS A
REPRESENTATIVE OF SAN FRANCISCO.
OUGHT TO HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
FOR THIS DIALOGUE.
BUT I DO HOPE THAT WE ARE ABLE
TO TEST IF IT WORKS AND IT IS
THAT NARROW -- THIS IS AN IDEA
THAT I THINK MANY OF US WHEN WE
FIRST HEAR ABOUT IT IT TAKES A
LITTLE TIME. TO UNDERSTAND IT
AND TO UNDERSTAND WHAT THE DATA
IS BUT IF YOU LOOK AROUND THE
WORLD THAT STUDIES.
ARE AROUND THE GLOBE WE HAVE
SEEN THIS WORK AND THIS IS WHY
PUBLIC HEALTH PROFESSIONALS
SUPPORTED IF YOU LOOK AT IT FROM
A FISCAL STANDPOINT THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT COULD SAVE
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
BECAUSE IT ALREADY HAS IN OTHER
JURISDICTIONS IF YOU LOOK AT IT
FROM A PUBLIC SAFETY STANDPOINT
THE REASON LAW ENFORCEMENT
SUPPORTS THIS IS A NOTE THIS IS
A DIFFERENT SOLUTION.
THAT ACTUALLY WORKS BUT IN SHORT
THERE ARE THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE
WHO ARE DYING ON THE STREETS.
IN OUR COMMUNITIES UP AND DOWN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA WHAT
WE'RE ASKING FOR THIS BILL IS TO
ALLOW FOR ONE PILOT.
IN A CITY THAT IS SEVEN BY SEVEN
SQUARE MILES TO SEE IF THIS WILL
WORK AND IF IT DOES WE CAN HAVE
A CONVERSATION ABOUT EXPANDING
IT AROUND THE STATE.
AT THE END OF THE DAY WE HAVE A
DUTY TO MAKE SURE WE'RE DOING
EVERYTHING WE CAN TO SAVE THE
LIVES OF OUR CONSTITUENTS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MISTER
MESS YOU ARE RECOGNIZED HIM AS
SPEAKER MEMBERS -- WHEN THIS
BILL WAS BROUGHT BEFORE THE
HEALTH COMMITTEE AND I FIRST SAW
THAT MY FIRST GUT INSTINCT WAS
THAT I WAS?
GOING TO VOTE NO ON THIS MEASURE
JUST LIKE SOME OF YOU IF YOU I'M
HAD READ THIS YOU'D THINK OH I
CAN'T SUPPORT THIS.
GIVE ME POLITICALLY DIFFICULT
FOR ME TO BE ABLE TO DO SO.
BUT WE KNOW THAT DRUG ADDICTION
IS A SERIOUS PROBLEM IT IS IN MY
DISTRICT AND I'LL TELL YOU THAT
I CARE AS MUCH ABOUT.
THE ADDICTS IN MY DISTRICT AS I
DO ABOUT THE ADDICTS IN THE CITY
AND COUNTY OF SAN FRANCISCO AND
THE TRUTH IS.
WHAT WE'RE DOING IS NOT WORKING
THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM IS
FAILING THESE PEOPLE THERE'S
THIS MIGHT NOT BE?
THE OVERALL ANSWER BUT FOR
GOODNESS SAKE LET'S TRY
SOMETHING ELSE I KNOW THAT MY
COLLEAGUE THE AUTHOR -- THE
MEMBER FROM A FROM STOCKTON IS
PUT A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF WORK
IN AND DO THIS I KNOW THAT THEIR
SUPPORT LOCALLY.
WITH THE CITY AND COUNTY OF SAN
FRANCISCO THAT THEY WILL BE A
SUPERVISING -- THIS -- THIS THIS
THESE PROGRAMS AND FOR THAT
REASON I'LL BE SUPPORTING THIS
MEASURE AGAIN TODAY.
THANK YOU MISS MAYES SEE NO
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THE ITEM.
DOCTOR EGGMAN YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS AND
THANK YOU ALL FOR THE
CONVERSATION I THINK.
WE'VE EVOLVED OVER THE COURSE OF
THE YEARS THAT WE'VE BEEN
TALKING ABOUT THIS WELL WE DON'T
TALK ABOUT IT WITH THE SAME
LEVEL OF THE TREE ALL.
TOWARDS THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
ADDICTS ARE THE PEOPLE WHO WANT
TO TRY TO DO SOMETHING TO HELP.
THIS IS AN ISSUE OF TREATMENT.
THIS IS AN ISSUE OF REDEMPTION
AND HOPE.
THIS IS AN ISSUE ABOUT HOW DO WE
TREAT THE LEAST OF US THAT IS
THE TRUE CALLING I THINK THAT
WE'RE ALL ALL OF US WHO FOR THE
LEAST OF US HOW CAN WE EXTEND.
THE THE GOOD CHRISTIAN LOVE ALL
SAY LIKE THAT HOW DO WE EXTEND
THAT.
AND THAT THAT THAT LOVE THAT
HOPE THAT RESPECT. TO EVERY
SINGLE PERSON.
THIS IS NOT A PERFECT BILL.
THIS HAS.
EIGHT REPORT BACK EVERY YEAR
THIS HAS A SIX YEAR SUNSET ON IT
THIS IS PART OF THE TREATMENT
CONTINUE ON THE CENTER IN SAN
FRANCISCO WHO IS SO FAR SAID
THAT THEY'RE WILLING TO DO IT IT
IS A CONTINUUM.
OF TREATMENT THIS IS ABOUT
SAVING LIVES IT'S ABOUT SAVING
MONEY.
AND IT'S ABOUT GATHERING MORE
DATA ON WHAT WE CAN ACTUALLY DO
TO ADDRESS THIS CRISIS IN A
COMPREHENSIVE WAY.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
WITHOUT THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS ARE THE START OF THE
ALL MEMBERS ARE RESERVE OF CLARK
WELL.
CLOSER ROLE TALLY THE VOTE ICE.
FORTY TWO KNOWS TWENTY ONE THAT
MEASURE PASSES.
BACK IN.
REGULAR FILE ORDER FILE ITEM.
TWO SEVENTY ONE IS AB THREE
TWENTY FOUR BY MISS AGUIAR-CURRY.
CLOCK RATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL THREE TWENTY FOUR
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER AGUIAR-CURRY
AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY THE
CHILD CARE.
IS AGUIAR-CURRY THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS SB THREE TWENTY
FOUR REQUIRES A CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION TO
DEVELOP STANDARDIZED EFFECTIVE
IN MEASURABLE GUIDELINES FOR THE
USE OF AB. TWO ONE TWO FUNDS AB
TWO WENT TO WAS A BILL FROM THE
ON OUR INNER ADOPTED IN TWO
THOUSAND THAT SET ASIDE ANNUAL
FUNDING TO IMPROVE THE RETENTION
OF CHILD CARE PROVIDERS.
AB THREE TWENTY FOUR ENSURES
THAT WE IMPLEMENT EFFECTIVE AB
TWO TO TWELVE FUNDING GUIDELINES
BY EXPANDING ELIGIBILITY MAKING
HIGHER EDUCATION STIPENDS MORE
INTENTIONAL AND INTEGRATING
STIPENDS INTO THE STATE WIDE
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT SYSTEM.
THIS BILL IS ENJOYED UNANIMOUS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT I ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS AGUIAR-CURRY
SENIOR DISCUSSION DEBATE CLERK
WILL OFFER THE ROLE.
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS
BUT RESERVE A ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL CLOSER ROLL TIDE
ABOUT AYE SIXTY NO.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
THERE IS WE ARE FILE I'M TWO
SEVENTY TWO AB THREE THIRTY
THREE BY DR EGGMAN.
CORPORATION ASSEMBLY BILL THREE
THIRTY THREE BY SOME REMEMBER
EGGMAN AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY
TO EMPLOYMENT.
DOCTOR EGGMAN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR SPEAKER
MEMBERS A SIMPLE LITTLE BILL.
EXTENDING WHISTLEBLOWER
PROTECTION IN CURRENT LAW TO
PATIENT RIGHTS ADVOCATES.
WITH THIS BILL WE ARE ADVOCATING
THOSE FOR THOSE WHO ADVOCATE FOR
OTHERS AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU DOCTOR EGGMAN SEE NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THIS ITEM.
LOCAL OF THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THESE ARE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTED AS ART OF THE ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
WORK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE OF A I SIXTY
FIVE NO.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES FILE
ITEM TO SEVENTY THREE IS AB.
THREE THIRTY SEVEN ASSEMBLY BILL
THREE THIRTY SEVEN BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER QUIRK SILVA AND OTHERS
AND EXPLAIN TO FOSTER CARE.
THIS QUIRK SILVA.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS --
TODAY I'D WANT TO PRESENT TO YOU
AB.
THREE THIRTY SEVEN A FOSTER
YOUTH STABILITY.
LADIES AND GENTLEMAN THIS WEEK
WE HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO BRING
YOUTH FROM THE CALIFORNIA YOUTH
CONNECTION TO SHADOW US AS
FORMER FOSTER YOU.
AND I WAS PLEASED TO HAVE JANET
GENESIS FROM.
STATE FULLERTON SHADOW ME ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT THEY TALKED
ABOUT IS THE DIFFICULTIES THAT
THEY GO THROUGH AS FOSTER
STUDENTS SHE'S NOW IN COLLEGE
SHE'S IN OUR LAST YEAR OF
COLLEGE.
EARNING A COMMUNICATIONS DEGREE
AND I'M SO PROUD OF HER BUT ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT SHE SAID THAT
SHE HAS GONE THROUGH AND OTHER
FOSTER.
STUDENTS.
ALL ARE BEING REMOVED FROM
HOUSING AND PLACED IN OTHER HOME
AND HOME PLACEMENTS MANY MANY
TIMES THIS BILL WOULD SIMPLY SAY
IF THE YOUTH IS CHANGE FROM A
PLACEMENT.
THAT THEY COULD HAVE THE OPTION
TO REMAIN AT THE SCHOOL OF A
REGION THIS SCHOOL OVER REGION
FOR MANY IS SOMETIMES THE
STABILITY THAT THEY HAVE WITH
BUILDING RELATIONSHIPS WITH NOT
ONLY OTHER.
APPEARS BUT THEIR TEACHERS IT'S
AN IMPORTANT BILL AND IT MEANS A
LOT TO OUR CALIFORNIA YOUTH
CONNECTION.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
THANK MAYES QUIRK SILVA SAYING
NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
[inaudible]
CLARK LIBERAL.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL CLOSE YOUR ROLL TIDE
ABOUT AYE SIXTY ONE NO.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES FILE
ITEM.
TO SEVENTY FOUR IS AB THREE
THIRTY EIGHT BY MISTER KANSEN
CHU.
REYES ASSEMBLY BILL THREE THIRTY
EIGHT BY SOMETHING MEMBER KANSEN
CHU AND OTHERS AND I PLAN TO
MANUFACTURED HOUSING.
MR SHOW.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER IS SAM
MEMBERS AB THREE THREE EIGHT
UPDATES EXISTING SMOKE DETECTORS
SANDERS.
BY REQUIRING LISTED THE STATE
FIRE MARSHAL SMOKE DETECTORS BE
PRESENT UPON LEASING OR SALE.
OF A MOBILE HOME OR
MANUFACTURING HOME. TO IMPROVE
**** STUDIO SO CRITICAL AS A
SAFETY MATERIALS THE BILL ALSO
REQUIRED THE DEPARTMENT OF
HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT. TO TRANSLATE
EXISTING MOBILE HOME PARK
EMERGENCY PREPAREDNESS PLAN.
IN TOOL COMMONLY SPOKEN LANGUAGE
IN EACH COUNTY UNDER THIS BILL
PARK OWNERS WILL MAKE TO
TRANSLATE THE PLAN AVAILABLE
WITH THE ENGLISH VERSION AND
NOTIFIED RESIDENTS ONCE A YEAR.
THAT THESE MATERIALS ARE
AVAILABLE TO THEM.
THIS BILL WILL SAVE LIVES AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR RIVAL.
THANK YOU MISS.
TO SEE NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON
THE ITEM.
CLUB CLUB THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE VOTE ON
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO
VOTE [inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ALL TIED UP.
I FORTY SIX KNOWS.
TEN THAT MEASURE PASSES FILE
ITEM. TWO SEVENTY FIVE IS AB
THREE FORTY CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL THREE FORTY BY
SELLING MEMBER IRWIN AND OTHERS
AND ACTUALLY FARMS RESERVE WHEN
YOU MAY OPEN THANK YOU I RISE
TODAY TO PRESENT AB THREE FORTY
AN INNOVATIVE APPROACH TO REDUCE
THE BACKLOG OF ARMED PROHIBITED
POSSESSORS IN CALIFORNIA.
BY CREATING A PILOT PROGRAM IN
VENTURA COUNTY I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR I'VE A THANK YOU MISTER
WHEN SEEING THEIR DISCUSSION
DEBATE.
CLARK WELL OVER THERE ALL.
ON MEMBERS OTHERS ARE TO VOTE.
ON MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO VOTE
ALL MEMBERS SO BIZARRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE BUT I FIFTY FOUR
NO.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM TWO SEVENTY SIX IS AB
THREE FIVE SEVEN BY MISTER
NAZARIAN COOKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL THREE FIFTY SEVEN
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER NAZARIAN AND
ACTUALLY TO TAXATION MISTER
NAZARIAN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
THIS IS A. B. THREE FIFTY SEVEN
IS A TECHNICAL BILL DEALING WITH
THE STATUE OF LIMITATIONS OF
TWENTY YEARS FOR THE FRANCHISE
TAX BOARD TO COLLECT ON AN
OUTSTANDING.
TAX LIABILITY THIS BILL WILL
CLARIFY FOR THE F. T. B. THAT
THE TWENTY YEAR STATUTE OF
LIMITATION WOULD START BASED ON
THE ASSESSMENT DATE OF A TAX
LIABILITY.
IF NEW ASSOCIATED LIABILITIES
ARE INCURRED SUCH AS A LEAN OR
FEET -- THEY WOULD BE SUBJECT TO
THE SAME TWENTY YEAR STATUTE OF
LIMITATION BASED OFF OF THE
ASSESSMENT DATE OF THE ORIGINAL
TAX LIABILITY.
AB THREE FIFTY SEVEN WILL ENSURE
THAT THE FRANCHISE TAX BOARD
MAINTAINS THE ABILITY TO COLLECT
DEBTS BUT PROTECTS TAXPAYERS
FROM OVER BURDENSOME LIABILITIES
THAT CURRENTLY.
CAN BE WITH THEM UNTIL THEIR
DEATH THIS BILL HAS ENJOYED
UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOU I
VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTRESS ERIN SEE NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CLARK WILL OF THE ROLE.
VOTERS ARE VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF THE DESIRED ABOUT.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE OF WHAT I SIXTY
FOUR NO.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
A PAST RETAIN A FOLLOW ON TO
SEVENTY SEVEN FILE ITEM TWO
SEVENTY EIGHT IS AB THREE EIGHTY
EIGHT BY MS LEMOND.
OPERATE.
A SOME REAL THREE EIGHTY EIGHT
BY SOMETHING MEMBER LIMóN AND
OTHERS AND EXPLAIN TO
ALZHEIMER'S DISEASE AS LONG.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER TODAY
OVER TWO POINT THREE MILLION
CALIFORNIANS ARE LIVING WITH OR
CARING FOR A LOVED ONE WITH
ALZHEIMER'S.
LESS THAN HALF OF ALL
CALIFORNIANS AFFECTED.
HAVE BEEN FORMALLY DIAGNOSED BY
A CLINICIAN.
ALTHOUGH THE ONSET OF
ALZHEIMER'S CANNOT YET BE
STOPPER RIVERS EARLY DETECTION
AND DIAGNOSIS CAN MAKE IT EASIER
FOR PATIENTS AND THEIR FAMILIES
TO MANAGE THE DISEASE.
AB THREE EIGHT WILL PROMOTE
PARTNERSHIPS WITH LOCAL
ORGANIZATIONS AND STATE
RESOURCES AND MAKE SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENTS IN PILOT PROGRAMS TO
ENCOURAGE.
ENCOURAGE EARLY DETECTION AND
DIAGNOSIS.
IT'S MEASURE ALSO ENCOURAGES
IMMEDIATE ACTION ON THE KEY
RECOMMENDATIONS WITH THE CENTERS
FOR DISEASE CONTROL HEALTHY
BRAIN INITIATIVE.
IT'S TIME CALIFORNIA INVEST NOT
ONLY REDUCING THE COST OF
ALZHEIMER'S BUT TAKE ACTIVE
STEPS IN IMPROVING PATIENT
OUTCOMES.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
THANK MISS AMOUNT MISTER
RODRIGUEZ HERE RECOGNIZED.
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS TODAY
ALSO RISE.
IN SRONG SUPPORT FOR A BI THREE
EIGHTY EIGHT AND THOSE LIVING
WITH ALZHEIMER'S.
ALZHEIMER'S IMPACTS MILLIONS OF
LIVES THROUGHOUT OUR STATE.
AND THOUGH IT CANNOT BE CURED
EARLY DETECTION CAN ONLY HELP
THE PATIENT BUT THE LOVE ONES AS
WELL.
IT IS TIME TO RAISE PUBLIC
AWARENESS FOR IMPROVING HEALTH
OUTCOMES.
AND ENSURING ACCESS TO
BENEFICIAL INTERVIEW AND
INTERVENTIONS.
AS MANY OF YOU KNOW FOR THE LAST
SEVERAL YEARS I CARE FOR BOTH OF
MY PARENTS AS THE AGE.
THIS WAS NOT EASY AND I TRULY
APPRECIATE ALL THOSE FAMILIES
AND OUR COMMUNITIES WHO ALSO
MAKE THOSE SACRIFICES.
IN PARTICULAR THIS MAJOR HITS
HOME BECAUSE MY FATHER WAS
DIAGNOSED WITH ALZHEIMER'S.
AND MY MOTHER WITH DEMENTIA LIKE
MANY CALIFORNIANS WHAT WE CANNOT
GET THESE YEARS BACK.
IT IS IMPORTANT THAT WE MAKE
PROGRESS IN AWARENESS FOR FUTRE
GENERATIONS.
I WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THIS MEASURE FORT NURSE
BUCKLEY OPTION FOR AN AYE VOTE
ON A. B..
THREE EIGHTY EIGHT THANK YOU
MISTER RODRIGUEZ SAY NO
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THE ITEM.
CLARK LIBERAL.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE YOUR ROLL TIDE ABOUT AYE
SIXTY ONE NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES FILE ITEM TO SEVENTY NINE
ZB.
THREE NINETY SEVEN HARPER READ A
SAMPLE THREE NINETY SEVEN BY
SOME NUMBER CHAO AND OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY TO DRIVING UNDER THE
INFLUENCE.
MR TROUT.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS SO AB THREE NINETY SEVEN
IT WILL REQUIRE LAW ENFORCEMENT
ENTITIES BEGINNING IN JANUARY.
TWENTY TWENTY TWO TO ANNUALLY
REPORT TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE DATA RELATING TO ARREST
FOR DRIVING UNDER THE INFLUENCE
OF CANNABIS.
OTHER STATES THAT LEGALIZE
CANNABIS WITNESS INCREASES IN
FATAL ACCIDENTS INVOLVING
INDIVIDUALSDRIVING UNDER THE
INFLUENCE OF CANNABIS.
THE LEGALIZATION HERE IN
CALIFORNIA WILL LIKELY
CONTRIBUTE TO THE RISE OF
IMPAIRED DRIVING AS WELL.
WHILE LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE
INDEPENDENTLY KEEP STATISTICS ON
CANNABIS RELATED THE U. R.
ARRESTS.
OUR STATE HAS NO UNIFORM
MECHANISM IN PLACE TO EVALUATE
CANNABIS DRUG DRIVING ARREST.
AB THREE NINETY SEVEN WILL ALLOW
THE STATE TO HAVE ACCURATE AND
RELIABLE DATA OF HOW MANY
CANNABIS DO YOU EYES OCCUR.
IN THE STATE ANNUALLY WHICH WILL
BE HELPFUL IN FORMULATING
POLICIES AROUND CANNABIS THE WHY.
AS WE TRANSITION INTO THE
LEGALIZE CANNABIS MARKET.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE [inaudible]
THANK.
THANK MICHELLE.
SEE NO DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CAR CLUB OF THE ROLE.
ON MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF THE
ALL MEMBERS OTHERS ARE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
PARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE BUT I SIXTY ONE
KNOWS.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
WE'RE GOING TO PASS TEMPORARILY.
ON FILE ITEM.
TWO EIGHTY PASS AND RETAIN ON
TWO EIGHTY ONE AND TWO EIGHTY
TWO WITH THAT BRINGS US TO FILE
ITEM.
TWO EIGHTY THREE EIGHTY FOUR
TWENTY SIX ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR
TWENTY SIX BY SOME REMEMBER
MAIENSCHEIN AND ACTUALLY THE
PUBLIC SOCIAL SERVICES.
MR MAIENSCHEIN THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS IN TWENTY
ELEVEN THE LEGISLATURE ENACTED A
REQUIREMENT THAT I HSS
APPLICANTS SUBMIT A STATEMENT
FROM A MEDICAL PROFESSIONAL THAT
THEY NEED IN HOME SUPPORTIVE
SERVICES.
UNFORTUNATELY THIS REQUIREMENT
IS ACTED AS A BARRIER TO
ADEQUATE TO APPLICANTS AS
DOCTORS CHARGE UP TO A HUNDRED
DOLLARS TO COMPLETE THE FORM.
THE FORM IS CONSIDERED AS ONE
INDICATOR OF THE INDIVIDUALS
NEED -- FOR AYE HSS AND NOT THE
SOLE DETERMINING FACTOR AB FOR
TWENTY SIX REPEAL THE
REQUIREMENT FROM CURRENT LAW
REQUIRING THE COMPLETION.
OF THIS EXTRA FORM THANK YOU I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AND I ABOUT.
THINGS MAIENSCHEIN SEEN NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE
[inaudible]
CEREMONY.
ALL MEMBERS OTHERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLICK WELL CLOSER ROLL TIDE
ABOUT ICE FIFTY ONE KNOWS.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES FILE
AND TWO EIGHTY FOUR IS ABFOR
FIFTY FOUR BY MISTER KALRA
CORPORATION.
ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR FIFTY FOUR BY
FAMILY MEMBER KALRA AND ACTUALLY
THE MIGRATORY BIRDS.
MISTER KALRA.
THANK THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS THE OPTION PRESENT AB
FOR FIFTY FOUR BUT JUST DRESS IS
A DANGEROUS LUPONE CALIFORNIA'S
WILDLIFE PROTECTION LAW.
THE MOST RECENT AMENDMENTS TO AB
FORTY FOUR REMOVE OPPOSITION
FROM GROUPS REPRESENTING
AGRICULTURE AND TIMBER HRVEST.
CAL CHAMBER AS WELL AS THE
WESTERN STATES PETROLEUM
ASSOCIATION THEY WILL ALL BE
MOVING OPPOSITION.
AS WE SEE WITH OTHER
ENVIRONMENTAL ISSUES A GREAT
IMPORTANCE CLEAN WATER CLEAN AIR
ENDANGERED SPECIES OFFICER OIL.
ATTEMPTS TO DISMANTLE FEDERAL
LAWS AND STANDARDS BUT
CALIFORNIA THE CHALLENGING
POSITION OF HAVING TO SECURE
PROTECTION FAR RESOURCES AND
ENVIRONMENT. FOR OVER A HUNDRED
YEARS THE FEDERAL MIGRATORY BIRD
TREATY ACT OR MBTA HAS BEEN THE
PRIMARY PROTECTIVE LAW FOR BIRDS
ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
AND FOR SEVERAL DECADES IT HAS
BEEN ADMINISTERED BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TO PROHIBIT
INCIDENTAL TAKE OR THE
UNINTENTIONAL BUT FORESEEABLE
KILLING OF MIGRATORY BIRDS
DURING OTHERWISE LEGAL
ACTIVITIES.
THE MBTA IS CREDITED WITH
HELPING CONSERVE HUNDREDS OF
BIRD SPECIES AND PROVIDE THE
BASIS RECOVERING NATURAL
RESOURCE DAMAGES FROM EVENTS
LIKE THE COSCO BUSAN SPILL IN
THE SAN FRANCISCO BAY.
IT ALSO IS INCENTIVIZE
INDUSTRIES WHOSE ACTIVITIES KILL
BIRDS TO DEVELOP METHODS TO
AVOID AND MINIMIZE OUR IMPACTS.
HOWEVER IN LATE TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION ISSUED A LEGAL
OPINION THAT RIVERS DECADES OF
BIPARTISAN GOVERNMENT POLICY AND
PRACTICE ON THE IMPLEMENTATION
AND FOR SOME OF THE MBTA.
LAST NOVEMBER THE CALIFORNIA
ATTORNEY GENERAL THE DIRECTOR
THE DEPARTMENT FISH AND WILDLIFE
IT'S A LEGAL ADVISORY
REAFFIRMING CALIFORNIA'S STATE
LAW PROTECTION FOR BIRDS AS A IN
THAT STATE LAW PROHIBITS
INCIDENTAL TAKE.
AB FOR FIFTY FOUR WILL ALLOW
CALIFORNIA TO CONTINUE TO
PROTECT BIRDS WHILE PROVIDING
CERTAINTY FOR INDUSTRIES WITHOUT
STARVING ECONOMIC GROWTH OR
RENEWABLE ENERGY GOALS AVOIDING
THE CONFLICTS AND LITIGATION
THAT SURROUND MBTA TODAY.
ASSEMBLY BILL FORTY FOUR SIMPLY
MAKE SURE THAT CALIFORNIA
RETAINS AUTHORITY TO MAKE ITS
OWN RULES REGARDING MIGRATORY
BIRD PROTECTIONS IT ALL OUT
CALIFORNIA MANAGES
CONSTITUTIONAL PUBLIC TRUST
RESPONSIBLY.
UP A TRUCK PUBLIC RESPONSE TO
PROTECT VULNERABLE WILDLIFE.
AND VITAL HABITATS WITHOUT A
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER KALRA.
SAYING NO MEMBERS SEEKING
RECOGNITION.
OR CALL THE ROLL.
THESE ARE VOTE ON MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE THE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT
OF THOSE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE NO DESIRE TO
VOTE [inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE BUT I'D FORTY
FIVE KNOWS.
EIGHTEEN THAT MEASURE PASSES
FILE ITEM TWO EIGHTY FIVE IS AB
FOR SEVENTY NINE CLERK WILL READ.
AS LEGAL FOR SEVENTY NINE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER NAZARIAN AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY TO SCHOOL
MEALS.
MISTRESS AREA.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER THROUGH
AB FOR SEVENTY NINE K. THROUGH
TWELVE PUBLIC SCHOOLS WILL
RECEIVE ADDITIONAL STATE FUNDING.
TO SUPPORT SERVING PLANT BASED
FOOD AND BEVERAGE CHOICES.
THE BILL WILL ALSO PROVIDE
CRITICAL SUPPORT FOR STAFF
TRAINING STUDENT ENGAGEMENT --
RECIPE DEVELOPMENT AND OTHER
ASSISTANCE NEEDED TO HELP
SCHOOLS SUCCESSFULLY SERVE PLANT
BASED OPTIONS THIS BILL
ULTIMATELY WILL ACCOMPLISH THE
FOLLOWING ONE ASSISTS SCHOOLS TO
EXPAND THEIR AVAILABLE FOOD AND
BEVERAGE CHOICES. TO IMPROVE
ACCESS TO HEALTHY PLANT BASED
OPTIONS FOR LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES AND THREE
ACCOMMODATE STUDENTS WITH
RELIGIOUS AND CULTURAL NEEDS TO
BE CLEAR A BEFORE SEVENTY NINE
DOES NOT TELL SCHOOLS. TO STOP
SERVING MEAT OR DAIRY A BEFORE
SEVEN NINE WILL SIMPLY EMPOWER
OUR SCHOOLS TO RE THINK THE FOOD
THEY OFFERED TO SUPPORT A
BALANCED DIET.
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
VERY AYE VOTE -- AND I'M JOINED
BY MY WONDERFUL COCOA.
A CO AUTHOR.
FROM THE BAY AREA.
THANK YOU MISSION SERVICE CALL
ROUGH YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK
YOU SPEAKER MEMBERS WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR -- I PROBABLY
JOINT IS A JOINT AUTHOR ON THIS
BILL I THINK -- IT MAKES A LOT
OF SENSE I THINK IT'S GREAT THAT
WE'RE OFFERING INCENTIVES FOR
SCHOOLS -- TO MOVE FORWARD IN A
MUCH TO ALLOW FOR MUCH HEALTHIER
OPTIONS -- FOR OUR STUDENTS I
THINK THE SCHOOL NUTRITION IS
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT IT ALWAYS --
FUNDED ANOTHER'S LEATHERS --
GOING TO BE -- OPPORTUNITIES NOT
JUST FUND INCENTIVES BUT TO
REALLY MOVE SCHOOLS IN A
DIRECTION THAT'S POSITIVE WE
KNOW THE SCHOOLS WANT TO DO IT.
I THINK THIS WILL HELP THE MOVE
IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION WITH THAT
ASPECT YES FROM ABOUT.
THANK YOU MISTER KALRA SAYING NO
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION ON THE
ADAM.
CAR CLUB RURAL.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTE.
IT IS AT A VOTE [inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ON TIED ABOUT EYES FORTY
SIX DOES.
ELEVEN THE MEASURE PASSES.
PASS RETAIL FILE ITEM TWO EIGHTY
SIX FILE ITEM.
TWO EIGHTY SEVEN IS AB FIVE
TWELVE BY MR TANG.
SAYS MR TANK CORPORATION.
ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE TWELVE BY
SOME MEMBER TING AND OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY MEDI CAL.
WE SHOULD TAKE THE MAIL.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
CURRENTLY UNDER EXISTING LAW
UNDER THE FEDERAL PATIENT
PROTECTION AND AFFORDABLE CARE
ACT.
THE REQUIREMENTS FOR NEARLY ALL
HEALTH PLANS TO PROVIDE MENTAL
HEALTH CARE. FOR THEIR MEMBERS.
AND ALTHOUGH THERE HAS BEEN
TREMENDOUS GAINS IN MENTAL
HEALTH CARE COMMUNITIES OF COLOR
STILL FAR FAR BEHIND.
THE SO OUR BILL EXPANDS
INFORMATION COLLECTED REPORTED
AT THE END UTILIZED IN CULTURAL
COMPETENCY PLANS FOR COUNTY
MENTAL HEALTH CARE PROGRAMS.
IN ADDITION TO CREATE A LOCAL
COUNTY COMMITTEE FOR COMMUNITIES
TO ENGAGE AND GIVE THEIR INPUT
ON HOW TO IMPROVE ACCESS --
WHILE WE'VE MADE GREAT STRIDES
IN THIS AREA AND FORTUNE
COMMUTES THE COLOR HAS BEEN SOME
OF THE LAST TO ACTUALLY GO REACH
OUT AND GET MENTAL HEALTH CARE.
SO WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AYE BOTH FOR AB.
FIVE TWELVE THANK YOU MISTER
TANG SEE NO DISCUSSION DEBATE
[inaudible]
GLOBAL ROLE.
SORRY ABOUT ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
WELL.
CLOSER ALL.
TIED ABOUT ICE.
FIFTY KNOWS.
ONE THAT MEASURE PASSES.
FIRE ALARM TO EIGHTY EIGHT IS AB
FIVE FIFTEEN CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE FIFTEEN BY
SOME REMEMBER MATHIS AND
ACTUALLY MEDI CAL.
THIS MATHIS THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS AB.
FIVE FIFTEEN IS A BILL THAT IS
DESIGNED FOR OUR PROVIDERS --
THAT DEAL WITH MEDI CAL.
AND WHAT'S HAPPENING HERE IS THE
STATE.
OFTENTIMES WITH THE
REIMBURSEMENTS.
OVER PAYS THEM AND THEN CHARGES
THEM AN EXTREME AMOUNT OF
INTEREST. FOR THEM TO THEN REPAY
THE STATE FOR THEIR MISTAKE.
THIS BILL FIXES THAT AND LOWERS
THOSE INTEREST RATES WHICH HELPS
KEEP OUR MEDICAL PROVIDERS OPEN
AND KEEPS OUR CLINICS OPEN TO
PROVIDE ACCESS TO CARE.
MEMBERS I ASK YOU FOR AN AYE
VOTE THANK YOU.
THEY WAS MATHIS SENIOR
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CLUB CLUB THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS OTHERS ARE VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO THE ALL MEMBERS
VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLICK WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE BUT I
SIXTY ONE NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
THIS IS FILE ITEM TO EIGHTY NINE
AB.
FIVE EIGHTEEN ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE
EIGHTEEN BY THE COMMITTEE ON
ACCOUNTABILITY AND
ADMINISTRATIVE REVIEW AND
ACTUALLY IN STATE GOVERNMENT.
THIS PETRIE-NORRIS THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS TODAY I
RISE AS THE CHAIR OF THE
ASSEMBLY IS ACCOUNTABILITY AND
ADMINISTRATIVE REVIEW COMMITTEE.
I THE PURPOSE OF THIS COMMITTEE
BELL IS TO ELIMINATE -- SEVEN
UNNECESSARY FINANCIAL REPORTING
WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH THE
STATE COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE ON
THIS SPELL.
ON EIGHTY FIVE EIGHTEEN REPEALS
THE ANNUAL REPORTING REQUIREMENT
UNDER THE ACCOUNT RECEIVABLES
MANAGEMENT ACT AT ONE POINT
THESE ANNUAL REPORTS WERE USED
BY THE STATE COMPTROLLER'S
OFFICE TO COMPILE STATEWIDE
REPORTS. FIVE YEARS THEY HAVE
NOT BEEN USED FOR ANYTHING.
I ACCORDING TO THE STATE
COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE THERE'S
ABSOLUTELY NO PURPOSE FOR
AGENCIES TO CONTINUE COMPLETING
THESE REPORTS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE.
ON THIS CLEAN UP BILL.
THANK MISS BETWEEN HOURS SAYING
NO DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CLUB CLUB ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE VOTE ON
MEMBERS VOTERS THERE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS ARE IS AT ABOUT.
WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE BUT I SIXTY
FIVE NO.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES FILE
ITEM TO NINETY IS AB FIVE TWENTY
SIX CLICK READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE TWENTY SIX BY
SOME REMEMBER PETRIE-NORRIS AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY MEDI CAL WAS
PETRIE-NORRIS YOU MAKE AN OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
TODAY I RISE TO ASK YOUR SUPPORT
FOR EIGHTY FIVE TWENTY SIX THIS
BILL RICK WILL CREATE AN
EXPEDITED ENROLLMENT PATHWAY.
FOR MEDI CAL FROM THE SPECIAL
SUPPLEMENTAL NUTRITION PROGRAM
FOR WOMEN INFANTS AND CHILDREN
COMMONLY KNOWN AS WET.
THIS CLOSES A CRITICAL HEALTH
CARE COVERAGE GAP FOR SOME OF
OUR MOST VULNERABLE CALIFORNIANS
THE ELIGIBILITY CRITERIA FOR FOR
WEEK AND FOR MEDI CAL.
ARE ALMOST THE SAME DESPITE THAT
THERE ARE EIGHTY THOUSAND
INFANTS AND CHILDREN IN
CALIFORNIA WHO QUALIFY FOR MEDI
CAL THAT ARE CURRENTLY NOT
ENROLLED IN RECEIVING HEALTH
CARE COVERAGE.
CLOSING THIS COVERAGE GAP IS
BOTH THE RIGHT THING TO DO AND
IT'S ALSO THE SMART THING TO DO
BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT.
HEALTH CARE AT THIS CRITICAL
STAGE IMPROVES LONG TERM
OUTCOMES AND REDUCES LONG TERM
COSTS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE THAT.
THANK MISS PEACH NORRIS.
SEEING -- MEMBERS SEEKING
RECOGNITION ON THE ITEM.
CLARK WELL FOR THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRED ABOUT.
ALL MEMBERS OTHERS AT ABOUT.
CLICK WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE BUT I
SIXTY SIX NO.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
FILE I'M TO NINETY ONE IS AB
FIVE THIRTY ONE BY MISS FRIEDMAN
CORPORATION.
ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE THIRTY ONE BY
SOME THE MEMBER FRIEDMAN AND
ACTUALLY THE FOSTER YOUTH.
MS FRIEDMAN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
FOSTER YOUTH ARE SOME OF OUR
MOST CHALLENGING VULNERABLE
POPULATION IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
THESE KIDS GO THROUGH SO MUCH
AND HAVE TO OVERCOME SO MUCH
JUST TO HAVE THE OPPORTUNITIES
THAT EVERYBODY ELSE HAS.
NOW WE CREATED IN TWO THOUSAND
TEN THE EXCITED FOSTER YOUTH
PROGRAM WHICH HAS BEEN A BIG
THIS TAX WHEN IT COMES TO
EDUCATION AND EMPLOYMENT.
BUT WHEN OF FOSTER YOUTH
EMANCIPATE OUT OF THE SYSTEM WE
KNOW THAT OVER 35% OF THEM
REPORT HOMELESSNESS 35%.
AND THESE ARE OUR KIDS THESE ARE
USUALLY CHILDREN AND YOUNG
PEOPLE WHO DON'T HAVE OTHER
FAMILY MEMBERS THAT THEY CAN
RELY ON TO HELP THEM WITH
HOUSING.
SO WHEN THEY COME OUT OF THE
FOSTER CARE SYSTEM UNPREPARED TO
FIND THEIR OWN HOUSING.
THEY SUFFER OFTEN END UP.
IN PRISON.
OR ON THE STREETS AND WE ALL
SUFFER AS A RESULT.
AB FIVE THIRTY ONE HAS WORKED
WITH THE FOSTER CARE ADVOCATES A
COME UP WITH A VERY.
CLEAR AND DEFINED WAY OF TRYING
TO HELP THESE YOUNG PEOPLE FROM
BEING HOMELESS.
IT CREATES A HOUSING NAVIGATORS
AT THE COUNTY LEVEL STREAMLINED
AND RESTRUCTURED THE
ADMINISTRATIVE PROCESS FOR
APPROVED HOUSING PROVIDERS AND
PAYMENTS.
AND DEVELOP CAPACITY TO MEET THE
A MEETING MEDIAN HOUSING NEEDS
OF YOUNG PEOPLE.
THE ADVOCATES BELIEVE THAT THIS
IS A STRONG ATTEMPT -- TO
ALLEVIATE THIS PROBLEM AND GET
THE SUPPORT THAT THESE CHILDREN
DESERVE TO THEM.
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE TODAY.
FAMOUS FRIEDMAN.
SINGER DISCUSSION DEBATE
[inaudible]
CORPS CORPORAL.
THESE ARE VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLICK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT AYE AYES
SIXTY FOUR NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
FILE ITEM TO NINETY TWO IS AB
FIVE SEVENTY TWO QUICK READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE SEVENTY TWO
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER KALRA AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY THE PUBLIC
CONTRACTS.
MISTER KALRA.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS FROM.
THE BIRDS TO THE TREES ASSEMBLY
BILL FIVE SEVENTY TWO THE
CALIFORNIA DEFORESTATION FREE
PICK HERMAN ACT.
REQUIRES STATE PROCUREMENT
CONTRACTS OF FOREST WAS
COMMODITIES LIKE PALM OIL SOY
CATTLE RUBBER APPALLED ENTERED A
RENEWED ON OR AFTER JANUARY
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY TWO TO
CERTIFY THAT THEIR OPERATIONS
AND THEIR SUPPLY CHAINS ARE NOT
CONTRIBUTING. TO TROPICAL
DEFORESTATION.
TROPICAL DEFORESTATION IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR A SIGNIFICANT
PORTION OF GLOBAL GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS THAT CAUSE CLIMATE
CHANGE AS WELL AS WIDE RANGING
IMPACTS ON BIODIVERSITY.
AND HUMAN RIGHTS.
AB BY SUBMIT TO A SEARCH OUR
CALIFORNIA VALUES AND EXTENDS
ENVIRONMENT LEADERSHIP TO THE
PROTECTION OF TROPICAL FORCING A
POWERFUL SIGNAL TO GLOBAL
MARKETS THAT ILLEGAL AND
DESTRUCTIVE COMMODITY DRIVEN
DEFORESTATION WILL NO LONGER BE
TOLERATED.
AB BY SOMEBODY TO IS NOT
DISSIMILAR TO WAYS TGS CERTIFIES
CONTRACTORS ARE NOT ENGAGING IN
CERTAIN BEHAVIORS.
AND THE BILL IS MODELED AFTER AN
EXISTING PROCUREMENT BAN AGAINST
CHILD LABOR THE STATE HAS HAD IN
PRACTICE FOR MANY YEARS.
I'M WORKING WITH OPPOSITION
MEMBERS TO BE TAKEN IN THE
SENATE TO ADDRESS THE BILL'S
APPLICATION TO PUBLIC WORKS
PROJECTS AND WITH THAT AT
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THERE WAS KALRA MISTER BLOOM
YOUR RECOGNIZE THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER TROPICAL DEFORESTATION
NOT ONLY HARMS BIODIVERSITY AND
ECOSYSTEMS IT ALSO INCREASES THE
GREENHOUSE GAS.
IN OUR ATMOSPHERE AND IT
JEOPARDIZES THE RIGHTS AND
LIVELIHOODS OF MANY INDIGENOUS
COMMUNITIES WHO LIVE ON FORESTED
LANDS.
CLIMATE CHANGE IS TRULY A GLOBAL
PROBLEM THIS BILL ALLOWS US TO
HAVE AN IMPACT ON ENVIRONMENTAL
POLICIES OUTSIDE THE BORDERS OF
OUR STATE.
A MOLECULE OF CARBON.
GOES WHERE IT WANTS TO GO.
SAID THIS IS REALLY A GLOBAL
PROBLEM AND I WANT TO THANK THE
MEMBER FROM SAN JOSE FOR BRING
THIS MEASURE FORWARD.
I'M PROUD TO BE A CO AUTHOR AN
ESSENTIAL JOIN ME IN SUPPORTING
THE BILL.
THERE'S ONE SCENE -- ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSION OF THE ITEM CARPOOL
OF THE ROLE.
WE DESIRE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE OF THE ALL MEMBERS
VOTE [inaudible]
DESIRABLE.
QUIRK WELL.
CLOSER ALL TIE VOTE ICE FORTY
FIVE KNOWS FIFTEEN THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
FILE ITEM TO NINETY THREE IS AB
FIVE NINETY FOUR BY MISTER CELIS.
ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE NINETY FOUR
BY FAMILY MEMBER SALAS AND
ACTUALLY IN ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE.
MR SALAS YOU MAIL.
THANK YOU MISS FIGURES.
MISTER SPEAKER AND ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE
NINETY FOUR WOULD ESTABLISH A
CHIEF ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE
OFFICER WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT OF
TECHNOLOGY RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER CELIS SEEN NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
WELL OVER THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO
VOTE ON MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO
VOTE [inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ALL TALLY OF A AYE SIXTY
ONE NO.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
WE ARE GOING.
TO HACER RETAIN A FILE ITEM.
TO NINETY FOUR THAT BRINGS US
FILE ITEM.
TO NINETY FIVE SB.
SIX FOURTEEN KERKORIAN.
ASSEMBLY BILL SIX FOURTEEN BY
SOME NEW MEMBER EIGHT MEN AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY TO TAXATION
TO TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY TAX
LEVY.
DOCTORATE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS -- TODAY I RISE
TO PRESENT AB SIX FOURTEEN THE
FARM TO FOOD BANK TAX CREDIT.
HUNGER IS AN ISSUE THAT TOUCHES
EVERY COUNTY IN CALIFORNIA WITH
YOU LIVE IN A MAJOR URBAN AREA
OR IN RURAL AGRICULTURAL LAND
FINDING HEALTHY AND AFFORDABLE
FOOD.
IS A STATE WIDE ISSUE.
CALIFORNIA HAS OVER SIX MILLION
PEOPLE WHO ARE OVER WHO ARE FOOD
INSECURE.
AND AT THE WELL THE SAME TIME WE
THROW AWAY ALMOST SIX MILLION
TONS OF FOOD PER YEAR.
IN ECONOMY AND STATE AS BIG AS
OURS WASTING RESOURCES WHEN SO
MANY.
ARE HUNGRY IS INEXCUSABLE.
THE EXISTING TAX CREDIT ONLY
APPLIES TO FRESH FRUITS AND
VEGETABLES WELL THIS IS HELPFUL
WE KNOW THAT PANTRY STAPLE FOOD
ARE ALSO IN HIGH DEMAND AND OUR
FOOD BANKS.
THIS BILL WOULD ADD CALIFORNIA
GROWN AND PRODUCED ITEMS SUCH AS
NUTS BEANS MEAT AND DAIRY.
THE LIST OF ITEMS ELIGIBLE UNDER
THE FARM TO FOOD BANKS TAX
CREDIT.
AB SIX FOURTEEN IS ONE ANSWER TO
TO RELATED ISSUES IT REDUCES THE
AMOUNT OF FOOD WASTE PILING UP
IN OUR LANDFILLS AND INCREASES
ACCESS TO FRESH AND HEALTHY FOOD
FOR FOOD IN SECURE FAMILIES.
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU DOCTOR EGGMAN SAYING
NO DISCUSSION OF EIGHT ON THE
ITEM.
COUPLE OF THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE VOTE
[inaudible]
BURKE WELL.
CLOSER ROLE TALLY THE VOTE.
I SIXTY THREE KNOWS.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR PROCEDURAL
MOTION.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
RESCIND THE ACTUAR BY AMENDMENTS
WERE ADOPTED TODAY ON ITEM FORTY
TWO A. B. FIVE AND SALAS.
THE IMAM'S CONTAINED DRAFTING
ERROR AND A NEW AMENDMENTS WILL
BE SUBMITTED.
WITHOUT OBJECTION THAT REQUEST
IS GRANTED.
I WAS GOING TO GO TO MISTER
KALRA.
BUT HE'S WONDERING THE REAR
CHAMBER THIS CALL ARE YOU READY
TO TAKE UP.
FILE ITEM.
TWO EIGHTY IN THE AFFIRMATIVE.
THIS IS FILE ITEM.
TWO EIGHT AB [inaudible]
FOUR ZERO THREE CORRECT.
ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR ZERO THREE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER KALRA AN
EXCELLENT EMPLOYMENT
[inaudible]
MISTER KALRA.
YOU.
MAY OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
EIGHTY FOUR OH THREE INCREASES
TOUCH LIMITATION WERE FOLLOWING
A WORKER RETALIATION CLAIM.
FROM SIX MONTHS TO TWO YEARS
WORKPLACE RETALIATION OCCURS
WHEN EMPLOYERS FIRE DEMOTE
SUSPENDER SUBJECT EMPLOYEES TO
AN ADVERSE ACTION FOR EXERCISING
THEIR RIGHTS UNDER THE LABOR
CODE. FOR THE RETALIATION RANGE
OF SUBTLE RECKLESS INTIMIDATION
TO OUTRIGHT THREATS AND
TERMINATION.
IN FACT IN ITS TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN RETALIATION COMPLAINT
REPORT THE LEGISLATURE.
LABOR COMMISSIONER REPORT A
DOUBLING OF THE NUMBER OF
RETALIATION COMPLAINTS BASED
UPON SEX RACE OR ETHNICITY FROM
THE PREVIOUS YEAR.
METALLIC ASHEN VALLEY PERVASIVE
BUT ALSO A GROWING PROBLEM TO
THE CURRENT POLITICAL CLIMATE IS
RUNNING IMMIGRATION SEXUAL
HARASSMENT.
OFTENTIMES THE BURDEN OF PAYING
ATTORNEYS FEES CAN BE A
DETERRENT FOR AGGRIEVED WORKERS
ESPECIALLY THOSE WERE LOW WAGE
AND UNFORTUNATELY THE PROCESS OF
FILING TO LABOR COMMISSION COULD
TAKE YEARS. TWO YEARS AGO THE
LEGISLATURE ADOPTED THE GOVERNOR
SIGNED SB NINETY SIX INTO LAW
WHICH PROVIDED THE DEPARTMENT OF
LABOR STANDARDS ENFORCEMENT THE
RIGHT TO REASONABLE ATTORNEY'S
FEES FROM THE EMPLOYER.
IF THE LABOR COMMISSIONER
PREVAILS AB FOR ALL TO PROVIDE
THE SAME ITEM BILLION PARTIES
WHO TAKE HIS RETALIATION CASES
OFTEN ON PRO BONO STATUS.
ON BEHALF OF WORKERS THIS IS
REALLY TALKING ABOUT FOR THE
MOST PART.
LAW CLINICS AND NON PROFITS AND
AND PRO BONO CASES BECAUSE THERE
ISN'T A CASH COW IN THESE TYPES
OF CASES BUT RATHER THERE'S A
LACK OF INCENTIVE OF TAKING ON
ANY CASES.
ON BEHALF OF THE WORKERS BECAUSE
OF THE BECAUSE THE ATTORNEYS
FEES.
PROVISION IS NOT THERE AND
THAT'S WHY THAT ASPECT OF IT IS
CRITICAL.
WITH MORE TIME TO FILE A BEFORE
A THREE STRENGTHENS LEGAL RIGHTS
OF WHISTLE BLOWERS FACED
DELEGATION.
AND ESPECIALLY HELPS LOWER WAGE
WORKERS ATTAIN LEGAL
REPRESENTATION WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK IMAGE KALRA.
SEE NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
CLARK LOCAL ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE ABOUT.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE ABOUT.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
MISTER KALRA.
DID YOU KALRA BOATSWAIN CALL
.
BACK IN FILE ORDER.
THIS IS FILE ITEM TO NINETY SIX
A. B.. SIX TWENTY SEVEN BY
MISTER FRAZIER.
ASSEMBLY BILL SIX TWENTY SEVEN
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRAZIER AND
ACTUALLY DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES.
THE CLUB MEMBERS THAT ALIVE.
MR FRAZIER THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS AB SIX TWENTY
SEVEN REQUIRES THE DEPARTMENT OF
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES. TO
IDENTIFY REGIONAL CENTERS THAT
ARE IN NEED OF SATELLITE OFFICES
AND TO CONSULT WITH EACH
IDENTIFIED REGIONAL CENTER TO
DETERMINE THE LOCATION OF ITS
SATELLITE OFFICE OR OFFICES.
AB SIX TWENTY SEVEN WILL
IDENTIFY THOSE AREAS MOST IN
NEED OF ONE OR MORE ADDITIONAL
REGIONAL CENTER SATELLITE
OFFICES SO THAT EVERY PERSON
WITH ID DE.
CAN BE PROVIDED WITH ADEQUATE
SERVICES.
THIS BILL HAD UNANIMOUS SUPPORT
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS FRAZIER SEE NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
VOTERS ARE AMONG.
ALL MEMBER SERVICE ARE THE ALL
MEMBERS OF A DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLICK WELL.
LOW'S ROLL TIDE BUT I SIXTY TWO
NO ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEMS TO NINETY SEVEN
THROUGH THREE OH ONE PASS AND
RETAIN.
WE ARE GOING TO PASS TEMPORARILY
ON FILE ITEM.
THREE OH TWO FILE ITEM. THREE OH
THREE IS AB SEVEN EIGHTEEN BY
DOCTOR EGGMAN.
KERKORIAN.
ASSEMBLY WILL SEVEN EIGHTEEN BY
SOME THE MEMBER EGGMAN AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY DID YOU CAN
ALSO.
WE MAY PASS TEMPORARILY.
FILE ITEM THREE OR FOUR AB SEVEN
NINETEEN BY MISTER DEEP.
ASSEMBLY WILL SEVEN NINETEEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER DEEP AND OTHERS
AND ACTUALLY MEDI CAL.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MISTER
SPEAKER I RISE TO PRESENT AB
SEVEN NINE NINETEEN THIS BILL
EXPRESSES THE INTENT OF THE
LEGISLATURE. TO AN CUTS THAT
WERE MADE TO MEDI CAL PROVIDERS
BACK IN.
TWENTY ELEVEN AND TWENTY ELEVEN
WHEN THE STATE WAS GOING THROUGH
A BUDGET DEFICIT.
MEDI CAL PROVIDERS REIMBURSEMENT
RATES WERE REDUCED BY 10% SEVEN
YEARS LATER THESE CUTS ARE STILL
IN PLACE.
THE STATE IS NO LONGER IN A
BUDGET DEFICIT SO WE SHOULD
FOCUS SOME OF OUR RESOURCES TO
PROVIDING MORE SERVICES TO OUR
CONSTITUENTS.
A COLLEAGUES I HOPE NEXT YEAR WE
CAN ALL WORK TOGETHER TO
ACTUALLY REMOVE THESE CUT.
OUR CONSTITUENT DESERVE TO HAVE
ACCESS TO SERVICES.
RATHER THAN JUST.
HAVING AN INSURANCE CAR.
AND SAY THERE AND SURE.
IN MY COMMUNITY WE HAVE
NONPROFIT HOSPITAL THAT RECENTLY
CANCEL.
THEIR MEDI CAL CONTRACT.
BECAUSE OF THE LOW REIMBURSEMENT
RATES I REALLY HOPE THAT WE CAN
WORK ON THIS NEXT YEAR.
AND THANK YOU MISTER THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AND I ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER DEEP BY C.
MICROPHONES MEMBERS THIS IS
SUPPORT SUPPORT.
THIS IS A SUPPORT SUPPORT ITEM.
MR OBERNOLTE.
MAYBE CALL.
MR OBERNOLTE YOUR RECOGNIZED.
MISTER SPEAKER A QUESTION THE
AUTHOR [inaudible]
WITHOUT OBJECTION.
ASSEMBLYMAN IS THIS YOUR FIRST
BILL.
MR DAVE YOU MAY OR MAY NOT
ANSWER THAT QUESTION.
THIS IS SPEAKER THIS IS THE NOT
MY FIRST BILL.
THANK YOU MISTER DATE.
ASSEMBLYMAN I ACTUALLY ASKED IF
THIS WAS YOUR FIRST BILL NOT A
BILL THAT YOU HAD JOINT AUTHORED
WITH A MORE EXPERIENCED MEMBER
OF THE LEGISLATURE.
MY QUESTION THOUGH IS.
IN READING THE BILL IT SEEMS
LIKE THIS JUST EXPRESSES
LEGISLATIVE INTENT IS THAT
ANOTHER WAY OF SAYING THAT THE
BILL DOESN'T ACTUALLY DO
ANYTHING AND A FOLLOW ON
QUESTION.
THIS IS THE KIND OF HARD HITTING
LEGISLATION WE CAN EXPECT FROM
YOU IN THE FUTURE [inaudible]
MR DAVE.
OUT I WENT THROUGH MY CLOTHES
THIS IS A BIGGER.
THAT'S WHAT WE CALL THE EASY WAY
OUT MR THE DR [inaudible]
CHOI.
YES SPEAKER AND A COLLEAGUE SAW
YOU SUPPORT OUR A. B. I. SEVEN
NINETEEN I'M NOT GONNA ROAST YOU.
ARE THE ORIGIN OR LANGUAGE OF
THIS BE A LAW ALSO TO A DIRECTLY
ADDRESSED THE PRIMARY CARE
SHORTAGE HERE IN THIS STATE THAT.
ARE IN OUT IN TALKING WITH THE
DOCTOR SO FROM MY DISTRICT AND
THE FROM ACROSS OF A STATE.
MANY OF WHICH USED TO BE OUR
PRIMARY CARE AND I HAVE SINCE I
LEFT THE PRACTICE.
THE TESTIMONY ARE ALWAYS THE
SAME.
DOCTORS TO ACTUALLY TAKE A LOSS
IN TREATING MEDI CAL PATIENTS A
BECAUSE OF THE CUTS -- IN
REIMBURSEMENT TO AND UP
PAPERWORK REQUIRED THE FOR THE
ARMENIAN Là.
REIMBURSEMENT THE ASSET THE
CURRENTLY STANDS.
WHILE I DO STAND UP TO THE
SUPPORT -- CURRENTLY -- I FEEL
THAT THE WE NEED TO MORE THAN.
MOM I'M MORE THAN US STATE
INTENT AND A START -- BACKING
OUR INTENT THE WITH AN AXE ON WE
WILL NOT TO ATTRACTED DOCTORS TO
PRACTICE -- IN OUR STATE IF WE
DO NOT -- A DISCONTINUE THE IN
REIMBURSEMENT CUTS A DAPPER DA
WE ARE A DID TO IS STILL FIVE
THE RESET RECESSION.
COLLEAGUES WITH THE ARE --
TWENTY ONE POINT FOUR BILLION
DOLLARS SO IS SO PLUS SO WE NEED
TO DISCONTINUE IT THIS CUTS AND
ATTRACTED DOCTORS BACK TO THE
PRIMARY CARE.
OF OUR CALIFORNIA FAMILIES.
I YEAH RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE.
APPRECIATE THE SUBSTANTIVE
COMMENT MISTER DE.
DOCTOR WHAT I'M SORRY MISTER
DOCTOR CHOI DOCTOR WOULD.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
I RISE IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL --
I APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY THE
EFFORTS OF THE AUTHOR WE HAVE.
DURING THE DURING THE RECESSION
PRIOR ALL OF US BEING HERE QUITE
FRANKLY -- THERE WAS SOME PRETTY
DEVASTATING CUTS TO A LOT OF
PROGRAMS STATEWIDE IN A LOT OF
PROGRAMS THAT WE HEARD IN OUR
BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE HAVE NEVER
BEEN FULLY REFUNDED TO THE
LEVELS THEY WERE PRE RECESSION.
THE CONCERN I HAVE AS WE GO
FORWARD AND EXPAND COVERAGE AND
CARE FOR MORE AND MORE PEOPLE IN
CALIFORNIA WE ARE POTENTIALLY.
PROVIDING -- PUTTING THEM INTO A
SITUATION WHERE THEY'RE NOT
GOING TO GET THE CARE THEY COULD
GET BECAUSE THE PROGRAMS HAVE
NOT BEEN ABLE TO BE REFUNDED.
AND I'M TALKING ABOUT PROGRAMS
RELATED TO INDIVIDUALS OF WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES --
OUR AGING POPULATION GREAT
PROGRAMS THAT DON'T HAVE
NECESSARILY -- THE HUGE OF HIGH
POWERED ADVOCATES TO BE.
OUT THERE PUSHING FOR A THESE
KINDS OF RESOURCES -- THEY RELY
ON MEMBERS AND AND GRASSROOTS
AND AND PEOPLE WERE CARD BUT
THESE ARE WORTHWHILE PROGRAMS
AND I AM AT THE INTENT IS TO SEE
THAT WE FIND A WAY TO REAP REAP.
FIND RESTORE THE INTEGRITY OF
SOME OF THESE PROGRAMS -- THAT
PROVIDE REALLY VALUABLE SIT UP
SERVICES THIS IS PART OF OUR
STATE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU DOCTOR WHAT.
MR GALLAGHER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
IT THIS IS A VERY IMPORTANT
ISSUE I GUESS THE CONCERN I
THINK BEING EXPRESSED IS THAT
THIS BILL APPEARS TO BE A MILE
WIDE.
IN ONLY AN INCH DEEP.
SEEING NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION.
ON THE BILL.
MR DATE YOU MAY CLOSE.
MS WITH THE SPEAKER AND IN OUR
DEFENSE WHEN THIS BILL WAS
PRESENT IN THE HEALTH COMMITTEE.
IT WAS PASSED UNANIMOUSLY AND A
CARRY A PRICE TAG OF A HUNDRED
EIGHTY THREE MILLION DOLLARS.
BUT THE ONLY WAY THAT THIS BILL
CAN GET OUT OF PROCREATION.
WAS BECOMING A BILL AND I HOPE
THAT THE CHAIR OF THE BROOK
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE CAN
WORK WITH ME AND DOCTOR WOULD
NEXT YEAR.
TO MAKE IT MORE THAN JUST AN
INTENT BILL.
WITH THAT I ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
[inaudible]
AMOS DEEP.
WITHOUT THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VETERANS OUT OF A
ALL MEMBERS OF REDUCE IRON TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OTHERS ARE ABOUT THE
CLERK WILL CLOSE TO ROLAND TELL
YOU VOTE.
I SIXTY ONE NO.
ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES.
THIS IS FILE ITEM THREE OH FIVE
AB SEVEN THIRTY ONE CROCKERY.
AS SOME PEOPLE SEVEN THIRTY ONE
BUY SOMETHING MEMBER KALRA AND
ACTUALLY TO HEALTH CARE COVERAGE
MISTER KALRA.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
IN CALIFORNIA PREMIUMS FOR
EMPLOYER HEALTH INSURANCE PLANS
OF RISEN TO HONOR 49% SINCE TWO
THOUSAND TO MORE THAN SIX TIMES
TO INCREASE THE STATE'S OVERALL
INFLATION.
THE SKYROCKETING COST OF
HEALTHCARE IS CONTRIBUTING TO
WAGE STAGNATION AND FUELING
INCOME INEQUALITY IN THE STATE
BECAUSE WE PUT INTO OUR
HEALTHCARE SYSTEM.
BECAUSE WHAT WE PUT INTO OUR
HEALTHCARE SYSTEM AUTUMN WE
COMPETE FOR THE WAGE INCREASES
AND HOUSEHOLD BUDGETS.
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN THIRTY ONE
EXPANDS THE RATE REVIEW PROCESS
TO THE LARGE GROUP MARKET AND
ENHANCES THE PROCESS TO PROVIDE
CONSUMERS.
AND REGULATORS A CLEAR PICTURE
OF HEALTHCARE COSTS.
THIS IS A CRITICALLY IMPORTANT
COST CONTAINMENT BILL THAT HAS
BROAD SUPPORT CONSUMER GROUPS
LABOR AND EMPLOYERS.
AMENDMENTS TAKEN ADDRESS
WORKLOAD CONCERNS BY REQUIRING
GMH D. M. H. C. S. C. I'D ONLY
RATE REVIEW THE METHODOLOGY USED
FOR LARGE GROUP RATES.
AND DETERMINATION WHETHER ANY
TERMINATION OF WHETHER THE BASE
RATE EXPERIENCE RATING WITH
METHODOLOGIES AND REASONABLE RUN
JUST FIVE OF THOSE EXPERIENCE
RATED PLANS.
CALIFORNIA HAS HAD A ROBUST RATE
REVIEW. FOR THE INDIVIDUAL AND
SMALL GROUP MRKETS FOR HEALTH
INSURANCE SINCE TWO THOUSAND
ELEVEN AND HAS SAVED INDIVIDUALS
AND SMALL BUSINESSES TWO HUNDRED
TWENTY SIX A MILLION DOLLARS.
SINCE LAW WAS ENACTED.
IMPROVING AND BUILDING UPON RATE
REVIEW ALLOW GREATER SCRUTINY ON
WHAT IS DRIVING RISING PREMIUMS
AND PROVIDE NECESSARY RELIEF FOR
MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIANS UNABLE
TO AFFORD THEIR HEALTH CARE.
WITHOUT A RESPECTFULLY ASK WHEN
I VOTE.
THERE WAS KALRA.
SEE NO DISCUSSION DEBATE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
THESE ARE VOTE ON MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE THE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE
TO VOTE
.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE ABOUT
MISTER KALRA MOVES A CALL
.
MEMBERS WE ARE FILE ITEM THREE
OF SIX AB SEVEN THIRTY THREE BY
DR QUIRK.
CORKERY ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN
THIRTY THREE BY SOME THE MEMBER
QUIRK AND ACTUALLY TO HAZARDOUS
WASTE.
DOCTOR QUIRK YES I'M ASKING FOR
YOUR VOTE ON A. B. SEVEN THIRTY
THREE THE SAVE THE MEADOWS BELL.
BOTH INDUSTRY ENVIRONMENTAL
GROUPS.
AND SEC AND THE ANIMAL WELFARE
GROUPS ARE SUPPORTING THIS BILL.
THE REASON IS THAT RIGHT NOW IF
YOU WANT TO DETERMINE IF
SOMETHING IS A TOXIC WASTE.
YOU ADDED TO AN AQUARIUM FILLED
WITH MANTO'S.
THE DIFFICULTY IS IS NOT A GREAT
CAST AND IF YOU USE THAT TEST
AND URINE INDUSTRY YOU CAN NO
LONGER SAY IT'S ANIMAL CRUELTY
FREE.
SO INDUSTRY WANTS A DIFFERENT
KIND OF TESTS -- EUROPE HAS
DEVELOP SUCH TESTS WERE ASKING
THE DEPARTMENT TO TAKE A LOOK AT
THOSE IN ADOPT THEM IF THEY FEEL.
THAT THEIR ADEQUATE THERE'S NO
REASON BY THE WAY TO THINK THAT
THE MAN -- TEST IS A
PARTICULARLY GOOD TESTS OF THESE.
ALTERNATIVES MAY ACTUALLY BE
BETTER TESTS.
SO AGAIN THE PROBLEM WITH NOT
TAKING THE TEST.
IS THAT THEN EVERYTHING IS
CALLED A HAZARDOUS WASTE SO YOUR
CHOICES THEY DO THE YEAR
CURRENTLY IS EITHER GOING TO BE
CALLED -- SOMETHING THAT YOU'RE
GOING TO SAY THAT THE THAT
YOU'RE CRUEL TO ANIMALS OR THAT
IT'S A TOXIC WASTE WE HAVE TO
CHANGE THAT.
CHOICE THANK YOU.
DATA QUIRK SAYING NO DISCUSSION
ON THE ITEM.
CARPOOL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS OTHERS OUT OF OF ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE THOáT
[inaudible]
WELL.
CLOSE YOUR ROLL TIDE ABOUT EYES
FIFTY SIX DOES.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS
WE ARE GOING TO GO BACK IN THE
FILE. TO FILE ITEM.
THREE OH THREE THIS IS ABC SEVEN
EIGHTEEN BY DOCTOR EGGMAN
CORPORATION.
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN EIGHTEEN BY
SOME THE MEMBER EIGHT MEN AND
ACTION AND YOU CAN ALSO.
DR.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
AB SEVEN EIGHTEEN HAS TO DO WITH
FOSTER YOUTH AND THIS BILL
REQUIRES OF THEIR VITAL
DOCUMENTS BE PROVIDED AT THEIR
FIRST REGULARLY SCHEDULED
HEARING.
AFTER THEY HAVE REACHED THE AGE
OF SIXTEEN I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
DATA DRIVEN SEE NO DISCUSSION
DEBATE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO
VOTE ON MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO
THE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO
VOTE.
CLICK WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE BUT I
SIXTY NO.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
BACK IN FILE ORDER FILE ITEM
THREE OH SEVEN IS AB SEVEN
THIRTY FOUR BY MISTER
MAIENSCHEIN COVERAGE.
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN THIRTY FOUR
BY FAMILY MEMBER MAIENSCHEIN AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY TO FOSTER
CARE MR MAIENSCHEIN THANK YOU
MADAM ARE MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS.
WHEN CHILDREN UNDERGO MULTIPLE
FOSTER CARE PLACEMENTS THEY ARE
LIKELY TO EXPERIENCE SEVERE
TRAUMA THIS TRAUMA MANIFOLDS
MANIFESTS ITSELF BEHAVE O'REILY
EMOTIONALLY SOCIALLY AND
ACADEMICALLY?
MAKING IT LESS LIKELY FOR THESE
FOSTER YOUTH TO FIND PERMANENCE
IN ADOPTION OR REUNIFICATION.
AB SEVEN THIRTY FOUR WILL
ESTABLISH A TWO YEAR PILOT
PROGRAM WHICH AIMS TO PROVIDE
RESOURCE FAMILIES WITH THE
NECESSARY INFORMATION.
AND TOOLS TO ENSURE THE SUCCESS
OF THE PERMANENT SICH SITUATION
ADDITIONALLY THE PILOT WILL
ALLOW THE OPTION FOR COUNTIES TO
EXPAND OTHER SUPPORT SERVICES.
SUCH AS TRANSPORTATION AND
RESPITE CARE THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AND I ABOUT.
THERE WAS MENTION.
SEE NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE
ITEM.
COR CORPORAL.
MEMBERS LETTERS ARE VOTE ON
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE ABOUT.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
QUIRK WELL CLOSER ROLE.
TELL YOU VOTE.
I SIXTY FOUR NO.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES FILE
ITEM. THREE OH EIGHT THIS AB
SEVEN FORTY FOUR CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN FORTY FOUR
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER AGUIAR-CURRY
AND ACTUALLY TO HEALTHCARE
COVERAGE.
IS AGUIAR-CURRY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AB
SEVEN FORTY FOUR CREATES TRUE
TELEHEALTH PARITY'S SO THAT ALL
CALIFORNIANS HAVE ACCESS TO
HEALTH CARE REGARDLESS OF THE
LOCATION.
AND PROVIDERS CAN EXPAND THE
REACH.
THIS BILL STRENGTHENS
NONDISCRIMINATION STATUTES IN
EXISTING LAW TO ENSURE THAT A
HEALTH CARE PROVIDER IS
REIMBURSE FOR SERVICES DELIVERED
TO AN ENROLLEE THROUGH
TELEHEALTH.
IF THOSE SAME SERVICES ARE
COVERED NGUYEN PROVIDED IN
PERSON.
I HAVE AMENDED THE BILL TO
CLARIFY THAT IS NOT RATE SETTING
AND THAT PLANTS A PROVIDERS MAY
STILL NEGOTIATE ON CONTRACTED
RATES FOR TELEHEALTH SERVICES.
BY UPDATING TELEHEALTH Là AB
SEVEN FORTY FOUR WILL ENSURE THE
CALIFORNIANS IN RURAL
COMMUNITIES MEDICALLY
UNDERSERVED AREAS OR WHO HAVE
BEEN DISPLACED BY NATURAL
DISASTERS.
HAVE ACCESS TO ESSENTIAL HEALTH
CARE I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MS SAGER COURTESY
NOTICE CASH TO MAKE CARPOOL OF
THE ROLE.
BETTER IS OUT OF A ALL MEMBERS
OTHERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
WELL CLOSER ROLL TIDE BUT I
SIXTY ONE NO.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES
FOLLOWING THREE OH NINE IS AB
SEVEN FORTY EIGHT BY MISTER
GIBSON CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN FORTY EIGHT
BY SOME THE MEMBER GIPSON AND
ACTUALLY NO NON MINOR DEPENDENCE.
MISTER GIBSON.
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
AUTHORIZED TO ASK MY COLLEAGUES
WERE SUPPORT OF AB SEVEN FORTY
EIGHT WHICH WILL ELIMINATE
BARRIERS TO ENSURE THAT FOSTER
YOUTH IN NEED OF TRANSITIONAL
SERVICES ARE ABLE.
TO ENTER AND RE ENTER TO
EXTENDED OF FOSTER CARE.
AB -- SEVEN FORTY EIGHT IS ABOUT
CLOSING THE GAP FOR BARBEL
TRANSITIONAL AGE FOSTER YOUTH
AND A VERY NARROW SITUATIONS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK WHAT I VOTE ON
AB.
SEVEN FORTY EIGHT THEY MUST GIVE
SEND SENIOR DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
OUR GLOBAL ROLE.
RESERVE AT ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE THE ALL MEMBER SERVICE OUT
OF A WELL CLOSER ALL TIES BUT I
SIXTY FOUR NO.
ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES AB PART
ME FILE ITEM THREE TEN IS AB.
SEVEN FIFTY TWO COREY.
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN FIFTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GABRIEL AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY THE PUBLIC
TRANSIT RICHARD GABRIEL THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I
AM PLEASED TODAY TO PRESENT AB
SEVEN FIFTY TO A BILL THAT WILL
ENSURE.
THE NURSING WOMEN ARE PROVIDED
WITH A SAFE AND HYGIENIC SPACE
TO BREAST FEED OR PUMP BREAST
MILK WHILE TRAVELING.
THIS BILL WOULD ADDRESS A
FUNDAMENTAL IN EQUITY FOR WOMEN
WHO TRAVEL BY RAIL OR BUS BY
ENSURING THAT.
NEW OR RENOVATED TRANSIT
STATIONS THE MEET CERTAIN
CRITERIA PROVIDE A SAFE AND
ADEQUATE LACTATION SPACE.
THIS IS AN IMPORTANT STEP TO
PROMOTE EQUITY SUPPORT FAMILIES
AND EMPOWER CALIFORNIANS TO MAKE
IMPORTANT DECISIONS RELATED TO
RAISING THEIR CHILDREN.
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE.
NAME IS GABRIEL SAY NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF THEM.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE THE ALL
MEMBERS VOTE.
IT IS OUR TO VOTE [inaudible]
QUIRK WELL.
CLOSER ROLE.
TYLER ICE FIFTY SIX NOW.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS
ARE PREPARED TO LIFT THE CALL.
ON AB ONE HERBIE FILE ITEM ONE
SEVENTY TWO A. B.. SEVEN THIRTY
ONE SORRY.
THIS IS FILE ITEM.
THREE OH FIVE AB.
SEVEN THIRTY ONE THE CALL FOR
COMPOSED.
ALL MEMBERS WOULD WISH TO VOTE
ON MEMBERS VOTER WHICH TO VOTE.
WELL.
CLOSER ROLL TIDE BUT ICE.
FORTY FOUR KNOWS.
NINETEEN THAT MEASURE PASSES
.
AND MEMBERS PREPARED TO LET THE
CALL ON FILE ITEM. ONE SEVENTY
TWO A. B. THIRTEEN SIXTY BY MR
TANG [inaudible]
CARPOOL POSTS.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRED OF
THE ALL MEMBER SERVICE ARE THE
WELL CLOSER ALL.
TELL YOU ABOUT AYE AYES FORTY
TWO KNOWS.
TWENTY TWO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
THE RESPECT OF THE FILE FILE
ITEM THREE ELEVEN PASS RETAIN
FILE ITEM [inaudible]
THREE TWELVE MR GRAY.
AB.
SEVEN SIXTY THREE CLOCK RATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN SIXTY THREE
BY SOMETHING MEMBER GRAY AND
ACTUALLY MEDI CAL.
MR BREATH.
THANK YOU MISTER GRAHAM'S AB
SEVEN SIXTY THREE WILL INCREASE
ACCESS TO SPECIALTY MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES. FOR CHILDREN
THE MEDICARE PROGRAM BY
STANDARDIZING THE PAPERWORK
PROVIDERS REQUIRED TO USE.
THIS WILL STREAM LIVE STERILIZE
MOST BURDENSOME SETS PAPERWORK
TO PEDIATRIC SPECIALTY MENTAL
HEALTH PROVIDERS MUST COMPLETE
AND I WAS BACK FASTER AYE VOTE.
FAMOUS GRAY.
SENIOR MEMBER SEEKING
RECOGNITION ON THE ITEM QUIRK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS OF DESIRE TO VOTE ON
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF THE THE SERVER
[inaudible]
PARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT ICE.
SIXTY THREE NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
MEMBERS ARE GOING TO LIVE THE
CALL ON FILE ITEM TO EIGHTY
THAT'S A BEFORE OF THREE KALRA
CARPOOL POSTS.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WHICH TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OTHERS ARE ABOUT
MORE PLACE THE CALL.
FILE ITEMS.
THREE THIRTEEN THREE THREE
EIGHTEEN PAST RETAIN.
FILE ITEM.
THREE NINETEEN AB EIGHT FORTY
THREE BY MISTER RODRIGUEZ.
CORPORATION AS A LEGAL EIGHT
FORTY THREE BY SOME REMEMBER
RODRIGUEZ AND ACTUALLY TO
STUDENT FINANCIAL AID.
THIS RODRIGUEZ MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS THE ASSUMPTION PROGRAM
OF LOANS FOR EDUCATION APPLE IS
THE FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE PROGRAM
CREATED TO HELP K. THROUGH
TWELVE EDUCATORS WITH THE BURDEN
OF SCRATCHING STUDENT LOANS.
APPLE WAS CREATED IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY TWO BUT WAS DEFINED IT
AND TWENTY TWELVE DUE TO BUDGET
CONSTRAINTS.
WITH THE HIGH COST.
AND DEPTH SO SHOULD WERE
PURSUING A TEACHERS DEGREE LOW
SALARIES AND HIGH COST OF LIVING
IT HAS BECOME CHALLENGING TO
RECRUIT AND TRAIN.
QUALIFIED TEACHERS IN CALIFORNIA.
THIS BILL SEEKS TO REINSTATE
APPLE AND PROVIDE OUR EDUCATORS
WITH SOME STUDENT LOAN RELIEF.
RESPECT THE OSCAR I WROTE.
THANK YOU MISS RODRIGUEZ SEEN NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM.
OUR CLUB THE ROLE.
THE START OF IT ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE THE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE [inaudible]
KIRK WELL.
CLOSER ROLE AND TALLY THE VOTE.
I SIXTY NINE NO ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES.
WE ARE GOING TO TAKE A FILE ITEM.
THREE TWENTY BY MISTER BONTA.
AB EIGHT FORTY NINE CLERK WILL
READ.
AT SOME LEVEL EIGHT FORTY NINE
BY SOME REMEMBER BONTA AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY TO ELECTIONS.
MR BONTA.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES REDISTRICTING IS OF
CRUCIAL IMPORTANCE TO LOCAL
DEMOCRACY HOW CITY OR COUNTY.
ELECTION.
DISTRICTS ARE DRAWN CAN HELP
DETERMINE WHETHER OR NOT A
COMMUNITY WILL BE FAIRLY
REPRESENTED BY THE MOST INTIMATE
AND PROXIMATE.
GOVERNMENT BODIES UNLIKE STATE
LEVEL REDISTRICTING THERE ARE
VERY FEW REQUIREMENTS GOVERNING
CITY AND COUNTY REDISTRICTING TO
ENSURE THE PROCESS IS FAIR.
AND TRANSPARENT AND THAT THE
PUBLIC ESPECIALLY UNDER
REPRESENTED COMMUNITIES ARE
ENGAGED IN THE PROCESS AB EIGHT
FORTY NINE WILL BRING
TRANSPARENCY AND CREATE CLEAR
STANDARDS THE CITY AND COUNTY.
REDISTRICTING BY EXPANDING
OPPORTUNITIES FOR PUBLIC
PARTICIPATION FOR NON ENGLISH
SPEAKING COMMUNITIES THAT ARE
OTHERWISE ALL TOO OFTEN
OVERLOOKED.
THE BILL WAS AMENDED COMING OUT
OF THE ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE AND IT NO LONGER
APPLIES TO SCHOOL DISTRICTS
COUNTY BOARDS OF EDUCATION
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICTS OR
SPECIAL DISTRICTS THESE GROUPS
HAVE ALL REMOVED THEIR
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
AB EIGHT FORTY NINE GIVES
DISENFRANCHISED COMMUNITIES A
VOICE PREVENTS GERRYMANDERING
AND ESTABLISHES A FAIR CITY AND
COUNTY REDISTRICTING PROCESS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK IMAGE BONTA SEEING NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
COUPLE OF THE ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
RESERVE VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
ART OF THE ALL MEMBERS VOTE
[inaudible]
ROSARIO.
THE CLERK WILL.
LOW'S A ROLL TIDE OF A AYE AYES
FORTY FOUR NO.
SIXTEEN THAT MEASURE PASSES.
PASS RETAIN ON FILE ITEMS THREE
TWENTY ONE FILE ITEM.
THREE TWENTY TWO IS AB.
EIGHT FIFTY NINE CORPORATION.
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHT FIFTY NINE
BY SOME REMEMBER MAIENSCHEIN AND
ACTUALLY TO DO THAT ALSO.
MR MAIENSCHEIN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS WHEN A CHILD IS FOUND TO
BE WITHIN THE DEPENDENCY
JURISDICTION OF THE JUVENILE
COURT.
THE STATE UNDERTAKES A
RESPONSIBILITY TO MAKE ALL
SIGNIFICANT PARENTAL DECISIONS
FOR A CHILD.
JUDGES PLAY A CRUCIAL ROLE IN
THIS PROCESS HOWEVER HIGH
CASELOADS CAN BECOME A BARRIER
TO GETTING TO KNOW EACH CHILD
AND OBTAINING NECESSARY
INFORMATION TO ACT.
IN THEIR BEST INTEREST AB EIGHT
FIFTY NINE WILL ASK THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL TO STUDY CASELOAD
STANDARDS FOR JUDGES WHO
ADJUDICATE JUVENILE DEPENDENCY
PROCEEDINGS THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AND I ABOUT.
THANK YOU IS RANGE I SEE NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
OUR CLUB RURAL.
RESERVE AT ALL MEMBERS WERE
RESERVE OF ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE -- WELL CLOSER ALL
TIED ABOUT AYE SIXTY FIVE NO.
ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES FILE
ITEM THREE TWENTY THREE AB EIGHT
SIXTY FIVE I MISS REYES CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY WILL EIGHT SIXTY FIVE
BY SELLING MEMBER REYES AND
ACTUALLY TO FOSTER CARE MS REYES.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
TODAY PRESENTED AB EIGHT SIXTY
FIVE A BILL WHICH EXPANDS
CURRENT TRAINING PROVIDED FOR
FOSTER YOUTH RESOURCE FAMILIES
TO INCLUDE.
INFORMATION ON HUMAN TRAFFICKING.
THIS TRAINING WILL SPECIFICALLY
FOCUS ON RISK FACTORS FOR
COMMERCIAL AND SEXUAL
EXPLOITATION AND LABOR
TRAFFICKING.
HUMAN TRAFFICKING IS A CRITICAL
ISSUE IN THE RISK TO THIS
POPULATION IS CLEAR.
BUT CARE GIVERS WHO ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR THESE YOUTH ARE
NOT PROVIDED WITH ACCESS TO
PROPER TRAINING.
AND RESOURCES TO BETTER SUPPORT
THEM WE MUST DO BETTER.
AB EIGHT SIXTY FIVE N. SHORES OF
FOSTER FAMILIES WILL BE PROPERLY
EDUCATED ON HOW TO CARE FOR
THESE YOU.
IN AN APPROPRIATE AND LOVING
MANNER I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MS REYES.
SEE NO DISCUSSION DEBATE.
MARK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS REPRESENT OF THOSE.
ALL MEMBERS OTHERS ARE THE ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE THOSE.
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE OF WHAT I SIXTY
SEVEN NO I SIXTY EIGHT NO.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEMS THREE TWENTY FOUR AND
THREE TWENTY FIVE PASS RETAIN.
FILE ITEM THREE TWENTY SIX A. B.
NINE FOURTEEN BY MR HOLDEN.
KERKORIAN ASSEMBLY BILL NINE
FOURTEEN BY FAMILY MEMBER HOLDEN
AND ACTUALLY MEDI CAL.
MR HOLDEN.
IF YOU MISTER SPEAKER AB NINE
FOURTEEN WILL REQUIRE THE
SUSPENSION OF MEDI CAL BENEFITS
AND READ A TERMINATION OF
ELIGIBILITY THROUGH A SIMPLIFIED.
YEARLY PROCESS FOR MEMBERS OF A
PUBLIC INSTITUTION UNDER THE AGE
OF TWENTY SIX UNDER CURRENT LAW
AND INDIVIDUALS MEDI CAL
BENEFITS ARE TERMINATED AFTER
ONE YEAR OF BEING AN INMATE.
OF A PUBLIC INSTITUTION.
WHEN THAT INDIVIDUAL IS OTHER
ELIGIBLE FOR RELEASE CDC OUR
PROGRAMS HELP THEM RE APPLY FOR
MEDICAL BENEFITS FOURTEEN TO A
HUNDRED AND TWENTY DAYS BEFORE
THE RELEASE DATE?
ALTHOUGH THESE PROGRAMS HAVE
BEEN SIX RUSSELL AND ROPE AND
ROLLING PEOPLE INTO MEDI CAL.
IT CAN TAKE YOU CAN STILL TAKE
WEEKS AFTER RELEASE BEFORE THEY
HAVE ACCESS TO CARE.
AND MEDICATIONS.
THE SPIRIT IS CRITICAL FOR ALL
PEOPLE FACING REINTEGRATION AND
IS ESPECIALLY CRITICAL FOR THOSE
WITH CHRONIC CONDITIONS.
CANNOT CHEMICAL DEPENDENCIES OR
MEDICAL ILLNESSES.
WITHOUT PROPER CARE OR RELIABLE
ACCESS TO MEDICINE THESE
INDIVIDUALS ARE VULNERABLE TO
THE CONDITIONS THAT MAY HAVE
INITIALLY GOT THEM ARRESTED.
CONTINUITY OF CARE IS ESSENTIAL
TO MAINTAINING POSITIVE HEALTH
OUTCOMES IN PREVENTING COSTLIER
HEALTHCARE DOWN THE ROAD.
AB NINE FOURTEEN WILL DECREASE
RATES OF ILLNESS DEATH AND
RECIDIVISM BY IMPROVING
IMMEDIATE ACCESS TO HEALTH
SERVICES.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MUCH HOLDEN SEE NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
CARP LIBERAL.
ALL MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OTHERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF RESERVE --CLERK
WILL.
CULTURAL TIES BUT I SIXTY TWO NO
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES. FIVE
THREE TWENTY SEVEN AB NINE
THIRTY MISTER GLORIA CORKERY.
AS A LEGAL NINE THIRTY BY
SOMETHING MEMBER GLORIA AND
OTHERS AND I PLAN TO POST
SECONDARY EDUCATION.
MR GLORIA.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER --
EIGHTY NINE THIRTY WILL PROMOTE
COLLEGE AFFORDABILITY AND
TRANSPARENCY BY PROHIBITING
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
BOARD OF TRUSTEES FOR INCREASING
EXECUTIVE COMPENSATION WHEN
STUDENT TUITION IS INCREASED.
UNDER GOVERNOR NEWSOME'S
PROPOSED BUDGET THE CS YOU WILL
RECEIVE AN ADDITIONAL THREE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS IN
ONGOING FUNDING FOR STUDENT
ENROLLMENT.
UNDER THE CONDITION THAT SHE DID
TUITION NOT BE INCREASED. EIGHTY
NINE THIRTY WOULD MAKE SURE THE
CSU LIVES UP TO THIS CONDITION
BY REQUIRING THE FOLLOWING.
FIRST EXECUTIVE PAY CANNOT BE
INCREASED IN YEARS IN WHICH
TUITION IS INCREASED SECOND ANY
CHANGES TO POLICIES PROCEDURES
OR INCREASES EXECUTIVE
COMPENSATION MUST BE PLACED ON A
BOARD AGENDA. FOR AND HIS A
PUBLIC HEARING WITH A VOTE ON A
SECOND SUBSEQUENT HEARING AND
FINALLY THE CSU CHANCELLOR MUST
MANDATE EACH CAMPUS TO PREPARE A
REPORT.
BY ANNUAL COMPARISONS OF CAN'T
BUT CAMPUS BUDGET TO ITS ACTUAL
SPENDING LEVELS.
THIS BILL HAS ENJOYED BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANKS GLORIA SAYING NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO
VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE [inaudible]
CLARK WELL [inaudible]
CLOSE ROLE.
TELL YOU VOTE.
I SIXTY THREE NO ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM.
THREE TWENTY EIGHT A. B. NINE
THIRTY THREE CORPORATION.
ASSEMBLY BILL NINE THIRTY THREE
BY SELLING OF PETRIE-NORRIS AND
OTHERS AND I PLAN TO RESOURCE
PROTECTION.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
I RISE TODAY TO ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT FOR AB.
NINE THIRTY THREE THIS BILL WILL
ESTABLISH THE ECOSYSTEM
RESILIENCE PROGRAM WITH IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF CONSERVATION.
THIS BILL IS RECEIVED BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT AND NO VOTE NO NO VOTES
THROUGHOUT THE COMMITTEE PROCESS
I A I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
I'VE IT TODAY.
THANK YOU IS PETRIE-NORRIS SEE
NO DISCUSSION DEBATE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE.
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
CLARK WELL CLOSER ROLE TALLY THE
I SIXTY SIX NO.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WE HAVE ONE REMAINING
ITEM ON CALL THIS IS FILE ITEM
TWO EIGHTY A. B. FOUR OH THREE
THE CLERK WILL POST.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO WISH TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS WOULD WISH TO VOTE
.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER WISH TO VOTE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
WELL PLACE THE CALL.
MEMBERS WE HAVE A CONSENT
CALENDAR.
WE HAVE A CONFIRMED COUNTER
WRITTEN.
MEMBERS THIS IS A CONSENT
CALENDAR.
THE CITY MEMBER WHICH WHICH TO
REMOVE AN ITEM FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR SEEING AND HEARING NONE.
CLERK WILL READ THE SECOND EGG
THE SECOND OWNER.
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
FORTY ONE BY SENATOR ALLEN AND
OTHERS RELATIVE TO CALIFORNIA
HOLOCAUST MEMORIAL DAY.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE ON IN
TOWN OR MEMBERS THIS IS THE
CONSENT CALENDAR.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE ABOUT
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE THE ROLE TALLY THE VOTE I
SEVENTY SIX NO ZERO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR IS ADOPTED.
MEMBERS WE HAVE ONE ITEM ON CALL.
FILE ITEM TWO EIGHTY A BEFORE
THREE CORPORAL POST.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A
WORK
WILL.
TALENT OF A AYE AYES FORTY ONE
THOSE TWENTY SEVEN THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
ANNOUNCEMENTS SESSION SCHEDULE
IS AS FOLLOWS FRIDAY MAY TWENTY
FOURTH FLOOR SESSION IS A NINE
AM.
ALL OTHER ITEMS REMAINING WILL
BE PASSED RETAIN A MOTION SHALL
BE CONTINUED.
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
BUSINESS I'M READY TO ENTERTAIN
A MOTION TO ADJOURN.
THIS CALDERON MOVES MISTER
FLORES SECOND SET THIS HOUSE
STANDS ADJOURNED.
UNTIL FRIDAY MAY TWENTY FOURTH
AT NINE AM.
THAT'S TOMORROW AT NINE QUORUM
CALLS LIFTED
[inaudible]
WALDRON.
FILE NUMBER TWO SIX NINE A. B..
THREE EIGHTEEN NO TO I THE
CHANGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER WALDRON
IT'S ONLY ABOUT THREE EIGHTEEN
NO T<c.cyan>.</c>
VOTE CHANGE BONTA AB SEVENTEEN
THIRTY ONE I TO NOT VOTING.
THE CHANGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER BONTA
AS LEGAL SEVENTEEN THIRTY ONE I
TO NOT VOTING
.
BOTH CHANGED JONES SAWYER AB
THREE FOUR ZERO THREE FORTY I DO
NOT VOTING.
THE CHANGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER JONES
SAWYER.
ASSEMBLY BILL. THREE FORTY FIVE
NOT VOTING.
VOTE CHANGE ARAMBULA AB ONE
SIXTY ONE I TO NOT VOTING.
THE CHANGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ARAMBULA ASSEMBLY BILL ONE SIXTY
ONE I TO NOT VOTING.
VOTE CHANGE TO FILE ITEM TWO OF
FIVE NO TWO HI.
CANNOT FILE ITEM TWO OH FIVE OH
TO LEVINE BILL [inaudible]
AB. ONE FIVE EIGHT ZERO I'LL DO
IT AGAIN.
CHIU VOTE CHANGE FILE ITEM TO A
FIVE AB.
ONE FIVE EIGHT ZERO NO TWO BY.
VOTE CHANGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
DAVID CHIU ASSEMBLY WILL FIFTEEN
EIGHTY NOTE I GIPSON VOTE CHANGE
AB NINE FROM I TO NOT VOTING
[inaudible]
AB.
NINE THE CHANGE ASSEMBLYMEMBER
GIPSON ASSEMBLY WILL NINE I IT'S
NOT VOTING.
GIPSON VOTE CHANGE A. B. OF FILE
NUMBER ONE THIRTY THREE A. B.
TEN TWENTY FIVE FROM NO -- TO HI.
THE CHANGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GIPSON.
ASSEMBLY WILL TEN TWENTY FIVE
NOTES I
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CECILIA
AGUIAR-CURRY.
WHILE NUMBER TWO NINETY TWO AB.
FIVE SEVEN TWO I TO NOT VOTING.
THE CHANGE ASSEMBLYMEMBER
AGUIAR-CURRY.
AS A LABEL FIVE SEVENTY TWO I TO
NOT VOTING.
THERE WE ARE.
IRWIN VOTE CHANGE AB THIRTEEN
TWENTY EITHER NOT VOTING.
THE CHANGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER IRWIN
AS LABEL THIRTEEN TWENTY I TO
NOT VOTING.
MAIENSCHEIN AB SEVENTEEN THIRTY
ONE NO TO NOT VOTING.
THE CHANGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MAIENSCHEIN.
THIS LABEL SEVENTY THIRTY ONE
NOTES NOT VOTING.
GLORIA VOTE CHANGED AB SEVENTEEN
THIRTY ONE FROM NOT VOTING TO
KNOW [inaudible]
RIGHT.
VOTE CHANGE MURATSUCHI FILE ITEM
ONE EIGHTY TWO A. B..
FOURTEEN TWENTY FOUR I TO NOT
VOTING.
THE CHANGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MURATSUCHI SOME LEVEL FOURTEEN
TWENTY FOUR I TO NOT VOTING
.
GALLAGHER AB.
THREE THREE ONE I TO KNOW.
THE CHANGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GALLAGHER AS LABEL THREE THIRTY
ONE I KNOW.
GALLAGHER AB.
FIVE HUNDRED I TO NOT VOTING.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GALLAGHER
ASSEMBLY WILL FIVE HUNDRED I
IT'S NOT VOTING [inaudible]
GALLAGHER.
AB THIRTEEN EIGHTY FIVE NO T<c.cyan>.</c>
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GALLAGHER.
AS AN ABLE THIRTEEN EIGHTY FIVE
NOTES I AUTUMN BURKE.
ASSEMBLY WILL WITH THE FIVE
THIRTY NINE I TO NOT VOTING.
THE CHANGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER BURKE.
AT SOME LEVEL FIVE THIRTY NINE I
TO NOT VOTING.
THANK YOU